what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and thank you for
a hundred thousand subscribers
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell like the video on your
way in today we have a special exciting
show for you where we are going live for
24 hours going over red pill topics
I don't know if you guys have ever seen
a red pill live stream this long but I
think we are the first ones to do it I
think so
um okay guys so today I got some special
guests in the room why don't we go
around everyone say your name your age
your relationship status and um where
you're from
um my name is Daniel everyone called me
Franklin uh I'm 26. just turned 26 and
I'm from Southeast London and I'm in a
relationship
my name is Iman I'm 21 years old I'm
Moroccan and I'm single
my name is Sasha I'm from New Mexico I'm
25 years old and I'm single yes my name
is P silver I'm 30. I'm from South East
London and I am single hi my name is
Jessica I am from California I am 27
years old almost 28 birthdays next week
and I am single
happy birthday in advance
okay guys so um today we are going over
the like fundamentals of red pill topics
so um how many of you know what the red
pill is I know you said you you're like
into this type of content what about you
guys not so much
you kind of know guys so guys know girls
I'm still learning
yes okay good news
so I I think the the fundamental of the
red pill is
showing like what the world really is
and it's showing women's true nature
now who here knows what hypergamy is yep
you guys know okay not yet so
um
hypergamy is the action of marrying or
forming a sexual relationship with a
person of a superior sociological or
educational background women date across
and up hierarchies
so it's basically saying that if a girl
is making 45 000 a year she wants a guy
that's making 70. like we we want a guy
that we can look up to
all right so would you guys as girls
what do you what do you think of that do
you think that's true with what you see
I think that's very true
um I see it a lot I hear it a lot from
girls like
my man's gonna be making gonna be making
over six figures they have to do this
they have to do that but so a lot of
them aren't even making that
um so yeah I hear that more than
anything
yeah I do definitely ground up there are
so many people who have a huge list of
requirements when they try to find their
Partners especially financial status
okay and what about you guys have you
guys ever found that women have rejected
you for not making enough money or maybe
not being you guys are both pretty tall
but like another way is height that
women reject Ben yeah
um back when I wasn't huge yeah back
when back when I was a noble-sized human
being right I wasn't
admirable by females I wasn't really
looked at a surprise in any way but as
soon as you have something that they
like or you are something that they want
to have uh then yeah you're gonna get
all the all the attention right then
because yeah and I think the attention
comes with um what they what they
perceive as well like if you're around
you know whoever you're around if
they're around the guys that go around
they got swag and they all automatically
think that yeah you've got a swag in it
because um buzz of the same feather
flocked together kind of thing so it
depends on your circle and if the girls
are seeing that a lot of girls want you
as well they'll want a piece of that 100
yeah I mean so have I experienced a time
where girls rejected me I mean girls
rejects guys all the time so
like yeah it's just about what they they
see to be honest you know so um part of
hypergamy is that women all want a very
small percentage of men
so um this is something that literally
blew my mind when I first started when I
first started like watching this content
if you ask 80 of women what they want in
a man they list 20 of men
so the reason that girls say things like
men are trash men are the problem is
because we're all sleeping with the same
ones for example Sasha how how tall are
you five step in how tall would you like
your your potential like boyfriend to be
uh like ideally like perfect world oh
perfect world okay he had to be over six
foot over six foot yeah what what
percent of guys do you think are over
six foot maybe
like
30 40 no 15 15.
and so it's kind of the curse of as as
like as I'm tall I'm six foot so I
understand I understand it but but it's
kind of a curse in a way because if
you're six foot or tall or you're
looking for a guy that's six foot or
taller you're competing with everyone
because all the girls want him even the
short girls yeah yeah
unfortunately no they do
yeah yeah
it doesn't make sense to me I'm like
you're five you're five foot you can get
somebody that's five five it's gonna be
five inches taller you don't need nobody
that's six foot leave it to the tall
people and it's it's interesting because
after I learned this stat I would start
to like walk into a room right and I
would just look at it differently and
there's a whole group of men that like
women just don't we do not see like the
guy behind the checkout counter at
McDonald's like and I would start to
take notes in a room if there was like
10 guys in it like how many I was
actually attracted to and I I was like
damn that's some good study that's some
good studies and the crazy thing is 20
is the high end like there are some
studies that say it's five percent
there's some studies that say it's 10
like basically five to twenty percent of
men are sleeping with all of the girls
wow yikes now as a guy does this
surprise you no uh no it doesn't
surprise me at all right
it's actually pretty funny when
when you actually think about it because
um you see it in school all the time
when you're growing up you see these
kind of like social hierarchies
happening in school you'll see that you
know it's either the athlete the guy
that you know is playing football or you
know the rapper the guy that everyone
knows there's a rapper in school like
all the girls like it more the football
all the girls like him or the funny guy
you know the comedian you get me all the
girls lacking but um it's like the
boring guys and all the more quiet guys
are the it's more the majority of boys
in school anyway when you see a snowman
George and the girls just won't go for
them kind of guys I have this one friend
I'm not gonna say his name he's one of
my closest friends from like uni time
and uh
he looks like I always tell my friends
he looks like a Hollister model like he
looks exactly what you would Envision a
Hollister model to look like in the face
right Hollister yeah oh like uh like the
clothing brand you know you know those
guys used to stand outside the shop
shirtless randomly yeah yeah yeah he
looks like one of those right so I've
been with this guy all night so and he's
drunk out of his mind can't string two
words together he will lean lean on the
bar and a girl will come to him and
it'll work out together and it's like oh
whoa
are you saying that's not the experience
of the average man no way in hell
he got lucky and he did get lucky but
you know wait do you think that's luck
no it was it was a joke
but it's interesting because like once
you once you see this you can't unsee it
yeah and so once as a girl I think as a
girl we're shielded from reality a lot
so I think men are a lot more aware of
hierarchies than women so why do you
think we have movements like
fat phobic and ageist because everyone
wants to be cuddled right it's easy to
say don't be fat phobic it's harder to
actually put the work in to lose the
weight right because everyone when
people say
um you should just go to the gym and
lose weight I think
people on the other side of that uh
phrase what they hear is it's easy it's
easy no one said it was going to be easy
just because I said go to the gym
doesn't mean it's going to be easy
you're gonna have to go to the gym
pretty much every day for like a year
for like a few months to even see any
sort of changes but if the action of
going to the gym that will help you yeah
there's a lot of people who just like
they'll push it down the road push it
down the road push down the road and
when you push it down the road that much
it builds so by the time you decide to
actually face it it's too big for you to
deal with like uh like uh you know those
100 100 pound sisters
600 pounds yeah one of them's lost a
bunch away one of them has put on an
enormous amount of weight right because
she just kept pushing it down pushing it
down you got over 600 pounds she got
fatter yeah one of the sisters oh
okay sorry keep going no just like how
do you get fatter than the 600 wow when
you get a chance go look at them now
right okay they literally look like
okay what's that alien in Star Wars
oh I don't oh no
[Laughter]
no because then you watch the show and
it's like she just kept pushing it
pushing it pushing it to the point where
now she doesn't even want to tackle it
because it's too much of a big toss
because now instead of just going to the
gym to lose 10 pounds whatever now you
have to go to the gym to be able to walk
first and then from there you can then
joke or speed walking and jogging and
run because you've been neglecting it
for so long so I personally I feel like
that's basically what's going on people
just don't want to deal with their
issues and they want to blame other
people for not wanting to deal with
their issues do you think as women we're
honest to each other no I don't
completely think so either yeah
we're not friends of each other what
about you um I would partially agree to
it yeah no that we're not honest to eat
with each other yeah 100 how do you
think women like each other yeah
I mean not everyone but yeah just do you
like me
[Laughter]
all the people that you call friends how
many of them have you spoken about
behind their back
oh shoot
if I say something about behind one of
my boys back it's something that I have
or will say to his face but ask yourself
to be honest like how many times have
you talked about that person you call
your friend yeah his girls are more
emotional that's what I'm saying so like
I feel like girls do it in a form of
like venting and then they get it out
and then like we come back down to earth
and we're like okay that's rational
enough to like bring it up to her we're
a man I think men are just more like
rooted in logic yeah but then if you
find out that your emotional friends
that x y and said about you when she was
conventing yeah I don't know I like as
girls like you kind of know like your
friends are gonna talk about you a
little bit yeah and I I just don't get
mad because I'm like okay if she's
venting and then if it's a big enough
problem they'll bring it to you I don't
know if you guys feel the same way but
no I do go ahead for me when I do vent
the only person I've been to is my
brother because I know that he's a guy
he's not gonna go say anything but
I I analyze when females vent to me from
like if you're gonna say that about that
person you say that's your best friend
you say yeah
then what are you saying about me and
and it no just how I am in like the
relationship with them
no I think the same thing like
especially if they're like yeah she told
me not to tell anyone this but I'm
telling you I'm like that that line that
is the last
time I share anything ever
well for me it's because when I was in
sixth form
um well I I became really good friends
with this girl
um we became best friends we're still
best friends to this day so um having a
female best friend which is I advocate
for everyone to have a really close
friend from the opposite sex because it
benefits even more ways than one right
so you think that 100 I got this I got
yeah I think men and women can't be
friends but it's down to how mature you
are as individuals do you find so she if
she tried to sleep with you would you
say no yeah I mean
I'm in a relationship right now so
obviously that's no but
yeah so
so if he wasn't in a relationship you'll
sleep with her I think personally right
from from having a we've been so close
for so long that I now see you as a
sister that's regardless bro if she
tried it on you would you give it to me
maybe let me first we're friends sure no
no
I think it's easier okay okay okay
you're alone she walks in naked you're
not you're
you're gonna say no no you're gonna try
it see next time y'all hang out
it's gonna be because the thing is like
like I said is it's down to the the
individuals themselves right it's not
it's like it's one of those things where
like I can't make a blanket statement of
oatmeal it could be friends with all
females because it's not true it depends
on the female it depends on the male me
and my friend have got to a point where
we now see each other as just family
members rather than friends so I think
for us personally just for our situation
which I know we hate doing we're talking
about
in these situations in the crimes game
but like
it it really comes down to how you guys
communicate with each other and like
yeah because the thing is she knows that
I fancy done with me for when we first
started draw I think like my opinion on
your situation it's uh
you've got to a point with that gold
where you know you don't want to ruin
the Friendship yeah and but I think if
there was she gave you some sort of Hall
Pass where you don't ruin the Friendship
but you can still hit I think you'll
take that bro it isn't maturity knowing
when to do things and know when not to
do things is your girlfriend watching
yeah okay
I'm sure
if women can see their truths I'm going
to say
[Laughter]
but yeah I really do genuinely think
that it's really a thing where like it's
an individual base because
right no I agree with that I think what
I would say is is there a possibility
that in that Dynamic of your friendship
with that female the roles changed and
where it was once upon a time you liked
her the fact that you're still friends
and you're not in a relationship maybe
she likes you
and that's what's holding that
friendship
together no no no next time if you guys
ever invite me on I'll ask you to come
you're gonna you know like January
all right yeah yeah we'll see how she
looks at you
but I I do get that I'm not the norm and
I do think for the most part a lot of
guys are not mature enough to be friends
with a lot of girls and a lot of girls
the same way a lot of girls are just
antonious guys which is something that I
found out in my late years and they
don't tell you that when you I don't
think it's a thing of being mature I
just think it's known exactly who you
are and what you're about I think if you
can be with if you like as you said you
can be friends with her and whatnot if
you feel like you can do that then dude
do it like me personally like I've got I
can probably say I've got like one
female friend that I'm not attracted to
and it's like yeah cool we're cool how
attend what would you rare
like the things she used to be a tomboy
and like and stuff like that in it so it
kind of yeah it's like it's kind of so
what's the rating I'll give it
I'll give you I'll give her a good six
geez yeah can we be a girl that's less
than a six have I beat a girl that's
less than the six uh probably okay so
but but that's what I'm saying that me
I'm not attracted to her in it do you
get me I'm not trying to tell her so I
can be that yeah with friends in it to
get me but if I was attracted to her if
I did think she's sexy and what not that
then I wouldn't
I wouldn't be I wouldn't be friends with
her like that
because I feel like I look at my friend
as good looking to see my look is my
male friends is a good looking girl
Sports
One Two is obviously it's obviously a
little bit different yeah have you ever
checked out her butt
um
we were kids when we met I'm 26 now we
made in trouble so you haven't done that
in the last year no
is your girlfriend's watching yeah
um moving on so um so the first thing
when I'm like listening to the red pill
you learn about is hypergamy
and
at first it really sounds like a girl
only cares about a guy's money but
there's more to it they call it money
muscles and game so if a guy wants to
improve his status basically and like be
more attractive to women he either needs
to get muscles he needs to make money or
he needs to learn game and that's how he
increases his value in the market
um is there anything as a guy you think
I missed
um
foreign
no because money is definitely one of
them yeah my father literally gave me
that talk and that was a weird talk to
her father but I thought that you should
definitely have with your future sons at
some point that don't chase these women
chase the bag and the women will come
that's fine
wow it's me personally I think I think
you need at least two
um yeah these two of those things like
because uh
money obviously is that will pay your
bills but if you've got game and muscles
yeah you ain't got no money yet you can
use gaming muscle to get money but I'm
trying to think is is there like a
fourth one because I feel like that I
feel like it's one of those ones where
like
once you think about it in more depth
like there is definitely well there's
work ethic too but that goes into money
you know ambition when girls say
ambition it's just it just means he can
provide for her later there's money so
yeah I think that three is like yeah I
think they're all kind of synonyms of
those three well and it goes back into
that men have a duty of performance
so men are expendable and success object
and objectified worse than women
because men are the ones that are
expendable as in if there's a war who's
fighting
who does all the hard jobs see this is
why I mess with you this is my message
and at first yeah and at first when I
heard this I kind of was like ah that
doesn't sound nice but there's just a
percentage of men that one are invisible
to women like we just do not see unless
they are successful yeah and if
um
and the in part of the red pill is that
women can't love the way that men love
so we will never understand what it's
like for a man to love because a man can
love a girl that is just like
dead broke doesn't really do much and
like he he will probably and I guess
like men can love multiple women at a
time so maybe an ex-girlfriend that he's
had he still like loves her in a certain
way where girls can only love one guy at
a time
and a girl
um
and if if a guy becomes a bum like she
marries a guy and he he just starts
doing nothing becomes an absolute bum
like most women will leave
it's not I I wouldn't say it's
necessarily a gold digger because it's
not it's not about money like even Rich
guys get cheated on it's about
how do it it's yeah partially power it's
about like like if I married a guy okay
and he was a hard-working ambitious
Driven Man right that's what we're
attracted to so if tomorrow he stops
doing those things I'm not going to be
attracted to him anymore
where a girl could just do nothing and
like the guy is in love with like who
she is yeah yeah and so
um a lot of times when guys find the red
pill they get angry because we just
cannot love the way that they love and
so if guys can't measure up to women's
standards then they they just start to
get angry because they realize they're
going to end up alone and that's where
you get like the red pill rage yeah and
it's and it's hard because when you
start looking into that Red Bull content
like especially for me personally when I
did start looking into red pill content
it was like you start having like
epiphanies and it's like wow okay I
didn't realize that before oh okay I was
you know just chilling with girls and in
my head I was thinking uh that I would
have you know I'll I'll do that but it's
like I'm thinking is that bad thoughts
and whatnot and it's like it's that red
pill tells you no don't suppress that
that's your masculinity said in it
that's just your masculine side and
whatnot and the best thing to do is just
remove yourself from that situation kind
of thing and work on yourself and stuff
like that because
I think before the red pill
a lot of guys do like putting effort
into girls because we we love women look
at me we love women we want to be around
women you know women bring
peace sometimes and um and you know you
want to be around female energy but
I think with
with the feminism movement and all the
things that they've portrayed and
whatnot it's like we love him to a sense
of removing our own masculinity and
stuff like that so when I started
getting into the red pill that's why I
started understanding okay you know I
get it now would you say this because
innately we are taught that masculinity
is kind of bad I think in this day and
age we are yeah because think about it
toxic masculinity is a thing that is
widely said but if you use the words
toxic femininity you're all of a sudden
about a guy all of a sudden you're this
weird guy but if man if masculinity has
toxic traits and how can feminine not
happen you know I I hear toxic
femininity but it's by feminists by
girls that are like calling girls more
traditional toxic which is it's the
crazy thing the phrase doesn't tell the
same way when it goes the other way no
no it's like they just use the toxic
to when it benefits them basically do
you think it's too late for women to be
traditional some I I think after the
development of birth I I don't think it
was feminism and necessarily I think it
was more the development of birth
control and the lack of consequences for
women okay so when before women valued a
guy that was
a provider more
because
I want to say roll out tomorrow I would
like to give Rolo credits A lot of these
ideas are from Rolo but basically when
the birth control pill came out it gave
women the ability to sleep with the guys
that had the genes that they wanted with
no consequence and then still marry the
provider guy later
wow yeah and before that girls couldn't
have access to those guys because the
the consequence was too high they might
get pregnant and he might leave
but now we we have the pill
and so it gets rid of the consequence
and then on top of that if even we can
get married to the provider guy that
we're not attracted to maybe have a
couple kids by him and then get child
support divorce him take half his stuff
and we're chilling
and so it's like we're taking away the
consequences for women in society
and so why would women be better if
there's no incentive to be better and
simps will still date the girl that's
been like ran through by everybody have
you heard the statistic about
um I forgot where it was but it said
basically out of
um all children tested for DNA by the
mother and father about 33 of those kids
on the Dutch yep that's crazy yeah
that's that's great yeah raising kids
that are not theirs one in three yeah
because the girl it's a mating strategy
so the girl got the jeans from the guy
she wanted and the resources from the
guy she that she wasn't as attracted to
um it's wild that's wild there's a lot
of Statistics I think that's I think
that's a guy's worst nightmare yeah
raising a kid that's not his and he
thought that's his and there's no
there's no legal ramification for it
either I think if you trap a guy and you
know that that's not his kid or there's
a possibility it's not his kid yeah and
you let him spend that money I think one
you should pay him double what you took
and two you should you should go to jail
for the amount of time you spend doing
that yeah
in this day and age that kind of Bill it
wouldn't pass oh no not at all this is
just if I ever ran for a vote for parole
I'm not running for anything but if I
ever do
oh
um
so and another interesting stat I found
out one out of three men report no sex
in the last year under the age of 29
report no sex in the last year or that
they're virgins
and so that goes back that is true uh
well I can't speak for me but you know
the stats is it but I believe it's true
it's one of those things where like
again you can't see once you see it you
can't unsee it yeah
like you said like you said earlier when
you were saying how the the funny guy
the the sports guy that all those guys
have seen and there's all those guys in
the middle right think back to uh when
you were like in secondary school time
who was who was pressing pressing things
yeah right it was the popular ones the
knee the the nerdy guys the guys were
inside didn't talk to girls until later
on in their life all right and then by
the time they got to the stage of
talking to girls their pool is really
low because one the unattractive
physically because like let's be let's
be honest why most people who do maths
and Science and those like indoors
things aren't the most attractive people
right so Adam the the
lower the total opponent looks bead are
probably socially awkward to some extent
because they haven't been around that
many people because they have been
indoors grinding on whatever they're
doing all right and all of that adds up
into them just like never speaking to a
female that's either not in the same
field as them or like not in the same
like hobby group or stuff yeah because
where else is he going to find a female
if they're not in like the in at work or
at the places that he likes to go to
because
what girls got into a let's say he's
really nerd what go what eight out of
ten nine out of ten is going to like a
comic book store like or like Comic-Con
or one of those like laughing
conventions not many
[Music]
but that's what makes it hard isn't it
that's what makes it hard for those guys
and those guys do I feel like yeah they
do build up the majority of men and
those like one in a million kind of guys
are the ones that girls are usually
chasing you know twitch and another and
this isn't just now it's actually
historically 8 000 years ago guess how
many women reproduced for every one man
guess how so so for every girl that
reproduced like for every one guy that
reproduced guess how many girls
reproduced for him
I don't even want to know
10 10 to one okay what do you think I'll
probably like eight eight
should I say ten ten yeah same I'm
thinking a little bit higher because
I do know
Genghis Khan like a lot of people that
are living oh yeah
like in Asian artist you know I'm gonna
take I'm gonna take a shot in the dark
and go 1-25. you're closest
um 17 women reproduced for every one man
eight thousand years ago yeah
Genghis Khan did have a lot of her kids
like a lot of people in Asia are
descendants of wasn't that like partly
to do with like mortality partly to do
with finding the best quote-unquote male
to pass on the genes and it's just a
bunch of things added together well yeah
I mean I I'd imagine when you have to
protect women in order to reproduce with
them there's only a small percentage of
men that can do it and the ones that can
if I had to guess I didn't actually see
it the number so I don't know how it
divides but I bet there's a small
percentage that had like a stupid amount
of concubines yeah where maybe the rest
it was like less if I had to guess yeah
I can see that I can see uh didn't Henry
the effort it was
yes yeah
and that's just some reason we're not
even going back I feel like that's the
same nowadays it's just not I've seen as
much in the states I think in um in Utah
they taped a show called Sister Wives
and it was
um in the Mormon Community I don't know
if everybody in the Mormon community
participates in this but they believe in
having multiple wives well the ones that
were on the show and they had their own
little houses they had their own little
Community each man had like two or three
wives and then they would talk about
bringing on another one and so I I can
understand it it's crazy to think that
but
um it's still happening nowadays and
it's would you guys ever be open to
having having a sister away no no what
if it was between that or being homeless
would you do it yes
spare change
I would do it if it was over being
homeless if I had to share dude or be
homeless I would pick sister wife no see
it for me like I told you in issue uh
was it yesterday or the day before it is
I've been homeless before so I'm just
like I can get out of that situation I
wouldn't I wouldn't want to be a sister
wife I know that I wouldn't be I'd be
happier homeless and by myself than
being a sister wife yeah true so it just
sounds so miserable though it sounds
amazing do you think so
yes because I don't know for me for how
long
it's a fun game yeah
oh forever yeah I'm not talking you
can't get out of it two years in yeah I
think I can get out of home I can't get
out of homelessness this isn't a caveat
question it's homeless it's like this is
women
that's not the question I asked I said
you're homeless are you good to be in a
house with sister alive if I could never
get out of it and then I would I'll
settle for being a sister one
the first one I'm gonna be the main one
no you're second
I'ma have a side piece as well
this is the questions
this isn't the question
[Laughter]
I really don't think that could ever
work because I remember watching a video
um for like uh brother husbands or
whatever you just said I watched a video
of this girl she was with a dude and
then she was talking to her main guy I
couldn't remember if it was her husband
or not and they were talking about
adding another dude and then they added
on two more and they're sitting there
she's pregnant and they're like who's
the baby father and they're just all
sitting there they look miserable if you
ever get a chance
yes yeah but that's the other way around
yeah that's what I'm saying that doesn't
go with nature one woman having many men
yeah it's just like with um the one guy
having multiple wives that goes with
nature more yeah I'm not saying I would
pick it over homeless I wouldn't really
pick that
but but I I do think
I I think one mom and one dad is the
most conducive for families but I do
think girls can share a guy better than
men can share a woman yeah yeah
we're doing it anyway we're doing it
anyway
unfortunately I don't think any guy in
his right mind will want to show his
woman because that's actually a good
point because if you think about it
right if if you're a guy and you find
your and you you find out one of your
friends to step up the Goyo scene you
look at your goal with if you're a girl
and you find out a girl what's up with
the guy who's seeing yeah you look at
your friend weird yeah yeah
the guy in question yeah just wait how
many how many times do side chicks fight
oh
but you know you never see side dudes
fighting like that
they both left
they're like okay on to the next one
which so that's also
um a red pill truth is that
different than with women yeah so when a
guy cheats like like women if she's
cheating on you she's leaving like she
doesn't really want to be with you or
she's just she's already left yeah like
mentally or she's just with you for your
resources but if a dude like I I
I was shocked when
I realized I had to worry about ugly
girls too
and it's because
and it's because it's because men cheat
differently like they can have sex with
another girl and it's like a handshake
I've had guys describe it to be like a
handshake that's crazy
like I I wouldn't Champion it but I can
see a way
I mean it's just natural in it it's just
natural because when a guy has sex black
men don't cheat yeah
when a guy have sex oh God it's not it's
not emotionally connected I'm not making
an emotional bond with you when I'm
having sex with you it's like that's odd
I've heard I've heard men say that they
slept with a girl and she was just
better than their hand yeah oh
[Laughter]
yeah yeah sometimes the streets get
rough sometimes sometimes you just need
a like an escape like yeah she was just
there yeah
it's because it's true like everyone's
at least
it's definitely on that right none of
that are you retired from the game
what's that
um
guys guys
[Laughter]
but when I first heard that I was like
what no they can't feel nothing when
they but it's kind of just a red pill
truth or like sex is just different for
men and for women yeah I mean you have
to obviously you have to Sweet her you
have to that make her feel nice because
no one like no girl is just gonna give
up if we're being absolutely rude
like as a man yeah and it depends on
yeah so you have the kind of life in
anywhere kind of have to sweet talk her
and whatnot like so she can feel
comfortable but once it's done
huh are you using women for sex am I
using women for sex uh I think we're
both using each other
can I add a question to on the back of
your one if he says yes to that could we
admit that you're you're probably using
the guy for money or we're just going to
play this game like no one's using
anyone for anything
right okay fair enough I will uh
agree with what you said about how it
all depends on what you if you sweet
talking sweet talk in a girl and um
she'll have sex with you I have a friend
who she didn't find the guy attractive
at all but I don't know what he said to
her like how he acted towards her but
she was like it's just a it's just that
need to be scratched and I'm just like
how if you don't find him attractive how
are you able to
sleep with him and when you said that it
was just like oh wow because because you
could be ugly as I mean I don't think
I'm the most beautiful man in the world
but thing was it like I can make it up
with other things whether I've got money
whether I've Got Game you know without
not to talk to a girl if you know how to
talk to a girl you know you bypass a lot
of things yeah like you know so it's
like men fall in love with what they see
where women fall in love with what they
hear we all know that guy that's why I
meant like and women wear makeup yeah
I mean we all know that that
unattractive guy that's just like
pulling dimes he's left and right you're
like wow
but some some guys grow on to you though
I've felt like there's this one guy I
was um it was at my old uni and at first
me and some of my friends were like nah
he is ugly like he's just saw it and
then I got to know him and I was like
okay so you're kind of cute you're kind
of cute now so that's not a game yeah
yeah it was like his personality like
took him
over the top yeah
and the other thing that was a red pill
truth is that women are more attracted
to men when they cheat
you ever yeah you ever okay and I know
you guys you guys are looking at me
crazy okay okay how many girls do you
know that have been cheated on and went
back yeah multiple I'm like like it
doesn't matter he could cheat a million
times he's gonna cheat a million more
she's not leaving it's because we can't
undo our biology now we don't we don't
enjoy being cheated on
but we can't help we're attracted to it
because that's a sign of pre-selection
so if a man can get other girls that
that's validating our choice because
historically a man that could get a lot
of women
um it signaled that he could take care
of us
and yeah look at Justin's face
and so it's not I don't I don't enjoy
this but
I mean we were saying that earlier the
truth hurts and the truth is you know a
bittersweet it's like a bit of pills
I do have a question when it did all of
like this red pill information like come
about or like a rise to the surface
um well I
who would you guys say is the father of
the manosphere in my opinion I I think
Rolo tomasi best puts together the ideas
I think Kevin Samuels communicated them
the best and had the biggest like impact
and reach but a lot of those ideas I've
seen like Rollo tomasi's work is the
furthest dated I've heard there's
someone before rollout that he kind of
built his ideas off of yeah I I first
heard it from like um my first person
that I saw red pill in people was Kevin
Samuels and um and then when I did my
research I found out about Rolo tomasi
as well and I did some research and I
kind of and I read his book to be honest
and the thing was it and it's a good
book and really information and uh who
else I think fresh and fit because
they've you know yeah they kind of like
bring all the goals and stuff and have
that that conversation level and suffer
so after fresher fit it was Sarah gavi
because I actually wanted to like see
what the UK people got and Freestar
agave
[Laughter]
so that was my kind of like red pill
Journey so it's like Kevin Samuels went
back to roll old and fresher fit and
Sarah them
and and the the comments are saying
Patrice O'Neill um I've never watched
Audrey Sonia okay I think that's what
happened Tom Tom lycus oh someone
commented about Patrice O'Neal yeah
that's the that's what the chat is
saying because if you go back and listen
to his jokes they're hilarious but
there's so much truth behind it a lot of
what he's saying and it like resonates
even to this day and it's like oh he was
making a joke but damn that does happen
oh damn I don't think people do that
but I think a lot of red pool were said
through jokes yeah like previously but
you know you know what my first rock
used to do it there was a point where it
turned right and uh
like in cells and those those like
really really far off the edge guys kind
of quote Truth Hurts yeah it's men too
yeah it's fun too and someone can't take
it and so one thing I learned from Rolo
tomasi is I wish I'm gonna be honest
guys I don't know how to flash a graph
on the screen
um while we're live I haven't figured it
out yet I wish I wish I could but Rolo
tomasi has a chart that goes through
um they call it do you know what sexual
market value is you guys know what that
is it's it's basically like your value
in the marketplace
so men are judged by money muscle's game
frame women are judged by fertility
Youth and Beauty basically
and
something that I found out about was the
wall have you ever heard of that
don't anyone talk about it
um Okay so
our as women our primary agency is our
sexuality and how good we look that's
why you see whenever there's a political
protest what do women do
they take off their clothes yeah they
get they always get naked because that's
the one way to get men's attention so if
you want to get
powerful men's attention like women use
their beauty to get there
so
we live to be like 90s like odds are
we'll all live to be 90 but our our Peak
like the way we look is is between the
ages of 18 and 28 the best men between
yeah men between the ages of 20 to 70
rate 22 23 and 24 year olds as the most
attractive
um and so at about 28 it's not age but
it's a mindset it is a subconscious
acknowledgment that we cannot compete in
the same way we did when we were younger
so at about 28 29 mentally We compare
where we were at 18 and just realized
that we were like we weren't as hot as
we aren't as hot as we were
um
if you if you send me the graph I can
put it on oh really okay okay it's kind
of like it's kind of like the sports the
sports player Theory like how many does
anyone play these baseball
it's going to be a point when you get to
like 40 because you might have had it
when you were you might I had it when
you were a kid but then you grow up and
then you you can't you can't exercise
anymore and you lose it and then you
think you still have it but you get on
the court and there's this young kid
the old heads
your ass yeah there's a circle of life
happens in Lions happens to spoils
happens literally but I think you know
what was painful I think
um
the older women get
I think they don't like educating the
younger women and telling them about
Clues only if they're single if the
older women are single they look at them
as competition yeah that's true mothers
will tell you that's true see like
because that's how I feel like how can
women not know about the war but
I think it does go to what you're saying
like only if they're single because
probably they've hit the one they're
trying they're still trying to compete
with the younger women and you know it's
hard well it's a cope that's why you see
these girls on tick tock
I'm just as hot as I was years ago like
being single and childless and 35 is the
best time to date like ages fat phobic
it's everyone trying to justify where
they're at yeah did you guys see the
video
um Abram preach made a video a while
back about this 50 year old model
and she made like a she wrote like a
piece right and she was literally if you
couldn't read it it's her complaining
about guys not finding her as attractive
at 50 as they did when she was 21
22 years old she's like I walk into a
place and no one turns around like they
used to and it's like uh yeah you might
still be attractive for a 50 year old
yeah she's the one from what and she
built a career off of her life yeah
exactly and now now it's a problem now
it's a problem you weren't complaining
when they were picking you over the old
old women you were the young woman that
the old woman complained about at some
point but I think with that then it's
like for them especially when she was
talking about that it's a harder
transition I guess you could say because
you know she's so used to that attention
from her looks and now she's not
obviously she's not used to getting that
so she's like she doesn't know how to
cope with that and try to understand
like it's not how it used to be yeah
wow if it's 20 22. yeah there you go so
can we
is there a way we can put that on the
other monitor so they can see it
yeah yes um we're gonna show you guys
the Rolo tomasi's famous chart I don't
even want to see it basically so it
shows
um basically when men and women hit
their peak in terms of sexual market
value so when the most people want them
from the opposite gender the audience
should be able to see a home yeah let me
know if you can I can show it on my
laptop around this hair
uh so you can try to pass it around yeah
um everyone at home can see it
okay yeah
seems about right yeah so so that is
where um
[Music]
so you see how much it drops at 30
because it's because men are attracted
to fertility so at 30 or 40 or 90 of our
eggs are gone I'm a little hurt but I'm
completely hurts
um so Paul when you get the chance could
you just talk us through the chart
um
um so basically this is Rolo tomasi made
a chart talking about
when men are the most attractive and
when women are the most attractive so
they surveyed men between the ages of 20
and 70 and they found that women at the
age of like 22 to 24 the most sexually
desirable
so
and they surveyed and it's based off of
like dating app data and just he said
that he made this chart without any data
just based on like common sense and then
over time like the data came to him and
it basically
fit what he originally predicted but at
the age of about 27 28 girls realized
that oh [__] my agency is is going away
fast because we stopped producing
collagen in our skin around 25. so yeah
so and it's different it's different for
every girl so I mean some girls are in
better shape so maybe their wall comes
at like 32.33 so so
some some girls are in worse shape so
maybe their wall comes at 25 24. but the
point is girls realize we can't compete
in the sexual Marketplace the same way
we used to so it's basically find a man
fast and the guys and basically before
the age of 27 28 women were looking for
the alpha guy the best jeans the hot guy
at the phone foam Cannon party is what
Rolo uses to describe it so basically
like the guy that's tall handsome like
best jeans but maybe not the best
long-term provider maybe he can't keep a
job maybe he he wouldn't be a good dad
maybe he's a cheater whatever whatever
it is and then at 27 28 our brain starts
to change because we realize that oh
[__] I need to get a guy that's gonna
stick around so we'll pick a guy
based on long-term security but the
problem is we're not as physically
attracted to that guy at times so what
girls will do is they will
marry the long-term security guy but
still sleep with the other guy with the
good genes
and men's Peak is around 35 but the
reason you see people get married around
28 29 is because that's where the charts
cross so if you see right here yeah that
that's where you see people get married
because their sexual market value is
about the same okay nice
um and it's funny that the female where
they do cross the female sexual value is
going down and the man's sexual value is
starting to steady go up steadily go up
if if a guy fulfills his burden of
performance I will say I don't think
most men's sexual market value goes up
the majority I I would say don't
but for for some men yeah
and one of my friends was boating when a
few of my friends are building early but
he's in he's been in a long time
long-term relationship for a long time
so what was that they were Bolding
what's Bolding bold oh boy
he was building and it's one of the
things where he was quite self-conscious
about it but he was been in a long-term
relationship for a long time and they're
still together I think they'll probably
get married but there's other guys that
I know who's also building
uh
it's just about to remember call lines
here because it's true not everyone
hates that because everyone wants to
grind but not everyone hits the stride
that they want to and this life happens
in a
sometimes it takes you away sometimes
and it's also women prefer men five to
seven years older um
yeah yeah because we we like a guy that
we can look up to it goes back to the
hypergamy thing but the thing that
basically throws everything off okay is
social media so and I want to say it's
like around 2010 when social media
don't roast me in the chat if that's
wrong I don't remember who went I I feel
like it was when I was in around 8th
grade well when social media kind of
like yeah when it took off yeah I think
you're right okay
sometimes they'd be roasting me I'm like
I'm doing my best
um so when that happened women's rate of
depression like skyrocketed and because
I think women is women We compare to
each other more and a lot of times we do
that in relationships and you see the
rate of
um
like you you see it increase in women
leaving so basically grass is greener on
the other side
and
because social media has kind of made
the world smaller yeah you know like you
can be from London and you see a girl
from New York or whatever and if you've
got the money you can fly over to get me
so and it made girls think that we're
hotter than we are because I I I once I
saw this I couldn't unsee it because I
started to like objectively like rate
people one to ten and Kevin Samuels had
a scale that's like five sixes normal
looking is five six is cute seven you
can't use eight nine or ten is you could
get a modeling contract modeling people
chase you down like like you walk down
the street someone might offer you a
contract if you're in a big city
something like that and I would start to
like objectively like look at the guys
and look at the girls and look at the
girl the guys that the girls were
rejecting and a lot of times I'm like
just based off of facial symmetry I
would say that she
is less attractive than him and she's
still rejecting him
and you see
the the everything
a smaller and smaller and smaller
percentage of men sleeping with more and
more of the girls and a rising number of
men not having sex after the development
of social media because basically women
keep wanting to date up and up and up
and up and then on top of that there's a
rising growing number of single
childless women
and and so
50 I think I want to say it's over 50 of
women over 30 are single and childless
and it's growing it's getting bigger and
bigger and bigger because women don't
want to settle they'd rather be alone
than settle for a guy that they view as
average but they shouldn't the only
reason they view him as average is
because they've been sleeping with guys
out of their league
because those guys would sleep with her
but they'd never wipe her so do you
think if there was a no social media
that settling wouldn't be like as
prevalent as it is today yeah yeah
because you wouldn't know you wouldn't
really know what you're missing out on
yeah yeah there was wasn't there like a
study or something about how before
social media you only really know like a
thousand people and all those thousand
people get ranks downwards right so like
um it's something like 600 or
acquaintances 100 of people that you
call friends or that out that 150 you
cool close friends or that 50 15 people
or you're in a circle and out of 15 it's
like two people three people they're
like you're real friends but with social
media
people are having hundreds of thousands
of subscribers geez my life
if you have like a bunch of followers
and you're following a bunch of people
you can have like you could talk into a
million people and like for real you
don't know these people there's no way
for you to remember happy face so like
you're just it's like a it's like Tinder
but like no in terms of when I say it's
to like tennis like you know how there's
never really an end well that's that's
like Instagram is the biggest date yeah
yeah it's the number one way people meet
each other is online so of course it's
going to influence dating yeah
because like as as women when we
when we get a certain type of guy if we
don't marry someone on that little level
we will feel like we settled yeah
and so that's that's what something that
manosphere they call an alpha Widow an
alpha window yeah so
basically okay have you ever seen girls
they always have that one X that they
can't get over yeah they could date the
next guy the next guy they could date
like the nicest guy in the world he
might have more going for him but they
can't get that last guy out of their
head yeah that's an alpha Widow
basically that girl sees that guy as the
best that she can do okay and anything
past him like she she can't get in her
head better and what what better it is
is it differs from girl to girl but that
guy had something that she can't replace
um
because and I want to say Rolo says it's
because and tell me if I'm butchering
this in the chat but
back in the the tribal days
um the basically the men would fight and
the winner would take the girl so you
would only get with the best guy because
like if not he would get killed and you
would get the best guy basically yeah
don't do that now
what don't tears do that
I I don't know they just do that like
the metals fire over the female whoever
wins the fight gets the female I know
Lions do that I know Lions will go into
a pride and um kill the males kill all
the Melt or kill all the Cubs or
children that build had with any of the
females and then start his own crazy
yeah but that's why women move on this
is something men don't really understand
because
when I got and you guys can tell me if
I'm wrong on this but from what I
understand if a guy like loves a girl
there's always going to be a part of him
even if they break up they will always
like love her in some way yeah yeah yeah
and he'll put it we call it have love
for her yeah yeah but but women we're
we're gone three months at least before
we left the relationship mentally like
and so men will be like what she has a
new boyfriend already yeah and we're
like we mentally broke up with you three
months ago did you not see the signs
[Laughter]
I mean we went out the other day yeah if
I asked you you were good and you said
you were good
[Laughter]
I think but that's not going to do
because I have to talk about my
girlfriend all the time it's like we
should not go into you
how is it mindful that I can't read your
your mind how is it my fault that you
can't verbalize what you want from me
and now I have to go through Reading
cues and and figuring I'm not I'm not
Sherlock Holmes right I I didn't get in
this relationship to be a detective I am
not training to be a detective I don't
work in the police force none of my
family or detective so why do I have to
be one in order to understand because
think about it when your partner with
your exes
when he's upset you know because you can
just tell he will ever act really angry
and then be like I'm not in the mood or
you can just tell the Vibes change but
with a girl if her vibe changes and I
call her out on a Vibe change how guys
in the room how many times has that
started an argument that I've noticed
that you're angry
me noticing that you're upset has got
you upset why
right but I also have to know is that
you're upset but when I do know is that
you're upset you get more upset
it's the catch 22. yeah I think yeah
that's what that's about what it's a
catch-22 with Joel's like I don't know
man I don't know how yeah I don't know
either I don't know
too complicated to understand we don't
even understand that's part of the red
that's part of the red pill too is
understanding that would be crazy yeah
yeah because we're chemically different
every single day
and so we kind of a guy that's
constantly like reacting to the girl it
makes us mad because we're like you
don't see that we're crazy like no
because we looked at you guys for for
guidance and like to decipher you know
what I mean and so a guy that's
constantly like what's wrong are you
okay no no I'm like
like let me you know let me chill for us
first it doesn't make sense but I the
girls understand yeah
and it always like complaining about
communication yeah
women don't we don't know what we want
so it's the best thing not to call it
out and just to modify your behavior
they don't call it out they still get
upset yeah because they call it out they
didn't see that they were upset at that
moment like how can you not see that I'm
upset I'm not talking to you I'm sitting
over here my face is pouting but you
don't call it out it's like well last
time I called it out you got upset
the best advice that I've heard and I
hate I hate that this is good advice but
to treat women like children so if
they're having a temper tantrum oh that
would be so bad
I like that they're having a temper
tantrum to ignore it what happens when a
child having a temper tantrum what
happens when you give them more
attention
yeah they keep going what happens yeah
with my dog what happens when we go in
there and like
barks even more yeah and what happens
when you leave her alone she stops and
she comes down at some point you have to
stop yeah I'm not I'm not saying this
and I like I keep seeing in the chat
that I keep I keep seeing in the chat
that we're making
we're making excuses for like we're
using history to excuse bad behavior and
guys I'm not excusing bad behavior I'm
just explaining it so you get don't
shoot the messenger here to understand
the future you have to understand the
past yeah
um
I feel like I feel like Ellie knew I was
talking about him
um okay so that but that kind of ties
into body count
and so now we hear this we hear [__]
shaming right and this is why like older
women give younger women such bad advice
so this is this is a red pill moment
what is your chance of a happy marriage
as a virgin and they
I want to say they measured this by they
either surveyed them or it's like the
length of the marriage so I think it
I wish I could remember off the top of
my head
um oh it's it's having a marriage of
five years or more what is your chance
of that as a virgin if you get married
what do you think
wait say that one more time okay if
you're a virgin when you get married
what is your chance of 10 years later
having a happy marriage
I feel like it's it's really low because
whoever's the ver like the I this is
just like a thought though okay if
somebody thinks like
they're a virgin and they only slept
with one person I feel like they're
going to want to venture out because
they've only experienced one person the
entire time that's not necessarily for
everybody but I would just think they
would wanna that happens sometimes yeah
um from my knowledge if the woman
is a version I would say the marriage
would last longer because of what I know
about the body count yeah from women to
men and if the man's aversion I think
that the marriage won't last as long
okay what about the both if they're both
versions
I guess it's lost I think it would last
all depends on like their
upbringing I think if they were like
innocence brought up in the church I
think it will last because they're both
virgins got married all that good jazz
but I think if they're
I don't say not I think it'll be a
little bit different okay what about you
I believe that if women
I guess it would
love if
the the percentage of a woman having a
happy marriage is 80 as a virgin
wow and I will say the highest
percentage is when they're both virgins
so I know that I know the nanosphere
doesn't like to acknowledge this but but
if a girl's had more than five partners
it drops down to 30 percent oh
where where men it increases a little
bit at like nine or seven to nine
Partners their marital happiness goes up
wow like I the guys it remains a lot
more stagnant throughout like they sleep
with more people it doesn't really
change their marital happiness I think
that goes into the whole you know when
guys have sex they're not emotionally
tied into the sex so
um if a guy's uh getting his body count
up and he and his head knows that I'm
not taking any of these skills seriously
like when he does meet a girl that he
wants to say seriously there'll be that
you know extra effort 100 so so so then
it will be you know it would make sense
if it lasts longer and the guy's body
chart as well I'm not going to disclose
my body count but it's all right it's up
there right yeah but like like I said
I'm retired but I'm retired for a reason
because you find someone that you find
someone that you understand in front of
it well I think men learned a little bit
more about female like they know know
how to deal with girls better when they
sleep with more people I I do think
there's a level of Purity you really
can't get back and I I do think like the
ideal is of Virgin but we're also in a
world where most women aren't virgins so
um
the
I will say one thing actually
um when I was like when I had my first
my first partner like I didn't know
anything different
um so like the idea of like wanting to
venture out was never something that I
wanted to do because I knew no better
this was all I knew it was only when I
moved on to the second part it was like
okay this is different okay and then
moving from there it was like okay now I
understand how things differ but like
the first person you're with you're like
you don't really know any better so
everything's gonna the norm well I think
that's why the highest rate of marriage
is between two virgins but because you
know there's a level of Innocence you
really can't get back yeah but
on top of that their higher body count
is linked to depression for women
and
women married in their mid-20s where
they haven't lived with a guy before as
they have the lowest rate of divorce
um
wait wait wait
in the mid-20s who haven't lived with
anyone so the lowest for divorce yeah
wow that's one that actually surprises
me yeah you think that you think it
would be higher I thought it would be
higher because I thought it would be one
of those things where like again grass
is greener and if you haven't lived with
a gun you live with a guy and all of a
sudden you now realize that living with
a guy obviously has a downfalls but
messy creatures yeah but I think you
also if a girl's lived with a guy she's
probably lived with other guys yeah so
it's more more to compare it to but
that's that's the problem with women
when we when we sleep with more people
we we compare them and that's why you
you see girls when they're younger
they're like oh I just hope he's cute
and by the time they're 36 6 feet 6
inches six figures
and when they're when they're 18 they're
like oh I just hope he's cute enough and
it's true because when I get when I get
people on my show the I've just noticed
it assuming they're not in the super
like I know the girls that they bring on
like fresh and fit and stuff or have a
lot of Standards but I've just noticed
if if they're younger they just the list
is shorter yeah I think that's because
they haven't explored much yet as well I
don't know what's out there yeah I don't
know what's out there but we're we're we
compare that's why social media affects
us so much and so we we compare the guys
too because there's a little theory that
I'm thinking of right and it's like wow
because um you know it goes back to the
whole guys a logical girls uh the thing
with emotion so guys for the most part
well not for the most part a lot of guys
will have the quote-unquote whole face
but that's just the thing that that kind
of happens right you go the whole phrase
is it well for a lot of the guys that I
know is when you go from
not as attractive to the populace to an
increase in attractiveness and now you
want to venture in how far you can go
with this increase attractiveness in the
field so you kind of just keep going
right
you kind of just keep going you're
trying to see oh can I push even more oh
can I talk to disco are you in a club oh
am I hot enough to talk to her do I have
enough games to talk to her oh yes okay
cool we're going back to mine okay cool
and it's like it really is again yeah
one thing I will say is not a lot of
guys do that yeah that more than you
think no it's less than you think really
well one one in three men under 30 are
virtually oh yeah yeah and most guys are
invisible with that yeah so you might
find the people in your circle are doing
that and the people around you are able
to do that but a lot of guys can't do
what you're saying you're a basketball
player as well yeah I mean I'm in the
fields but but that's also that's
awesome
[Laughter]
but
that's also because men their their smv
goes up later in life as I showed you
guys with the graph so when you see guys
get like a midlife crisis
have you ever have you ever heard of
that term midlife crisis yeah that's men
thinking oh [__] this is what it's like
to get female attention let me let me go
buy the sports car let me go because we
get that from from the job I mean I
don't know how old you guys were the
first time guys started hitting on you
but I remember being like 15 and I was
like
wait what this is like a whole different
world and and and but that that doesn't
happen to guys and that's so normal to
us
and so when it happens for guys later
they they kind of as he said they go
wild because you have to ask the guys
the same question when was the first
time you ever got hit on by a girl yeah
I'm 26 now so it was about
24. I mean it doesn't it doesn't happen
that much it doesn't get hit on bike oh
like
because the thing is yeah the thing is
with girls girls
black if they hit on you they're not
going to
directly hit on your way Jonathan it's
not like how I would come up to be like
oh you're watching did you get me like
it's not gonna be direct it'll she'll
kind of like
give you a leeway for you to hit for
YouTube
it was one of those ones where um they
were like I moved to guys all the time
yeah and I was like okay cool how many
times have you all your friends walked
up to the guy and started a conversation
and kept it going
um well
um I don't actually do that but I have
moved to guys before it's like so moving
to guys for girls is like is showing
them that you're there I'm available to
me for YouTube to me I have a question
for the women when did you realize like
dudes starting to hit on you
mine was probably
maybe like 16 17. I had to get a glow up
a little bit so you know
yeah I would say 17 as well 17 18. like
15 16. okay guys for me it was like 18
19 it wasn't until I got until like my
first and second year of college yeah
yeah I was a tomboy all throughout my
life yeah
it well I'm trying to think so that was
when creepy guys started to hit on me
15. it wasn't guys I liked it it had a
meeting it was what we call in the UK
nonsense
[Laughter]
um
so then the next and people will argue
whether or not this is red pill but the
next red pill moment that I had was that
the pay Gap doesn't exist it doesn't
exist yeah okay so yeah so and that
women arguably have more power in
society than men
we talked about this last time so I
think when you put the statistics up I
was like well when you put it like that
that is very true so yeah I don't think
um there is a pay Gap
it's really weird it's like some of the
stuff they leave out it's just like how
can you leave that out and have a
genuine honest I think they do it to get
money out of it like feminists I think
they they use the pay Gap to get money
there's no way they can be
putting that stat on such a big platform
like if I even say one stat that's a
little off I get common after common
after comment telling me where I went
wrong so I don't know how I don't know
how yeah usually they don't really talk
about the why I said they don't really
talk about the white maybe it is because
of the money
um I think I remember watching uh
Jordan Peterson and and he was talking
to a woman about and she was she wanted
them to acknowledge that it's there
wasn't the one or the brunette one uh it
was channel four oh oh yeah that's the
that's the one we watched yes the first
one is second one the Kathy Newman Kathy
Newman and I think it was a thing of
what he was trying to say yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so I think it's a thing of they want
people to just be like oh it's there and
that's the problem is that like
after but then obviously he Jordan
Peterson was talking about you have to
talk about why if there's always a why
do you understand so nothing happens
because it just happens yeah like you
have to understand why and the mass
behind yeah because basically like they
don't take into account when they when
they do the pay Gap all they did was
divide how much how many women there are
based on how much the average they just
took the average of how much women make
and at the average of how much men make
put them together and said oh there's a
gap it must be discrimination but what
they didn't talk about was who works
longer hours what jobs do they pick are
there personality traits that that
increase that make it harder for women
to make more money and so one of those
is the trade agreeableness so it women
sixty percent of women have never asked
for a raise
and they'll quit their job before they
ask for a raise
um
so the trade agreeableness is basically
like your ability I think Jordan
Peterson says it means you're kind
caring compassionate and polite and
those people work better with people but
they don't ask for raises and they don't
take control of situations as well it's
kind of like I always say on a
basketball team the bitchiest girl is
always the captain
because she's always the one that's
going to take charge yeah and that's and
that's a really good trait to make money
yeah and and men tend to do that more on
a law of averages okay so between that
they work longer hours they pick harder
jobs of course they're going to make
more money um and it's funny because
you see women complaining about the pay
Gap but they never talk about the gap
um and Between Women make more money and
modeling where's the equality
um
I work in construction I'm a chronic
surveyor and I'm also studying and when
I tell you in a class full of like a
hundred people I can assure you there's
about eight girls
in the entire class right and I think
that's pushing it it may be like nine
maybe six but like there's not many and
what I do makes a lot of money yeah and
it's like okay if I know that right and
these girls who are in this room know
that and it's a thing when everyone
knows that once you get qualified from
this once I get charted my pay raise
basically doubles if I want to if I want
to go other places right because I'm
basically I've become a specialist but
it's like if you're not putting the work
to become that Specialist or become that
person that is sought after value-wise
monetarily wise
then how can you say that you deserve
the money because it's like all right if
I put in
six extra hours in a week than you do
how many more hours does it add up
between a month how many more hours does
that add up to in six months yeah and
then two years we'll never catch up
never catch up
and there's also the problem where they
can't keep women over a certain age
um Jordan Peterson talks about how there
were lawyers in Canada like high paying
professional lawyers and over it was
like 30 to 35 they couldn't pay these
women to stay because they said okay I
have more money that I know what to do
with I want to go spend time with my
family they can't pay to keep them
[Music]
and that goes into the personal choices
females females really in that they want
to be around family and if they can you
know take time off to be to have a
family and it's not the weirdest thing
about the the
um wage Gap thing they don't even take
into account how it's worked yeah
like we can be in the same job but I
have a 40 hour a week contract and you
have a third Year OB contract and they
won't even take into account the 10
hours the contracted difference between
you guys they would just say that oh you
made me money then I made more money
than you and you're on the same position
how dare I it's like um you work four
days a week I work five
yeah of course I'm gonna get paid more
than you why would I not pay you again
and once you start to see this you start
to realize that everything in society is
female Centric because women make 70 to
80 percent of consumer buying decisions
so every scene everything we see in the
media is geared towards women
so think about it do do men want to see
fat chicks on the cover of magazines
Sports magazines yeah do they want do
they want to see Ashley Graham
uh Playboy I don't know
I think it was I think it was I think it
was a Sports Illustration
one is one but like this was like
Playboy's last attempt to like be back
in like the mainstream and I think they
got I think it was James Charles
I'm covered with Playboy and I'm like
gee I'm gonna come up
the the gay YouTuber go the makeup the
makeup guy he was like the first boy
yeah Covergirl oh no I think I see I
think I remember because the thing is
let's not get it twisted I rate James
Charles right that person as a human
being is what he does but like there's a
time and place to put certain things
right and that just just isn't it no
because I'm a socialistic it's like I'm
not putting a sweaty Dwayne The Rock
Johnson with his shirt ripped off on the
front of a cooking book because he just
shouldn't be there right yeah like sure
he you can put him there but doesn't
mean you should
that makes sense men are 23 times more
likely to die in the workplace than
women
[Music]
um
but you never see any marches about this
wow people people men get four times
the amount of jail
for the same four times the amount of
sentencing for the same crime than women
I could see that um
yeah
I mean she's broke now but she's not in
jail yeah and that's it the um Australia
uh uh they might do it for perjury crazy
oh really yeah because you know how she
lied about her dogs yeah yeah it is in
Australia I think after the whole thing
went down with the trial I think they're
gonna actually bring him up on the line
to the police about bringing the dogs in
yeah I mean they should I hope so I hope
they do but and even even the me too
movement was that fair believe all women
was that fair
well and imagine imagine if the the
slogan was believe all men
just us laughing here like whenever I
flip something it's never okay like I'll
have girls on this show come on and say
yeah like I hit him but like I've had
girls admit to abuse on this show and I
always think if he came in and admitted
to abuse
but women admit to it all the time even
even cheating if a man's a cheater
everyone tears him down on social media
if a woman cheats admits it look at the
comment section on Tick Tock it'll
always someone has an excuse for well
maybe she wasn't happy maybe this maybe
like but for men they see that video of
the two girls who um
it's an American podcast and he
basically said if you cheat on your wife
you're a bad father
it's like huh
because you're not respecting her the
mother of your child it has nothing to
do nothing to do yeah the child or being
a parent yeah does that mean I'm a
shitty husband maybe but but that
doesn't make me a bad father by any
means by any means yeah I could be there
every single day but just because I
cheat on you doesn't mean that you want
a kid right or they even said MLK oh
yeah yeah
MLK I don't know if he said he was a bad
person he said he was a bad person a bad
father because he died
husband and a bad father yeah yeah but
he was a good person he wasn't a really
good man because he wasn't he wasn't
good to his wife at all times let's flip
it imagine if women talked like they
talked like this about a woman who's
very accomplished I I can't maybe Oprah
I don't I know it's not the same I
couldn't think of one one that was the
equivalent I couldn't think of what but
but Oprah was a bad person because she
cheated on a guy oh David because Oprah
was she admitted that she was like a
side chick for a little bit when she was
younger so what what if they said that
they said oh her accomplishments don't
mean anything because she cheated
it doesn't change yeah
they would go berserk but for some
reason for men it's okay
when I heard Martin Luther King when I
was like wow so when when did they say
he cheated all these years Martin Luther
King been dead now all of a sudden
basically right this is this is again me
putting my tin foil high on
the FBI will um you know how the FBI
would like like watching him all the
time yeah all right so the FBI back in
the time released a report I might be
wrong right again chat
tell me if I'm wrong they released a
report and basically because the FBI
have been tapping their phones and doing
all of that they basically made a report
saying that he's cheating on his wife
and they put it on the news to try and
defame him or like make him look bad in
in the public so it's one of those
things where if do you believe it's true
or do you believe that this is a story
that the FBI put in the news to make you
believe it and now you but even even if
it was true it shouldn't matter
you don't know maybe she knew yeah like
you know and that's true the thing is
there are two black girls
it's like how dare you in a way like the
he is the reason that you are able to be
on that camera and speak your truth
how are you gunning a person who put you
in a situation that you're in right now
because he wasn't 100 a saint let's say
the story is true because he wasn't a
saint to every single person involved
then all of a sudden he's the devil like
now I think obviously I think in
hindsight a lot of people can see like
certain things like for them to I don't
I'm not I don't think they wanted to
counsel Martin Luther King but like for
them to bring that up I think it's just
hindsight and it's just the privilege of
being in this kind of position where we
can talk on mics and stuff like that and
the hindsight it's like you know they
don't really
the appreciate what he's done
trying to see it I'm going to read some
super chats super hot second so
um guys we are saving for new cameras my
goal is to get like eight cameras in
here so all the super chats go towards
getting new cameras I really appreciate
you guys sending money
um
so let's start with David Turner 50
Super Chat thank you so much
I just popped in to say congrats Pearl
on making 100K keep pushing thank you
um I am just Jules two dollars
um Albert retro um boycott Thor love and
thunder and makes a mockery of male
victims of sa uh Manny fresh what do the
ladies think about the fact that white
and Asian women make more on average
than Black and Hispanic men
um barely here I hear a lot of women
talk about how they feel the biggest
problem is that women's feelings do not
equal reality La sir Horton this is one
of the many reasons I consider emotional
weakness now don't get me wrong it is
perfectly fine to show weakness in a
controlled situation but name a
situation where emotion can reach a
better outcome than logic Jay yeah Jess
is looking beautiful as always but baby
girl in green is is blowing my mind
right now Pearl do you think you can
last the whole 24 hours hell yeah I can
last the whole 24 hours
um Z Lorenzo the red pill conversation
has started decade years ago share share
us oh God
Ali Patrice O'Neil bilber and so many
others Kevin Samuels and Rolo just
studied and perfected it tion skull
skull Chen
honesty honestly Patrice was the best
order in regards to Red Pill knowledge
he predicts a lot of the culture we see
now the red pill Community became a
necessity after the word synth became
common
skitzler1123 I normally just lurk but
coming off some cash just to say Jess is
looking fine as ever we see you girl
hsk please get Dad Dania
hijagi on the show and have the red pill
convo she wrote a hit piece like Amber
and Tom Toreno a dating Coach inspired
by tomasi and got him canceled he
shortly took his own life oh that's
really sad
um wooden chair Johnny Depp should have
used me on Amber Heard instead of that
weak bottle plus why do women fight
scene science scenes it says oh why do
you use women use me in fight scenes oh
um hsk
um 20 20 pound Super Chat thank you
appreciate you guys them
okay
um
so
the next red pill moments we did body
count
um
we did
the wall
we did the pay Gap okay the next red
pill
this I don't even know if you know this
dress because I I think the wall is like
where I enter like the pit not the pig
yeah the pay Gap the last one we talked
about I think that's where my knowledge
of the red pill and so I'm I'm a little
so so feminism is and has always been a
hate movement
and it started in 1848 in Seneca Falls
New York the suffrages had 200 men and
100 women in the 1800s to 1920s they
were seen as terrorists planning
assassination assassinations it is a
supremacism the majority of women did
not actually want the right to vote
because it came with being drafted that
is true that the thing is I believe I
agree with the last part not so much the
beginning part so much how can you
disagree with like like the way that
they they viewed that movement back then
yeah I think it has been turned into a
hate group but at the beginning I mean
you could say the same about like Martin
Luther King and Malcolm X can you the
beginning quote-unquote hate group in
certain people's eyes but like I think
so you think if they're planning
assassinations
that doesn't that doesn't that doesn't
put them yeah I mean it puts them as a
as a and it was the majority men led the
suffrages had 200 men yeah they're a
threat right and it was a terrorist
organization but I wouldn't say they
were hate group they become a hate group
they have become a hate group but I
don't think they started originally to
be a hate group so you just like don't
believe them no no I believe it and and
I agree with that with the with how it's
being said but I don't agree with
I think it's just the word hate group I
don't think that's the right word to use
I think why because it's a hate group
now okay and it's and it's ramped up
with third wave so if it's a hate group
now it is ramped up right but it was it
was it basically wanted to give women
more power without the responsibility
yeah yeah so at the cost of that in a
way because if we wanted the power of
being able to vote but we didn't want to
get drafted like the majority of people
throughout history didn't get the right
to vote because you had to own land yeah
how is it
I'm trying to understand like how is it
how would you consider it a hate group
now but not back then and they're
consider their
uh what did they say about
assassinations
terrorists they said if they were alive
today they would have been seen the way
that
um people see antifa I'm 100 yeah
but I don't I also thought it wouldn't
be weird because it's weird because um
I think the way my mind works is they
they there was at least at the beginning
a fight now the fight is just the fight
the fight the fight that they're having
now is just the fight to have a fight
because there is nothing that you don't
have there's nothing that you don't you
can't do there's no
thing that you can't do but the reason I
don't quote him and hate you back then
is because at least maybe I'm speaking
with hindsight the same way those girls
were speaking at least you could argue
oh they were fighting for something that
was tangible that assassinations
assassinations is crazy no matter what
you did but then we have to ask the
questions like yo does that make America
so in general are we gonna start when we
start going down that rabbit hole it's
like me
uh does anyone know why we're in war
with Syria
right but that's a whole different
but like that's that I think the
political standpoint is why I wouldn't
necessarily call them a hate group what
if I said I don't believe in abortion so
what if I said we should assassinate
that guy because I have a good cause
again
very good because
it doesn't legitimate assassination the
assassinations I'm not back in in any
way no I know I know but yeah but yeah
it's just like I think I think my
biggest issue is just the word because I
think they're a hiccup now right I think
if they've become a hate group
but in my head to justify me thinking
they've become a hate group
you kind of have to think that they've
at least come from a place of making
some sort of fight for some thing that
somewhat makes sense to some people okay
so so again so the pro-life thing that
would make sense to some people yeah you
know if I was leading a group of people
and I said let's let's kill let's let
them I want to say the song but let's
assassinate a certain political figure
in the name of this group you think I
wouldn't be a hate group of course so
what about sir I'm not even gonna say
the group but what about a certain group
that um
huh no no no no no no a group back in
the day they had an idea that they they
were Superior than a certain group and
so they thought in their mind hey let's
try to
assassinate them does it start with okay
so but then but then it's one of those
things where it's like
the people on the other side could
literally say the Black Panthers were
the same thing
it obviously it was in self-defense but
history is written by the winners
[Laughter]
but they weren't planning assassination
yeah some
they were harmful I mean assassins
planning violence in some respect they
were planning violence oh I didn't know
that I think you're talking about
violence and defense yeah of course but
that's not really planning violence as
well standing outside your house yeah of
course that's what I'm saying we're con
different angles and different views
this is this is what my point was I
don't know if I would use the word my
whole thing was fixated on the word
Hebrew right it wasn't I agreed with
everything else you said it's just the
word hate people I think that's a level
nine when they were a level seven
they're planning assassination yeah
that's a that's a not that's not a nine
I don't know what a nine is what group
who wants to make a change it isn't
planning assassination I can think of
the pro-life movement I could take a one
right there I mean I mean but you
wouldn't cool I wouldn't call the
pro-life movement aggressive I know yeah
so it's not a hate group you know
they're aggressive and angry but and
they do it at the like the the feminism
did it at the expense of men because
again they were taking away the
responsibility of what came with voting
100 and so 100 that's what I'm saying so
I was it's a hate group if they're
planning assassinations and getting
rights at the expense of men
I don't know I think hate group is
slightly too again it sounds so feminine
no because it's just the words
now
yes are they still planning
assassinations they're not planning
assassinations but I would call them I
would call them a hate group
they hate men yeah and it's at the
expense of men so you know yeah
it's like and they do character
assassinations oh they do they ruin
lives God they might not be planning to
do it with a gun but [__] they ruined
Johnny Depp's life and a lot of that I
think I'm very fixated on the language
side rather than that like more than I
probably should be yeah I don't know
they're assassinating mentally mentally
financially yeah then physically weird
but I do agree with the fact that one
the the pill and and the vote was to not
go into the draft Solaris because you
lost a lot of females all right cool
would you go into the draft now the
answer is no
I would give up my right to vote yeah if
I had to pick between getting drafted
and vote out hey easy the thing is take
away if you ask a lot of guys they say
the same but we're just gonna have to do
it because because you don't have a
choice yeah it goes back to men are seen
as Expendable in society yeah if there's
if there's a boat going down who gets
off first the women and the children
yeah if there's a fire you guys go first
yep if King Kong comes to break down the
whole thing you have to escort you guys
up first
and it goes so going off of feminism so
feminism encouraged women basically to
sleep around
right which we went over that as
negative consequences to chase their
career over a family and prioritize that
first
which
um single childless women over the age
of 45 are the least happy
um
and on top of that
um they wanted
abortion as a Fail-Safe so they push for
abortion rights
and I bur abortion is the ultimate form
of hypergamy
so it's basically saying I that guy is
not good enough to be a father because
if a girl's obsessed with a guy she's
carrying his kid he can't convince her
to abort it yeah
how many how many of those uh like uh
what's it mind blown yeah how many of
those cases but a guy has to pay what's
up I can't even think of the word child
support how many other child support
cases do you think is from a from a
child that was born because the mom
wanted it and the dad didn't
I mean they'll steal condoms to get it
if they want to carry a dude's kid like
a girl will jump
over Hoops to carry it she wants to
carry it and she's already pregnant
she's holding it yeah that's what
happened to it um did you hear about
that thing with Drake it was a while
back yeah yeah where you put hot sauce
in the condom yeah because he was trying
to she was trying to keep it and she put
my husband will say well he shouldn't be
sleeping with the women like that and
it's like how someone said it on the
last podcast and I was sitting in the
corner I was like how can you how do you
say that I'm like obviously it's Drake
and he's not gonna be like well hey are
you gonna try to take my sperm out the
condom and insert it in you after this
like Drake's gonna do what he he wants
to do because he's in that position to
do that yeah and it's like nobody looked
at the female like why are you doing
that like why is that um like like
that's crazy that you actually went in
the bathroom and was like I'm going to
trap Drake because he's Drake yeah I
think the fact that she can actually go
to like
I'd try to press charges on him yeah
that is the audacity for you to think
through that at what exactly what you
just explained that she did and then for
her to even have the audacity to even go
and press charges on him like he's done
something like you did it to yourself
did you guys hear about this season
sorry story a while back oh the comedian
who basically looked canceled because he
had a bad date with a girl yeah like she
he was pressuring her he was like
pressure he was pressuring her but
pressuring isn't assault don't get me
wrong I it's annoying it is I'm sure
every girl in this room has bet like
been in a situation where a guy just
won't leave it alone but we're not gonna
put it on the men because like you put
yourself in that situation you can leave
um they gave you trouble oral sex like
at least three times each
and then she made an anonymous like twit
Vlog oh that she gave him I thought I
thought I thought he was like pushing
her to do it and they both did it
through each other they were drinking
wine that just makes it worse they went
they were they were in from my
recollection they were in a she took on
a date
um he kind of rushed through the dinner
because obviously I think his mind was
somewhere else and it was part of the
whole forcing thing right of Russian so
he was rushing through the Bottle Bar
and he wanted to bring a bottle of wine
home they get they get home they started
drinking
she says that she's somewhat
uncomfortable while according to her
story
um
but then they start uh kissing and she
gets more slightly more comfortable with
it to the point where they give each
other over sex like three or four times
each right so she gives it to him he
gives it to her and then uh like a few
weeks months passed and then she made
like a Twitter video Twitter uh post
basically saying oh this guy uh as he's
on survey should be canceled because he
forced me into giving him oral sex three
times
I was like uh first of all no one forced
to you
[Music]
I think he just he just there's social
pressure sure but you don't have to give
in to that so you know you understand
that man
like it's weird but like we live in we
live in a society where a girl can do it
like imagine if a guy did that
um she pressured like basically she
pressured me or she pressured me into
sex yeah
they wouldn't I know a lot I'm not sure
let me let me not say it with chest but
I know there's a lot of guys maybe both
of you guys in this room who've had
stories where you were pressured by her
she put on you big man it wasn't you one
of her
he's loving because he knows the thing
is he's laughing because he knows but a
lot of guys have gone through that
situation where Loki it wasn't me that
insinuated this low-key obviously I'm
gonna go with it because I'm a man and
you know being being yeah but Loki you
pushed it on me but
if I was to then the next day be like oh
my I didn't actually want to have sex in
here
[Laughter]
don't I look like a [__]
though like it's so it's so weird
because once you see this you can't
unsee it that's the thing and it's it's
every it's literally everywhere in
society and it's crazy too because when
we're incentivized for bad behavior
so if we get we if we're a single mom
like what we get child support yeah
for 18 years so so we're paid to be
single mothers
like how how insane is that if we if we
sleep with the with the rapper and we
get a kid off of him we get a bag for 18
years yeah
what did what did Kevin Samuel say about
um future in the 10 why over there Kevin
Simmons it was like everyone gets on the
future for having 10 kids but no one
gets an old yeah the nine goes after the
first one right because there's there's
always an excuse for women like if a
man's sleeping around we we hear that
all the time Jazz oh he shouldn't be
slaving around he should wrap it but
when a girl gets pregnant if I say okay
that's your own fault
um you put yourself in that situation
um there's a million firms of birth
control you could have tried you also
could have an abortion worst case so if
you're a single mom I don't feel bad for
you because you chose that and if if you
picked the wrong guy I I don't feel bad
for you either because you need to learn
to pick better that's your own it's your
own five empathy for you but like you
made your bed but that's crazy but
when we I say whenever I show empathy to
men the first reaction is oh well he
shouldn't sleep around yeah but if I say
that about women it's it's like people
people I think I think nowadays women
expect to be cuddled for the bad choices
yeah they expect other women to
understand you understand you're a woman
so so it's that I think when especially
when a woman checks especially I think
I've watched a few episodes yeah that
you checked about a couple girls when a
woman checks a girl it's like they kind
of can't believe it yeah yeah yeah how
dare you how can you talk how can you
tell me about my [__] there you go
against The Sisterhood how dare you yeah
I mean I've had girls of blame their
debt on the fact that we couldn't vote
in the 20s
I'm like what the you were there that
episode you were that you were
absolutely there that episode it was one
of the first ones and I claimed the debt
yeah because that's that's the other
thing like single women spend way too
much money we own two-thirds of Consumer
Debt
even though we make ten thousand dollars
less per year than that it's a pink tax
have you looked for the men in the
female deodorant or razors or it's not a
pink seat like you're taking
accountability off of women
I'm saying in terms of business because
back when I studied it's literally
called a pink text because so the same
thing because it's like the same razor
and I can charge a woman 10 more because
she will buy it yeah yeah because they
raise it's supply and demand like women
women will buy it that's the point if we
didn't buy it they would lower the
prices like right is it right God no put
up pace
there's one deodorant that I think they
did a study on it and it's the men and
the women's ones the same thing
but the women's one is actually
in a different boat one more expensive
I forgot what I think it was Right Guard
or I think I forgot what it was and I
think they just added like one
difference in Scent yeah for the female
but maybe sure that makes sense if it
was sure but like yeah it's like
it's literally the same yeah sure for
men yeah sure for men and sure yeah it
could have been that it's literally the
same exact thing except the men's one is
cheaper women's will understand like 15
more just because they can't well and it
goes back too so we need 2.5 million to
retire and feminism says it like never
settle you're a queen no matter how fat
you are no matter how old you are you're
still worth just as much as you were
when you were young
and they're predicting that women are
going to be the largest growing homeless
population yeah because of poor yeah
because you need 2.5 million to retire
so you can't do that off of one income
you need to unless you're in the top
like 10 of female earners
so we're basically feminism is basically
teaching girls how to be homeless and
they can all get together
that's what you'll probably see is old
roommates would you rather have old
roommates or an old husband
[Music]
you need 2.5 million to retire by 65 70
to 80 of consumer decisions are made by
women and that's why um they call it the
she economy and they're saying to invest
in things like wine cat food yeah dog
food no because this is what single
childless women are getting buy a dog
die alone yeah where do you think he got
that from
[Laughter]
you know know hate on Kevin Samuel's
first like being so like harsh but it's
just a reality I guess he had the
reality yeah reality is cruel to accept
yeah you have to admit that was cool and
I guess maybe social media has just made
it so idealistic that we can't believe
in reality anymore that even when we
hear the statistics we're just like nah
that's [__] no I'll be fine exactly
will you it's not even like
it's just yeah I get I would blame all
of this on social media actually because
we reached a certain point of Ideal life
and social media that we just ignores
the real we just ignore the reality
which is really bad and if you chase the
career and you out earn your husband
married women were twice as likely to be
divorced three years after their
promotion to a CEO level compared to
their male counterbar parts if you if
you get if you work too hard and get too
successful you leave because you're not
attracted to him because you out earn
him and you're the provider
[Music]
wow
wowing again what mine's blown again
so for me it's like it goes back to my
question of
do you think that women can actually be
like traditional again and like I'd be
on a level where they you know they're
comfortable with a guy that's or settle
I guess it all depends on balance though
if you know how to balance your life
balance your career and balance maybe
your family you'd be fine we're not
saying that oh don't work and don't do
anything just stay home and depend on a
guy completely but if you know how to
balance between your career like don't
focus on your career only and be like I
don't need anything I don't need anyone
else I only make my career Because deep
down you know that you need something
else right but because when you chase
some like that's how indecisive we are I
guess that's how human beings how inside
for human beings are because when you
chase something deep down you want this
the other thing because you you just
need to know how to balance between both
of things and you will be fine don't
chase something more than another I I
wish that was true that's what I'm
saying the reality is cruel yeah but you
can't have everything and I think if if
we could we wouldn't see over 50 percent
of women over 30 being single and
childless yeah
yeah because then again it goes back to
the whole thing of like how many times
have you in life made a huge life Target
for yourself and you hit it and like Yay
is that kind of once you've heard
exactly because yeah yeah you always did
something at some point and you have to
set another one for like the next year
yeah exactly it's all about targets and
objectives keep just chasing something
and when it ends then what's up next
exactly I think a lot of people haven't
misconstrued when it comes to like
doesn't work because it's like oh but he
he just grinds and he wants to go all
the way to the top like to be able to go
to get to the top you have to be a
certain type of human being yeah I mean
my dad's in the top one percent of
earners he worked 80 hours a week my
whole life I don't know many people that
could do that doing that I don't know
many men or women that could or want to
do that I I do not Dad if you're
watching
probably beneficial for my career
that's 12 hour days I think I think no
one really wants to do it but it's like
it's it's with men it becomes it's
almost like it's a duty it's not it's an
overnight I have a choice especially
especially if like you want to become
like post that like a one percent or
like you have no you have no choice it's
your duty in it so work 80 hours a week
yeah bro all right remember like most
people are on like 40 hours a week I
mean obviously it's better to work smart
than hard yeah so if you can you know
make the same kind of money in less time
I would obviously go for that that's
cool I just think there's one percent of
men that are willing to work the 80
hours I think men like commend men that
work 60 hours that's still a lot but the
80 hours is like
that's a different level yeah because I
do for you and by 30 by far you want to
kill myself
I can't lie well that's normal most
people don't want to work 80 hour a week
so when you hear girls saying oh the one
percent like the one percent they'll
complain about the one percent while
using the products that they benefit
from so Amazon if Amazon disappeared
tomorrow we would be tripping that'd be
terrible we would be tripping but we'll
we'll constantly complain about the
people running those companies while not
wanting to do it ourselves you're
entitled this sounds and we're all
complaining about the Gap and wealth but
none of us want to step up and do it
yeah do you know what that links to
what's it it links to because I was
having a conversation with um a feminist
one time jealousy no not even that yeah
it's like um
there's no cons there's no concept of
like what hard work is you know I mean
like like hard work has just lost on
people right so it's one of those things
where like this people see the end
result and they went like I said you
went with me shooting in the gym right
yeah you weren't women shooting in the
gym you want that so you don't know how
much work I put into this you just see
the end product and see me living the
life of a billionaire or a
multi-millionaire and obviously now
because I have this these resources it's
easier to live right so you see me now
but has anyone seen Mark Zuckerberg's
room when he was back at Uni before
Facebook has anyone seen where Google
was created in the back of a garage
somewhere has anyone yeah that's cool
well did it doesn't Elon Musk like sleep
at his job yeah Tesla yeah and he bought
he bought like uh 40 40 000 little cubic
houses yeah near his near his work just
to like have like a place to like shower
and stuff yeah which is crazy and so he
has all this money but he doesn't even
he's it's just working exactly that's
the thing when you chase something so
much you just miss on a few things that
you would not realize you have missed on
them until you reach that point when
you're like okay now what it won't come
back because we know like we won't we
won't go back to the youth we won't go
back to what we miss on well life's
about trade-offs yeah I mean because I I
go to so my parents we have um private
banking events and
it's basically like you have to have a
certain amount of money to go through
these events so like typically they'll
invite
um like a speaker and usually it's like
a political guy either from the right or
the left like they usually alternate and
when I'm in the room I'm I'm the
youngest one like by far okay and my
parents are even the youngest younger
ones everyone there is like 60 70 and I
had this thought when I was in the room
like they have all the money in the
world but they probably if they could
would trade places with me because I
have a youth and they can't buy that
yeah one thing would you rather be old
and rich or young and broke I think most
people would pick young and broke so you
can build it yeah
[Music]
wait what would you say no just I said
I'm young and broke now let's use that
one
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
so then okay another red pill fact we
did feminism is okay so another red pill
fact is that women initiate divorce 70
to 80 of the time
[Music]
so and if you're college educated it's
90.
so your you guys's chance of being
divorced is 10 if you get divorced or
being divorced like they they serve you
if you divorce you'll you'll be the one
that leaves
these guys don't care about your degree
but girls care about the guys yeah it's
weird
that's interesting there's no way
because again the more the more educated
you get the smaller and smaller that you
you have to pick from and so it's likely
it's more likely that you picked a guy
that maybe wasn't your first choice
okay if I'm if I'm to elaborate why I
don't think it's weird men and women
look for different traits yeah men are
looking for a woman that's submissive
um the cooperative and brings peace
whereas women are looking at hypergamy
what can this man bring me yeah in
simple terms men are looking at a
woman's past
and women are looking at a man's future
yeah because the reason the reason I say
it's weird is because it's like I get
that in and I get that on a macro scale
because having a degree and having a
masters was more likely to push you into
that world but like bro we went to
school in the same place
I went to school like if you're both at
Uni you both we went to school in the
same place we went to UNI at the same
time but we both finished in the same
year how are you looking at me
differently than I look at you in that
respect especially because when it comes
to money right when I say when I see
like money being involved like yeah fine
you could be hurt like I don't agree
with her pugging people like
if he's really rich and you're not like
I get it like cool blah blah blah blah
you guys are literally literally in this
is the exact same place but they're not
the same yeah because girls want a guy
that we can look up to yeah so it
doesn't mean that if you marry a guy
that's making less than you that you
automatically are going to get divorced
but you have to look up to him in some
way yeah so okay I'll give you an
example say I make more money than a
guy's content creator if I Married An
engineer I would always look up to him
because I know that he's smarter than me
I mean token me around this is fun it
takes a lot of hard work but I wouldn't
say that the IQ of content creators is
that high above the rest of the
population
sorry guys
just I think we're good at talking oh my
gosh great communicators
we fit in the community yeah don't get
me wrong I love it I love you guys oh
sorry but but or it might be muscles
like he's better looking than her but
like girls have to look up to the guy in
some way no girl is gonna date a guy
that's worse than her in every way
and think wow I gotta catch they won't
even date a guy he was literally the
same as you and everywhere or not he has
to he has to be above her in some way
but what would you say well that's true
then because I was like what would you
say about girls I've heard a lot of
girls that they'll date guys who just
mooch off of them and like she has to
play she's taking care of bills and he's
like the woman she's usually a um What's
the phrase oh Pookie or Ray Ray yeah
she's usually a good looking a good
looking guy who's smooth he may not be
going anywhere
he's
chiseled but he lives in the hood and
he's not trying to get out yeah
that's the good genes that's like the
alpha side because there's there's two
parts of hypergamy that they talk about
and
it's um alpha alpha fox and beta box and
so okay
I'm sure so out of the guys that you
guys have like slept with dated whatever
I'm sure you can think of a guy where
immediately like you wanted to sleep
with him like right off the bat like oh
my God he's so fine versus the other guy
who he kind of had to be your friend
first he kind of had to like kind of
have to like weasel his way in there and
then over time you're like you know what
[Laughter]
some of my friends and people are
acquaintances I know have like yeah took
on some Talent oh it took me some time
to warm up too but yeah good now or like
the ones like oh he's fine I would I
would have his babies or something like
that you know yeah and so that's that's
like the two ways that girls look at
guys so they call it alpha fox which
that means he has good genes basically
okay
um maybe I think you guys let me know in
the chat would you say social status is
included in Alpha [__]
because I don't know I think it may be
um like game I would say maybe it's been
there but and then beta bucks is someone
you see as a long-term provider and
there's different mating strategies that
women have so one is they want someone
to continue
um Legacy basically so he won't cheat on
you publicly he won't embarrass the
family like that sort of thing so Pookie
and ray rays don't have that no Legacy
with them but what they might have is
good genes they might have
um
social status which is like that's why a
guy with a blue check mark that he might
not even be cute or whatever but like if
he's got a blue check mark like girls
are coming yeah yeah yeah
and then there's there's long-term
security which is like
either they think he might not maybe
have a lot of money but they know he
would stick around and take care of the
kid or he he's a provider he has that
money
okay so oftentimes girls will marry the
beta guy that they're really not as
attracted to but they know he's the
better father for their kids
have a couple kids with them and cheat
with the alpha guy or get the beta if
they can really fulfill their mating
strategy they will marry the beta guy
and get pregnant by the alpha guy and
have the beta guy raise the kids oh God
wouldn't that be like a part of in a
sense of good guys finish last yes yeah
okay and that's part of the red pill for
men is realizing that the nice guys
don't finish last because in society
they've always been told that be nice
you know get a job be be a provider type
of guy and you will get the best results
and so it's like these guys do that and
they're like where are my [__]
where where the hoes at I'm here but
then we look but then you look at the
guys you know the bad guys and you know
the bad boys and the replays and rappers
and athletes understand what they're
getting all together this is a question
to the guys oh
was there an age where you made the
change and do you remember that as you
remember what age you were when you
finally made that change what kind of
changed
because maybe it was just me I used to
be this huge sweet boy some people could
call me as simp if you look back here
but there's usually a point in a lot of
man's life and I've seen it with a lot
of my friends there's an age there's a
time right but a change happened it
might be for a little bit you might go
back to being a sweet boy but like a lot
of people I know go through
Like the Wolf is different for guys is
the switch because it goes from like I'm
gonna I'm gonna take on dates I'm gonna
buy your flowers every day so you know
what yeah yeah
[Music]
okay it's kind of like okay if a guy
says hey babe can you please be quieter
shut the [__] up which one are you more
attracted to
because in my head if someone's telling
me Shut the [__] up I'ma cuss him out
too like we're just gonna have a battle
away I can't but it depends on if you're
interested
if some attracted to told you to shut
the [__] up
he told you shut the [__] up you'll buck
up but if you're attracted to him like
if he's unattractive or attractive I'm
gonna I I will argue back I will say
something back I'm not just gonna be
like okay I'm not gonna do that I can't
like I can't Michael Jordan says it to
you in this recipe as little boys like
yo babe shut the [__] up
I just no I can't
but there are some women that'd be like
I love it when he tells me to shut the
[__] up I can't do that but it's it's a
guy it's basically like we don't like
guys that can't kiss our ass
that's why you see that's why you see
okay Will and Jada why doesn't she
respect him because because he's been
putting her on a pedestal like you see
him at the red culprit event that's
about him and he's he's going like this
to her oh yeah yeah like we hate that
because it's like I feel like girls know
on some level that none of us are [__]
like we all ain't [__] so if you're
treating us like we're the [__] we're
like what's wrong with you
like why are you because it's true the
guy buys you flowers and takes you on an
extravagant first day you're like why
quite what I like that but I like it but
in the back your head you're like why
like like right okay why is he doing
that yeah okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
what was your question again oh do you
guys remember or did did you guys ever
go through a point in your life where a
change happened right that like someone
might have hurt you or you started to
see the world in a different light and
you're no longer the nice guy who takes
people out as much as you did you're now
the guy who just plays the field as much
as you can even you know it might be for
a little bit yeah no I think I think I
may have gone through that change I
think it happens
yeah but it was heartbreak it went of
course same
that's what I think it's for most guys
it's hard
for me it was the other way around oh
you broke at her no no no for me for me
it was um I was really like
I was I didn't care about it what anyone
thought like if if I had a girlfriend I
don't care what you think I was kind of
like that but then I kind of Switched
okay I became more caring and more you
know may I ask what changed and what I
think it was the circle that I kept to
get me I had a lot of female friends
back then and those always you know give
you advice that you know relationship
advice so you know make your girl feel
welcomed and make her feel nice and
stuff like that and it was like all that
advice turns you into a Sim kind of
thing and then you start doing too much
and then when you start doing too much
the girls kind of switch
so it's like like before they used to
like me when I was a wasteman or not
away from about a [__] yeah like get
me I used to talk to you anyhow and you
would like that and when I'm actually
being respectful and nice and you know
opening the door and doing all these
gentlemen things yeah you're trying to
take my weakness oh my kindness for
weakness kind of thing so it's like
that's for me that's so it happened
opposite and then kind of switched back
when the red pill kind of thing came
along that's when I was like okay now I
realize and it's kind of gone back but I
was kind of doing it doing I was kind of
red pill subconsciously
when you were at Red turn blue right
back
I've heard this story from so many guys
where they say oh I was so nice to these
girls and I realized they don't like
that yeah
and so I stopped doing it and then I got
more girls yeah do you think but don't
you think it's like what women I guess
like what women are used to now so like
how do you say that yeah so like our
generation now like they don't care
about really it doesn't seem like they
care about taking girls out to eat
anymore and doing like those kind things
and so they're so used to like
guy's not doing anything or talking to
him however you do it they're just like
what the hell is going on yeah like why
are you doing why are you doing it yeah
this is the reason behind that you need
something in the egg situation I think
I think we're all going for the same men
and so those guys don't have the time to
take us out on dates because we're
picking the guys that everyone wants hmm
because I'm saying it's a chicken in the
egg situation you can't which you think
came for us the guys kind of not
treating it goes as nicely as they that
they did priority because the girls
didn't want it or the girls or the girls
having the bed in the stick which do you
think came first
men men will do anything to get laid
yeah
they're taking us on dates and being
chivalrous got them like yeah yeah I
think if she like if goals required
chivalry
well when it like back in the like way
back in the day like the the housewives
you know the love that when it when it
weren't they more like like I'll tell
you why birth control changed the game
yeah in 1965 when they developed birth
control that was that was the beginning
of modern women because then girls got
the opportunity just to
Screw the guys like the alpha alpha fox
where before they had to pick a beta Guy
and because they didn't have anything to
compare it to they were they were pretty
happy and their dads would maybe help
them a little bit vet the guys so they
could say that guy would be a good
long-term partner because you know a lot
of girls were virgins back then yeah but
so now girls get ran through throughout
their 20s screwing all the the bad boys
and then expect a beta guy to pick up
the pieces at 30. hmm
so it fulfills both mating strategies
that's why girls argue so hard for
abortion and for birth control wow
because they they want the best of both
worlds
okay
mad it's a lot yeah
it's so unfair and I feel like this is
why do you think it's unfair just like
for as you said a bit like a guy getting
a wrong woman yeah and a good woman
getting the wrong guy it's just well I
think very unfair good women make poor
choices and those are the consequences
yeah yeah yeah and so like we chose to
be on birth control
you know so in a way I think I think
women ruin the dating Market more than
men
because I I think men will we jump
through hoops I've seen men just adapt
yeah to what the what what it takes to
get that sex yeah I think men just adapt
to what you know like if it was if if in
the 1950s it was being shiverish and
whatnot I'll be the most Shivers
gentleman ever okay yeah yeah yeah that
was what was in nowadays it doesn't take
much you know you just have to sweet
talk or have some swag about you and uh
that makes a lot of sense you'll get the
couch because there is a greater cost
like before birth control you could get
pregnant by the guy so you couldn't risk
screwing the alpha [__] because you
might have a child because there's no
birth control yeah and how many shotgun
weddings did they have yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I don't even know what this is
worked out still a lot of those like
grandparents or grandparents great
grandparents even if it was a shotgun
wedding they would stay together why
because those girls didn't get ran
through because they couldn't it wasn't
and people will say oh like girls were
just as sexual then but they couldn't do
it because there was a consequence so
you they in 1965 that changed the world
forever and the consequence was that
girls are [__]
men do less to get laid but it's a very
small percentage of men there's an
increase of virgins
and there's more single mothers and
single childless women over 30 because
they're all reproducing and sleeping
with the same men
and a bunch of angry men that are like
what is this [__]
sorry bottom thirty percent
because the the middle like eight the
middle 70 are in a weird limbo but a
bomb 30 I feel really bad for
I mean like the top 10 of the top 10 I
don't feel bad for them they live life
like do your thing yeah and the people
it benefits is that I mean the guys in
the top ten percent they're living a
dream yeah dream life like they they get
[__] on demand
they they can get them pregnant and
their girls will still get an abortion
maybe I mean minus the there's a
difference but girls are on birth
control now right yeah I mean the only
the only downside for those guys is the
is the like the Drakes of the world yeah
you know catching a kid going back we
said earlier I just remembered this are
we forgetting that Blac Chyna really had
a kid with Rob to try and get the card
that's your name yeah oh yeah and then
yeah
that's really really let's sit back and
digest
she went and tried to sue the
Kardashians for the name after and once
is she trying to get child support too
but she was taking care of her more than
she had the baby most days of the week
and she was asking for child support
from him that's crazy did she get it I
don't think so well that's that's the
other thing it's another way women
aren't like they're not punished for bad
choices is if you pick the wrong guy
like before there's
of you you were it was really bad if you
picked the wrong guy because
you have a kid with that person there
was no child support and stuff but then
they added in child support and no fault
divorce that they can get pregnant by
the wrong guy catch the CH get a check
from him
and then marry the beta later and take
half his stuff too and still get the
check from the dead yeah
and then the laws I've heard of if a
woman if a man's name is on a birth
certificate and he doesn't contest it he
still owes the woman child support even
if later it proved they prove that it's
not his kid and women with when women
oftentimes will use kids as pawns
against men and there's no punishment
for this that's crazy and it takes them
months it takes months to get back in
court and like fight for the kid and by
then you're missing the kid's life like
I've had two guys on here the other day
that both said they didn't see their kid
for a year because the mom wouldn't let
him see him and this happens all the
time there's no punishment you don't go
to jail for withholding the children or
they yeah they just do it out of spite
just to because they're mad at you or
whatever feed the kid lies about the
Dead behind yes and then the kid goes up
thinking the dad wasn't big bad because
they got that didn't want to be there
meanwhile he was really trying to be
there the whole time it's just your mom
made it really hard and it's hard to
tell those kids in today's day and age
your mom is actually the bad guy here
because saying that makes you a bad guy
flipping it up
and I think most men won't speak poorly
about the mother of their kids yeah
that's true yeah and women you break her
heart I mean even we had this girl on
the podcast the other day that's Aaron
all of her family's business on the
internet but that's still their kid's
dad yeah yeah that's crazy
I think it's just the Dead the day and
age that we're in like women don't feel
no way to talk about men like in any way
it doesn't matter if that's the father
of your child doesn't matter if that's
your brother that's your whoever they
will feel like because I think there's a
sense especially in like in the internet
there's a sense of you know a girl can
say anything about a guy there's other
girls that's going to understand where
she's coming from so it's like it's like
this they're almost free to say whatever
that goes back to women agreeing with
women
you will rarely see if a woman is bad
talking a man a woman like stuff and be
like no no you shouldn't say that about
him they'll be like yeah girl I feel the
same way
yeah pick me if you try to back up but
no one would say that yeah you made the
wrong choice you chose the wrong guy
yeah no one would say that no look at
you like you're crazy like how dare you
that's it but I love him yeah but how do
they I mean how do the girls look at me
when I tell them that when I say look at
I mean you should pick better what the
[__] exactly and I don't come from a
place of oh I've never picked the wrong
guy I have but you could either learn
from it and blame yourself or you can
blame everyone else for your problem
you attract who you are so if you keep
attracting toxic people that you're
toxic and I think that's important to
understand that and pass on to that
especially the next generation of girls
like that it's important to really take
resp accountability of the choices that
you make you understand because no one
no one can and tell you to open your
legs like no one can force you to open
your legs no one can force you to do
anything you understand if they do they
go in jail so like it's about taking you
know accountability of the people that
you sleep with the people that you let
into your life
people can't even take accountability I
think men jumping at jackets for what I
can't take I kind of believe her
bringing clothing to a nightclub when it
might rain
you know I mean like why why would you
not bring an umbrella with you if you
know that we're in the winter and it
might rain people or women
yeah that's what I'm saying I think men
take accountability women don't but it's
because we grow up in a society that
doesn't hold women accountable because
there's always an excuse do you keep
getting cheated on like it's your own
damn fault you keep picking cheaters you
can't just make the mistake twice Thrice
yeah I'm doing it but girls little girls
will pick cheater after cheater after
cheater cry on the internet say oh poor
me I'm I'm always getting cheated on and
girls will still back her yeah you're
off to the the cheetah
they'll be the side chick of a dude and
be like oh he'll never do that to me
he's like he's cheating on his
girlfriend with you what makes you think
that he won't do that thank you exactly
yeah now remember that little time frame
where like goes on Tick Tock we're
trying to get famous with the celebrity
guys that they slept with
[Music]
he tries to get big because you slept
with five famous people like how
disgusting is it like how is that how is
that Fame though like yeah and it's
bringing your clouds
but nowadays anybody can be famous if
you're famous it's free anyways yep it's
crazy because when I saw those videos
I'm like ew like like what do you mean
because again like Paul said if you
switch the genders if a guy like starts
posting all the girls of High Caliber
that you slept with all of a sudden he's
misogynist guy that treats women badly
and looks down on women but like all
these girls are saying oh I step with
this celebrity celebrity the celebrity
and it's like I was on the same thing
but I think with that the only thing I
would say is guys will praise him for
that though yeah and girls will get
shamed ghosts
I would think like girls would still get
shamed by other girls for that because
they would think like oh like you slept
with this many people and you're just
giving Africa and guys would say the
same thing yeah but it's because we're
biologically different yeah yeah I mean
it's just like there's some there's a
million double standards that benefit
women like we get into bars for free we
get free drinks yeah there's women only
grants that's just that's like the one
that doesn't benefit us is don't sleep
with too many people yeah and I think
the girls
um
the goals that you're saying that you
said girls get shamed um I mean guys
guys don't get ashamed yeah not by other
guys like they'll get shamed by girls
but not other people they're [__]
shaming but that's a thing like when I
say [__] shaming everyone knows what
that is right yeah but if there's no
broke shaming Short change
[Laughter]
I don't complain go ahead with the guy
with the girls that um but it goes that
uh that shame
um thing what's that I think no shame
they'll shame you in private but in
public though kind of like Oh They'll
pick you up oh she's doing whatever she
wants kind of thing I don't think girls
will shame another girl
in like interface or publicly yeah yeah
so I don't think girls don't really like
confrontation it's like not it's like
yeah not as likely it's not it's not as
confident that girls are not
confrontational so like you know them
you might you might tell your friend oh
she's a little [__] yeah me but for you
to go and actually tell her to her face
that you know you're behaving like a
[__] oh yeah
exactly yeah on the guy's side like you
know if if if if my if my boys behaving
like a wasteland or he's behaving like a
simp how about a bro pan up man like you
know you're doing too much for this girl
a little bit Yeah Jonathan like you're
doing too much like calm down and do you
understand that you told the guy in it
and I think that's the difference
between the men and women do you you
think women like this request for
everybody
um do you think women when they shame
somebody there's like a little bit of
like jealousy it depends it depends it
depends yeah it depends on the topic
because because
like for example I don't think Paul's
jealous of any of these girls that she
calls out like if if the girls are [__]
she's a [__] I don't think like I don't
think you're jealous but I don't think
you know you get jealous of it I just
think you call out things in it I do
understand where you're coming from
though like because if um
maybe a girl maybe you like the guy that
she likes and maybe you'll shame her to
that guy or shame her you know shame her
name or her character to that so that
you can you know get the better up
the tough female show aggression I mean
character assassination men men will
fight but women we don't we're not we're
not wired the same way it's character
assassination that's like you're right
is that attractive to men well
characters
[Music]
[Laughter]
be comfortable with your own swag yeah
because don't tell me about her because
then I'll be like I'll look at her more
now I think what I think women hit below
the belt a lot more than men do yeah
women like to hit where it hurts yeah
that's just what this is what there was
a rule that like this sounds crazy but
um like my the older males in my life
told me before when I was growing up
like don't tell women your doctor Secret
ever no yeah
yeah don't ever tell a female your dog
is secret because it doesn't matter if
that's your wife at some point you're
gonna use against you
yeah
this is the red pill for men but that's
because women and men operate on
different kind of wavelengths especially
when it comes to arguments a man will
understand in an argument with another
man that there's below the belt and you
don't go there whereas a woman it's like
all things go I'm angry anything goes it
is where it is I'm gonna use but it's
just like women women were more
emotional men act more with logic that
are more aggressive
unless it does with men women have a
conversation with men there's always
that you know there's always that layer
of it can get you know it can get on
yeah
if you go below the boat I'll bang you
in your face let's go crazy but with
when it's like
with a man having a conversation with a
woman
girls can go below the belt but a guy
can't respond how he would respond to a
man the way he would respond to woman
like if a guy goes on the belt with me
I'll probably punch him but a girl goes
under the belt it's like
what do you do what do you do like that
ex-girlfriend who threw his uh she found
out her boyfriend was cheating and
through his mom's asses oh I saw that I
didn't know there was a lot oh I saw
that he got charged yeah she needed to
go to jail period
the lack of consequences for women like
why do you think we see these women that
act like men that are so aggressive it's
because they can get away with it
because women if a man calls the police
on a woman there's accounts that the man
that the police arrest the man even
though he called the police on her and
if a guy if a guy hits a girl back what
happens
and everyone looks at him like he's the
bad guy even if she hit first yeah and
so it's like that's why we see these
modern women that are super aggressive
they're career oriented they're
depressed they have a lot of cat food
and dogs and why and they're like damn
near alcoholics one out of four women
are on anti-depression medications
like and the
um and they're growing in hope to be one
of the biggest growing homeless
populations
I was like we're we're destruct like we
are destroying the family Yeah question
what do you think could save the world
in terms of the next 20 to 50 years what
would save the world what would put the
world because we've all agreed that the
world is going in a really bad direction
right and if nothing is changed it could
just progressively get worse and worse
and worse so does anyone have any ideas
what we what could be done even if it's
a small thing that doesn't fix
everything just one area that could
potentially benefit the world 10 years
from now I would say probably people
being more accountable or self-aware
and not accepted mistakes yeah and not
pointing the finger at everybody like
well I did this because you did this to
me it's like accept what you did hold
accountability for yourself and not
blaming everybody or wanting to be
coddled like a little baby you're an
adult you're a grown person like except
what accept the consequences for your
actions yeah I think in order to get
that we need to see the laws change I
think especially when it comes to child
support when it comes to alimony and
divorce courts I think I need to see
women being held more accountable in the
justice system where they're getting
similar sentences to the same crime
um I I think we just need to bring back
I mean we're never going to undo birth
control
like I that so and social media it's
never going back yeah but I I think we
would see women act better if there was
more consequences for their actions like
if we saw Amber Heard face 10 years of
prison time you think girls would hit
twice if the Earths are not here twice I
think think twice before hitting a guy
yeah yeah I think it would try to yeah
change up a little thing yeah or if we
saw if we saw a girl that
um trapped a guy with a kid go to jail
you think maybe they'd think twice
before doing it if that was the
consequences like crazy people
I mean they're nuts but the consequences
work yeah they do
I think it's crazy like they say that
how can we change it because in my head
I personally think what we've come to an
age where girls not women don't listen
to men no more remember don't listen to
women no more
and that's the issue because if women
don't listen to men women don't listen
to women
do you understand and
women are 80 of the consumer based so a
lot of things that are going to go down
you have to go through women to make
sure that it gets done
is that how do we now go back because
you can't take away what they've
quote unquote fought for exactly
Jonathan so it's like how do we now go
back do we take away the sexual
Liberation do we take away the you know
equal opportunity for work I'm okay with
returning our right to vote
I'll take one for the team guys
I'll take I wouldn't say women
don't listen to women anymore they
listen to them but it's the wrong advice
or the wrong thing that they listen to
they don't give them sound
um
sound like uh what's the word I'm
looking for yes advice is more like just
what's bad or what can
flip the scenario onto the man to make
him feel a certain way or
what Empower what makes the woman feel
better so I think they listen but not to
the right to the voice yeah to the right
that takes it takes you back to
accountability if we're accountable for
our own mistakes we wouldn't we would
listen to what we say to ourselves we
would not meet for like a pajama party
for a crying over ice cream and be like
oh he cheated on me yeah go yeah yeah
cheat on him blah blah blah she will be
like the friend would be like yeah but
you chose the wrong person you can't
just be like crying over ice cream just
because he cheated on you you knew you
were waiting for it like you were
expecting that to happen because you
chose the wrong person if a person would
like yeah you chose the wrong person and
she'd be like oh yeah that's true
instead of telling her no he's wrong
he's he's an [__] blah blah all that
then maybe yeah yeah the consequences
would be different yeah
I'm going to read some super chats real
quick look at the chat
um okay because my laptop's about to die
so I'm making sure I read them first
okay
um Nat
I'm so sorry
lazy dappy
um if she hit below the belt just cut
the utilities off
um oh 90 for Tope um men are bears and
women are salmon covered in honey we're
also different also save the world men
have to be men and the woman and women
be women Jesus is the Lord egg Xanax
serious question would red pilling women
lead to more marriageable women but the
same family court pitfalls remain why
would any man sane man accept that it's
still Russian Roulette the laws need to
change I agree I don't think
I don't think
um will have more marriageable women
until the laws change that's just my
opinion
um the saving ninja follow up the on the
black currency question they may not
know what a sigma is
um we are a very rare breed Pearl is a
correct woman
um must have something to look up to
Austin Potter thank you so much for the
20 Super Chat black currency how to um
how does one each one on the panel
identify as a Sigma Alpha Beta gamma
Omega or Delta okay get for the guys
all right what do you guys what do you
guys think you are uh to be honest I
don't know in it but um
I mean like around my friends they say
yo your house
you're an alpha okay what are you hey
I was I was thinking that's moving too
far I I wouldn't call myself a bear and
if I have to give myself whatever my I
guess I'd say Alpha but that sounds
what's up there's another one yeah I'm
not on the panel yeah
my first answer was it
says Alpha Beta gamma Omega Delta I only
know Alpha and beta I know Sigma I think
that's like I think Omega is half of
that in between alpharettes
this is the thing this is the thing the
red pill Community this is what they
lose me right when they start
blaming themselves like Pokemon like
sounds like you're playing so much you
have to think about it depends on the
most guys are beta because most guys are
followers yeah so could you be the CEO
of company uh me yeah uh yeah yeah could
you my code it's probably more Alpha
than beta but it's like you have to have
that personality that like you could
lead a company that's like my opinion
anyway
um okay okay
Javier Ramirez perlier that given that
you're six foot and come from a one
percent dad and you're getting closer to
the wall
um have you adjusted your standards for
a man um since becoming red pill and
what are your minimum requirements oh
gosh
don't tell them um keep them guessing I
I would say I'm six foot I like guys
like five ten or taller so like an inch
or two shorter or taller
um
yeah hello cute nice anyways
anyways um and he's got to be like more
conservative I can't do I think I'm too
opinionated I would try to drive a
liberal crazy
um okay Albert retro
um there is nothing Alpha about a mooch
um Mr
um Nitro congrat congratulations on
hitting 100K in your unbelievable growth
if I'm not Mis not mistaken you were
just at 86k a week ago I was keep up the
great dialogue um amen 139 CAD look what
yeah
um this is the stream sponsor
um scariest thing is how mothers are
truly raising their boys let alone their
girls are they sacrificing their son's
masculinity so their daughters can rule
over Society the features at the hands
of modern mothers today and it's scary
bring the asteroid okay that's a little
dramatic yeah that's a little dramatic
you don't need to die like we could just
maybe start by changing the laws
[Laughter]
um
he can't articulate that assassinations
are the signifiers of a terrorist group
whereas hate groups should show overt
signs of hate rather than over signs of
violence to achieve political goals just
human Margaret Sanger and a bunch of
other feminists were eugenicists Susan B
Anthony and Elizabeth Cody's Stanton
thought black men were incompetent and
not deserving of the vote
um despite Frederick Douglass speaking
on their behalf
um Joe Joseph 19 to be fair the pro-life
movement has done assassinations and
bombings Albert retro you need to find a
way to get Karen's draw on your show
she'll set everybody straight on
everything if she I I think I know who
that is if she wants to come on I would
love to have her
um cam Tech
careful making the Assumption hate group
is the worst relatable it is not modern
feminism is a hate group but there are
levels it may reach terrorism which is
still rooted in hey it started off as a
hate group and developed even further
over time Keys Prime Time what is
y'all's thoughts on the Michael B Jordan
and Lori Harvey situation it ended
because he wanted to take the next level
to marriage
but how do we know that's the reason why
though
um
look he was my husband before yeah
you leave her for you uh no I can't like
I don't I couldn't do that I just might
talk about it
wasn't it like the PR move was like oh
they just saw the difference what was
the phrase that Lori said it went on the
same page but like she just belongs to
the streets bro
the only thing that threw me was when um
she she dated who did she she dated P
Diddy and her future but she dated like
she dated P Diddy and his son yeah so
after she was done with P Diddy she
dated his son
and that was crazy that was crazy to me
but because there's only a few type of
the men so they're all living in the
same cycle yeah that's true it kind of
makes sense but I know it's weird but
it's very weird
it's weird but for me it's weird that
you can say no
to Michael B Jordan but you know what
what did he give her for her bro he gave
her like stocks or something for her
birthday like he was just
because I can't understand me she
belongs to the streets
because he was offering like all of it
and I think she stole she says she's
still young she still wants to chase her
career then why get in a relationship if
you wanna if you want to just live your
life while I date him then for the
security she looks at Michael B Jordan
as beta think about that wow yeah she
viewed him as Alpha she'd be married
yeah also so she wouldn't she think that
all of them were beta then like even
future or even no no no I don't feel
shortly to Mario oh yeah that's that's
true I just would think because like
didn't I don't know who broke up with
who though I don't know if she broke up
with him or he broke up with her future
wise I mean I don't I don't know which
one it was but I guarantee there's
someone yeah I get like with the guy all
the guys she's dated one of them one of
them has has her yeah
which one yeah
yeah as soon as they started dating her
image went she went straight up a lot of
people didn't know who she was yeah yeah
she got more famous the people who did
know her looked at her in like a better
light than they did previously so it's
like make you fumbled up back like
Laurie Harvey was basically the youngest
Sierra yeah the future had been there a
couple others and then boom she went and
got this awesome game down to four
seconds left she fumbled it turn over on
the sidelines
hate to see it and even and even you see
Sierra now like that's why you can't
wait for her what's she doing now what
was she doing now oh yeah she split up
with that guy no no they're still
together
is embarrassing him like I mean he's
allowing her to do it but she's like
twerking and like posting her butt on
Instagram imagine like your mother no
what are you doing bring back shame
I remember
I just you wouldn't say something no
because I was thinking about what you
told me about how
women will go through this whole phase
and then all of a sudden they'll find
Jesus to marry to get marry somebody and
it had just thought about that with
Sierra she went through I don't know if
she went to a whole face but she went
through her face before she met uh
Russell uh Wilson and she found Jesus or
she already knew him or she was more
open about it because he
was open about his relationship with
Jesus and I'm just like yo literally my
brain has been blown all night and I'm
just like connecting the dots like and
does it and does it seem just seem like
it was a genuine relationship with Jesus
now that she's twerking on Instagram I
don't know yet but the answer is no
maybe maybe it was a mating strategy to
find a husband because then she goes I
got him locked down they got like four
three four kids together now yeah family
photos too but it goes back to like
future was the alpha she got the jeans
from him
he the kid is named after future so
Russell has to call that kid future and
like say his name is
say that again when you think about that
that's like that yes that's the name I
mean I don't know if it's like future
whatever Future's real name is but he's
a junior yeah
so he has to like call this like her
ex's name in this house he's a beta and
everyone can't believe like and so
Russell Wilson is a hero to single
mothers because they're like oh maybe
someday that'll be me so to them he's
the hero and Russell Wilson's a joke to
the men because they're like why you you
have everything why would you pick
Sierra like you go money you've got the
look you've got like 200 million dollars
that's why that's why men dog on him and
women love him because they say oh I had
a hoe face like that means I can come
out okay
no
it's amazing yeah it's amazing strategy
and you'll see that girls fight find God
around the 20 around like 27 to like 30.
yeah because around around that age
that's when yeah Megan good too right
and then and then that's the problem
though is because once they get the the
long-term security once they get the
kids they start wilding out again yeah
and and they return back to the streets
and that's why you can't wife a hoe
there's no need to kiss your thought up
anymore yeah
even though she's Sierra of course she
is
and so yeah it's you're seeing both of
the mating strategies like live
basically and and now and before men
weren't really up on game but with the
red pill it's like the reason if you
Google red pill it's gonna say misogyny
and all this stuff but women are just
mad that the men are understanding
what's happening so when she says oh I
was so broken that just means oh I was
so horny
is that good moving chess they're like
ha now we know yeah we check maze
because I mean you all know if a girl
like cries mender just like oh like they
have that innate instinct to protect
women and if he says oh he treated me so
bad like no he just rocked her world and
like and and it just didn't work
girl because we all know as women the
ones that the the girls complain about
the most that's who has her yeah
that's it's not the one the guys you
don't you never hear about
they did she didn't care about him
but there's always one
and there's yeah mind blowing right I'm
just like I mean I'm gonna keep reading
the Super Chat that's about you guys
yeah yeah um okay so
um the suffrage movement was female lead
um Sims have been around for a long time
if you look up Charles Fourier the
French philosopher that coined the term
bait and based practice of defying women
and hating men the first male feminist
um Alan strange Stringer the original
suffrage movement was created in
opposition to black men getting the
right to vote before white moment white
women
[Music]
um ever heard of the New York comedian
and political commentator Dave Smith he
went from degenerate young guy to family
man with two kids after he found the
right woman please check him out
um Harold Thomas Maya algo the I don't
put it on three different husbands but
you don't hear that who's Maya algello
my ogalo Maya Angelou Maya Angelou oh
yeah okay Angela
you know who that is yeah
her husband wait she cheated on her
husband three times yeah three different
husbands not mine three different
husbands oh my God someone told that
podcast
um there was a mean girl lawsuit where
um where a girl accused a guy of grape
and was proven wrong admitted she lied
not a single repercussion the poor guy
self-deleted nothing happened to her
um I just popped in to say congrats on
100K Subs keep pushing thank you
oh wait I read these already sorry guys
um let's see if this is
oh God but if I now make a video saying
Maya Angelou wasn't this yeah yeah I'm
gonna read them but um and and the other
thing is when when girls cheat they
always get an explanation when men like
they always get that hear them out this
is why I cheated when men cheat he's
trashed
um okay Megan Good dated 50 Cent Soldier
Boy Nick Cannon Nelly and more froze her
eggs and married a preacher gave the
preacher no kids then divorced
Jesus Jesus Jesus Jesus Jesus um Kyle
one I've seen I didn't know she did all
of that
I've seen women muddy the water and
excuse Amber heard's Behavior by saying
Johnny is no saint equating drug and
alcohol abuse to Violent felonies
imagine if Adolf Hitler was a woman
um oh my God 200 US dollars
new stream sponsored thank you the
market and your results tell the truth I
love the long form podcast thank you so
much
um Mt one of the reasons modern women
overvalue their SMB as they start
believing their own face filters and
Photoshop I think that's true yeah
um okay
um a point on bat oh John Ashby a point
on bad advice women put morbidly obese
models on the cover of magazines Matt
butcher women have the government behind
them do a show on if the violence
against women act do on the reality of
the violence against women act I
actually don't know a lot about that but
yeah I can research it
um osmosis reacts great setup and camera
work thank you um Rebel
um Rebel um Without a Cause yeah I think
think ish good job
I don't know thank you thank you I
appreciate it just just your answer was
self-awareness and it's a good answer
but it's lacking self-awareness without
perspective and realistic real world
wisdom can devolve into delusion not lay
oh wait I did this one already okay I
don't have to read your name twice
because the Amber Heard thing that is
true because I've been seeing the media
trying to spin this and I'm like me
what do you mean is a certain women back
the fact no this is boosting up victims
isn't all because we found out that the
person who was the victim was victimized
even more by getting his career taken
yeah after being a victim yeah so it's
like that person still and what what
annoys me the most is when people are
always toxic on both sides I don't agree
with that because it was probably how
many times have you been like has anyone
got siblings here I know I know Pearl
does yeah how many times have you when
you were younger your younger siblings
is
the moment you retaliate is when your
mom is like oh my gosh why are you so
aggressive it's like used to what's so
bad towards each other no I retaliate in
the last five seconds because of the
loss but I also think it's your ability
to pick yeah yeah of course of course
and and I I still I I honestly believe
you attract what you are and if you keep
finding yourself with shitty partner
after shitty partner after shitty
partner like it says something about you
Johnny had good party I'm not saying I'm
not talking about Johnny Depp I'm just
talking about in general yeah yeah and I
mean that's part of the reason I think
that made his case so strong is all of
his exes said no he never hit me
even even if you know maybe it ended
badly they'd still come up and like
defend him yeah
but I think like with all the evidence
and her lying on the stand and stuff
like you would think like that's the
thing yeah
being over dramatic yeah we're reacting
for no reason may that even worse
attempting to use her acting oh my God
she clearly was not a good actor and
that's the crazy thing like there's
people that are still like I'm with
Amber forget Johnny is like did you hear
what she said like were you listening to
the same court cases that everybody else
was listening did you see people debunk
her theory on how he broke his finger
no because basically he said she said
sorry that he broke his finger because
he was like slamming a phone into the
floor into that the table right and then
he must have cut himself in the finger
and it wasn't me throwing the boat away
his finger that did it it was actually
him having a rage having a phone in his
hand and just punching the table cool
that's been debunked by people on the
internet which is funny how people on
the internet did more for this than the
actual media right that's funny but
people on the internet found pictures of
the house right out of the room because
obviously they were selling they had to
sell the house at some point so like
really real estate pictures and once you
look at the picture of that room you can
see the phone isn't where she said it
was the phone was on the other side of
the room the phone's on the other side
of the room there is no feasible way
there is no way that he could have broke
his finger over there but the phone is
over here
but then people would see that evidence
and be like no but they just lied and
they just if you listen to Amber's
Amber's teams or they're just putting
out information just hearsay yeah well
it's it goes back to like only a women a
woman would get away with this and
that's and that's the
it's so weird because like at first when
you start listening to Red Pill like
there's like phases as a girl first
there's like shock a little bit because
they're talking about how it's over
basically when you hit 30. and and we
might be homeless and all these all
these stats that like I'm like oh my God
no
like and then like at 25 I'm like I
peaked two years ago
geez actually I kind of knew that I feel
like most people peak in high school
actually and just personal opinion
because I feel like most people gain
weight in college yeah yeah like yeah
um but
like you get all these numbers but then
you you just start to like see the world
differently and just realize how Society
caters and favors women almost at the
expense of men yeah and like once you
see it once you start like looking at
the world through this lens you start to
flip situations like when a girl says
something you say it from like the guy's
point of view and you think would that
be okay and like 90 of the time it's no
it's so weird and it's like you can't go
back once you see it
and just the same way that men can't go
back once they realize women don't like
nice guys yeah yeah
it's true
it's true because have you ever tried to
you know did any of the guys know girls
who were really into like the idea of
the [__] walk right and then uh because
I knew girls who had boyfriends and they
were a part of that they didn't want to
be a part of it and the boyfriend I
asked her I was like all right cool if
you're gonna do the slot work where
you're you're basically you've got your
whole body out can I go to work on my
underwear he said no it's like why
where's the broke men walk
exactly you see what if that what if
there was broken like demanding women
like them that's what [__] are doing
they're demanding men like them imagine
there's a great sweatpants walk
down run that one yeah
where's the short man walk but that's
what all these movements are they're
shaming men into liking them the ageism
yeah that's shaming men saying like me
and and like oh single dating in my 30s
is the best even though 50 of your
options are gone by 30 like
I know see these facts aren't fun
and um yeah fat phobic so when a guy
when a guy like says oh you know what I
like skinny girls then he's fat phobic
or if a guy says you know what I don't
date single moms I don't want to raise
no one else's kid then he's the bad guy
it's like all of these things are
shaming mad
and even even when Kevin Samuel said
leftover women
I mean what else is there those are the
women that are left over
[Music]
I'm not saying every girl over 30 is
like it's over for her but what I am
saying is that if you found demand in
your 20s that you wanted to marry you
would be married so the man that you
want to marry don't want you
tough and so like if you're single and
I'm single right this isn't that means
for some reason the men that you want
don't want you
or you don't know where to find them and
you haven't put in the effort to find
them I mean how many girls have really
researched
if they want to guide a certain income
bracket what cities they live in where
do they hang out
oh yeah
yeah
gotta do some researching again she's
like
researcher
and you've got all stream yep
24 hours oh yeah we got it
wow what hour are we uh
my laptop just died
it's crazy because
um I think the [__] walk
me personally I think slot Walkers when
women officially stopped listening to
what men think what they care like what
they hear about if they care and whatnot
and I think I think that movement kind
of
put a stamp on when men can't speak for
women yeah for me personally because
it's like if they cared then um yeah
what I probably probably would have done
it like you're saying about your friends
go and whatnot yeah yeah did she end up
going I don't even know that about that
story but he told me I was like bro
that's crazy
if she did end up going there she
probably belongs to history so it
probably belongs to the streets because
it's like [__] walk fine but it's a gang
bang a walk so I rode my walk I want to
be a road man I just wanna I'm not
actually
I wear glasses and I work in office
yeah I mean I guess
it's like advocating for knife crime I
mean like if you don't also advocate for
knife crime with me you're a bad guy
it's like no knife crime is bad
do you feel we should take a book out of
like
Muslim culture yes where girls cover
themselves I think I personally think
that's where it's gonna added to because
I think girls have taken off their
clothes so much the only direction to go
is put on your clothes and then it's
gonna go to a level where
I think the Muslim culture has a lot of
obviously they have their own issues but
they have a lot of like it's a lot of
it's based in well from the outside
looking in it's based a lot in like
having a mutual somewhat of respect for
each other
even if that respect might come from an
authoritarian standpoint it's still like
having the respect to like do or be what
your partner wants you or needs you to
be like outside of religion obviously
they have their own the things that they
have to follow right and having those
sets of rules are also great because it
gives you a sense of sense of purpose
and there's a question I was going to
ask oh that was gonna do you think
people are really into zodiac signs now
because they're becoming less religious
as a whole I didn't want to find some
sort of a higher purpose women that um
believe in zodiac people that believe in
zodiac sign have higher narcissistic
traits fun fact yeah yeah I can see that
because have you read every horoscope in
the day and be like if you if you read a
horoscope read all of them and you know
and see which ones don't apply to you
laughs
it's easy to count the ones that don't
apply it than the ones that do yeah
because it's like maybe one or two that
might not apply
for the rest of them are just like look
vague it's like you're gonna put your
shoes your shoes on left foot first okay
[Laughter]
wow wow
I think you're all right though I think
uh Zodiacs and stuff like that it's it's
uh the world's becoming because because
yeah because the world's becoming like
further away from God like they look for
like a replacement yeah
basically the reason that that came to
my mind is to go back to your like point
of life should we move to the Muslim
faith and I'm like I think people have
already started to find their own quote
unquote religion with Zodiacs which is
why I don't think it can really go to
the whole putting clothes on because
everyone how how long do you think it's
going to be between now and zodiac
becoming an actual religion this is
spaghetti religion the thing is with
zodiac is it aligns with what you
actually want to hear yeah of course
yeah yeah like they give you what you
actually want to consume you want you
want to hear like all the positive
things about yourself even if you're in
the wrong place yeah that was a zodiac
Church how many people do you think will
go
[Music]
Legend is for women
selfish
everything's about me what are Zodiacs
about me
why should you leave a divorce for me I
want to be happy me
my happiness is more important than my
kids happiness me like that's that's
perfectly acceptable to say nowadays
you think about how selfish that is hey
it's crazy when like every time I went
on a podcast and this clip went viral
because I said if I have kids and I'm
married and I'm not happy I will say
because my kids happiness is more
important than my own and like to me
that's just common sense like if I'm a
mother like I would hope I love the kids
more than myself but modern women don't
they love themselves
why do you why do you think I've heard
of so many girls saying their moms used
to compete with them yeah yeah and get
jealous and and even a lot of numbers
suggest that men are better single
fathers than single mothers and they put
the kids especially financially they're
they're much better with their money
and yet women win them in custody
battles
when it's not it's not apparent that
they're better parents
which goes up I was literally thinking
it's in the train today
that a lot of people forget that men
love the kids too and that's really
weird
men are better parents over the age of
like seven yeah because because women
were chemically different every single
day like we all know whose mom was Moody
at times yeah
and honestly a lot of people I talk to
if I said would you rather if your
parents got divorced would you rather
live with your mom or your dad a lot of
people that I've talked to would say Dad
[Music]
um
um it's true yeah because even though it
does give the quote unquote tough love
that everyone wants to be oh you're so
heartless but the advice given to you by
your dad a lot of times is the advice
that you probably need to hear the most
because it's like he's coming from a
place of you know you have to if you
want to be successful you have to do
this well the mom's coming from a place
of if you want to be happy you have to
do this
and that's I think and that's like the
girl's new religion is selfish and happy
yeah I think I think a dad's advice will
keep you agile 100
and uh maybe for a girl keep you off the
stripper poles I like that and I'll keep
you off the streets so
um you know
like I think you're right I think that
that does come has to come in the
later stages of uh of a child's life
another phrase I'm a 10.
no I'm serious what is that that's me
that's selfish that's that's narcissism
I am the table yeah
it's like narcissism is women's new
religion that's a better word for it
narcissism is women's new religion
the phrase I on the table makes me laugh
because every time I someone says that
to me I was like you know what you
should do change the word table to
relationship and see if that makes sense
to you
I am the relationship
[Laughter]
change the word from table to
relationship and see if that makes sense
to you I am the relationship no you know
no no no no you know this is a mutual
thing oh it should be at least and then
we feminine feminism feminizes men too
they even even when we advocate for Men
We Do It selfishly because we want them
to be more emotionally available for us
so even even like the men didn't say we
want to be more emotionally available
like you know I never I bring men on the
tie all the time on my show I've never
heard a guy say I want to be more
emotionally available it's the girl
saying I want them to be more
emotionally available so even when
they're advocating for men it's still
about women
um but don't say that but they'll say it
will be good for us yeah it's good for
you
[Laughter]
do it and we leave
again
they want it but with stipulations if
you don't bring the what they want
wrapped up how they want it then I'll be
like I don't mind like that I want that
but
let me tell you how I want it so you can
give it to me how I want it well then
it's not natural I usually guys will
just not do it yeah
if you're giving me anything with
sepulations I'm just not gonna do it
doing it
again that's some guys a lot a lot of
guys out here might just fold and bend
the wheel and that's because like those
are the ones that are not getting
they're not getting any you know guys
are like that sounds too complicated I'm
just gonna do what works
yeah and that goes along with women guys
wanting women to be their peace and one
of them feel calm around them if there's
too many stipulations and all these
boxes they got to check before they walk
through the front door it's like
tired you're already tired before you
interact with her
tired from fighting everyone in the
world coming your house and I'm still
fighting still fighting with my wrist
can I sleep
and that's when I started listening to
Amanda's fear content and they started
talking about like what men want it's so
easy compared to what women want they
just want a girl that's fit feminine and
friendly and yet we still complain
that men are too picky even though they
swipe right 50 of the time on dating
apps where women swipe right between
five and twenty percent depending on the
study but they're the two picky ones and
every time I talk to them they're like
man they want the Kim Kardashian
hourglass shape and the guys are like
just not obese please that's pretty
that's not a whale
not a whale and girls are like fat
phobic and they're like look I mean 35
and under please and they're like you're
ageist I just I want a girl that can
give me kids ageism
all right you know what why does she
can't have kids yeah
which is like my minority of women well
she has both genders like we can
like what's happening
yeah yeah like like Gino what's his name
Gino d'acampo said if my Grandma had
rules she'd be a bike like
oh
was that that white guy that said
my Grandma had a wheelie she'd be a bike
[Laughter]
British TV
none of them did you get it
I'll send it to you guys okay
the other so the other thing with
feminism is that the
the grape statistics are incorrect the
one in four I don't were you guys on
shows where I talked about this yeah so
maybe you weren't so the
feminism will preach that women are
oppressed right and that women are
in danger in society and that men are
violently attacking women and that we
should be scared but men are more likely
to be victims of a violent crime than
women
and so often when I talk to women like I
was doing Street interviews the other
day and I was like what are we fighting
for and they said the ability to walk
alone at night I'm like I walk alone at
night all the time and I'm chilling like
I'm not in a bat if I'm in too sketchy
of a neighborhood I'm gonna be more
careful but if if he walks alone at
night in a bad neighborhood he's gonna
get jumped too like shitty bro where you
from bro
I was like like I'm not saying that you
deserve whatever and I hate when people
construe like what what were you wearing
to all she deserved it was like no
because I can't walk down Brixton 06
with bad change my watch on that's true
because why because I have the sense
knowing that something might happen
right um
and a lot of people don't have that
sense and it's like when something does
happen it's the other person's fault
like yeah of course the other person
should not have done that but to some
extent
you could have prevented a lot of
situations a lot of people get in you
could have prevented yourself no I mean
that's and I people hate that term like
what was she wearing and like they're
gonna get mad and I'm not I would never
blame someone but I I think there's
steps we can take to prevent things and
if we're not honest like
you like you're right with the chains
like someone's more likely to rob you if
you have chains out it's just common
sense if your whole body if you're
walking around at the [__] March naked
you might like someone else
that's another thing is when
um growing up when the shorts got
shorter to where you can see like the
under cup of the butt and then they'd be
upset that someone touched them and just
like
you're showing it why why are you upset
with someone like did someone said
something or like did something out of
the norm it's like if you don't want
them to do that then
don't show up but then they'll say it's
my body I can do what I want it's just
like well then don't get upset if
someone insists I'm like oh girl I see
your your booty hanging out oh you
sexualized me I'm like what do you mean
then wear a nun outfit like what the I
think touching's a whole different thing
though yeah
it doesn't give you the right to yeah
touch somebody nobody likes to just
unless you into that but just in general
that's somebody's personal space well
I'm not saying it gives them the right
but I would say it's probably more
likely to happen yeah it is and I I just
don't think it's honest to say like and
wear whatever you want nothing's gonna
happen like I think there's steps we can
take to prevent things yeah because
shitty people are gonna be shitty we
can't get rid of them like I'm not I'm
not I can't go up to grapes and say
please don't grape
I think all women have the right to not
be touched at all or sexualize in any
type of way but if you understand
um men's mindsets men are like dogs like
when it comes to sex and things like
that
um post not Clarity comes into play and
like men personal Clarity it comes after
the fact so the whole time they're
probably in their own like sex drive
especially if they see some type of body
bum or anything sexualized so it's very
hard for a man that has no self-control
to not try to try and control his
urges yeah and so
you'll find this is the weak men in
society as such but what does happen is
they will end up committing
forms of sexual assault on the basis
that they couldn't control their urges
so it goes back to the idea that women
can
put measures in place to protect
themselves from
malt like assaults in general yeah but
it just also makes me think though that
it gives men an excuse though like
because I can't control my urges yeah I
can do yeah they're not the same like I
can do this but like just because I
couldn't or I didn't have no self and I
could see it exactly I don't know if I
go back to my point with wearing the
chains and picks in the 3am because
obviously the the the guys who would rub
me I'm giving them the option to by
walking through the area but if I didn't
walk through that area A or B if I
didn't walk through with as much things
out I'm less of a Target you paint a
bigger Target on your back depending on
the stuff that you wear no one wants to
say these things right but it's true
right yeah and if I go to a if I go to a
store a clothing store and I've got a
tracksuit all of my hoodies up I've
painted a Target to myself to the
security guards yeah I mean because
they're going to come to me and be like
yo you look like you're gonna do blah
blah blah blah blah is that fair no but
because of the way I presented myself I
presented a Target on my bike different
places have different targets I just
don't think rapists are are thinking oh
I need an excuse to do this yeah yeah
yeah I just think I think it's a very
small I think one we another law I would
like to see I would like to see longer
sentences maybe castration oh
[Laughter]
I think if you grape a girl
yeah
less people would do it yeah look at it
would more people lie about it happening
to them what grape why isn't ghost yeah
we can make it equal if you lie about it
oh yeah same punishment would it be
castration often like the third or
fourth like
um would you call it handmaids too if
it's if it's a kid nah first no no no
Peter fitted is different sorry yeah
well too much just grape in general no I
think first because first could be a
false accusation there's no pattern of
behavior and therefore if you've made
that decision of castration upon the
first
um sentencing then
what happens when it comes to light that
he didn't actually do it so he wasn't
believed for six years and so like more
so I'd look at it and go pattern of
behavior I could understand but first I
it there's a there's a likelihood that
there was lies involved I don't know put
it into mice and give it back to him
okay I could see the argument for that
and maybe it just means we get
put measures in place but no I mean
I I just I think if you grape a girl you
should be castrated yeah I just even if
it was once why no no I'm not I'm not
just green like if you if you did it
then yes but I'm talking about
sentencing wise if they should at least
get life in prison they let these people
out yeah they let them crazy to me
that's crazy that you can grape a girl
and be out in 10 years and then they do
it again even less than that five yeah
which is insane to me unacceptable
but
not I say first one 100 shop it off and
I do well the first time would be the
answer but in the world that we live in
where people that live there you can't
really get evidence you have to there's
a whole bunch of hearsay objection but
just imagine like a girl puts a false
like oh he raped me and he really did
great oh sorry great sorry great
um and the world was like he got
castrated and he ended up that's what I
said put on some ice it'll be fine
I'll be wild but yeah I don't know in an
Ideal World first time yes but then
we're gonna have to have like a I don't
know a real life like lighter tender
test you can put on their helmets
system still is it's innocent until
proven guilty
like it's it's not easy to convict
someone of grape like usually they
reduce it to SA or something
like it's not it's not easy to convict
someone of that to be fair yeah what was
it like that college kid was he a
swimmer yeah we left the girl in the
bushes by like the dumpsters
you only got like probation that was
crazy yeah it was at um university it
was it like ucos it's like UCLA I think
it was UCLA I think I think it was I
know like a big that's a big yeah
it was like a big athlete at this big
place and they basically have
corroborating stories from different
people at that party that he did this oh
that one yeah and he left her behind
like a garbage bag behind some bushes
that's crazy yeah it was I mean I think
there's there's definitely Rich
privilege a good lawyer can get you
something
but I mean at least in the US it's
it has to be Beyond a reasonable doubt
that they did it it's not it's not easy
to convict someone of something a lot of
people walk for stuff yeah
and it depends what each state too you
know just what they what their laws are
and stuff like that but it also it also
but it kind of ties into like feminism
because like feminism if it really was
out there trying to protect women why
would they promote a [__] March no I'm
saying like why would you promote a [__]
March when women that sleep with more
people have high it's linked up higher
rates of depression it your marriage is
isn't going to be as long and walking
around naked more it's more likely that
something's gonna happen to you can you
help me understand the the [__] March oh
they wanted the ability to walk around
naked
you never heard of the [__] March I've
heard of it I'm trying to remember
there's been so many marches that I'm
like which ones the men are like oh okay
okay
you're like please please
everyone can just walk around wearing
whatever you want to wear God what is it
I do remember that in Oklahoma I was
surprised Oklahoma has this Oklahoma has
like a thing they do every year
um it's like the Naked Bike Ride so
everybody's naked everybody's butt naked
riding bikes in Oklahoma and Oklahoma's
like a big Bible Belt so I was like this
is happening in Oklahoma out of all
places I would expect that from like
Oregon or you know California or
something like that yeah Florida
Oklahoma
cause them I didn't get to well I didn't
want to see it but um
but like it was on TV they're talking
about you know they made it's a new
thing now they made it it's probably
been around for like three or four years
now but like then I could bike ride and
I was like why
I don't want to see yeah put that away I
don't want to see that
and the men are like only if she's
skinny
like why do you think nudist beaches are
one of those things that kids love to
idealize and dream about because you get
to see naked women but now you just call
the middle man and said oh no you just
be naked in the street anytime and it's
a nude beach nude Beach's entire little
boys
well the idea of it does
practicality because practicality is
just middle-aged people like with stuff
that you don't really see you know a
little bit older than you think they
would be
oh gosh you know it's funny it's like
feminism said okay let's
let's let women sleep with whoever they
want and the men are like okay you have
to work the men are like [__] okay
and they're like they're like and let's
put them on birthstone control so they
can not know me like not nothing will
happen guys are like okay
you don't have to marry him to get sex
no matter like so why are you guys
they're like
it's too good
because you're a demon all the time
that's the catch the spoon of the devil
no matter what I do oh that's crazy it's
like they said go to work more
um have more casual sex with less
commitment
and and the guys they're like yeah even
if you get her pregnant she can go get
an abortion
this is like the perfect world for a guy
a small percentage it sounds amazing
sounds amazing sounds amazing but then
but then you see all the 10
[Laughter]
that's so true
and I think women want a guy that makes
I forgot what the percentages I wish my
laptop died otherwise I'd look it up but
I want to say it's like they want a guy
that makes at least 50 more than them
that's wild maybe thirty percent let me
know in the chat I bet the chat knows it
wow always knows it more did you see um
might take a while did you see the I
forgot who it was mediocre reviews he
did this thing where he was talking to
some people and he had a panelist on and
this lady with her full let me know let
me not be mean she was she kind of
looked like the 10 out of 10 you had the
other day I guess just keep it there let
me be a nice guy and say that right
so he's like yo a lot of women want
hypogly and blah blah like um and fifth
they want someone who's earning 100K
like 50k to anyone who knows money is
enough to live off right and then she
said that's not enough for the house
that I won
and then when he called around I was
like you see that's exactly what I'm
talking I was like no no but my
standards and blah blah blah oh I I had
a girl call into my YouTube and say she
wanted she was um like 30 or 31. she'd
never had a relationship 56 is the
percent oh 56 okay yeah yeah she this
girl had never ever had a relationship I
would say she was slightly overweight
um and she demanded a 200 000 engagement
ring
and I told her and she and her her
reasoning was because she felt like guys
cared that she made a lot of money I
don't care and I men don't give a [__]
about your career it's like it's like a
shoe collection to us like when we hear
a guy as a shoe collection it's it's
it's cool like nice but I'm not like do
you care I don't know yeah or a baseball
Jordan I mean if they if they clean cool
tonight
the same size I'm gonna put them on
but and then and so she was under the
impression that because she made a lot
of money like she was attractive to a
guy that makes a lot of money and I tell
her I'm like
you you you're I think guys want girls
younger than you and she's like oh no
they don't I'm like okay and and uh and
at the time I was I was dating a guy
that like that had a good chunk of
change and I'm like you could be
learning something from me if and like
I'm from a family all my brothers make
six figures to be honest that are older
than me anyways and so I'm like I talk
to these guys I know what they want it's
not you
and it was just funny she kept scoffing
at the guy's like other guys because for
every reason she's like oh he's five
nine I'm like what but you're fat I'm
sorry
I just thought I came up with too much
lit it's like the lady on um Kevin
Samuels the one that like blew up
yeah average at best and she was
um talking about everything that she did
and whatnot when I first saw that clip I
was like he's so mean like why does he
have to be so mean there and then I
watch the whole video I'm like he's
telling the truth because nobody no man
tell me if I'm wrong no man's gonna want
an older woman with a teenage child and
she has baby daddy problems and she's
starting a business
yeah it's just like I don't want to deal
with that but man I just felt like the
way you said it I just spells headache
like
first of all you've got a child that's a
couple years younger than me that's
already you know
but on top of that you know you've got
baby father drama and you know baby
father drama that means that you know he
can always come back and you know on a
good day he might smash get me so it's
like that's that's another headache and
um
and you're older you get me so you're
not even as buff as girls that I could
probably get to get me so it's that for
me it's just it's just headache it's
just headache like I can't really deal
with
those those old problems and I can't
really even personally can't really deal
with all of that stuff I want peace on
problems always
that's just kind of what it is it's like
any any excuse to start an argument over
I don't know it's like
because guys can look at things and be
like this might not benefit me but I
understand the generality of why it's
here right and a lot of modern women
can't do that like if if it's not okay
like you like you said before because
everything is Catered towards like women
these days it's like the the times where
it isn't are the times where they get
the most mad and it's like what because
of the three things that we have
and men aren't able to be this
delusional well not only women can get
that old to be that delusional because
I'm I'm sitting there and I'm telling
her I'm like look it
and the nicest I'm kind of I'm pretty
agreeable so I was I was in a nice way
I'm like I think I think they want
they well they don't men care about your
money well the men I talk to don't care
they care about my money I'm like are
they broke yeah and the broke men might
care but a guy a guy that has money it's
nothing to him and yeah because you know
she's not going to spend it on you no
wait no no
whether you have a million or 200 pounds
in your account like you're not gonna
spend it on me but if I have a milliona
mark how you would expect me to spend it
like me to pay for all the bills pay for
all your bags pay for whatever but the
thing is I understand that as a guy I
get that you get me but it's like you
have to pick the right one that you want
to do that for to be honest well I think
I think I think men are like I think I
think men for women are are very kind
and they're very much willing to spend
money and time on a girl but the problem
is they're tired of spending money and
time on a girl that doesn't appreciate
it yeah and they're sick of of wasting
all their time energy and resources on a
girl that doesn't appreciate it and then
feeling used because they're like what
the f did I do all that for and then
it's like they're a little bit more
they're not as quick to do it for the
next girl because like the last girl
used them wasn't that like a statistic
that didn't dates for first dates are
actually decreasing in number oh yeah
because people uh because like men are
like I forgot what it was enough I don't
even know this is a real thing but like
the amount of first dates that dinner
dates is decreasing because guys are
seeing in a lot of these a lot of amount
of women are just using the dinner date
to get food from you so it's like if you
want to date me let's do coffee if you
say no to coffee then I know you were
here some guys are there we have to do
the deed before I even take you out yeah
because if you if you can't
especially with the coffee well like the
if you do the cheap one and she has an
issue with it and that means that she
there's one thing that she values it
wasn't you if Drake asked her to Coffee
she'd be going yeah
she's going okay I prefer coffee dates
because I don't like it if a guy like
expects something so I'd rather just
keep it like low investment than have
him expect something and and it's if
you're crazy I can leave yeah you know
yeah and it's like middle of the day so
it's not like yeah you're fine
the most part
yeah yeah I don't
they call them steak daddies
tell them Jess what's the steak daddy
mistake daddy is someone that you
you just call to get a free meal if you
know that they're gonna pay any time of
the week any any situation you just say
hey like let's go get dinner you know
they're gonna pay so that's your steak
daddy you can save it I had a friend
tell me back in college she she told me
you need a guy to have um to get food
he's always going to pay for food
someone to call when you just want to
listen some someone just to hang out
with and then someone to take you places
you need to have those people in your
phone and she was like name them those
names and I was like
no I'm okay but they call them steak
daddies so if you're thinking that they
one day wanted to get something would
you not would he be allowed to
I don't know the rules was she sleeping
with him
what'd you say was she sleeping with her
steak Daddy
I don't I don't know
but I would say that if he
if he offered it or if it was just the
right situation it would have happened
I don't know I don't I don't know the
stipulation in the rules I just know
they take Daddy's yeah well I just
crazy to me that every single standard a
guy has it's it's like girls just [__]
on it and they'll call and it's funny
because if if the if it's funny it's
always the girls that don't measure up
to guys standards they'll say they'll
call the guys broke Dusty like but you
don't see men going around I'll call
women whales
but but men typically like they don't
they just say oh I don't date fat girls
and then internet erupts I like a girl
that's submissive internet internet
erupts because I think men are trying to
find the nicest way to say it but there
isn't a nice way there's no nice way to
say the like because it's like you can't
say I don't date white girls
because what's the nicest way of saying
that gym [__] you had that thing where
people just assume that you date out
your race I know I I know I am yes but
like people walk up to me like you
definitely day white girls it's like
what what does that even
yeah yes I do but I hate I hate your
assumption
again again I'm retired guys
like why would you assume that but yes
I hate that you know that also Asians
also blacks but like yeah
it's my my ex-boyfriend was black like
both of them and they both I feel like I
wasn't their type like typically like
they typically dated black girls and the
next girl they dated was black I was
like the only white girl they dated
so like they always say like leave you
for a Becky I'm like I have had the
opposite experience
[Music]
what I got the reverse
like yeah tell us more yeah I don't know
back it again I need to preface
everything I'm saying in this in this
period of saying I'm retired I've been
retired for two years your girl's not
gonna kill you bro don't worry no she
knows you know just in case the comments
start moving why
[Laughter]
not stop who I am finding out where I
live
but yeah it was a thing where
um because I was not
so after and then I was right
it was just anyone and everyone right
five six eight I had a threesome
um
yeah that didn't end up too well I was
weird anyway tell us more yeah
yeah what happened
um Spark Notes I went to a night out uh
one ghost like talking to me in the
night out I went at the end of the night
I went home with her her housemate was
walking with us back to her house her
housemate started acting all jealous and
mad like oh you guys got to have fun so
I said you could join us if you want as
a joke right genuinely hand on Bible it
was like it was it was just like
tongue-in-chees someone else if you want
and she was like yeah well and I looked
over the girl she said yeah I'm like oh
oh okay cool this is happening but then
halfway through turns out that the girl
that I was talking to at first um I had
a boyfriend or something so she like
left of him crying like halfway through
and then go one gets upset leaves the
room starts crying I mean go two is
still going on go one comes back and
like stops everyone it's just like no
this isn't happening anymore you have to
leave it's like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
wow but yeah if you the thing is if you
throw yourself in situations then you're
gonna find yourself in weird situations
and it it takes you going through that
to realize that that's not the life it's
not fun like in the moment it could be a
little bit fun but like I mean it only
wasn't fun because girl one kind of
spoiled yeah I mean yeah
[Laughter]
what does that mean
that means you got Sean Paul bro you got
some game hey but what does that mean
I'm talking about in an introspective
like I smoke a lot of weed
type of self-selection yeah yeah
if I have for threesome that's not a lot
of guys go through that that's true it's
true anytime people say uh play the game
never have ever that's the first thing I
bring up every single time did you did
you um did you finish with the second
girl or was it like was the Roman ruined
was the crap like I just got a question
for once I'll go up to 75 oh come on
yeah I was vexed you know I laughed
[Laughter]
were you in the first girl let's go to
him
[Laughter]
all right we said earlier once the tears
started I'm not about because this can
turn into a situation that I can get
called anything they could they can say
that yo I wasn't distressing x y and I
said and all these things were playing
through my head now that's why you just
don't fall for Tears bro and get again
I'll charge no I'm good
but she's she's not crying because of
our charge she's crying because of her
oh yeah because of her own thing exactly
so why would you think anything hey if
the second if gold number two starts to
cry as well because I don't know she
feels bad about goal number one they can
both say that they were crying and then
I look like
yeah have you so one thing I've heard
from guys is that when they start being
like more of a hoe and they start like
sleeping around it kind of ruins their
perception of women for them because
they see the amount of girls that like
hook up with them with boyfriends yeah
yeah and like I've heard guys tell me
stories where they're like yeah I was
hooking up with this girl and she goes
to the bathroom and is calling her
boyfriend yeah or something like that
and then they're like yeah it's like the
girls you'd never expect the girls next
door all the girls so it it it changes
their perception of women because when
they're the boyfriend they don't know if
they can like trust the girl yeah
because um the Hollister model friend
had a situation like that right
this is so crazy
so he plays a sport that is
non-disclosed obviously I'm not gonna
just in case people go on my uh
he plays a sport
um on his team
um with another guy uh he started he was
sleeping with this girl turns out that
she was dating his teammate and uh
that's not where it gets crazy so so
one night we were in the nightclub right
this girl is absolutely nuts right like
I won't say her nickname I'll maybe say
uh some other point because it dates
around but um
so we're in a nightclub I mean my guys
my housemates and then the guys who
didn't go out text a group chat like um
there's a girl in our living room right
she said she knew one of you so I opened
the door like uh so like does anyone
know this girl so we're going around
like does anyone know who you could be
in this house right now like like the
Hollister model cut off with this girl
weeks pride and said yo once I once he
found out what was going was like yo you
can't I didn't know that blah blah blah
so she literally she comes to the house
around
11.
we don't get home till four she's still
there
sitting in the living room not saying
the word to anyone right anyone else who
was in the house was just sitting there
just like this just don't know I just
for five hours all right all right so we
get back and then we walk in we see who
he is I'm like oh [__]
yo you're up you have to go do it that
way all right so he takes him into his
room
and we all kind of thought oh no this
might happen again but he basically had
to like
quietly berate her which is something
quietly berated her and be like yo don't
come back to my house like that again
especially when I'm not here like that's
really that's weird it's weird that's
scary that's and then that's like but
because again you also have a boyfriend
so she came to a man's house while she
had a boyfriend yes it was too damn bro
they didn't break up like let's say
let's say you do a thing with a girl
right
and then you find out that that girl is
actually dating one of your
acquaintances right
and you're like wow that's kind of mad
because she never told me hey she was in
a relationship and B I didn't know the
person that she's in relationship is so
close to my circle right
and you tell her to cut off and instead
of just cut off cutting it off
she starts stalking you coming to your
house when you're not there she starts
moving moving to you in nightclubs with
the boy from right next to her she
starts yeah she's yeah yeah yeah
it's genoasia oh [__] you know in that
situation yeah
it depends on my relationship with the
guy
um
it depends on my direction of the guy if
the guy is my friend if he's my friend
like I respect him you have to tell him
I'll tell him you have to tell him I'll
tell him right I'll be like bro
you have to watch that go blah blah blah
tell him whatever but if he's not why do
you know that Bob I'll tell him
but if it's like
if he's not my friend hmm
I wouldn't really care what about if
he's an acquaintance that you respect
yeah if I respect him yeah if it's
someone that I respect I would tell him
but if I have respect for him even if
it's like oh it's an acquaintance maybe
he's friends with my friend and they do
business together or whatever but
there's some sort of respect level like
I respect what you do or I expect what
you're about do you understand I'll tell
you do you understand but if it's like
if it's just anybody that can equate us
it's my friend's friend but I don't know
him from anywhere that's his teammate
though but his girl this girl's coming
coming to me bro be careful I think you
might look at it from like you it's not
your business
like that's that's your girl bro talk to
your girlfriend at some point because
you're intercepted you've inserted
yourself into the business
she inserted you into the middle I've
heard guys say and one guy say I did her
a favor
those are the Savages not him I did him
a favor oh yeah I did him a favor yeah
yeah
isn't that usually after they they slept
with someone that they didn't really
necessarily want to sleep with so now
all of a sudden I have a heat it's
actually a graped her uh touched
inappropriately or she did him a favor
no no it's all right the boy is telling
another boy the Boy oh I did you a favor
because like you didn't know your girl
was a hoe before and now that I've
smoked Oh I thought you were a favor
that's a Savage
no it was married apparently
still goes to uel you know him oh my oh
oh my God
that's not a secret it's on the live
it was on the line yeah I'm gonna have
to go back through the line oh gosh
there's like 50 episodes Good Luck
um okay so I have okay
around the floor I have
um I have some comments from this post I
posted I asked what comments people
wanted me to ask like panels
um so explain this contradiction women
always make I wish I wish men would just
leave us alone and not approach them in
public like at a bar or an event to
start a conversation but men going their
own way is misogynistic and they hate
women
foreign
so men going their own way is like a new
movement where men say I'm not getting
married anymore so it's like that
miracle and extreme so they call that
misogynistic but if men approach them in
public they'll they'll be offended yeah
those are the stipulations again yeah
there's tons of conditions I think oh
a lot of modern women have been
Sean took have their cake and eat it too
all right you can't have it both ways
you can you can find a balance of the
in-between or both but you can't
literally have both of those answers you
can't they can't leave you alone and
talk to you yeah
type of music exclusive they're not the
same like literally follow up with it
yeah
and this doesn't go out to every single
man but it goes out to the majority of
men which is the men that the women
don't want yeah yeah so I think I think
there's never a wrong time for the right
person and it's always the wrong time
for the right person or whatever however
that goes the wrong time for them yeah
that's always the wrong time for the
wrong person
approached any of us here
that's what I'm saying so it's like when
whenever the right person approaches you
it doesn't matter where it could be in a
club coffee shop it can be at the
library whatever it's always he's the
right person doesn't that go into the
fact that they're kind of being
dishonest with that statement because
again it's not the actual Act of talking
to you is the the act that you don't
like him and you don't want to say that
out loud because it's like if you say oh
no you can't talk to me because I don't
like you that pains you out to be
someone who's exactly what you are like
people try and hide their hands and
that's kind of we've been hiding their
hands a lot in the last like because
when third wave feminine releases really
start I would say about 2012 maybe 2011
Maybe
that's when I really started like I
think there's only one feminism I don't
I don't think there was different waves
I believe there's waves I think they're
extreme they're a hate group from the
beginning they're still a hate group now
hmm
yeah I think there may be waves too
sorry I think I kind of agree with you
on that I just think like now
um a lot of like feminists or everybody
has their own idea of what feminine yeah
feminism is so like I've I think I've
seen like some like group of feminists
who were like they don't hate men they
love men so they're just working on I
guess things that will help women
um and then there's the ones like I hate
men men are trash so I think there's
just different definitions different
groups even but even the ones that are
less I just find they still have slight
undertones of hatred for men it's just
not as obvious yeah it's kind of
entrenched in the whole movement
yeah like I I don't think you can
I I find it rare that I find true
feminists that actually like like men
and don't don't
sort of paint them as a lesser than
women
okay because they say things like women
empowerment but if there's male
empowerment people would be like yeah
man empowering him empowerment is
misogyny but do you think like with
feminism a per would a person be a
feminist if they didn't agree with
everything feminism stands for would
they still be a feminist
um
I don't can you repeat the question so
like
obviously depending like what people
think the definition of feminism is if
somebody
doesn't necessarily agree with
everything that they think feminism is
would they still be a feminist like to
like let's say me and Jess are both
feminists right and she thinks feminism
is this this and that and I don't agree
with everything that she thinks feminism
is it depends on the conception you want
to say yeah the concept of what you
think feminism everyone thinks feminism
like each person thinks what feminism is
well I I think
I think that's kind of common as women
like it's to kind of blur definitions
like my truth is very common but and
feminism is the equality between men and
women but I I think reality is men and
women aren't equal and will never be
equal and and so I I just think anyone I
think well actually there's Rolo has um
a belief that anyone born after 1965 is
somehow influenced by feminism so I do
think everyone's influenced by it in
some way but I I think
that
I think feminists hate men
yeah but like don't feminists have
arguments between themselves about how
much it's like it's like with each
student it's not how extreme are you how
much of it yeah they hate men but that's
all they talk to their friends about
yeah
because they're dating all the same men
um okay do you notice how men are
portrayed in films for the last decade
women must be the real heroes in the
story they demon they demonize men beat
them up and portray them as bad toxic
and stupid and everyone laughs and
cheers
yeah it's kind of not even a movie it's
not even just in movies like look at all
the sitcoms with families if you look at
the The Stereotype for all the sitcoms
of families it's fat slob stupid father
Family Guy American Dad oh he's not fat
he's just done like all of a fat dumb
stupid lazy father woman the smartest
person in the house that fixes
everything low-key kids uh if the if
it's a boy it's a rendition of the dad
if it's a girl it's a rendition of the
mum
um Chris Meg yeah uh Lisa but
uh in Bob's Burgers Gene and the titles
the mom is always I never thought about
that wow wait say that again for me
in a lot of these TV shows not even just
the movies right
they depict the families it's like the
same thing the daddies is really dumb
really slow really backwards guy the mum
is like this whole like smarter than
them right for the household what could
a household backbone and the kids are a
small version of whatever gender
they are the small version of the parent
that the legend is of so Chris is a dumb
idiot like Peter but Meg is smarter but
less but lesser scene and less less
light because she's really the secret
hero like like Lois is in a lot of
episodes
kind of like Simpsons as well and Lisa
Lisa is really smart both the daughters
are really smart the one son they have
is an idiot and it's about is a demon
child
get in even That 70s Show
Kelso is an idiot
the girl is smart
the the other guy's the stoner the girl
is smart Scooby dude is Fred though Eric
wholey it's Eric or Donna Donna yeah
Donna's the more yeah that's but that's
how they have it in all the TV shows oh
my gosh that's wild to think about it
yeah could y'all think of any movies
where that is
um every movie you've made in the last
15 years that has both men and females
to some extent like like obviously is
different I can't think of anything like
Captain Captain Marvel did that but they
in movies they do it slightly
differently because movies have to end
on like a message or whatever so like tv
shows will hide it right in like the
characters in the character building
movies especially in the last like 10
years will overtly be like women women
in power she did it because she's bad
she did it like you would never see uh
you would never see a macho man like the
way you saw back in the day like as the
good character the superhero movie but
it looks so stupid having all those
girls like fighting out there
I mean when you look at it look when you
look at that old school superhero movies
like the men were all muscular and stuff
like that when you look at nowadays
superhero movies
like that the Hulk the Hulk is
Black Widow in real life ain't doing
[__]
[Laughter]
trained by the CIO give a [__] we have a
guy who [__] shoots [__] lasers
out of his arms and you think this
doesn't go with two Glock lines and her
hands gonna do anything tonight no come
on and they're always skinny the girls
too they're not even like Jack they have
like the perfect body which isn't you
know the idea isn't isn't jacked yeah
Iron Man suits made of titanium or
whatever and you're telling me that what
if you went to go on the 1v1 against
black widows you'd win impossible
impossible like actually impossible
because even Spider-Man will wrap her up
from
he's a kid I was trying to think even
before Wall Street
oh yeah yeah I mean I mean granted that
was a true story yeah I think it
probably did go like that especially
because of the lifestyle he lived yeah
but it's everywhere Kings of Queens if
you remember that show yeah
I love those shows and you're like he's
[__] dumb she's the actual brain to
the group they don't have
um the Titanic that's an alpha Widow
that's what happens in the movie because
that's why they they say this in the
manosphere five seconds of alpha trumps
a lifetime of beta are those those
orgasms will last a lifetime
because think about it think about it
she's with the she's with the faithful
beta the the guy yeah she he and even
the notebook too even the notebook
they're both Alpha widows because that's
the guy they did everything for her they
gave her the provider she meets the hot
guy in the foam Cannon party what does
she do cheat and she's an old lady still
thinking about the guy she met on a
freaking cruise ship in new for like a
week yeah and and it's the same thing
with the notebook she's with the new
provider guy that I thought I thought
that girl was such a hoe when I was a
kid I watched that movie I did not
understand the draw I was like Mom Dad
she's cheating she's cheating how is
this okay he's so nice and and like what
is she doing she's hooking up with this
guy and then they somehow these are two
of the biggest Romance novels of our
time are women cheating so what does
that say about our society what does
women want to do they're all these girls
why do women love these movies because
they're with the beta that they don't
want and so they and they're thinking
about that X that they don't have and so
they watched the movie and it resonates
with them
yeah and so because what percent of
women really marry their first choice
yeah I feel like that's such a low
percentage Yeah it's like 10.
what percent of women marry their first
choice and if they don't they'll die
like they die alone and that's what's
happening and and it's crazy because in
that movie like
that that that is an alpha Widow wow
that's crazy and how I hear obviously a
lot of girls like oh my God I love the
notebook it's so romantic I'm like
how no Titanic same thing I remember I
remember being a kid and being like I
remember telling telling my parents
because I don't have a lot of friends
like it was my parents
and so I was like Mom Dad it's not love
this is lust they knew each other for a
week like I was doing my tangents even
at 12. yes like this they're not in love
like she knew the guy for a week she's
gonna pedestalize him the rest of her
life now imagine like a 12 year old
Pearl doing this yeah
this YouTube was meant to happen
I haven't always known I was going to be
a you like I always knew that someday
something would happen like this I
didn't know what but I always I always
knew
okay
um
um oh I should I should read the super
chats I haven't read them in a minute
right yeah okay and they're still super
chats oh they're going for the whole 24.
I gotta I gotta pull up my laptop I will
say guys for the 100K Mark I'm I oh gosh
oh gosh I do appreciate all the guests
that have come over the last couple of
months because I for real would not be
able to make the show happen if I didn't
have guests so you guys are all really
really important for this show to happen
um especially just just came when no one
else would come she was she was one of
them I think you were on my first show
right you're on my first show and I kept
I kept having her come again and again
and again and it's funny because if you
watch the evolution like from when she
first came on to now it's like night and
day and she actually she's hired here
now so
and and a special thanks to ish who has
improved the quality of the production
she's got multiple cameras multiple mics
he's gonna have call-in shows this week
right
that is the plan that is definitely
we're gonna we're gonna have it this
week we're working on the audio but yeah
anyone knows anything about college
okay let me let me read the super chats
but I I seriously wouldn't be able to
make it happen without you guys so I
really appreciate it
um all the people that gave in their
time energy attention to me for free and
all the people in my DMs that help me
like
fix audio earlier like when I was
struggling with the equipment there were
so many people that DM me with like
quick fixes and just ways to like do
things so really appreciate it really
appreciate all the super chats
especially early on because it helped us
build this studio and the super chats
today because hopefully we can get we're
trying to get eight cameras in here ish
tell me how much you thought that would
cost eight cameras
for the cameras that I wanted yeah
um said that should we get the cameras
we want or should we settle
[Laughter]
but you know we're talking about um 15K
yeah I can do that that's easy
so we're trying to raise 15K for cameras
so hopefully we can get that in the next
couple of months
what soon yeah soon hopefully okay
um so Alan Maxwell panel we are in we
are just in transition to something
better for women and men the mismatch of
expectations is is just a symptom of the
transition thoughts um
I haven't seen any evidence that it's
getting better I'm not gonna lie to you
I I really like the hopeful person in me
likes to think that I just haven't seen
any data to indicate that it's getting
better
so I haven't seen anything yeah I really
hope yeah I hope but I'm I am an
optimist I think at some point there's
got to be a reset like at some point
women will face consequences because the
free like the Social Security is going
to run out and all the handouts are
gonna run out so it's either find a man
or be homeless and I do think at some
point women will pick an average guy it
just might be at you know 50.
um I'm afraid that's going to be like
two generations away from now though
maybe possibly oh my God it probably
won't be your kids I think it will be
sooner sooner yeah because of the way
money's running out and the scarcity of
it I think it will it will literally
come like a
Flash and it will happen and then you'll
see
I think the next big recession I think
we're starting the recession yeah but I
I you see people get together when
there's hard times because they they
literally like we need men and women
need each other yeah the part of the
country usually that's when men and
women usually go today
gender roles feminism doesn't really
exist in that jerk online
it doesn't exist in Congo evil yeah
when there's when there's a war where's
feminism you know what we will cook
I shall stay at home I mean we could try
us the women in Ukraine they said oh oh
it's a Western World phenomenon um
next Super Chat James Newell congrats on
100K Pearl thank you thank you
um okay man Drake
um I went through a Hot for Teacher
stage in my late 20s dated older women
had a ton of fun but regardless of what
they said three dates in they were
moving things and creating our new life
together nuts have you guys found that
yeah yeah that does happen sometimes but
like
yeah it's Monday when they won when they
won it
some some people just need to have it
like right there right then so they'll
do anything in their powers
to just live her in yeah um and even if
it is great
um okay Jay John 40 40 and USA there's a
white guy who graped a black child and
in her front yard after busting over the
head with a shovel he was served no time
WS is real
WS white supremacy oh wow white
supremacy okay oh maybe John said Pearl
the P the wrong people have been
exonerated on death row when they're
innocent you trust the state that that
executes people when they're innocent
not to screw up castration and
castrating innocent man Mt
um my truth is narcissism
um 90 for Tope um by the way I'm 6'4 Max
U.S work at a bank bills are paid 90 for
Tope there's a Bible verse to steal a
strong man's treasure you must first
bind him and then you can steal his
treasure why is masculinity on the
decline to ruin the family
Mt truth and accountability are the ban
of feminism in real life you don't get
to Cherry pick to be equal only when it
benefits you John Smith something I wish
we could understand when we see Johnny
Depp's Russell Wilson's Will Smith said
send us to the message that no matter
what you do you will never be happy
these men can't if these those men can't
make you happy nothing will ascensus
Megan oh this is back to Megan Good
dated okay
um
it's brazy out here in these streets
it's really scary let me make sure
before I feel good for my kids
generation okay okay there's one yeah I
can't imagine what it's gonna be like
hold on one more possible versus
probable women will hold on to the
thought that they can pot they can find
the right man but the older and older
they get is it probable
um okay and then so I had another
question
is a career and a higher education
really the best option for women
as a career in higher education yeah
we're all we're all Masters students
um
no depending on what you want from your
life right if you want
to just work which again people say they
won't but again like Kevin Samuel says
when you get to 50 and you have no kids
and all your friends have kids you're
gonna be lonely right but if that's the
way little life you want to live right
then sure but like if you're gonna if
you want to be happy no
so I didn't get it so you're saying that
higher education is not needed yeah I
don't know I I
all right I think like honestly I could
do what I'm doing without a degree I
don't I genuinely think most degrees are
worthless yeah a lot a lot of the like
how many people went to UNI to do
business you don't need to go to you
need to do business it's business so I
couldn't hear you yeah how many people
went to UNI to do business like think
about it I did yeah exactly
and it's putting women in debt we own
most of the college debt that's where
most of women's debt comes from and
there's not an Roi on it because
otherwise we wouldn't be in debt if we
were making more money than we spent and
so it's like it's it's further putting
us to be homeless plus the option of an
apprenticeship isn't really given to
people yeah or isn't really because I
didn't know about an apprenticeship
after until after I finished my first
time my first in the uni I've done a
full I've done four years
and then and then when I changed career
paths and I was like oh [__] if I want
to go back to UNI I'm gonna have to pay
out of my own pocket right and I was
like oh let's look for other avenues to
work and do that at the same time and
then I found an apprenticeship and I was
like why isn't this told to get to to
people from a young age why isn't it the
opportunity if you want to do the uni
thing that you can do it but you don't
have to pay the debt the company you
work for pays it for you you still make
money from working in a company so
you're making money from a younger age
which probably means a benefit both guys
and girls in those situations because
especially for the girls because you're
you're in the game a little bit earlier
you don't have debt so you can get out
the game earlier I think it's the
environment that you're in yeah so like
I was
um I I'm from east London originally
Stratford that's where I was born and
raised and I moved to Essex when I was
in my teen years and I found that
I was exposed to so much more beyond my
horizons when they moved out
wow in East London like I had dreamed my
dream was to become a PE teacher so all
I knew was school home P like I wanted
to become a teacher that was it it was
only when I moved out to Essex when they
started telling you okay you can get an
apprenticeship oh you have options you
can um go into business you could learn
a trade you could I had no clue that I
had all of these options and then I
realized the environment's different I'm
now in a place where
my horizons have been broadened
um I'm no longer in the so-called Hood
yeah and it just you find that
based on your environment you have
access to certain things
and even actually changed because
because apprenticeship is free but
that's just access to knowledge that's
not even access to like resources
because everyone has the resources to go
on the internet and look for and but are
they exposed to it exactly yeah like you
say exactly they're not exposed to which
is really are they exposed to the
internet no yeah to the idea that they
could go and find this particular idea
in a different avenue because I feel
like a lot of these a lot of modern
women who go to university if they did
an apprenticeship group they'd be a lot
happier long term oh no that's that's
the problem like
and women seem to think they're better
than guys that don't go to school even
though school really
like the the educate so I did my senior
I was it wasn't sorry I wasn't economics
major and I did my senior thesis on um
the decline in dogma of American
education so when they subsidized
education in the 1960s they basically
said they're like Oprah the government
said everyone should get a loan this
isn't fair only rich kids get to go to
college so let's give everyone a loan
regardless of if they could afford it so
it was like you get a loan you get a
loan you get a loan sounds nice right
but the problem is when you give loans
to people that they can't afford it they
can't pay it back and so colleges said
oh the government's giving everyone a
loan let's increase the price so this is
this is an American thing so but let's
increase the price of the of college and
um because I mean why wouldn't you if
you're if you're selling something and
the buyer gets unlimited money to buy it
like why would you not why would you not
up the price but they didn't have to up
the value they didn't have to make sure
that the kids learned more like there
weren't all these extravagant college
campuses before like they I see rock
climbing walls on colleges why the hell
do we need a rock climbing wall to learn
and you see this binge drinking culture
it wasn't always like this like college
was a lot harder and I don't know about
you I was an economics major and I
really didn't find it that hard and I
and I didn't really feel like it
transferred to real life experience and
you you see this because girls will
graduate with master's degrees and get
minimum wage jobs and so it's like yeah
it's and it's it's back to feminism
because they're saying oh go to college
get educated but then what happens they
they're in debt do you know the
percentage or like what the highest
um
group of women is that isn't like
married or is divorced do you know that
status what about what percent I think
of um when I say group of women like
either white black Chinese oh um Asian
of ever married I just know that it's
like Asians are the most married I don't
know where Latino women fall I know
white women it's like 50 are married and
black women is 25 are married or ever
married
75 don't get married and out of the 25
that do 85 percent are initiated by
women
yeah because I was thinking about that
earlier
um just how
when you were talking about when you're
educated
you're you look at a man differently if
he's like on the same level as you or if
he is on the same level as you and I
know that
um black women are one of the highest
educated like women's group across the
board and I was thinking I was like does
that play into why like black women
aren't getting married or aren't married
or getting divorced and it's like should
we not be educated but then you tell a
black woman to not get educated and
you're like well who are we going to
depend on we can't depend on nobody
because everybody's against us all this
other stuff I don't think it's I think I
I wanna I don't know if I'm wrong but I
want to say that black women are more
obese yeah than other races
and so if I had to guess I think
that's that's more of an issue than say
I mean education probably is part of it
I would guess
but
um I know the average black woman makes
less than the average black man so like
they still at black men are still out
earning black women but I would guess
it's probably more
um weight
yeah my my theory is the um they use the
black female population as the beta test
for model women
because all the traits of modern woman
that has like seeped into into
everywhere right it's traits that if you
look back it's been trades that like
stereotypically black like I don't need
no man you could say [__] that type of
[__] it started with the black community
and my favorite like I'm probably wrong
that they beta tested it with us and
then everyone because you know we make
Trends
we made tons of people follow it I mean
yeah it's happening everywhere like when
like every every race of women is
getting less and less married and
getting fatter and fatter
it's not like everyone's doing it
everyone's doing it but yeah because
because even from like the what the 70s
80s black women were saying my name ish
men ain't this uh he's a dead beautiful
flying out everywhere but no one could
say what they were and my theory is that
it's literally just
they took that and sort of it worked for
whatever they were trying to accomplish
and then just
you know you know it's another red pill
truth um plant Parenthood is basically
like eugenics
you heard that in the U.S anyway have
you heard that so Planned Parenthood was
start started to um like eliminate the
black population basically and so it was
started by Margaret Sanger and she she
um was like she believed in like keeping
the race races pure I think it's a
eugenicist am I saying that right I
don't think so I don't think they'll let
me know in the chat but basically they
they put planned parenthoods in black
neighborhoods and um
and basically like the black population
would be doubled today if it weren't for
Planned Parenthood so it's it's weird
because it's literally like they're
accomplishing the goal that they that
they set out to and nobody cares wow
that's crazy it would have been double
that's so no that's really crazy and I
oh my gosh I I want to find someone sent
me
this stat oh my gosh I wish I could find
it but
it was something about like the birth
rate like what percentage of black
babies are aborted like when they get
pregnant and it was it was stupid High
wow I I wish I could remember what it
was maybe they'll let me know in the
chat but it was when I saw it like I I
didn't think it was real I thought they
were making it up
and I did not know that at all
I feel I fear for the world no but it's
like all these red pilled fruits are
just like yeah it's like once you see
this stuff you can't look at the world
the same I should probably be the phrase
of this whole Channel
and it's just weird because okay imagine
if Nike was founded that way yeah people
would be outraged and like like even
even statues they'll pull down right in
the U.S because that person was a slave
owner or whatever and like fine fine
that's that's fine but why don't they
tear down Planned Parenthood because
they don't know they don't know again
it's going to be another like what
40 years maybe 50 years until people see
the actual effects of of that maybe
and then when they finally do it's
either going to be too late or
everyone's going to use the whole same
hindsight 50 50 that they use to save my
Martin Luther King was actually a bad
guy you know oh it says black women are
the most enrolled not the most educated
most enrolled
um
yeah that's what it says in the chat I
don't know if they're right or not
um
but
yeah I don't know when I when I found
out the thing about Planned Parenthood
that like blew my mind because I I just
couldn't believe that that was still
like a Live Well legal
it's like a it's called The Butterfly
Effect to some extent one little Ripple
will change a lot and you won't even
realize how much it actually changes
until you look back
x amount of years from now like oh yeah
okay quit Okay
um
sorry guys some people are coming in and
out of the podcast this is a 28 bye bye
Sasha thanks for coming
um we're doing a 24-hour live stream so
it's like sometimes people are coming in
and out oh yeah yeah yeah
um
but I wish I could find that stat
should we order pizza is it about that
time yes
know
people
um okay guys
hold on
y'all what what Pizza should we order
I'm sorry so guys we're trying to keep
up the quality of the show and obviously
during the night time
um it's just gonna be me red pilling
just because who the hell is up
I don't forget unless you all know
someone in London trying to pull up let
us know but I'm about to get pizza
um ish has to order it tomorrow
oh my God I'm starving are you hungry
yes I'm so hungry
okay let's
okay let's get pizza let us know in the
chat what pizza should we get
um
what's that app they have here so in the
US they have ubereats they have
we're getting pizza-ish
do you like pineapple on your pizza
it's okay I prefer just pepperoni okay I
I I'll eat some pineapple okay yeah you
want to get the Hawaiian one oh yeah I
wish you guys they're Domino's out here
yes there is you have to go on the
Domino's app or the Domino's website to
order it okay they have wings they have
cheesy bread
yeah but not this time oh they don't
are they closed
yeah they're closed
okay hold up okay
would you
sometimes sometimes when I'm talking a
while I can't tell if I'm like scaring
them
scaring the guests yeah yeah
I'm like I'm sorry I'm ruining every no
I think that um
I think that throughout the thing
throughout the podcast
it was for me when I was sitting there
it was just like it was setting in and I
was like realizing things throughout my
life and I think that's what was
happening with them I don't want to
speak for them but I get to see the
gears like turning in their brain just
how you see the world it really does you
can't unsee it like once once it's seen
it's like the world is I don't want to
say ruined forever but a little bit Yeah
like when I was sitting over there and
we were talking about everything I was
thinking about just like my life and
family members and situations and I was
like
what in the world is happening like this
I I see it now I see it and I understand
it now and I'm like my goodness yes get
a pineapple one or like a Hawaiian and
get a pepperoni
okay ish does owe us dinner on Saturday
he's taking he's taking me and Jess out
to dinner he's he's a player
I'm not a player guys you will know me
I'm just a guy just a guy
um
okay do you
I'm I'm low-key going to go change
all right so I need you to Red Pill him
while I change I'll be back I try to do
so my best pineapple
pepperoni what and
this was the third one you guys are
putting pineapple on pizzas or yikes
[Laughter]
they have wings oh barbecue wings if
they have it
I like how the whole stream is here in
your order
to facing it with you wow she told me to
Red Pill you I've been read from myself
yeah because I've literally like because
I was saying to these guys before I've
watched you guys this stuff for a while
so I've seen your journey of what of
what's your journey and it's like it's
cool to watch because it's like it's fun
watching other people learn
things are like innate
to groups that aren't theirs yeah all
right so it's like once you once you
broke through the threshold and you
start to see what life actually is just
like do you think the world would be
more beneficial if they started having
like a red pilling class I think the
world would be more beneficial with uh
young boys with red pills from like an
early age though really yeah because I
think a lot of the boy can I stay on
this it kind of like I think a lot of
[__] that happens right
is um because they're just allowed to
get away with it because of how the
society treats them if they don't get
away with it so if if kids if young boys
from an early age realize that this is
all set up against them and it's like
there's no what's the actual part of me
doing this like I'm not gonna bend over
backwards with someone who wouldn't bend
over backwards for me and I'm only going
to bend over backwards for someone who's
going to bend over backwards for me and
the world becomes a better place because
it's like everyone's as equal as each
other and yes it took the guys basically
just shunning a lot of these ideas to do
that
I can see that but like hey I was doing
and that would uh
I think it would be a reality check for
a lot of women to know that oh he's he
knows what I'm doing and he knows I'm
not gonna do this for him because it's
funny when me and my girlfriend get an
argument because it's like I see it and
sometimes I point out like I saw you did
that I'm not letting that side and then
like the whole attitude changes I was
like yeah I saw that
that's crazy like it was because I think
um mine and my girlfriend's religious
was really good because we were able to
like even if we disagree and stuff we
can at least have the conversation and
trying to understand where each other
was coming from and I think that's kind
of one of the biggest issues with today
you ever are on one side or or on
another right obviously with feminism
and red pill they all kind of Polo
represents of each other but but like
peace
[Laughter]
yes why can't we all just get along
[Music]
because Society doesn't want us to
you have you seen the theory that this
is all applied to just get keep us
confused so the evil powers that be
behind the scenes can do what they want
because if the men and the women are
arguing about dumb [__]
then hey they're distracted the
politicians can do whatever they want in
the backgrounds
it's
the red pill like just the red pill in
general it's
it's so it's simple but complex at the
same time yeah but once you get it and
once you see the things it's like damn
really damn it's like it's like that
whoa whoa whoa how long how long has
this been like that's why I asked Pearl
earlier I was like how long is this
that's been around has been around since
the beginning of time is Hawaiian
pineapple yeah it's pineapple ham I
thought I know he doesn't know
because I think the the first kind of
like red pill thought that I had in my
head when I was a kid and let's think
about it it probably was but like at the
time I wouldn't think it was uh
women are trash
men are trash women are trash but the
difference is men know that trash
um
like a trash a guy Who's acting crazy or
moving mad subconsciously at least knows
it right right they know they just take
they're just going as far as they
physically can with it they would push
it as far as they can yeah but a woman
who's being as toxic and is being trash
hey they don't they don't even
have the fathom to understand that they
are being trashed a lot of time and it's
like mate
and yeah again when it comes especially
in the early stages my relationship with
my girl it was a thing where like you
said the only time she would understand
where I was coming from was like okay so
would you let me do that to you
like no it's like okay then
what was the third what was the third
Pizza
oh we gotta get oh
um pineapple pepperoni and I said Wings
what do you like oh I don't think I'm
gonna be
was that not a third Pizza no I just
found pepperoni she wants pineapple
whatever if you like both of those and I
think if you get the largest we should
be good whatever Pizza you get you have
to add on to what you're getting them
for on Saturday hey
[Laughter]
it shows me dinner Saturday I'm so
excited sweet victory yeah so we had we
had a bet today okay to eat a bat on
when we would hit 100K and yesterday we
all we all put it in this chat to see
like who who who would guess first so I
guessed between 10 and 12 today we would
hit 100K what did you guess I guess
between
um I think it was two and four like
right now two and four okay and then
um ish guess tomorrow no like today like
10 no 10 or 10 a.m today yeah of little
days
hey there was some Rick and people I'm
telling you guys there was freaking
involved
okay yes as you know I post a million
times about it yeah but you had a
tactical Post in order to make sure it's
not my fault I knew I had a viral clip
coming I my audience loves Wiggles
what I what am I clearly what is the
coffee now
as well
that's exactly what she knew was gonna
come my thought process I was like oh we
just did a podcast and people are going
to review it you're gonna get a ton of
followers from it I was like it may
happen during the the live stream
oh man
girl how how do you feel hitting 100K oh
yeah and a follow-up story what's the
craziest person story that you have like
what's your favorite story on the show
um
and
and like so I'm at the point in my
business where like I'm hiring people
and I'm trying to get like the the parts
the pieces moving so it's it's I try
I've tried to remind myself I'm leaving
my dog out I love her too much
um I'm trying to remind myself to like
enjoy it because you like dogs I love
dogs okay okay guys I love dogs you're
on the couch so everyone can see her
yeah come on Ellie come on thickums
[Laughter]
she barks sometimes you're right by the
mic this is what happens when you live
stream for 24 hours you get to see the
behind the scenes
but it's hard it's hard to like
um enjoy sometimes because it's it's
weird I was thinking about the two sides
of success right but oh God yeah if you
want to take her off the couch
but I was thinking of the two sides of
success where it's like you want to
enjoy like the come up because that's
the best part in your career is like
when you're hot and at some point like
I'm not gonna be hot anymore and it's
gonna fade and you try to enjoy that but
that it's like when you're hot you're so
busy and so and so stressed that it's it
can be hard to enjoy at times so I try
to like
come here come here
I don't go that one
Lori Lori Chloe
um but I don't know I'm I'm really happy
like I I think this is like it's good
the most fulfilled I've been like I I've
never every job I've had I've always
felt like I didn't fit in like I was in
sales and I worked in corporate sales
and I just couldn't be as creative as I
wanted and like
um I I worked on Tick Tock for like two
years I had like no success like trying
to do that YouTube I had no like I had
very little I mean I guess I got a lot
of followers but who cares about
followers if you're not making money so
um I don't know it's it's like this is
the first thing that I feel like I'm
good at and that I'm like meant to do
yeah where everything else I've just
always felt like there was like because
when you have a YouTube personality you
know from a young age that you have a
YouTube personality that's why a lot of
famous people when they're young they're
like I knew someday I'd be famous like I
never thought I'd be like a world
Superstar but I always felt like I would
build something like I didn't know what
it was I just felt like I was gonna be
known because in every Community I've
been in like I've always been the person
like talking to everyone and like
throwing events or like so I don't know
what it was and but it also it kind of
makes it hard to fit in with people
because when you're unique you stand out
and that's great but it hard it's hard
to relate to people yeah because like
like no one knows what it's like to be
like I'm energetic all the freaking time
I don't ever I don't I don't know how
like
I don't know how to relate to people
because it's just there aren't many
people like me yeah so it's like there's
a there's a double-edged sword of a
YouTube personality but it's interesting
because the closer you get to YouTube
it's like you meet people that are that
are more like you and it's so fun
because because you're like oh my God
you don't shut up either we can both
talk for an hour straight
no wonder it pays the bills yes exactly
like I I met my friend Ally
um and maybe she's watching I don't know
but my friend Ally
um it was so fun because immediately we
were just like friends right away and
even me and Jess like when I met Jesse I
was like I I told her I never remember
people's names she's on my basketball
team and I was like I I remember you
were and you didn't know how big of a
compliment that was and now you know now
I know yes I'm like oh I didn't know
isha's name for like a week wow
I'll go by many names
why do you think I start my shows that I
said everyone introduces
it's because I don't know you know
what's great as well about your show
it's not like there's a lot of red post
shows that are like try to play because
the way that some people Pander to women
to try and sell stuff to women it's the
same way obviously in different respects
that people panned to men to try and
sell stuff to men right like I'm not
sure if I could I'm not sure if this
could cause a beef or whatever fashion
fit I personally don't like them right
I'm not a fan of them because it's like
they take everything four steps too far
and they don't really live in reality
and you could say that's their reality
but and it's like
but you make it seem like it's
everyone's reality and it's just isn't
some of it is right and it the part that
annoys me the most is the arguments that
have basis in truth but are mostly lies
like which ones like uh
like they will start off by saying men
and women different and men can cheat or
differently but then they were trying
they'll go on like a 20 minute tangent
on probably what they should I know
they'll go on on a thing where it's like
oh any any man who uses any of these
things or simps whatever but then you
find out who's on seeking Arrangements
oh yes and stuff like that and it's like
so you're sitting here just lying like
it's just my my platform's a little
different because I don't I don't really
give advice yeah you don't really see me
telling people what to do I'm sure I
mean there's a lot of hours in me
talking on the internet I'm sure you can
find me telling people to do something
but but I just I don't I don't like
lying to women that's what I don't like
I I don't even tell women to prioritize
family I say there's consequences if you
don't yeah 100 and and you know I'm I'm
lucky where I I always have a fallback
plan and a lot of a lot of women don't
and I I just don't like lying and I
don't like women like I just feel like
everything in your fault life is your
own goddamn fault and I'm just so
interested from women telling me a
different goddamn excuse yeah and I've
I've been the stupid girl like I I've
been cheated on and it was my own damn
faulty I literally look at like if I got
cheat on is my own fault because I
picked him yeah I I picked him so so why
on Earth am I gonna be I mean don't get
me wrong I'll
but and that was just a lesson that I
had to learn like don't I'm not going to
say I've never felt bad for myself I
have but it's like
life is easier I think when you just
take accountability for your own actions
yeah because then you can learn and move
better in the future exactly because
I've been cheated on once right did you
take her back
no
like I took her back before for done for
like other week because she had like
things a lot of anxiety problems and
stuff so like everything so like
especially towards the end of our
relationship you should like break up
and and he wants to get back and back it
wasn't me I was just in a bad place
whatever
but um she cheated on me
with this other guy and then it was a
thing where I hate the other guy for a
while that I hate myself for a while
then it came to realization of like it's
probably just there's probably a lot of
signs that I just missed like red flags
that I missed
but then this is the only part that
fills me with a little bit of indication
she cheated on him with a girl right and
she and she's like lesbian now and then
like maybe that was the problem exactly
it was like they're engaged I was like
oh I guess it wasn't me
it was you not me yeah it was your own
sexual preferences here it's not me
fun hello wow 3am 3am it's three a.m wow
that's when the pizza is gonna get here
oh dog I'm about to say it out 250 so
three Basics
I know I'm sad too Jesus I'm hungry now
oh yeah didn't you say you haven't eaten
all day hey guys we're here for the
content yeah
I'm saying so like we gonna struggle
through it and we we go
we're putting on a show I can't I can't
promise quality all 24 hours
I can promise we'll do the best we can
you might see me tomorrow if I can be
also come back from work but I might be
tired
we appreciate it what time do you get
off
9 30 to 5 30. all night oh yeah it's
true it's true nine three to five thirty
come on back we'll be here hey we'll be
here we'll be here but I'm happy I'm
happy I I came and to talk to you guys
because it's fun it's always good to
have these conversations with people
yeah yeah you were you were a last
minute guest yeah it was he messaged me
never had availability and I was like
you know what
okay because all of my guests showed up
but I like to have so the reason people
always ask for smaller shows but the
reason I don't is because if they don't
show up yeah so today I just wanted an
extra like I was like oh I could use one
more cushion in case someone cancels
yeah and I was that cushion that's
that's a that's a that's a rule mate
shoot your shot you never know right
oh you never know because I was
literally saying for like two weeks I'm
gonna message I'm gonna message I'm
gonna message and I didn't and I did
look at me in here you're on the most
important one yeah
I was I was like oh his Instagram looks
normal okay yes yes thank you so much my
very tiny girlfriend and was like how
the hell
I didn't look that closely I was just
like okay he's like there's other people
so you said when you were shorter like
life was different when did you hit your
growth Spurs I hit my growth spot in um
I I hit two one in the
uh in the end of year 11 going into
sixth form right and then one in my
second year of uni wow all right second
year of uni yeah that one was crazy
because I went from like five foot eight
five foot nine in the in the first world
so I went for like five eight five nine
to six two all right in one summer I
don't know what happened to my brother
yeah he was like five five though yeah
boom because it hits guys later yeah his
guys and it's the thing where like I
didn't even realize I was growing until
I go back to school and I know my
teachers were like yo what the what the
[__] happened to you and I was like what
do you mean it's like you were like down
here
and the thing is I guess it didn't help
me go into an old boys school as well so
what's up I went to put his potty ah all
his Polytechnic school for boys
no in East London I have not heard of
that one you know Road man like that is
that is a popular thing out here that
I've noticed people going to all boys
schools and um
do you think it's
beneficial or like I don't say harmful
but not beneficial I think I think it
definitely has its benefits and it
definitely has his drawbacks
right the benefits are
as your own gender you were able to live
in your gender's truth you know what I
mean like there's there's no reason
for you to change like in my classes
there's no reason for you to change up
your attitude because there's no go to
impress or there's no like there's no
like hierarchy you're trying to hit
because everyone's like obviously
there's got the school bullies and you
go to school nurse and then whatever and
that's the thing but like
when you insert goes into prepubescent
slash pre-person boys
it becomes the thing where it's like a
dick measurement comes the contest to
some extent right everyone wants to
outshine each other but like
at least I can only speak for all boys
school but like going for the old boys
school like
like really like a lot of my friends say
this dude didn't go to old boy at school
like
my school was closer like everyone was
closer to each other right every year no
like till this day right when I was in
year 11
and guys were in year seven and I see
them to this day
I might have only spoken to them three
times in the entire time that was there
but they know your face you know them
everyone's kind of copacetic because
there's not really any
like beef a lot of beef that happens
with guys is because it goes yeah always
four girls the same it's the same with
girls
with guys yeah it's because they were in
the same ones yeah you're fighting for
the same guy whatever the betas are
fighting the betas are like why do you
keep
there was like a chart where it showed
like this is like what a 20 man looks
like and like show like what the other
looks like because I just want to like
kind of do they have a delusion
calculator where you put in what you
want in a guy you want to do it here yes
you read my mind let's see live on chat
people first illusion shop measure
share your screen can you pull it up Ash
right can you share your screen or no I
I can share my screen okay okay so if
she's gonna we're gonna put in our
requirements it's gonna be terrible
because we're tall yeah no the height
really effs it up like negative 20. yeah
but don't even try the thing is how do
you how old are you guys again 25. oh
yeah I got two friends for you you guys
need that 27. I got two friends for both
of you you guys need them
sorry female delusion calculator
um he's a lawyer he played American
football back at Uni uh yeah yeah he did
and he broke his name because the female
delusion calculator right you know
that's funny I don't to me it's not
about income it's their Income At what
age yeah if it was my age if he's making
an average child he's my age but if he's
45 it's like how old is he yeah
like okay how old are they is this the
one question number one
I'll go first I'll I'll because it's
gonna be yeah so okay age
um so I'm 25 I could go down to like
when I'm 23 22 22. why not
45 45 yeah all right cool excluded
marriage
I can't date married guys okay okay race
that's like a seed in your eyes why
Asian or black yo don't put white
[Laughter]
I mean girl if you don't do the poem say
it with chest so don't say it so I think
I'm gonna put
no I mean
occasionally just say any yeah okay six
foot higher or you could do five ten you
could do five ten five five ten okay
real five times not you guys I'm so
tired that's a six four and a half
a real Five Ten
um are we um excluding obese of course I
mean you'd be surprised you'd be
surprised this isn't Jordan
[Laughter]
minimum income
um okay it depends on the age but I
guess is it in US Dollars yes
um I'd say like
20 like 23 okay if he's 23 right what's
and I'm guessing you'd expect him to
have less money what's the minimum there
40 boy Whoa okay American afraid right I
was about to say four years because I
mean that's what I mean when I worked in
sales my base was like find out I'm
commission okay ideal man probability
whoa yeah what is it four point five
percent noise
delusion to score three out of five yeah
yeah it's an inspiring cat lady did you
put black in there or did you put all
braces or races so it was just because
of the 40 000 I had to take out the
married and the and the height the
heights what does a bit yeah I'm
confused because
that's that's still half of guys like it
doesn't seem like I put anything that
crazy but it should also give you like
an option to put your height in the
situation down to see how delusional are
you actually being well you can you can
do that we'll have the guys do it too so
do just do yours now okay I'm next yeah
with me all right let's get into it age
minimum age
minimum 14.
we'll say 25 25 okay all right cool 25.
um um oh Max
um
we'll go 45 for all right cool we're
saying excluded marriage
uh yes yes yes yes okay uh
um race
you already know all right let's get it
uh minimum height
minimum height
I'll say 5 10 right 10 exclude a piece
hey do I have a maximum height or is it
just no no there's no maximum
um exclude obese yeah all right a
minimum income
um
see I ain't got the the thought process
Pearl does I don't I don't know
um
oh yeah you can't even see the screen
never mind
um
we'll say
30. okay all right cool yeah all right
let's find out
so probability oh my God
uh 0.99 and that is seven percent
yeah oh that's because
I give up you know what wait now do the
do the male delusion Google Mail
delusion what did it say 0.9
0.92.
what was I under on the delusional was I
a four out of five wait let me oh yeah I
think you you got you got it you
definitely got a cat bag yeah yeah you
go yeah you four out of five yeah uh cat
Enthusiast
um a dog Enthusiast bump them cats this
makes me sad because I have a dog and a
cat at home now okay so I'll be looking
for the male one way
[Music]
it's okay because we when we you when
you hit your wall what we can do is I
can do some wall reaction content
I know but it'll be great for you too
yeah um at least you could be at least
you can make some money depression do
you know where the male delusion
calculator is
um I think just Google it it doesn't
come up I'll have a look that's a harsh
reality yeah it hits you like it hits
you hard Jesus
[Music]
there's anybody out there that wants to
save me
0.92 remember that
[Laughter]
maybe I should maybe I should give the
others a try
no no no not like that I'm talking about
the other races she said a white guy was
cute the other day I did I did it happen
sometimes it does it is I feel you
there's some Asian boys that are cute
too so the Asian guys just are never
taller than you yeah they're like for me
Asian guys are very attractive I just
think they're never they're never taller
they're very small yeah quite small yeah
it's a race oh it's um realitycalc.com
thank you torsha
cheese wow we appreciate y'all staying
up I know it's like a different time in
the states no that's just awake yeah
it's just
the time West Coast and everything we
found it all right let's let's get into
40K average means 50 make less than that
oh that's why we're delusional down yeah
I should add in the broke guys I wasn't
sure I was like okay
my boy you ready not that's like um I'm
ready 30 here yeah yeah oh yeah it's
true all right so
minimum age minimum age
um I'm 26 so a minimum age has to be 21
21. all right mine's a bit young uh Max
this is hypothetically yeah Max 32 32 oh
okay 32. uh excludes married
yeah excludes mother
yeah
race any
maximum height
six eight because like she can't be
telling over me that's crazy
how tall are you bro I was six five this
is six eight and she's looking down at
me six seven school then
I mean I'm so confused six eight pushing
it six seven I kind of your logic is not
logical six seven is the highest I can
go anyway all right go six seven yeah um
does that exclude overweight of course
minimum income starts from zero
what's the minimum I'd like someone to
make yeah
um we have to convert it to dollars from
dollars from from dollars so tell me
your tell me what's the minimum wage
minimum wage it will get you what 17K
yeah put a slap on a 17K yeah
17K so you're talking about 20K dollars
wise yeah so 25k oh it's kind of reason
um
find out I'll finish it
my ideal woman
probability
5.7 percent wow roughly 1.5 million
women in the United States meet your
ideal woman standing wow well minimum
wage
oh wow two out of five kind of at the
same no no you're not he's down to earth
[Music]
I got like four percent he got five yeah
that's so similar what do you mean I'm
talking about the cat lady thing the
rating he's out of two you're right okay
yes you gotta do you oh okay wait wait
wait hold on hold on hold on I picked a
high of from basically major upwards you
just have to work and
oh no yeah I met the single mother I bet
a lot of women
obese and single mothers but we were
ruined me
okay
but like I'm not even girlfriend's
looking better yeah
hold on to that one oh good she died all
right so maximum age
at your age now I'm 26 in it so like
it's like
I think I think I'd go I've seen some 30
year olds that are looking
wonderful
special I lost my virginity so I have a
question come on you guys I wanna know
if this is I did a pull on my page I
said would you rather have a girl that
it has
um a butter face and a normal body or or
um wait a super oh it's hard super hot
body and butter face yeah or average
body really pretty face
hmm that's a really tough one actually
I think I might have to go with face you
pick face because
wait what what was that I'm sorry
um Buffet's average body average fate a
bad phase buff body wait like body or
face what's what what do you prefer
stuff right yeah it's tough it depends
it really does depend like because I'd
say I could say body here but I know
she's got a banging face I'm taking the
face yeah perfect the face is the first
thing you see yeah it's interesting when
I pulled up most guys said body I can
imagine most guys yeah buddy yeah I can
imagine that but I don't know because
this might be another one of those
things where like I'm being the type of
people I hate when I'm just continuing
to something like oh she can I can take
her to the gym
I was taking care of she didn't care
she's just doing some squats it's fine
but like them being the exact time I've
heard that guys tell me that like a butt
gives a girl a point or two points yeah
this is what I've heard from them yeah
best best
the point is strong it's a strong
question
could even be like a
yeah that's all you needed
because guys will have sex with only one
point and about well two points and
above two out of ten I swear to you but
yeah I'm talking about wife I'm talking
about a wife yeah a wife yeah I mean the
yeah I had a point to you
let me give you a point
um okay what'd you get it all right let
me um go back and find out I won't put
that up on us we try to hide it okay
so I was like yo let me just let them do
that
um so with all my requirements that I
put I got a 7.3
oh
yeah
um this is the least delusional the
least delusional is did you put single
mothers nah oh no did you put overweight
no
I think I put less money oh I'll take a
broker
I need 5K though only five kilos I'm not
that I'm even too fussed about the money
it's not yeah the reason I said minimum
wage and slap that honest because I want
you to at least not spend my money on
stuff that you can buy yourself that's
that's kind of it
I have a spocket yo says according to
Stats men preferred women who could at
least Mumble didn't care much if we
could speak
yeah yeah yeah that man them are not
getting picked a little yeah yeah yeah I
respect it as an average it's probably
it's definitely true yeah
uh what percent of guys so women want 20
of men right where would you rank
yourselves in terms of what percent of
men are you in I'm an AE but I'm I'm I'd
say with the career I mean did you say
top like 10 top 20s where would you
where would you rank yourself I'm top
I'm top 50 with aim and room to get
higher because with my career with with
the work that I do in the place that I
am as soon as I get charted like I said
my my pay increases by a substantial
amount and because I've done like other
things in the field which are similar
but not the same I now become as soon as
I get charged and I get my
qualifications I become a specialist
I'm so confused you just we can all see
this but you are six five yeah I know
you do realize that's put that puts you
in the top 20 I'm also skinny
you're six five yeah no no but like you
do realize that puts you in the top 20
oh yeah again and then you're saying
you're you're almost a chartered
accountant which means you're making a
certain amount put him in the female
delusion calculator let's see how rare
you are let's see how rare I am okay
let's see six five yeah I I don't I
don't think you've thought this through
oh no yeah the thing is I think I think
I'm I want to say I think when I heard
that question I'm like oh
it's one of those guy things of like oh
I'm not going to put myself so high
because I can still achieve more but
like
yeah I just don't think you've realized
what you've got yeah we're saying how
much money you make on stream yeah I'm
on 30k right now 30k okay as a trainee
let's see how rare he is I'm 30k right
now as a trainee but that boosts up to
50 or once I finish getting my degree
and I boost up to like 100 off at that
point
it says Pearl you got 4.5 not 45 I know
I know
him Jesus
yeah I think me being too bus case for
me like I said but yeah I think there's
a lot of things that like about me that
annoy a lot of women
like I don't I don't mind being a bad
guy a lot of times and I think that puts
me down percentage points because women
want submissive men more than men what
submissive women these days these days
but I'm seeing that shift more and more
you've got options unless you make it
apparent to her that you don't believe
you have options that's what they take
advantage that's true I do have options
I just don't use them okay okay so um
howdy I'm 26 26 all right sorry
oh seven each as well
um
you've been playing both from yes I'm
like 15. we've definitely been around
the same group definitely you know do
you give him the age range of like I
feel like most girls would date a guy
between
21 to yeah do like 21 to like 40. all
right okay
um black
exclude married because he's not married
I'm not married he's not married all
right so black yes I am yes cool Heights
minimum height six five yeah
Co excludes obese exclude obesity and
I'm very much so 30 kids like 40K in the
US yeah yeah so 40K like here find out
yeah this is gonna be a breezy thing
I gave myself uh
0.000 I'm looking at myself really badly
basically so we said I asked him if he
like where he'd rank himself
yeah and and I and so then I said let's
see how rare he is let's put him in the
delusion calculator he put himself into
50 yeah I said I gave myself like a 40
but I think that's me being
self-deprecating
0.00
0.001 of people in this world you can't
find Brothers like you yeah you said 50
yeah I said 50. you're a rare breed
wowzers only getting rare as time goes
on trying to find out where I'm at hey
do they have one for females I want to
know how rare I am yeah
[Laughter]
okay
I'm probably there that's why I already
found out I can't be rare this is
probably zero percent you are nobody
like you I know I'm on 2.6 yeah
I'm so confused
about yeah 2.6 if you put in the if you
put in the black it puts you down
because that's it
yeah okay the black thing yeah the black
things I think that's the difference
because because it is true because like
there's a lot of friends that I even
have right
that like
obviously a lot of them are like success
stories in their own right because
they've like made their own name from
like music or like art and stuff like
that but a lot of them are just in the
life and don't leave the life
because once you're in a hood sometimes
you just stay there unfortunately like
sometimes you just stuck the
it's just down to how
because
I'm working class about the thing about
me is
uh my family in like in Nigeria
I like government for some reason like
like they're my first cousins are like
really rich like super rich so I was
like I think again with the mixture of
the having a female best friend thing
with the whole have a family who's
really rich to see how the other side
really opens your heart like all these
experiences open your eyes to like what
it's real and what is not yeah
I do have a question for you and ish
this is something I've been thinking
about do you think that
being a black male
gives you a little bit more like um do
you think that
doesn't he talked to have you told
depends on demographic if I'm in a
certain area where there's less black
people may be seen as a um high quality
or or opposite the opposite yeah it
depends you can either be yeah it really
depends on a lot of things because where
I went to UNI was like it wasn't a lot
of two black guys from London right so I
think that probably helps with the whole
why I was able to like
sow my seed I don't know I don't want to
call it 30 of men under 30 are over six
foot in London so there's more tall guys
here yeah
the right City bless the Lord
there is more black tour guys oh there's
hope for me yet that study was in
America it was not here it was not here
sorry guys if you can hear something in
the background there's the kettle don't
worry about us we walk
power needs some tea
it's almost done yeah
warming naps I'm not sure to work in the
same clothes as I did yesterday what
happens
don't even worry about it
[Laughter]
where were you don't worry boss we are
just no I'm here at work
just know I made it hey my mom made it
30 more minutes there goes that man
there goes that man
interesting yeah because the thing is a
lot of my friends don't even know that I
subscribe to the red pills quote-unquote
red I always say quote because like I
think it's like an innate thing because
I don't like why people say I I think
the phrase it's not like I don't like it
it's just whenever I hear people call it
the red pool Community it's just like no
it's just like no facts of perfection
for the most part
what um what men in mainstream media
would you say
uh like outside of YouTube are
quote-unquote red pill like Community
mainstream media doesn't really save the
pro yes
but like it's very it's almost hidden
yeah like you you wouldn't be a
mainstream media speaking about red pill
because
it's not even like subconscious it
doesn't run even when subconsciously
even when there's a problem how many
times are you trying to cast him ah okay
okay
everyone from Every time from every
young women like LGBT any anyone he
talks about tries to constantly because
he's too quote I did it again
he's treading on them yeah yes he's just
talking about it and they don't like him
are you looking for honey Pearl
let them know what you're saying they
want to hear oh I just I was just asking
she was looking for honey Cooper honey
cheese I think there's more going on
here than just a friendship oh guys and
we do spend a lot of time together now
After Hours the hours they want to know
what you're doing in the kitchen Paul
says she's making a coffee I'm sure
is it's a 24-hour live stream should we
sleep on stream yeah you probably get
money from that there'll be some people
that would tune in yeah be like oh hey
we still have 600. two girls shout out
to my people that stayed up with us
you didn't see like a green and white
like I did it was on the bottom shelf in
that cabinet that's open
have you seen there's actually have you
seen those sleep streamers
I've seen a Ludwig do it yeah
great content yeah but the fact that it
exists kind of yeah I've seen it and I'm
like
you just have a camera just chilling
there and you're sleeping and they're
like for real sleep asleep and they wake
up
I wonder I wonder if they like take a
clip of them sleeping and they just
played on the league
for however many hours and people are
like oh my gosh
they open the same way I can't believe
you got 10 or I was asleep I'm so
jealous
wow guys next year me and Jess are going
to look together what if we just
streamed our on a second Channel we just
streamed our whole life everywhere in
the apartment we watched reality TV
just had Sim stream as a question not
this stream hasn't like yeah
torsha I like the way you think yeah go
get that bread sis
Ebony and Ivory is what we're gonna call
it
[Laughter]
so I'm guessing you guys would never do
an only fans
okay it all depends on what type of only
fans I like to sell some feed pictures
on only fans we should make it only fans
where we eat sandwiches yep messy ones
um y'all's getting to that time
you can sell your underwear yo there's
people who sell like cute tips on only
fish yeah you can sell your underwear I
can't sell some I've had people offer to
buy like my leggings before because I
had a Tic-Tac go viral where I like let
the dog in and
um like someone and I was just curious I
was like how much but I couldn't get
over the fact like
that I would have to I'd be sending like
I just know what do you do to it he's
gonna smell it and just wear it yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
does it smell like Monday
hey Tulsa really coming out with the
ideas what'd she say she says
Sim stream
with twitch
men paid women to sleep yeah yeah yeah
it's the things they're both things
let's just monetize our whole lives yes
I'm here for it if I can get paid just
to live stream well we'll have different
we'll have different streams in
different areas of the house okay hear
me out we'll have a sleep stream right
and then we'll go to the kitchen we'll
cook we'll be cooking stream yes we'll
go on live dates I'm I'm here I'm being
so serious I'm here I'm so serious I'm
so I can be bought yes
what you'll want to see let us know in
the chat nothing you know the line guys
and also I'm tired of the chat stop
arguing about how attractive I am I look
it I don't need to know it's always like
she's a four no she's a seven no she's a
10. she's a I'm a guy she's a 9.60 she
can't choose seven can't choose seven
two seven I'm like guys yo the first
time I heard Kevin Samuel say that I was
like because he was he was talking to
the girl and I was like I'd probably
like College time he's like you can't
choose seven I said oh well
you were a five six
that rule of the can't pick seven is
such a great rule it is literally as a
human if you're modest you'll always go
always go and I even did it to myself
okay he didn't say seven and a half yeah
I respect it good question yeah so I I
put red pill questions for people for us
to answer right I asked the channel and
I'm looking at the comments
um why shouldn't virginity be desirable
how does a woman's sexual experience
compensate for the uncertainty of
paternity as well as the the rest of bad
traits and habits that come with
experience
that's a loaded question that's a loaded
question that's a big one stone okay
part one
could you read that again
why shouldn't virginity be desirable
I think it should be I think it probably
should be he's probably better in your
life but I guess I guess the the answer
they're looking for is because you're
experiencing yeah and that's a good
experience lack of experiences is one uh
that's kind of yeah
from a guy's point of view or from a
girl's point of view this I mean it's
just a question so it's I mean it's from
your point of view I'm asking you
um from a guy's point of view like like
oh I can see why oh [__] virginity
wouldn't
come here
what's she doing that's her toy is back
there again staring at the sofa
this is the it's behind us behind the
scenes
back there I'm sorry sorry
is it on this side
okay that's fine
behind the scene
um but
I think it should be desirable but I can
understand why it's not desirable to
some people
I found that the majority of guys don't
want a virgin when I ask them unless
they are a virgin yeah
like occasionally every now and then
I'll get a guy like I feel like it
should probably be the type of guy that
get a version but like the majority of
guys I ask like don't really care that
much they just don't want to go that's
been ran through yeah
about it's one thing a virgin like it's
not so much I look I just want a person
that I can connect with on a deeper
level I think that the more promiscuous
you are uh the the less you're able to I
agree and that's super important for me
um obviously
I no I feel like like okay how do I put
it it seems like you correct me if I'm
wrong if you if you got a girl that was
a virgin that'd be like like you'd be
excited yeah yeah but
oh see see this is what I mean like
there's always nowadays when I talk to
guys it doesn't they don't seem to care
that much because I think it's it's the
idea that like
you'll find that
let's say you found that for example
right and you're like yeah you got it
whatever and then it wasn't everything
that you wanted in
a person well then
the fact that she was a virgin wasn't
the bill and end or was it no and
therefore it's like well what happens if
you meet someone that isn't a virgin and
she's everything you want well then
he is discarded like the fact that
obviously to an extent you really don't
want it to be a girl that's been with a
lot of guys of course not because you
understand that there's a lot of
promiscuity with that there's a lot of
consequences you'll find later on
there's a lot of connections she still
has a lot of it exactly
um a lot of alpha she's probably been
Alpha widowed but the more she's had sex
um and there's just a lot of
complications that come with that so no
I mean I I put it I I agree like I think
men should have whatever standards they
want to have and I think that meant like
should ideally want virgins but it's
it's kind of blows my mind when I talk
to guys there's
I've other than um Sterling and Jay
Waller but like those are YouTube got I
don't know that's a little different
I've never had a guy tell me he like
wants a virgin unless he's a virgin
himself and this is a virgin himself
like like I think the the criteria is
like what you said is like not
necessarily a virgin but like
don't get around food by the
teams hide it
yeah
pretend to throw it pretend to throw it
sorry guys behind the scenes
what was the um second half of that
question
ish oh I can't hold on I'll tell you I'm
about to put my dog away guys she's
she's wild I'm out oh okay
um
what was the second half of that
question
okay
oh
how does a woman's sexual experience
compensate for the uncertainty of
paternity as well as the rest of the bad
traits and habits that come with
experience it doesn't she wishes it does
you know what's interesting though and I
asked guys would you I interviewed guys
in the street and I said
would you rather have a guy a girl that
gave you the best head of your life or
the best like food like really would you
rather have a girl that's really good at
cooking or really good ahead and every
single guy except for like one said hat
I would have had food I would have said
food
no because oh those guys haven't thought
that through yeah think of food I look I
don't I think cooking is a skill I don't
know actually
is not that high comparatively to a lot
of people especially in my post
retirement years right it's not so
obviously I feel like a lot of guys who
said that like they just want to speak
but on stream still
hey you have to talk about encode you
know you guys you guys a girl can be
good at sex
what does that even mean yes no because
I've heard from guys that like girls
can't really be good at sex they're just
I get that I get the stand or I have a
bad old mediocre because it's like
no no no no no wait wait let's let's run
that back
yes they
can it depends how good the guy is is it
the coconut thing I think it's more so
like it takes two to tango yeah yeah and
also than anything if you have a bad
Dance part and then you're not gonna
have a great dance
like no matter how good you are it
doesn't matter I had one guy on the
podcast tell me that he found a girl
that was like he probably would have
married her but the sex was so bad
because she was so inexperienced yikes
that's kind of that yeah see it's kind
of the thing it's bad though because as
a guy you should be able to go okay cool
she's an experienced teacher teacher
it doesn't mean no sense you're a guy
like you pick a girl like it should
literally be like all right I'll teach
her what she needs to know and
understand about me and then I can find
out what her things are and then you've
got a girl
with these questions I need to see I I
need to see who wants to the age range
uh location geographical location
because it's like a lot of these things
add up right if it's like a 16 to 25
year old from like South London like
yeah
really wow
you'll probably find that one here's the
thing if you start teaching her
everything she knows will be from you
from you that's an imprint in her head
okay it's from you catered to you by you
like do you not think that's a valuable
in keeping a woman because like all the
memories come from yourself the thing is
I even literally found myself saying no
I don't want to teach them and then I
think that might have just been like a
like an innate thing that like Society
just says I'm teaching a virgin how to
have sex is long-winded because it's
like the again I I I caught myself
saying that I literally said like no
versions are I wouldn't go for a verdict
because I don't want to teach them but
then again like we said like we did just
now I just think about it for a second
I'm like but it does make sense though
and then I asked myself so why did I say
no to the verse in the first place yeah
and I feel like that could be like some
sort of societal thing now put it this
way if you have a woman that's
promiscuous right and has been she's
done what she's done and she she's had
every experience half widowed in every
way shape or form yeah and like you find
love with her like you'll never be able
to live up to the expectations that
she's had because she's probably been
ran through and she's damaged goods at
that moment maybe yeah and like you may
she may genuinely have feelings for you
in connection for you but you'll never
be able to live up to the expectation
yeah that's weird Okay question how many
bodies is too many bodies for you
and does body count matter if you never
find out
no uh second question yes I thought
about it for a second yeah I said no
initials oh I don't know about that yeah
you're dating no no no no no no no no no
no but then so you don't it doesn't
matter if you don't find it I mean I
mean I do it'll be one of those ones
where no it'll be one of those ones
where I'd I'd expect to have that
conversation at some point but I'm not
going to be like like a few years you've
been dating your girlfriend two years
and you've never asked I know how many
people okay you know yeah but it's just
it's just I think it's mostly about one
of those things about how you ask when
you ask and where it gets brought
because it's not going to be a thing
where I'm just gonna sit here before we
make it official how long did it take
for you to ask or it came up
two months two months and would you have
broken up with her if it was too high
maybe maybe
so how many bodies is Too Many Bodies
oh I think my number's a bit skewed
is it is it because your number's really
high and so you're more that's what I
found I found out that okay this is this
is what I found you guys can tell me in
the chat I found that the guys that
normally there's exceptions to this
usually they're YouTubers
but in general when I talk to like
normal people I find that the guys that
actually like get girls like that they
don't care as much because they feel
like they know girls true nature yeah so
they're like okay I don't believe it
yeah but but the guys that that
typically will say oh I want it to be
super low either are religious or they
don't have experience with women and I'm
not guys don't take this as me shaming
like men into like wanting a girl with a
bigger body I'm not I think it's
definitely ideal to like I think virgins
are ideal yeah but
this is just like anecdotal evidence
from talking to people the last three
months I can agree with you with that
one as well because mine's quite the
high and it's one of those things where
like in hindsight and look it's it's
above that it's in Midnight like the
highest he's going on 40s I think I
actually don't know at this point I
don't count but I know it's hiding like
35 right
and it's one of those ones because my
number's so like high comparatively I
was like I can't if you say you had 10
that's a third of mine
which which the other guys is
superintendent mad high right but like
I don't know like it's high but again
like you said because I know again we're
sleeping as many people like like you
know how people how women work yeah you
know how they work you know how they
operate you know how they think in a
sense because obviously no no it doesn't
matter okay so if a girl
does it matter
how long the girl was single like how
quickly she accumulated the bodies 100
so so if she let's say she was let's say
her body count is
I don't know like you said let's just go
with that number doesn't matter if
um like she was only single six months
she got the ten like other than that
she's always been in the relationship
like if it's like 10 in like two years
maybe fine babe it's 10 and let's
four months to six months it's like what
were you doing in those four months yeah
like two a week yeah
when I was going because because again I
was a virgin before uni my whole state
started uni
I just went wild like I just went wild
and it was like every night every other
night type thing for the first few years
and then you slow down you calm down
because you don't care anymore like
because it's like oh is this what they
were talking about when when it comes
like
chasing women is is this it and you
[__] bored
yeah like when I whenever okay and
whenever I hear a guy say like a super
low number it's usually and I there's
exceptions so guys don't roast me in the
chat I know there are high value guys
that want to grow with five or less
bodies or whatever but or whatever you
got two whatever you guys think is low
but I've just found that he doesn't have
as much experience with women typically
and the reason I say this is because I
see the most high value men and none of
them are really marrying virgins unless
they're YouTubers and their whole
platform is based on them getting the
highest value girl yeah so like I feel
like that's a little bit of an anomaly
this is just observations guys I'm not
not ashamed they always come at me I'm
not shaming anymore
one thing I might say is
I think sexual experience counts as well
yeah like if I go so I will have a
conversation with a girl I now know that
like
through that conversation
she may have had like multiple partners
but she's never been
pleasured in a certain type of way and
at that moment it's like okay so like if
it will be number one I I I haven't got
a I'm not gonna be like we're not doing
it's not gonna be a madness here like
I'll easily top any experience you've
ever had so but like not even that's not
even too much of an issue it's just that
you can have conversations with people
and kind of gather where they are at um
but unless you talk to a girl yeah I was
actually very worried about coming back
around these parts because
um before my girlfriend I was talking to
this one girl I'm not gonna say her name
and she literally lived One Stop away
from you guys
like I've literally I've walked past
this area with her at points and it
didn't end well so I was very and she
goes to ueo as well oh
she have a really high percent of bodies
no it's just I just got really worried
about being in this area because it
didn't end well from my end I kind of
did her wrong and I did a day but like
at the same time it's like personally I
didn't Manny I did because I was the guy
in a situation I could have handled it a
little better but
um as my girlfriend now blame her
if you see this yeah you know we did
what uh-ish what would be
uh what would be like a
what's the word I'm looking for too many
yeah too many for years
and oh other question does her age
matter like how old yes uh because I'm
kind of roughly calculating how you've
accumulated so many different kind of
times span if you've got 10 bodies and
you're 28 and you it's like all right
cool so you could have been probably
starting having sex that maybe you lost
in Virginia in like 18 17 16 whatever
and then from there it was like one
person every year or or you had like a
one year where you kind of went wild and
you didn't but like
when the numbers
of the men
if they're greater than the years it's
wild if it's the same it's like okay all
right are we talking long-term
relationships as well yeah I am I don't
really I don't yeah but it's about the
when in terms of long-term relationships
it's a very process because that person
could have had sex with many people and
they probably might not have the ability
to pair bond but
the only way you can find out if that's
true is you find out right
um so
how many bodies is Too Many Bodies
that's a good question
um
I would say four to seven anything over
you say 47.
now I say anything over double digits
really for me personally but uh lower
high double digit
um
I think it means 10. but okay this is
another thing I noticed when guys say
the bodies they really mean like 20 to
30 percent because like if you so let's
say yours is 10 yeah you meet a girl
that's at 12.
what's the difference yeah yeah like
yeah so you guys say whatever their body
counted I just gather this they really
mean whatever number they say they'll
accept like 20 to 30 more Bob I've also
got a client to take into consideration
like
how this has happened why like why you
got to this state was it a case of did
you start at a certain age
um was it relationships like were you
just like freely just giving it out to
guys that you found attractive
um or were you looking for something
what's your judgment calls on these kind
of men that you were dating like I'm I'm
looking at it from a perspective of how
did you get to this point why are you
there and if like
um how do you how do you view me like
there's multiple kind of yeah yeah
um because I think having no
relationships at old age is just as much
of a red flag
like if you're like 40 and you've only
had one partner and a partner has been a
long time that's a red flag yeah and me
and my friend
my front that's where we feel like
virgins get dusted too like yeah like
girls like I see a rising number of like
female 25 plus virgins and I don't
really think it goes well for them a lot
of the time like I I see them
like
because they can't the church guys just
aren't there nope and so when they do
lose their virginity it's to like that
guy that they can't almost help
themselves with because he's just she
sees him as Alpha but usually that guy
kind of was like yeah I mean these
outfits
you don't even want virgins yeah so it's
kind of it's kind of a weird
conversation because
I think like on the red pill there's a
balance where sometimes they're not
realistic with women today yeah but on
the on the other end it's like we have
these modern women that are like let me
just ride the CC and like saddle at 32
and
but then you get people like the the
reason that that kind of exists is
because you get people it wasn't named
Jackson
Derek Jackson
oh yeah
Derek Jackson you got that guy him
absolutely distribute in the red pill
Community
oh no they hate him he's the other side
before before he did all that no no no
no because he used literally come on and
be like women if you take anything less
than your man then 100 at all times then
that man is not worth keeping you should
just throw him away because if it was me
I would be there all the time and I
would do this and I will rub your feet
as soon as you walk in turns out he was
cheating on his girlfriend by the way
his wife his wife sorry sometimes I was
cheating his wife this is the same guy
who was just like dry simple and you'll
see you'll see this it's like the
panderers where the answer is never
women you'll see this not only with men
but with women too it's like the the
panderers and they'll say the men need
to be more basically men need to rise
and Rolo talks about this all the time
like it's always men need to be better
and be more and rise to the occasions
rather than talking about where the
women effed up yeah I'm gonna Read Super
chats
um
thank you so much for
being here and watching the Stream
who's gonna who's gonna watch the whole
24 hours put a one in the chat put a one
in the chat I watch from work
different about sex oxytocin causes a
sense of trust and longing for our
partner however oxy testosterone
suppresses oxytocin boy type more than
five bodies means her ability to
chemically pair bond is f she and she is
not going to be happier faithful in a
relationship
um five's only wife MD Monroe the Virgin
Thing versus not I think it's answered
more on The Dating perspective versus
marriage do you want to learn uh do you
want to learn and experience the new
things together or have it compared to
everything and everyone else guys want
to want experience for initial fun
Phillip blueprint is feminism red pill
is Trad wife
um Amir Ali I'm two hours early for the
stream it's funny and sad to see the
first signs of red pill rage on the
lady's face
um
[Laughter]
I mean yours you're making some funny
faces
because it was just like it wasn't rage
it was just like Oh my days like no no
you're not you're not Rachel no because
you're not Rachel you're not original no
it's just like reality hit I think I
think everyone's been through there oh
I've been through my red pill ratio oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the girls have a version of it too
where you just get all this anxiety
about getting older and it's really oh
my gosh it's like I'm going through that
right now yeah yeah yeah it's but my dad
told me like this is my dad my dad's
very logical I talk about a lot on my
channel and he told me he's like you
can't help how old you are because all
you can do is like make the best
decisions that you can and do do what
you can with the information you have at
the time like that is what my dad tells
me yeah he just says because a lot of a
lot of um
like unhappiness is comparison and I
think that's why in The Red Pill like we
get so mad because the guys will be like
oh those guys get all the girls but
you're just comparing I'm just comparing
and you can't you can't help you can't
help where you're at in the dating food
chain I mean I mean you can't I will you
can't help where you have you can't help
where you start no no no and so as a
girl like the way I look at it is okay
if I I'm working I'm trying to get into
like the best shape of my life and I if
you get in really good shape you're in
the top like 20 of females yeah so
regardless of age and then I was
thinking that
um I can't help how old I am so all I
can do is date as intentionally as I can
that's all you can really do so
um I don't know that's that's how I sort
of dealt with it I guess yeah yeah
hearing all of this and like talking
about the wall and eggs drying up but
then you say like if you're in shape
you're in the top 20 I'm like there's
still some hope for me it looks looks
wise but biology doesn't change that
yeah yeah and it also depends on your
family like my mom
I don't know like she's I think she's in
her 50s she still hasn't hit menopause
really yeah like my family just gives
like like and I realize I'm I'm in a
completely different position than most
women because like other and I'm not
gonna say like my goal is I want to get
married sooner rather than later like
that is that is I'm dating intentionally
that that's that's all it can do but if
I hate because they're gonna put in the
chat all the way oh she's a modern women
like some some girls if they do not make
the right decisions young they will be
homeless I know that is never going to
be an option like I will not that that's
never gonna happen to me yeah yeah yeah
yeah and and so I I think I'm very very
lucky but not every girl is
it's true
like the only reason I'm in coincidence
because my dad imagine if I ever like my
dad's been a quantity in the UK he's a
quantitative in Nigeria he's a
politician she's really funny wow right
but like um another reason I became a
quantity severe oh all got my first role
was because he talked to some of his
friends about it so I understand
the privilege that I hold where I am
right
but what I do with that is make sure
that I don't fumble the back like I make
sure that I come into work every day
trying to do as best as I can because I
know there's a lot of people who wish
they could be in my situation but it
wouldn't get that first opportunity in
the door because they don't have a dad
who knows someone who works they're like
I do right so the only thing you can do
right with whatever privilege you have
in because everyone this is one thing I
really hate about today's like everyone
has some sort of privilege in some sort
of way right every single person in this
world has privilege over someone else
over something right there is no one
person with no privilege over someone
else right and this is a this is like an
idea that gets pushed all the time that
like you can you can be not privileged
at all to anything it's like pretty
privileges exist higher privilege exist
like privileges there's white privileges
there's all racial privileges black
people doesn't exist okay go into a
black hair store as a black person and
see if you don't get violated then go
into that same store as a white person
or Foreigner and see if they don't hike
up the prices like crazy see if they
won't follow you around like crazy see
what they want to ask you questions like
like not of course they will like
everyone has their privileges but it's
just about how you use them
or abuse them
um that part do you know
you know what's interesting
um a lot of the things in the U.S that
you see deemed as like Black Culture
it's actually from East England yeah did
you know that like I'm sure if you're
familiar with Thomas Sowell
um to some extent I've heard I've heard
of a bit of a voice so like the the
dialects
um that are associated with and I don't
even like seeing Black Culture because
there's so many different like cultures
that I really don't even like saying
this but like you was walking you beat
like that that dialect it comes from
East England
well and it was from the Antebellum
South and so the slave owners like like
transplanted that culture onto the onto
the slaves and like that
that culture is heavily discriminated
against and the thing is um nine out of
every 10 black people back then came
from that culture were one out of every
three white people came from that
culture but the Discrimination you see
it in both cultures so when there was my
like when there was big groups that
migrated from the south that's when you
saw race relations
um get bad but you also saw it when the
white Southerners moved into like places
like Indiana like that's when you would
see the relations get better and the way
they would describe like the southern
blacks that came into the city these
they would they would describe the the
southern whites very similar
[Music]
what about dialects and high speeds yeah
but it wasn't just the dialects it's
like an emphasis on church but not
necessarily like doing the things that
like church entails and like another
thing was like they owned
I think one out of four dairy cows the
the Antebellum South
uh one other at one out of every four
dairy cows in the South was owned um was
there but they only produced like six
percent of the dairy wow yeah so it was
like an extremely unproductive like that
culture but like if you see Nigerian
Americans they make more than white
people in the U.S yeah because
like the thing is with America is weird
especially the Black Culture right this
is this is a conversation that a lot of
black British people have all the time
because we're just looking from the
outside in right
we will never understand what it's like
to be a an African-American because
for the most part we will know a
heritage
yeah you're gonna ask any black person
in this country right where are you from
and they want a lot of them won't say
England they'll tell you where they'll
where they're actually where their
bloodline is from where the bloodline is
from where I have cousins here I can go
back there at some point but yeah
because the slave thing still happened
over here it's just like
they didn't the slaves that were over
here were stripped of their history as
much as they were in the U.S yeah right
and it's like a thing where it's like
I don't even know why we know more about
our history over here well you're not a
first generation
me yeah no
or British no I'm a first I'm a I'm a
second generation American and uh
American okay second generation English
and like you know you know what else is
interesting so um there is a I don't
remember the name of it but there was a
slave Island where the culture wasn't
from the Annabelle himself and the
slaves from that Island went on to be
like the most successful black people in
the U.S and they were they were either
equal or outpacing whites and the one
out of the ten black people in the US
from back then that didn't come from
that culture they they would be at or
outpacing whites and it's interesting
because like have you ever heard people
say like you taught like like they and I
don't even understand why they say this
but they'll say like you don't talk like
a black person yeah like no which
doesn't make sense but because that
dialect is from it's from England yeah
and so it's and and one out of every
three white people derive from that yeah
wow yeah it's like an equivalency of
like Cockney vitamins like not really
it's like somewhat like it but like you
know it's like in the same vein ish like
not the same thing you said what type of
slime like Cockney rhyming slang like
have you heard have you come across that
while being in the UK uh maybe but
basically it would be like it would be
like
um I'm going up the apples and pears
stairs oh yeah no
apples and pears what does that have to
do
um
but it's like rhyming
the accent is a bit off and this is like
that like no I haven't heard that
obviously they're very different but
like they derived from similar places
similar backgrounds wow
interesting yeah yeah that's a really
weird fact you know you know another
crazy fact is in Louisiana one out of
every three
um black people that like freed slave or
black freed slaves own slaves hmm wait
say that again so one out of every one
out of every three
um freed black slaves in Louisiana went
on to them then themselves own slaves
yeah so when they talk about reparations
and stuff like that it's like how would
that work how would that work yeah and
I've heard I don't know if this is true
I've seen this comment in the chat so
many times I know it has to have come
from somewhere arguably so I've heard
that the first slave owner was black in
the U.S
I'm not sure about how true that is but
if that's true that's not hilarious I
think that's the wrong word to use but
interesting I mean it would it wouldn't
surprise me because you'd think that
the black slaves were sold by black
people yeah to the US yeah so then and
black people weren't even the first
people to ensure black people by the way
it was Arabians but like yeah yeah
[Music]
see like stuff like that that's
something that in the states
we're not taught like earlier we're
talking about how here you're talking
about like
uh history from everywhere in the states
is very rare we'll get like the
overarching stuff or the stuff that
America was
[Music]
um
involved in yeah
um like we'll learn about the like the
French Revolution in history because
yeah it's not it's not the history that
you're speaking of like we'll learn
about the French Revolution uh Nazi
Germany Germany not our own history oh
yeah that's what I mean yeah well like
you you guys learn more about yeah in
the UK world history because you're over
here in America we learn about world
history but it's not in depth like like
you just said like the
um the slaves yeah it's just like oh
like people were not the first people to
enslave black people yeah she's like oh
wow like what do you mean
so yeah it's just very is it is very
interesting I wish that everybody could
have the opportunity to like go overseas
yeah and I just think you guys need to
fix up your education system
like bro like I did an SAT test and go
to 1400 but no yeah it was a 1400
one of those ones where I did the test
and I got a good score for For What SAT
is right and I was just sitting there
after the test like me this is like yes
seven year eight work what do you mean
the English section is literally yeah
they'll just find a big word and be like
do you know what this means yeah no way
yeah I swear to you you'll have to
remember stuff that you learned in
elementary school and like middle school
once you take this test and it
determines where you go to college it's
just like do you know what the word
sophistication means like yeah of course
I do like I'm not an idiot like it's
just like how like how is this because
you know what it was it was from
watching all the American TV shows and
they make the SATs look like this huge
gigantic thing that's like so difficult
and so crazy and then I did it and I was
like wait hold on yeah Pizza
yes
yeah I don't know where you're going I
don't know where you're going ish with
the pizza
you can join us step out from behind the
cameras
[Music]
yeah I'm probably gonna head head soon
because
are you still awake let me put my phone
away that's okay
it's three a.m I was checking if anyone
in the house today until I was still
awake
it's meat lovers
that's the Hawaiian Max
the max SATs was one
sixteen hundreds 1600 for the max
really I got a 1400 and I didn't even
try
um it was
Center like all right what's going on
14 times 65 minus 6 with a calculator
what is that it's like huh
[Music]
because some of the streamism watching
you eat yeah
come on come on
what's good
take four pieces because I'm hungry this
is some big slices of ham
for real though when I learned the
slavery thing that like I was like shut
like the culture of that
that I don't know that made me look at
the world so different I didn't know
much about the slavery thing
I need to make sure the headphones are
on so I can hear what's good
oh my gosh
okay wait let me pull up
stream can you hear me
I don't know
hold up I can't put it up like this nice
nice
okay guys
I'm sorry I'm gonna eat
all right this is looking good on 24
hour live stream
ASMR
um
fire
what is that you're putting on there
Cayenne you want some I don't have a
crushed red pepper I ran out
I was so hungry
so I'm starving me three
if you guys want ASMR I'll do it
twenty dollar Super Chat okay
don't attempt to a hundred dollar Super
Chat I will give you a full five minutes
that'd be a good channel for you except
for nice boys
there's a whisper
as much as I don't like it
okay what
all right thank you for coming I
appreciate it
yo thank you for having me everyone yeah
yeah thank you for having me everyone uh
hopefully I could be back at some point
uh we'll see uh life is life love is
love all this life that's a sign up yeah
Daniel Franklin is out
at least you get to change your clothes
for work
go what
guys can we get to 1 500 likes
let's get to that
1100.
see you thank you for coming
so guys after shows miesh and Jess will
talk about the shows after the shows
today
yeah today was
I didn't have anyone to argue with today
yeah
but I feel like I got through a lot of
red pill points you sure did
because even though I've heard some of
those I was still
shocked
yeah it's kind of weird once the pieces
start like coming together yeah it is
and it's like weird when you start
seeing it from like stuff that has
happened like in your life in the past
and you're like
see it yeah
oh I'll let you out I think it's oh it's
you know I thought that's what he was
doing no he went to the
welcome
um I should get a Discord Channel
I don't know how to I don't know
anything about Discord
Maybe
oh my God I'm so hungry
you don't understand y'all
I like barely ate today
foreign
I literally like barely ate today
in fact same way
yes sometimes
because the shows are so long I'll be
like starving
like when they end I'm like oh my God
oh it's actually been a minute since
I've been on stream
um
yeah when's the last was it when you
were on the show when we first met uh
yeah
um
yeah I'll get you a camera soon yeah no
soon soon I know
um yeah no I think it was last time I
was on stream was
yeah during the show when I when I first
came
yeah it's wandered into my studio right
when I needed a producer it was a good
timing
perfect time perfect timing yeah if you
came a week earlier I don't think I
could have paid a producer
but it was like right the week you came
was when [__] was starting to blow up
it was funny because you found me
just through like DMS yeah it was like
your father of course everyone knows you
at uel now
yeah
you you yields my place
good people good man we spent like half
a decade at our school
true
I worked there studied there did my
master today I did my undergrad there
couldn't leave there because the way I
recruit is
through Instagram so I looked like
who people follow check their Instagram
look if they're not weird
and recruit them
and then yeah just see if they'll come
on
um
copy and paste so
okay it says Anthony Johnson was the
first to own slaves
um
wait
Anthony Johnson is the first to own
slaves in America look into it more to
understand he was a slave was traded as
a slave in Africa African tribes would
fight each other to gain women behind
behead children
or slave children and kill all the men
and use them as slaves to trade to other
countries
I guess
I don't know there's certain facts like
if I see something in my comment section
enough I know there's something behind
it
and I I don't quote it unless I've like
looked it up but
that's why I said that because I was
like I think there's something to it
I was like thinking I'm like was this a
good idea
now well I'm doing it I'm too late but I
was like
someone just sent 200 apparently
is that for ASMR Anthony Johnson is the
first to own slaves in America look into
it more to understand he was a slave was
traded as a slave in Africa tribes would
fight each other to gain women behead
children or slave children and kill all
men and use them as slaves and trade
them to other countries
I think there's right what's his name
Anthony Johnson
we can look we got time we can look it
up later 100 100
so interesting
hmm
welcome back to the Pearly things
podcast
the pregame podcast
how's everybody doing out there tonight
I think they're better now
are they better now
is anybody we basically have a podcast
up for every show
yeah very much so we didn't talk [__] we
could stream it
I mean we would never
would never never
is there anybody else
what is ASMR for those that don't know I
don't know what it stands for I just
know it's just people
talking very low and making like just hi
guys noise yeah
Josh has the perfect voice for it
because her voice is so soothing
bare White
but yeah
I feel like I like having British and
like American cultures come together
because there really isn't a manosphere
I don't I don't think there's a red pill
show like this in Britain
I think they one of the guests said that
the closest to it was sorrow yeah
wow
bless the Lord O my soul
oh they go wings oh that makes it good
Them Wings is winging yeah they look big
too pause
oh
British people say that pause
yeah just bring it over here because
I'ma want some too
many days
foreign
I have a question about like
um
not women standing but how men like view
women
is it do you think like the the value
goes up for women if they're athletes
no
really well
in shape brings your value up in jail
like but I don't think
like I think the wall is for everyone
maybe athletes it's just delayed a
couple years but
like like we like athletes because
there's status with it and men like
athletes because they're in shape it's
very different reasons I mean I think we
like the the muscles too don't of course
but you'll see like athletes tend to
date other athletes mm-hmm
okay
um
what's what's our type
yeah yeah so yeah
hmm
wow
but I think
it's just a lot of girls become the men
they want to marry that's what they say
in the manosphere so like
they'll want a guy that's correct that's
like ambitious
and that's tall or maybe not tall but
like ambitious driven
um
adventurous and so like they'll become
the guy that they want
um
I need to just have a self-evaluation
time for myself to be like have you
become this subconsciously well um
I think of women like it's it's trying
to be a little bit more feminine too
because I didn't realize how how much we
like
we like lose a point when we dress like
a dude
yeah and I know this sounds like common
sense
yeah but like when I started like seeing
videos of me last year when I was
dressing completely homeless versus like
in dress I'm like did I make myself lose
a point
but I think a lot of like tomboys we do
that because we're just not
like looking for that because we just
were
but
it's like weird men treat you so
different when you're just in a sundress
no I'm serious like I'll get like doors
open for me I'm like what the [__]
that is true
but I want to be comfy
I know but like it's home for that this
is the thing like I think it's just like
work attracting the guys that like like
because there's not enough to go around
so you have to compete for them but
that's not something we're taught as
girls we're taught
we're the prize and like he should come
to you but why is that guy gonna notice
you when he's got ton of their
that is true it's another girls that
look like you you gotta make yourself
stand out
maybe that's why I'm in the predicament
I'm in
hmm
well
at least you're not a feminist there's
no coming back from that yeah it's crazy
how many girls have we had on here that
said you know what I don't believe in
feminism anymore a lot that's that's the
difference between my show and the other
ones it's the other ones are just trying
to Humble them and I'm trying to like
change people's mind because I genuinely
think that like more women would
disagree with it if they understood like
what the men were talking about but men
don't know how to communicate it like
women do yep
yep yep yep
all right so true
because like we know how to say it in
like a nicer way a way that we
understand yeah yeah but I'm just like
they're like who cares if I'm screaming
at you it's a fact facts over feelings
exactly like it shouldn't matter what we
said or like how we said it it's what we
said but I know damn well that you know
the difference between like men
understand tonality not as much as women
do but if you're getting screamed at
versus like talk to like you know the
difference yeah
yep yep yeah but I just think it affects
women more I think it takes us a certain
man to kind of take a step back and
realize oh can you hear me I don't even
know oh it takes a certain amount to
kind of Step take a step back and kind
of realize Okay the reason why this
message isn't getting across is purely
because of tone purely because of the
way I'm coming at it and my Approach and
then to dial it back kind of reset
themselves
to then regurgitate the same stuff they
were saying
but in a different tone with a different
approach
so that the person consuming it can
really understand it's a hard kind of
it's a whole process for a man yeah no I
get it and most men just won't do it
they don't feel they need to and you can
pick up on like those inclinations
faster so like if I see a girl and I see
she's starting to get uncomfortable I
kind of joke with her like you know what
I mean like like do something to make
her feel a little more comfortable or or
add in like you know what this has
happened to me too yeah and I know I've
seen you both do that yeah and I say
that a lot because
it just helps women understand the
information where I'm not coming from
like a oh I'm better than you I'm just
telling you what is
and to men it's like well why wouldn't
you just tell us the information
and I'm like no no it's okay like this
has happened to me too everyone gets old
yeah
but that's what thank you
I don't know that's just like I think is
different about that's what people like
to see is they like to see people like
change their minds on camera yeah
because I don't think a lot of girls
have like thought through like when you
were we did the trans thing right and
you did a whole debate defending dragons
again you did what yeah yeah yeah
the reason I brought her on
well one she was interested in it yeah
but
I did my first show in my first show I
said men are like no we've done a couple
but one of my shows I said men are
better than women of basketball and Jess
was like
how dare you say that Blasphemous
statement
but it's it's sad but it's true yeah
like not obviously not all women and all
men like there's some that are better
than that's a a dime a dozen for the
majority it's just
men are better
at basketball than women yeah but it's
like and I know because men will take
this as oh you're just making excuses
like when when I say stuff like this but
we've been conditioned to like think a
certain way and like you can't undo the
impacts of feminism but when you point
it out I think a lot of girls are more
open to like understanding but yeah so
when she first started we I brought her
on for a debate and our conversation
because we were really like Angry yeah
but we were talking about trans and I
don't I don't even remember what you
were arguing
a dollar yeah I was saying that
um because you had asked if I would
um if I would like allow them to play
and I was like well I want them to be
included and so yeah and then you had
said what have you worked at something
your whole life and here uh trans woman
comes and she's just better biological
male yeah she says biologically better
than you and there's nothing you can do
about it and like he takes your spot on
the team and takes your plane I was like
No And then my thought process switch
and I was like that is right
like I I would be so like devastated if
I worked my whole life to get to
to get to a position where I could play
pro and like I had the opportunity
they're like ah we went with this person
and come to find out this person was a
trans woman I'd be like well I lost
before I even could even have a shot
because there's just biological things
that I don't have and that I will never
have because I was not biologically born
a male I'm just like damn I don't know
why I could like
I kind of I could tell which people
actually believe it and which people are
just like saying that because they think
it's politically correct when I met you
like my feeling was
you kind of were like I don't want to
say program because you're your own
person but I felt like if I explained
this to you like you would not yeah or
just like
one you're on the internet and you don't
want to say anything
crazy and two is like
you want to be cautious of everyone's
feelings and blah blah it's like if it's
the truth it's the truth and like
sometimes the truth just sucks and
sometimes you just gotta say say how it
is and say what it is
yeah yeah it's not it's not like I don't
enjoy all these facts like we're gonna
be alive till we're 90 probably more
pizza we eat maybe not I don't like to
think about like this is kind of the
best it's gonna get like looks wise it's
not getting better
um like maybe I'll get in better shape
but like that that's it yeah
but it's kind of like once you accept it
you can kind of like move accordingly
and I think that's the good thing about
the red pill is you can
you can at least do the best you can so
like when I find out
okay I know you guys said you take the
face but like most guys would take body
over face I'm like well f it I'm gonna
get on the God and I'm saying this as I
eat pizza
hey it is it's 3 30. we need to we need
to have food we're gonna eat salads and
be starving again in the next 30 minutes
but
um
I don't know so I think my logical is
more so you can change your body
not that a woman would change them
technically you can change your face the
problem is most people like we get
fatter so she's already fat like she's
probably gonna get fatter
nowadays you can change your face you
can be a completely different person
than what you look like when you were
born if you're not to use a brush
makeup brush yeah yeah
or if you have money
because there's some of these famous
people out here if they if they didn't
have the money they would be
ugly
would they I think they just look like a
normal human being
yeah yeah now they just they get the lip
fillers that I don't even know but they
just don't look
there's one person that passed into my
head but I'm not gonna say nothing wait
for what for if they didn't if they
didn't have
money they would be a normal both of
them they'd be a normal actually I don't
know about are they famous I would say
they're famous
um
I can never remember which one of the
Jenner sisters are is not a model oh
Kylie
yeah Kyle the one that's with uh
Travis
if she I would say if you look at her
her younger pictures and now yes you go
through puberty and whatnot but if
if she didn't have the money she would
just be a normal looking human being
like normal normal lips normal facial
features everything it only looks that
pretty in pictures and filters it's like
when you see those people in person that
have had a lot of work done on their
face they look weird
oh have you seen that in person no no
but I'm guessing I'm guessing because
it's like I almost think that the
filters make us delusional oh they do
and the Angles and the selfies like you
forget what you look like in in real
time yeah oh my God I I see myself on
the stream we don't got filters here I'm
like oh no I know sometimes I'll be like
dang oh
can you like Photoshop that is
post-production airbrush something real
life so that there is no post yeah
there's no but
when you see it I mean I'm sure you've
seen a girl in person that's had a lot
of work done and it's like their face
moves weird even yeah even Kylie like
they look good at first but then over
time they start to look weird
I just even if I did have the money I
wouldn't I wouldn't want to because
what if I get married to a person and I
look like this goddess perfect blah blah
blah and they never see a picture of me
before surgery and then I have a kid
with them they come out
completely different than what it's like
so whose kid is this because it looks
like the dad but not the mom and
biologically you can't do that is that a
stepmom it's like no that's the real
Mama's biological mom is just like
I didn't know my kid was going to come
out looking like this and so I was like
I got sold a dream yep
it's tough
that's one reason why I don't I choose
not to wear like a lot of makeup because
I'm like one
I was a tomboy and I play a lot of
sports but two it's like if you look a
certain way what happens when you take
all that off and your boyfriend or
husband had never seen you without
makeup
that's a tough one for women you know
yeah well and it's kind of nice when you
don't wear a lot of makeup but you're
like oh it's fine I do that all the time
yeah but when you talk to girls that
wear a lot of makeup they're like I
would rather go through hell than have
them see me without makeup I'm like I
almost prefer it yeah yeah I think a lot
of guys appreciate girls that don't wear
as much people really nice ASMR with the
water pouring
oh my gosh I hate it when I get super
hungry I can eat so much food like if I
let myself get too hungry I feel like I
can eat but then like I'll eat it and
then I'll have like a crash and get real
tired
I'm nervous we'll see I was literally
thinking I was thinking if I you got
that it is right now
yeah that's what I was thinking I was
like I'm still hungry right now but I'm
like no I need to wait because I'm not
really hungry yeah I just let myself get
to Hungry with me if I don't eat for a
long period of time and I'm like snacked
in between when I do eat my stomach
literally takes everything and like
fills up quick and so I can't eat at all
I can't eat a lot I hate it so so where
are you at in within that phase right
now I'm after like I ate those two
slices and those wings I'm full
I'm just like I want to eat more though
yeah me too I'm just like the struggle
anyway what's your stomach for me we'll
have more rooms because I will fall
asleep and I don't want to do that it's
only 3 35 we're going to 9 p.m people
right I'm like really like thinking
about like I'm like we're gonna do it
we're gonna do this we're gonna do for
sure I'm regretting it a lot also no
show Saturday yes we're going out to
celebrate 10K yeah
100K oh sorry I said 10K 100 okay you
said that a couple times did I yeah oh
I'm sorry
100K directing
um 100k
thought my brain be saying something
that might be saying another I'm gonna
read some super chats okay I love that
we're still getting super chats
the people yes
sign up for membership super chats will
be going away soon make sure to like the
video people uh we are at a hundred wait
are we at one thousand one thousand one
hundred let's get to one thousand five
hundred yep 1500 likes we're at one
thousand two hundred yeah one thousand
two hundred let's get it out you guys
are really doing it y'all got 100K
subscribers now let's go I put I put
just in charge of memberships that's her
job is to like create a you know a
culture memberships so if you guys want
to you know support not only me but just
too
come on it's gonna be fun behind the
scenes first behind the scenes will be
this Saturday when we go out to
celebrate our 10K we're gonna be looking
flying it's such a good idea I'm gonna
find so if you want to see our fits and
just where we're going out to dinner
issues buy-in and just like how the
night goes sign up for memberships and
you'll be able to check it out
yeah she's she's gonna do a good job
with it I already know it yes is it fun
like I don't know for you but like
I'm thinking like before I started a
YouTube channel I would have been so
excited to like work I I enjoy it a lot
it's it's cool for me I'm the type of
person that likes to be behind the
scenes likes to like help out the like
the same person you're like oh my God I
was like I was thinking you're like the
perfect Tire it's like she has she has
all the skills I don't have which is
exactly who you want to hire yeah and so
I'm all I'm like this is not something
that I'm like dang like why do I have to
I I enjoy doing it because I've done it
so much and just to see like how
everything works but to also be a part
of it it's great and you're also like
creative too yeah like which is not
everyone has like that creativity but
it's nice that I can give you projects
and I know you're like creative with it
yeah but I was I remember when I first
got paid on social media or off I was so
excited because I was like I get to pay
to do something I actually like versus
like do these stupid jobs that I don't
like yeah yo I'm tired of doing stupid
jobs
like whether even either it's with me or
someone else you'll have a career in
media yeah you're good at it
um
see Tim okay wait let me refresh the
super chats because I know that wasn't
the last one
you really sent 200 thanks Tim wow
wow 200.
okay um Tim North makeup destroys your
face you keep using it over time then it
dries up your face want to know more
look this stuff up makeup is a scam
against ugly people to keep them ugly
and lose money at the same time wow
that actually makes a lot of sense yeah
it's good because it's a good thing I
never wore a lot of makeup I don't know
it just makes you uglier and uglier you
know what you've convinced me because
I've started wearing makeup for this
show no more no more it'll be the bare
minimum yeah
um honest citizen the red pill
politicized
um such as right wing red pill might be
ironically secular and its Valiums
claims to be truth more than partial
facts well I my opinion is that I think
conservative and red pill line up a lot
because
I think conservative this is biased
obviously but I think conservatism is
rooted a lot in truth and so
I I think they're kind of aligned and
that's why I think people like this
channel because there's not really a
channel that's like
it's either red pill or conservative
interesting question for Pearl do I use
doc dot go as a search engine no I don't
what's DuckDuckGo
um
it's like I don't know search engine I
guess
real if I'm Sapient ah hi Ally that's my
friend Abby
um congrats Pearl you should do a coffee
chat when the day breaks yeah I can do a
coffee chat on stream
um Dragon stallion some women won't take
info from a man unless it's put it in a
shocking way I'm here live one dollar
Dalton Warner one day you should talk
about women in the military
um Dalton can be too louder in the mic
um I can sure oh I can't do Dalton hold
on I gotcha yeah
asking you shall receive I was saying I
wasn't hungry anymore but I got you how
like
I don't know a level of loudness just
loud I think he's being sarcastic yo yes
yes I'll do it yeah do it do it
shotgun crazy
oh my God I can't even listen to that
um 200 from Timothy North Anthony
Johnson is the first to own slaves in
America look into it more to understand
he was a slave was traded as a slave in
African tribes would fight each other to
gain women behead children or slave
children or kill all men or use them as
slaves to trade in other countries
Pearl where are you going to display
your 100K word
I don't know what
yeah yeah
oh
yeah have you have you changed your like
location on YouTube to out here or will
it ship back to Chicago
my manager told me I'll get it in a week
or like then I'll get the option in a
week to order it so we'll see
um MD Monroe do you think body count
opinion
um opinion differs depending on Love
Languages I would imagine like physical
touch probably has a higher body count
but that's just off of you know guessing
no I would agree with that
um info Vader
um who a woman's been with is more
important than how many how good a woman
treats you as an indicator that you
stand with her to her in previous men
especially over time I agree with that I
think the best way you can see how a
woman views you is how she treats you I
like actually agree with that a lot
um
and I I do agree I know I know the
chat's gonna go crazy but even Rolo
Tomas he says this I'm not just like I
think the the quality of the number
matters more than the number
yeah well I mean like like if a guy if a
guy's vetting a girl right I I think it
yes that's what I'm saying like I don't
think it's the number matters right so
I'm not saying the number like doesn't
for body count that it doesn't matter I
just I think it depends who her exes are
and does she view them as better than
you because the reason body count
matters in my opinion is because she
might think one of the X's is better
than you
so it's who are the x's and are you
better than them
like who are the access she cared the
most about and can you beat them
um Dylan a woman can have 365 bodies in
a year if she truly desired it so
numbers aren't important Tim a chemical
we re a chemical reason we feel
different about sex oxytocin causes a
sense of trust and longing for a partner
however testosterone suppresses oxytocin
oh I think I wrote the other ones
hmm
that's something that when you say that
to women they're like no women can have
sex and not be attached it's like
physically we cannot no matter how much
women say like oh no I can have sex with
multiple guys and not get attached
there's going to be something in you
that's a little bit attached even if you
suppress it or not because it's just how
we are biologically made okay every girl
I know that that doesn't get attached
I she she wasn't like that to start
um
like she had to like every girl that I
know that's to the point where she can
sleep with someone and not get attached
either
I I've seen this in two ways either the
guy she's sleeping with she doesn't
really like that much so it's kind of
like like she's not attached because she
just you know what I mean like she just
didn't view him like that yeah yeah or
she did something to herself so so like
she slept with so many people in the
beginning it hurt her a lot but like now
it's kind of like it's like she
conditioned herself to do it would you
call that a nymphomaniac I don't know
what a nymphomaniac is it's someone who
[Music]
um
I think I'm saying this right someone
who can who just likes sex you can just
have sex like to have sex just all the
time
um
some of them I would say I would say
some girls are just kind of like I don't
I don't think they like have sex all the
time but I think they just kind of like
casual sex here and there I don't know
nymphomaniac
that just sounds like such a sounds like
a deal
that's not my type of person
I was watching this one video on this
one uh Channel I forgot the name of it
but all their videos like all their um
cover art are in black and white and
they interview like real people and
there was like a nymphomaniac on there
and she was just talking about just how
she just
has sex with people and just how
um so it's not one person it's people
it'll be people throughout the week it's
a sex like addict okay that's that's
what I was thinking I don't think
they're addicted to sex I just think
it's kind of like a guy who watches corn
versus is addicted to Corn there's like
two different things and I would say the
girls that I know I wouldn't say are
addicted to sex but they they're casual
sex but they have it
um Tim
new Earth use deducto Duck Duck Go as a
search engine in Google and compare what
you search you'll be surprised Google
feeds you and hides people from the
truth from different sources
um oh Jess they want your cash app
someone super chatted me for your cash
app oh sure don't say it my birthday's
next week I need some birthday money
what'd you say cash app or venmo put
them both in the chat oh yes
wow I respect it you're looking good
they really dig your hair oh thank you I
appreciate it
um
what is my venmo I don't even know
tell him to catch up you got that mm-hmm
um my cash app is dollar sign uh Jessica
bieler
j-e-s-s-i-c-a-b-e-e-l-e-r no space in it
and then I think my memo is
uh
just underscore b94
and that is that if anybody wants my
PayPal I got that too
wow
if I get a notification on this live I'm
gonna scream
yeah that's a free shout out you know
yeah my boys you know what to do holla
at your girl you can follow me on
Instagram too
it's dot yeah dot girl underscore yes
okay you're getting it right now yeah I
know at first I was stumbling
laughs
um
let's see
ish how's it how has it been for you
working on the show it's been amazing
um
yeah no it's been amazing uh I've always
been flexible
I've learned so much I've been able to
work with some amazing equipment amazing
people too
come on come on
um but yeah and honestly it's just been
a learning curve I've been able to like
help Paul with production
um give her advice
uh she's taking it on really well
um I think the Channel's growing which
is what we love to see
um and yes no it's been a pleasure I've
thoroughly enjoyed my time it's only
been five weeks you know really yeah
yeah I know I know time moves slow when
you work as much honestly and I was
literally I was like oh that's like this
five weeks ago yeah no I feel like with
you at first you were like kind of slow
to it but once you got it you like got
it yeah and it's funny because I kind of
learned like that where like At first
it's like
I get overwhelmed and it like takes me a
second but then that's why I kind of
knew I was like he'll get it you just
gotta give him a little time yeah yeah
no I just remembered the first week was
the first terrible so that was horrible
that was bad yeah like we had audio
issues audio issues like every stream
every street no it was two streams you
know it was more than two
dang I'm telling you it was two streams
the first stream
we came and we used the roads
and I was like okay
um no the audio levels because you were
moving them up and down okay I remember
this
I had no clue about audio at that time
all I knew I could videography
videography that's all I knew yeah I
knew if I gave you time that I was like
you'll get it I appreciate the time you
gave me
paid off in the end
should we
should we FaceTime people and ask them
red pill questions oh yeah I wish we
could do a Colin so let me see if my
brother's up I wonder
I wonder could we do stream Labs oh no
but we couldn't hear it right yeah that
was a problem
um
that's too bad dream yard
what if oh can we get like a fake number
and like put it next what we could do
what oh no because that's on the stream
yeah you can get a Google number
and use that to call people or a
WhatsApp number but the problem is they
couldn't hear it on the yeah on the
audio we were trying to figure talking
about right now or just
all right because we could just put it
next to the mic that's what I was gonna
do at five if my brother was you know
how to do a Google note can you make one
we'll try it
I don't see why not you might must badly
we can just take it off
I haven't made a Google number in a
minute so
so you can make a Google number
and explain that to me
um
I'm trying to remember when I did it
it's been years tried doing it and then
you can talk me for it as you're doing
if that works
foreign
wow
did you ever look into How the Irish
were treated and valued and how the term
mulatto came to the U.S it was heavily
ignored and dismissed because it doesn't
fit The Narrative of black versus whites
it says
um yes I cringe every time you use
Google women can be red pill they
understand that they are hypergamous and
like an instinct and can learn and not
let it get carried away ask too much of
their partner and have unrealistic
standards I agree
okay my brother said he was free
see
he's watched your show Pearl oh yeah
my family doesn't even watch a mission
it's crazy my family doesn't even watch
this I asked my dad he's like I got
things to do
so you think I have time to watch a
three-hour stream I have to watch a
little bit of it
all right bro you just said you were
free
yeah a few of my friends watched the
show
it's kind of weird when random people
get recognized too much unless I'm at an
airport I always recognize that airports
because that's I feel like that's when
you get the most people but U.S airports
not like because more of my audiences in
the US but it's funny when people I know
say they saw me
like fury because we went to the same
Gem and
um even the the coach that you yell
Tope
no the oh uh
uh flow yeah like he he saw um
he he saw he I didn't tell him about the
channel like he I came up on his like
recommended yeah he saw a video that me
and pearl did okay
make sense
we still got to get him on the show
we've been dodging yeah I don't think he
wants to come on
she's like I'll let that one go
Pearl had 30k Subs I did have 30k Subs
what's up Dad then it was good say hi to
the people
what's up people I hear you watch
you hear Pearl
what's up she said I hear you watch oh
yeah I check it out got you
I appreciate you for uh looking out for
my sister like that man yeah of course I
love your sister oh yeah well like I
said we appreciate you got to show you
love too yeah and congrats on the 100K
too thank you thank you
okay Pearl what question do you have for
my brother
um
what is the difference between a girl
playing hard to get and not being
interested
what's the difference yeah
um
I feel like
I feel like a girl playing hard to get
she'll still interact with you but she
may not give you her full attention to
she knows like
you're you're interested in her the same
way that or you're yeah you're
interested in her the same way she's
interested in you but if she doesn't but
if she what was the second one playing
hard to get
no I think I answered the playing hard
to get one but what was the other one oh
I playing hard to get her not being
interested oh if she's not interested
she's just not interested she she's not
gonna when you text her she's not gonna
text back or she'll take forever to text
back yeah is she not interested she
won't answer your phone calls or she'll
just basically make it known like hey
like we're friends and that's pretty
much it do you think girls ever flirt
for attention
oh yeah 100
do you think that makes it confusing for
men
some men that don't know like the
difference yeah it can be confusing
do you do you get confused
um
no you can tell when someone's being
friendly and when someone's actually
like
like flirting with you and trying to get
to know you type two or like things
you're attractive and it's flirting with
you
okay next question how many bodies is
too many bodies for a girl
shoot we just don't even ask that
question
what what would you for you what would
you say is it too many bodies and like
the age yeah you might not asked she
just says you know just to be up front
I've slept with this many people and
like how many bodies would it take for
you to be like okay we gotta break up
like immediately
um
that's tough
because if you asked you could be lying
about it and I know you'd be upfront
they could be up front but still you
just don't know I would say for you if
you in the if you're in the hundreds
whatever the hundreds like in the
hundreds then I'm then I'm just like
dang that's a lot of bodies okay so what
about 50. I was just about to ask that
what about 50 yeah
right now
huh I said isha's face is shocked right
now
50. 50 bro 5-0
do you know do you know bro
how have you got to 50. think about it
like well girl could tell you she had
ten yeah and she really didn't have a
hundred and something and you would
never know you bro you would know
you know I I'm telling you you would
never know I don't care how good it is
and or how exactly how good it is you'll
never know bro if she says 10 you're
gonna believe her she said 10 right
no take it with a pinch of salt
whenever a girl's giving me a number for
bodycon I take it with a pinch of salt I
like if that's what you're saying okay I
I I'm gonna take it as what you've told
me but
okay does second question does body
count matter if you never find out and
then like this means she doesn't like
act like she has a high body count so
you you guys have a good relationship
she treats you like a king everything
you just it never comes up you never
find out
foreign
if you never find out
uh to me nah
um if I'm not if I don't ask about it
and she don't bring it up I'm Gucci and
she's and she's cool with me and it's
just me and her
be good
okay do you do you think that
that
um why do women consider bad men who
treat them badly as the prize after
exhausting many options then claim to
settle for a good man who treats them
right
I wasn't gonna say that one more time
why do women consider bad men who treat
them badly the prize they exhaust many
okay basically why do girls get ran
through by the bad boys and then feel
like they're settling for the good guys
hmm
I really don't know I've
I've tried to figure that out most of my
life
but I just I think it's like something
that
something in them that is exciting you
know what I'm saying like oh a guy
really doesn't want me but I'm gonna try
to get his validation or try to get his
attention and when they do get it then
they're trying to change him into a good
guy or into something that they want him
to be which that's not going to happen
so then they get hurt in the long run
and they got the the dudes that want to
be with them
on the side still trying to fight for
that uh attention and waiting for that
uh time where they break up with the bad
boy and it's just never gonna happen and
so
I don't know why I don't know why they
do it but it's weird to me
okay why how it is why do girls March
the streets
for gender inequality so like the pay
Gap
and we'll always hear them complain
about not being in enough fortunate CEO
positions but you never see women
advocating for men they make up more
worth workplace deaths they they're in
jail more they're the majority of
suicides why is it only one way
hmm
women complain about disparity
but they not in the justice system women
men get four times the same sentencing
for the same crime why is there no
outrage
what do you think is more so like social
media just like
I guess
like blowing it up it may not be all
women feel that way but it just may be
like a so like a little group of them
feel that way out I don't know why they
feel that way or why they don't
no I mean I talk to women all the time
and like I talk to women four days a
week for months and honestly most girls
believe the pay Gap is real and that
we're oppressed
in some way as a female
but they never talk about the ways that
men are disadvantaged
so why do you think that is
to be honest with you I really don't
know it could be from them feeling like
so many years that they haven't
had a fair advantage in life and so that
now since like I said social media has
given them a platform to speak out their
they're saying okay well hey like we're
gonna speak out now and come out and
feel this way but they may they may not
look at it like okay well men still have
a still have a disadvantage too with
with all the statistics that you said so
they just they may see it as a I want my
voice to be heard and I want this and I
want that but not look at well
how is it how is this affecting
somebody else if I'm going through it
right now I don't know why why do we
look at women as a disadvantage
throughout history when men had to fight
in most of the wars
I'm sorry say that again why do we look
at women as a disadvantage throughout
history when men had to fight in the
wars and typically if um One Tribe beat
the other the women and children would
get to survive and the men would be
killed off
yet we look at women as the oppressed
ones throughout history
that's a good point yeah and he's just
like is it I don't I don't know
women women fight for equality but when
a plane is but when a boat when the
Titanic was sinking who got to get off
the boat first
the women and the children why if we're
equal
are we are we saying that men's lives
are less valuable than women's
I mean that's what it sounds like yeah
what is is not good that's what it
sounds like
men are expendable well how do you think
how do you think we can make it better
though if is
if it's always going to be like that
it's always going to be two sides one
one somebody thinking that they deserve
more than what they're getting and
it's always going to be like that so
like how does everybody come to
understanding that
like
I guess we're all in it together trying
to
um well I think I think it's first
realizing that we're not the same
and I I don't and I think the second
thing is we need to advocate for laws to
make it equal or not equal at least
equal like I don't think men should be
on the hook for child support
okay I don't understand why women
automatically get the kids just because
we're women it doesn't mean we're
automatically better parents
and I think we need to stop excusing
women's bad behavior like I think it
comes from like other women calling out
bad behavior you
and that sucks for the guy also if he's
a like you're saying about the child
support if he's in the child's life does
everything that he needs to do like you
know what I'm saying like really is
there and loves the child too like and
then he has to be put on child support
like he like he's a deadbeat or like
he's not there like that sucks and it's
18 years and all depending on what the
judge says about your income it's trash
have you ever seen a guy that wants to
be in the kid's life but the mom doesn't
let him see them out of spite
yes I've seen that is have you ever seen
a guy give up trying to get in contact
with his kids because he's he's spent
too much money and he just can't afford
it anymore
I haven't seen it but heard it why is
that legal
why don't women face jail time for
putting the kids at every statistical
disadvantage
because if if you're if you have the
father out of the home you're putting
your kid at every statistical
disadvantage you're more likely to drop
out of high school you're more likely to
get into a gang get into drugs like
every possible negative statistic that
you can think of is associated with
single parent households so why don't
women face jail time for doing that when
that's an innocent child
that's a good question
out
I don't I don't know
I don't know about jail time but I feel
like it should be a punishment whether
whether they they take on the
responsibility of the child support or
whatever the case would be is it should
be something else if uh
if if it's like that and sometimes a guy
a guy will just be like it's easier just
to leave this situation than to put up
with somebody nagging on you and then
you got child support on top of that and
then when you do when you are trying to
see your kid you can't see him because
you're not with the uh mother of the
child so it's just sometimes it's it's
easier just to be like you know what hey
I'm out yeah so so you handle it so why
can't we send women to jail for that
they're they're taking away a child from
the father
like I I like that is the meanest thing
you can do to a child and it's because
of their feelings
don't you think they should face jail
time jail time for putting the kid at
risk
like I said I don't know about jail time
I mean even even sexual abuse
yeah yeah crazy yeah even even sexual
abuse you like the kids more likely to
be sexually abused by a step parent
yeah wow
and on top of that on top of that why
don't women face jail time for letting a
guy raise a kid that isn't his
so if a guy wastes two three years
thinking a child has and she knows
there's a possibility it isn't and she
lets him raise it why don't girls go to
jail for that I mean he wasted two three
years of his time attention and
resources that he can't get back yeah
yeah they said and then it said B you
pay you pay it back however much he he
spent that's a double at least double
for the time
you like but it's interesting because I
think men have a natural inclination to
like protect women the same way women
have a natural inclination to like
protect children and I can hear it in
your voice a little bit where you're
like well I don't know about jail time
even though if the roles were reversed
I'm sure you'd have no problem yeah like
if a guy if a guy kept the kid from the
mother for two years and I said should
he go to jail most guys would say hell
yeah
if
if that happened to you Jonathan
do you think that
uh
do you think that she should go to jail
if that was the situation oh yeah
touche touche touche Crow said not me I
don't even know if I would I don't even
know if I would think that
uh a dude should go to jail if you kept
her if he kept uh the child away from
their they're like their mom I really
wouldn't think that I like I said I
don't know if that
if he's just doing how to Sprite I feel
like it should be some type of penalty
or whatever but jail time I don't know
but that's the reality yeah by the women
yeah like you give me giving me like the
numbers and it's actually like that's
what happens yeah but
yeah I don't know a parent but I know it
had to be a long pass and stuff like
that but that stuff takes time
[Music]
it would take a long long time because
you're a man and it's just been there's
just been so many things put in place
for women and I was saying I think it
was yesterday on the podcast or another
day that you have to be like the woman
has to be like
literally the scum of the Earth for kids
to be taken away from them when it's a
dad he does something wrong the first
time boom kids are taken away and it's
and it sucks that it's that it's like
that
and it's interesting and I feel like
it's been
over the years has been like the mom is
the nurturer so like that's why they're
always saying I don't care like you said
you don't care if she's a drug addict or
anything like if she has a house or has
a stable stable living space they deem
her like okay the kids can go with her
because she's stable even though she may
be horrible and may not be as nurturing
as the father and it's trash because
then like initially we said everything
just go they need the father in their
life but now they can't see the father
because
the court system or the laws well and a
lot say that the mother is better well
and a lot of evidence suggests that
actually men make better single parents
and when I asked when I ask a lot of
like my friends
um if your parents got divorced who
would you rather live with a lot of them
say their dad
I'm not I'm sure a lot of them say the
father yeah like a lot of them say no my
mom's kind of crazy like that's the
response I get
if
if you don't want to answer this
question you ain't got to Jonathan but
if I was just getting ready to say
before you asked me
we'll go ahead my bad go ahead
and
Mom and Dad got divorced when we were
younger
who would you want to would want to have
to live with
by myself
I would have just [__] it out in the
cold
but like I don't I don't know to be
honest with you because if
it was just a weird dynamic back then
like
so I can't tell you who I would want to
stay with of course I would want to stay
with Dad because
it was just like a oh my dad let me do
whatever whatever really like there's no
really like boundary boundaries or rules
like that but with my with Mom it was
more so
not strict but just like she was
concerned and was looking out like that
so I don't know who I would want to stay
with it probably would be better to stay
with Mom
then then that high key hmm
interesting
um what about you
I don't know if it all depends on what
what um
what age now if it was younger younger I
probably would have been like Dad but as
I got older
it would have changed
it's just like the dynamic of our
relationship like my relationship with
dad changed in my relationship with Mom
change yeah okay other have you ever
heard the stat that one in five women
um have been great I can't say this on
YouTube but like no I got you yeah
graped on college campuses
have I heard the statistic no I haven't
heard the statistic but
I've heard about it though did you know
when they researched that stat they
included girls that hooked up with a guy
when they were drunk
so even if the guy was drunk too they
still counted it as grape
wow
why is it if why is it that if I get
drunk and rob somebody
that I consented to do that and I would
go to jail but if I get drunk and hook
up with somebody that's automatically
considered grape if I got too drunk but
if I got too drunk and robbed a story I
would be held accountable for it
foreign
yeah and why do you think feminists
parade that stat around Knowing damn
well that it's not accurate
why do we keep why do we keep hearing
about a pay Gap when when 60 of women
have never asked for a raise
so how are we going to make the same
amount of money if we never ask for a
raise
[Laughter]
it's crazy once you hear these things
Bros like wow what have we been taught
our whole life yeah that's right
yeah
it's facts man
thanks for coming on the show
oh yeah appreciate you
hello y'all show y'all be doing your
thing yeah so keep it up for real for
real we appreciate you if you want to
plug your Instagram you can if you want
people to follow you
no it's all good he's like please don't
[Laughter]
oh if you were you were you in my no you
weren't in that one but you'll be in a
video
no you were in the last one uh yeah you
were in that one eight hours yeah you
popped your head in
when we wrap brunch yeah there's my
older brother y'all
eat a [__]
I'm ready I love you Jessica all right
love you too talk to you later have a
good rest of your day
all right bye y'all take care Mom bye
I know everyone's messaging me asking
for the call-in number I feel like the
people have been wanting this for a
while
you're finally getting it okay how do I
make a Google number I can't give you
all my real number for real
uh download Google Voice Google Voice
okay let's see we gonna have keys
I can call another person okay in the
meantime let me see if images they're
like they're getting ahead and they're
getting ahead of us
they're like call a number now
yeah what if we did this once a month
that's what we're getting the equipment
for
wait the 24 hour live stream
what do you mean
is that what you meant by once a month
yeah
I got it because I feel like in a month
we could plan it a lot better oh yeah
100 I feel like
Google voice isn't supported in your
country oh what what the freak
how do I get anyone know how to get a
free number VPN oh just do Instagram
okay yeah let's do Instagram that's so
small yeah
I was smart Okay so
was that from chat
yeah yeah so
all right I'll I'll do O'Neill okay
where are you at
I don't I don't want to turn on the
okay I want the video off because I feel
weird okay
I'll turn can I turn this on speaker
wait smoking
hey
what's up what's up
um so what what did you want to call in
and say you want red pill questions
well whatever whatever you guys uh put
it next to the mile here yeah can you
guys hear it yeah you can okay
um so tell me how many bodies is too
many bodies for a girl
honestly
uh
I think after like maybe eight ten
I think 10 might be pushing it I might
be pushing that's a common consensus I
think I get 10 and 20 the most
double double digits is like
it just doesn't sound right
yeah that's what I've gotten the two
numbers I've gotten the most are 10 and
20. it's like it's like how many bad
decisions did you make
um
is like damn
yeah no I I get you that's why this
can't be cheeses though that's what
Beggars can't be cheesers are you
begging it no no I'm just saying if the
type of girl that you you find yourself
attracting it depends upon the
application though so like what what are
we talking are we talking like like long
term yeah oh long term damn it feels
long-term then it's got to be like
four or five four or five wow very
conservative like that that's that's
just me personally really it's crazy
because I would not have guessed that
based on
like
yeah if I'm just like going out and it's
just what it is then yeah I'm not gonna
ask so yeah so how how long would you
wait to ask a girl if you were like
taking her seriously
before
taking her serious like ask her to what
just like we gonna smash no no like like
if you're you're courting a girl dating
her
how long am I going to take to ask her
to date me no how many bodies she's had
oh oh honestly
damn that's a that's a hard one because
I've never had that real conversation
with a girl you kind of just know okay
like you you kind of know if it's a high
count just based on how she's moving you
know like in bed or like how she
how she world you know what I'm saying
is like how she how does she act in
front of other guys and like you know
does she know a lot of people like does
she like you know what I'm saying like
it's
she's seen a lot of dudes you know what
I'm saying and um
personally I can you can kind of tell
when a girl
has had a lot of guys I mean obviously
they're they're um ability to pair bond
is like not there so it's like
when when dealing with a girl with a
lesser body count like you know after
you guys have sex
like you guys like are attacked she's
almost attached almost you know but you
know when a girl
when you could have this is the first
time this ever happened to me you know
out in Atlanta in Georgia you know you
know went out with a girl we had a good
time we hooked up and like every girl
that I've ever had that happened to me
always been on me after afterwards
always I'm talking about that was the
first time I ever was ghosted like by a
girl I was like damn like that's how
they move in the city so it's like yo
that's how it is you feel you feel used
yeah I was like that's for the first
time the first time I was like dancer
this is how this [__] feels but she
didn't stay long enough for me to break
her heart
I've had you know
I get irritated because I've been trying
to recruit like girls hoes for the show
and itch never brings me in that's cause
I have none I do know some
I mean you you seem to have a couple
contacts a couple contacts a couple
first of all people know me uh-huh
show guests already knew you
she wrong
Hey look
s O'Neill by the way
[Laughter]
shout out oh no I I know your name yeah
but maybe the guests though I mean hey
what's up
okay okay how do you know oatmeal Pearl
oh I met him at the red pelt conference
yeah the CME okay gotcha
yeah
um
have I met O'Neil
over the phone no no no
um
would you
do you want a virgin
oh damn
honestly I've never I've never been with
a virgin before so I don't really even
know what it's like
um
uh but I want a girl that's a virgin
uh I think idealistically
like I would say yes but realistically I
I just can't have that expectation at
all I just can't there's no way I never
even met Like a Virgin girl unless like
probably when I was like 15 in high
school or middle school but like nah no
girls making it to be a Virgin by the
time she's 18. that's crazy what about a
born-again version
yo you're not laughed at that that was
rude that was actually rude
I can't even I can't even really uh be
down with that kind of uh cause because
that's just delusional at that point or
what about someone who's been like
celibate for five years
okay I mean that's fine that's cool you
know I know like it's everything kind of
like works his nature kind of does its
thing or after time over time but I
don't believe that a girl
it depends if she's like religious then
maybe but I don't believe her girl could
be celibate for five years like that
that's crazy challenge acceptance not
five years Jesus I did two once in my
life
I told you Ebony and Ivory
okay
um how how long is it too long to wait
for sex where you're like I just gotta
if you really really like a girl how
long would you hang on until you're like
I just gotta keep it pushing
okay
honestly
it depends on how much I invested into
it already
so if I've invested like low like not a
lot of my time and attention
I was I'll see her maybe like at least a
couple like more times
you know until she's comfortable with me
but if I'm like going in on her
I'm kind of expecting it I'm kind of
expecting like yo like we're gonna
I'm gonna get it on you know what I'm
saying like like it's kind of like at my
return for investment you know what I'm
saying like if I'm gonna invest like a
whole day's you know days at a time with
you going out you know we're going out
to eat and going out to places and stuff
like that doing things and having fun
I'm expected to like you know we're
going we're gonna have some fun you know
what I'm saying okay how how old are you
27 27 are you looking for something
long-term or like short-term more
right now I'm not looking for anything
long-term okay so now I'm really on the
on the on the streets on the prowl I get
you the Indian Street in the street so
so so question question
since like so you're saying you wouldn't
wait that long and I'm assuming though
that's because you're looking for
something short-term now how long would
you wait for a girl if it was long term
like if you're looking for a wife
I would I wouldn't
you see if this girl's gonna be my wife
she's gonna want to have sex with me
okay so do you like it like she should
she wouldn't wait you know what I'm
saying so do you think it's realistic to
expect a girl to hook up with you damn
near immediately and have four or five
bodies
because okay
um
like especially because you're 27 so if
she's your age yeah yeah no I wouldn't I
wouldn't expect her to have four or five
bodies at my age but
um no I wouldn't I wouldn't expect I
wouldn't hold that expectation on her
I just I'm confused because
the one thing I I could confuse red
pills like sometimes the things you guys
say you want kind of like are at
opposite because I actually I know a lot
of like mid 20 year old virgins like
weirdly enough through church or like
volleyball oddly enough and what
it says it's tough out there no I'm
telling you I know a decent amount like
female female but I think you've
probably met a couple you just didn't
know they were virgins yeah and no I'm
telling you and and
um I just know those girls like they
wouldn't they wouldn't they'd make a guy
wait
so like even if they're very attracted
to him
I don't know any about it I don't know
they've got it's like the grass I guess
I guess I've had a taste of women that
that would give it up to me
on the first yeah first time you know
what I'm saying so I've had that taste
and it's kind of like if at that point
in time it's like man I've already had
that kind of taste so yeah if I don't
really get it then it's kind of like ah
honestly I don't even think she's really
into me or she if she doesn't want to do
that
I don't think she's really into me yeah
no and that's fair it's like fair enough
and I I definitely see that point of
view but I just get like it just doesn't
seem like then it just doesn't seem like
you'd get the outcome of a girl with
four or five bodies like yeah like
ideally you know ideally no I was asking
what you what you would date though
that's what I was asking
are you with wife
honestly I probably would never know her
body account but
I mean yeah I guess I go with the the
like hopefully she's not she hasn't had
more than 10 guys like okay it's just
it's more of like you just hear the
number and it's like uh like it kind of
cringe you know like damn so does body
count matter if you never find out
oh yes it does body count still matters
like you you feel it like I've
I've had a girl before where
you could just I I could feel her body
and I was like yeah man like you've
you've had like the King Kong thing
you've had you know you've had this
already you know what I'm saying like
there's nothing new happening right now
and it it I don't know there's like this
uh disconnect especially with me I don't
I'm not even into it it's just
interesting because you just said you
probably would never know
I probably would never know you you
never truly know the number but you can
kind of like huh you know
on a spiritual level
like okay
do you feel like the guys actually know
as a girl
so you see you see the girls that get
wifed up and like long like and we're
gonna we're gonna measure it like this
like basically the girls like it dated
the longest I know that's not equal or
married right do you feel like the guy
the girls that the guys like are the
hoes who they would seem
no I think that there's some that can
hide it very well and
there's ways to
make yourself
um how can I say this there's a ways to
make yourself not seem like you've been
ran through
and I think women can like
physically emotionally and mentally hide
it very well like oh I'm this person
that's had maybe a few but really they
I always say I think hoes get wifed up
faster than prudes I just don't think
the guys know yeah I think yeah and the
only people that would know are the
girls yep yeah
you're never gonna know you never yeah
no you can always assume make
assumptions but she's never gonna tell
you the right number that's why you
always got to multiply times three word
of J Cole we should ask them if they
could guess our body count
no we ain't gotta say yes or no but they
can just guess it they could guess it
based off like what they've seen about
it I know but the thing is like the oh
yeah we could do that yeah we could do
that we ain't have this out oh yeah
that's right or no I for sure ain't
gonna say yes or no one
um hey you know how this goes
how what goes remember the last skill
that revealed her body count oh we
wouldn't reveal that they can just guess
I don't know I feel
yeah that's
don't do it y'all don't do it don't do
it
um
let's see oh my gosh I got between three
and nine thousand three golly
chat with the guesses three and nine
thousand that
that's ridiculous if there's someone
that has had that many partners just 18
Pearl 71.
Pearl five just fifty dang I promise I'm
not a hoe 100K party count celebration
yeah that would be the best clickbait
title
I know people would have been in there
like whoa what's this what's going on
here 100K body count celebration Jess is
a virgin
exactly thank you I appreciate that
guys I do think the ideal I think that's
best if both people are virgins oh yeah
like because that's the highest marriage
rate it's just like we're in a
post-marriage world that's the problem
birth control changed the game do you do
you think that
um
do you think red pilling women is a good
thing like it helps build better
families and wives now you think it's a
bad thing why but I don't think it's bad
I just don't think it's it's it's not
it's not gonna work okay why it's not
gonna work because
I mean at this point in time I truly
believe that women are going to operate
how they do and the red pilling the red
pilling
men is is waking them up to
understanding how I mean obviously red
pilling goes beyond women but you know
most men get to the red pill through a
woman like you know doing whatever
Etc
so that's kind of the way I see it and
every time that I've
maybe I'm just not good at it but every
time I've had red pill
talks with a woman
it's always been
never received at all in in the way that
just completely went over ahead
and and I just go by the the the the
rules it's like there's no real reason
to talk about red pill things
you kind of just navigate using the red
pill like knowledge that you know
yeah I think I think as girls when we
hear like the wall
I don't I think it's weird because I
feel like girls know this instinctually
but when you hear about like oh yeah but
but it's weird because I I used to I I
genuinely think most people peak in high
school I like I stand by this
maybe freshman sophomore year at college
but once they start drinking like it's
over with yeah
um because I remember being like 18 and
thinking that 21 because I feel like
girls notice wrinkles and stuff like
faster than men
because I remember my ex-boyfriend like
I was pointing out like wrinkles or
something and he was like oh I didn't
even notice that I like I saw another
girl but I was like I noticed that when
I was 18 on the 21 year olds where they
but it's like so faint guys would never
even
I mean is that's kind of how I
biologically
that women kind of operate yeah they're
always looking for like the Beauties the
beauty standard yeah so the moment they
see wrinkles or you know I'm saying you
see an old lady and then then you kind
of compare yourself to an older lady
you're like oh
you know what I'm saying yeah
um
how
how were you on sauce cast or was that
your brother
uh my brother my brother was on it but I
was I was in the building you know I was
chilling oh okay why didn't they have
you on
uh person and it was um the case had
happened where somebody was supposed to
be on they hadn't canceled they had no
showed and then Rolo tomasi had hit my
brother up so Rollo got to my brother
first and so he was like the one on on
the uh on the podcast okay we were just
there just chilling you guys coming to
London still
um I have plans to go to London I'm
going to Portugal
next month okay uh so I'm trying to get
a flight to London from Lisbon to London
uh from on the fifth or either on the
sixth I'm probably gonna like flying
just for that day because my guys are
going to be in Portugal and and trying
to get back out there and okay yeah if
you guys if you guys are in London you
can come on the show just let me know
what time what time do you have the
shows because it has to be late over
there right yeah well right now we're
doing a 24-hour live stream
okay yeah but it's um Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Saturday 8 PM is when we tell
people to get here
okay then probably
Wednesday okay either Tuesday or
Wednesday the fifth or the sixth okay
okay yeah that's fine oh yeah DM Jess
because she's in charge of recruiting
now yeah
okay okay well thanks for calling in
appreciate it all right all right I'll
see you when I get out there okay bye
we will miss the court of the way done I
know all right I got one person
foreign
Thai
[Music]
here we go Ty what's up
say hello to the people
how's it going from the states
we got Pearl and ish here say what's up
Ty
what's up mate
please don't embarrass me
um we're gonna ask you some
um red pill questions but before that
hey happy birthday it's the 10th over
here
oh I'm 27 over there hey thank you
is this your other brother no no this is
one of my best friends okay it might as
well be now yeah I know pretty much
um oh wait actually I got a question oh
I gotta go oh
[Applause]
dude I'm gonna give you the Pearl
so so I want to put your thing so
um hi how are you
good I'm gonna put your like the thing
right by the mic so
how long have you and just been friends
yeah 2014 2015. so how old
I think I was like 20. yeah I was like
20. she was grown okay
so so question
Jas calls you one day she says I'm horny
it's just one time let's [__]
you doing it I and she says it was not
gonna affect our friendship it's just
one time
[Music]
people keep it 100 Ty keep 100 speaking
you doing it
why wait he's laughing he's not
answering because he knows I think I
know what his answer is no I know like
this that caught me off guard as hell
but no you wouldn't do it
even okay okay she walks in butt naked
says I want you to [__] me
foreign
[Laughter]
what's the answer Jess he can answer it
what's the answer
alone
[Laughter]
is it what red pills yeah that's part of
the red pill you don't have any real guy
friends
okay okay what other questions
oh that's so funny
um what other red pill questions do I
have that's my body count what that's my
body count oh it's Jess's body count no
not about my body count ask him about it
is he gonna answer that video no I don't
even think he knows how many bodies is
too many bodies for a girl
how many bodies is Too Many Bodies
once we start counting toes
we got a problem
yeah
okay so so like over 10 I'm gonna start
like
okay so you know what I'm saying
so so 12 is that a problem
cute you dumping her at 12.
considering our age nah nah okay so 15
you dumping her
my eyebrows did raise
okay but it's not it's like it's if
she's a good girl it's like workable
yeah
30.
yeah I wouldn't even ask at that rate
does body count
self-reflecting to really see what I'm
going for because yeah
okay if you're able to name all 30 what
the [__]
yo that's right that's a lot of people
I can name all my numbers
I know yeah
Ish what's your body count
don't be City they said I can name all
my numbers
name them on the live
hey what's good
it's really the sun is really coming up
yeah honestly you say sun I just see
daylight I know there ain't no sun
that's what I mean it's cold okay would
you oh actually would you rather okay
would you rather have a girl slept with
five people right
but she got a train ran on her
so like like three were in the like same
same day
train okay but it's only five
or or Twenty
or Twenty
over time let's say over like five years
who you pick 24 five years that's three
that's that's four I'm not down with
nobody
gross
I say you picked the 20. that's right
that's four years okay would you rather
have a girl slept with 20 oh my God 20
guys that you'll never meet or one guy
that you know
four years not bad
for Guilt to be given up
you would have one one guy I know
what you really you'd pick the one guy
you know that's what most guys say that
20 I'll never meet I could I could know
someone just from work okay
you know what I'm saying walking past
them enough to where I know they are but
yeah
so this is this the freaking sex episode
Okay so
okay so question why are women looked at
as as oppressed throughout history when
men had to fight in most of the wars
why are women looked as oppressed when
men are doing the quote-unquote most of
the fighting no one more men died in
wars throughout history and women's were
the one women were the ones protected
but women are looked at as oppressed why
um
I don't know I don't think you could
just dwindle them down to
wartime efforts okay
but throughout history like it was
constant fighting for most of History oh
yeah yeah history major I freaking love
World War II okay but I'm just saying in
a sense of why okay
if we look at people like okay men or
whatever role there is or you want to
take it's just there's two general roles
in society the hunters and the gatherers
yes sir and they both
you
do what they have to do to make this
thing Spin and go and do what it's doing
so I don't think that their oppression
is
a result of any wars or anything like
that but I don't think that what y'all
go through is
or that it equates to what you have done
for the society okay so it is
it is a bit unfair and y'all do kind of
get the butt end of the stick but at the
same time women do make it hard to make
it a way for y'all because sometimes
that's a moving goal post like I heard
this a comedy uh or this like joke that
was said in this comedy special where
like the whole me too movement where
uh before the metoo movement if a man
said I understand
I feel where you're coming from and
we're going to move forward and we're
going to do better and that's [__]
cool you know what I'm saying but then
when it came down to the me too you know
and all that those four things being
said all of a sudden is not [__] cool
no more like a man understanding you
feeling where you're coming from
writing is wrongs and moving forward
positively was not good enough for women
and I I kind of agree because I'm like
yeah like
I'm offering you progress but sometimes
it's kind of hard to give it to you
because it's always moving first it's
over here maybe it's over here now and
now it's over here you know what I'm
saying so
um
yeah okay so other question
why do women always talk about how there
aren't enough women in power positions
right so there aren't enough women like
CEOs and that sort of thing
and they cite that disparity as a form
of discrimination however they don't
talk about how men make up the majority
of the prison population and men get
three times the amount of sentencing as
women for the same crime why don't you
hear feminists outraged over this
because they're not real feminist okay
straight up he's red pill
I might get like flat four but Dave
Chappelle is one of the most down Earth
feminists I've ever met or encountered
or seen because like
feminism is legit the advancement of
women so
like
um here so I can say it right ask me a
question one more time trying to worry
about my answer correctly so women
always talk about the pay Gap and cite
it as a form of of discrimination
okay
um however they don't talk about the Gap
in prison sentences so for example men
get three times the amount of sentencing
for the same crime as women and men make
up the majority of the prison population
why don't you see feminists marching the
street for this in the name of equality
times like the hunters and gatherers
men what they don't realize is that
we've accepted in society that we have
to take
the [__] brunt of it like
not to say like you know y'all not going
through your stuff but as a man in
society that's just how we're positioned
like if if we're the Frontiers or
another Frontiers the pioneers of this
whole thing then
you know we're kind of not helpful
different standards you just have the
the rules of society hit us in a
different way that you know it seemed in
numbers like you just shown
so and I think they're not marching in
making a scene of that because it
conflicts with what they say yeah
of the day isn't even really feminism
why don't feminists when uh when there's
a war why don't feminists demand that
they're enlisted
when the ship was going down in the
Titanic why didn't the feminists demand
the men go first
in the name of equality
[Music]
a moving goal post because like kind of
like
I don't know it's kind of like being
black like everybody wants to be a like
black until it's time to be black you
know like everybody wants that equality
like to feel like up there quote unquote
with men until it's time to really go
through the [__] that men go through
so like something that we go through is
yeah you gotta die first bro like [__]
going down You Gotta Die first that's
how it is or you know like uh wartime
yeah we're gonna pick you first We're
Not Gonna you know so
yeah I think that
you know feminism unchecked has a hard
time
even standing on even one foot because
there's so much stuff that men go
through we just don't [__] complain
about it or make any
issues really you know we just us is
like no that's just Mansion you know you
gotta man up like and not even like man
up in the toxic way but it's just you
know that's how men are supposed to be
so
yeah well thank you appreciate you
taking this
hell yeah yeah thanks Tom I hope Jess is
in one day you know for that
yeah go ahead plug your stuff
all right I'm on Facebook at smile more
s-m-y-l-e
-m-o-r check me out I got season one up
at least 10 episodes in that one season
two is uh on our third episode I got
more in the works me and Jess and a
friend of ours Sarah did an episode back
in the States over an hour long I'm
gonna upload that one here shortly
um also Facebook yeah smile more
Instagram smile dot more m-o-r not
m-o-r-e
and yeah check me out check us out
appreciate you guys awesome
everybody was telling you to stop
captain on that first question
if you would have saw if you would have
saw the comments in it yo it would have
had you dying okay now because since you
want to expose me I'm gonna say what my
answer was the way it was
we've had that talk I know that's why
that's why I said I would know the
answer yes
yes yeah yeah
see I already knew the answer
that's why I was like just say it you
booty
what do you expect from me and I've
known you this long way
get off my mind
there you go chat he answered the
question so are you guys really friends
then yeah we're like because we've had
conversations like this a lot but we've
we've come we both have come to the
agreement like yeah we'll just be better
as friends
okay so you came no like no
what do you say Ty okay you might okay
okay
would you would you marry Jess
what would you say would you marry Jess
don't don't my parents want us to get
married yes is it his parents his
stepdad always talks about yeah okay
that wasn't the question that wasn't the
question they said that wasn't the
question
yeah I would marry Jess
but the world not perfect
what like why why why
I was like what
yo
yeah why won't you why won't you why
won't you give it a chance Jess because
we've talked about this before and so he
said he said
he said he
mash and marry you
know and you said you wouldn't so why
not wouldn't what you would you wouldn't
you wouldn't be into doing that
yeah why won't you date him no no I
never said I wouldn't okay you might no
I would but we've talked we've talked
about it that's why I wouldn't okay yeah
we've had conversations I'd like to be
in the loop
so what what's the what's the issue here
what's the hold up we just think that
we would just be better as friend like
long story short there's just things and
um stuff that we both have been through
that we don't we wouldn't want to
jeopardize the friendship that we have
because the Friendship is dope and if
there was anything to mess that up it
would it would just suck to not just
have each other in each other's lives as
friends if anything Chad what'd you
think they think she's putting them in
the back pocket until she hits her wall
who knows
she said they said it's not what it's
not we think this it's just things no
it's not I promise yeah I don't know why
you're lying to yourself I'm not
I shouldn't have called you you just
said you're pretty light-skinned
you're all out in the open hell yeah
we almost said so so are you are you
saying it might happen are you saying it
might not bring it back bring it back
bring it back are you saying like what
are what are his chances like like does
he have any chance
like could it happen it could happen it
could happen yeah what would it have to
take for it to happen would you just
have to be like super smooth with it one
day
I don't know I've never thought about
what would it take for it to happen like
why why hasn't it hasn't it happened
okay like I don't know Ty why hasn't it
happened
you I mean are we being for real right
now yeah for real
I think it hasn't happened because
you haven't tried it
your night
playing balling cans because you flew
out
um
you pick me up every time I land
come on Woody
be careful because there'll be guys that
will actually try it what this could be
your husband right here oh my days this
could be your your wall is coming Josh
just chill out
when our family's linked up it was like
this so let me get this straight let me
get this oh let me get this straight so
the fans would have called you all right
no no no no no no no no no let's let's
talk let's talk as a as a group I like
to be included I like to be included
where's the chat saying
the chocolate heat for y'all let's talk
let's talk so he's into you right
all right
okay okay let's hold on guys we're
getting off topic I'd like to eat okay
let's let's Okay so let's let's get this
straight let's get this straight okay so
he he wants to bang right he's down
um and you your families get along you
guys clearly get along is it do you just
not see yourself like sleeping with him
is that like could you just not see the
sex part no no you couldn't see the sex
part or no that's not what it is that's
not what it is so you could see yourself
sleeping with him
possibly pot you okay have you thought
about have you thought about it is
shut up
emotional damage okay okay have you have
you thought about it yeah you thought
about hooking up with him yeah so this
could be the husband right here is there
does he have a butt is there like
something that like makes you hesitant
other than the Friendship
no not gonna hurt any feelings just no
men can take this stuff no fat like men
just they're used to it they're used to
ones sitting on them all the time I'm
not saying it's not right but he could
take it there's no butt because I like
thought about it like I had a guy that I
was friends with for a while and I
probably would have dated him like but I
just wasn't like super like crazy
attract like he just wasn't he's Wyatt
that's it but he he seems to be your
tithe
yeah just right now chooses to be the
friend that hooks me up
with her friends knowing that the [__]
probably not gonna work first of all
first of all first of all first of all
Ty well I'm like yo yes
don't even don't even do that is it
maybe okay has he never like taken the
masculine lead and been like and like oh
he's trying to hit it through the friend
zone that's a feminine way to do it the
masculine thing is just to like ask her
out have you has he ever asked you out
no he's never asked you out
I'm the first one that brought up the
conversation about
yeah but that's it we could do that and
she was like nah no but but that's a
feminine okay come here
Paul gonna put you on games let me put
you on game let me put
you put Let me I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry
when did this turn into that okay I'm
sorry when guys go through the friend
zone to get to us I'm leaving it makes
you look like look at you like one of
our [__] like we don't want to screw
one of our [__] I'm sorry I I hate to
like be the bearer of bad news but if
you come at us and you're like look it
I'm sexually I'm sorry I'm sexually
attracted to you I'd like to take you on
a date like that is way more masculine
than like going through the friend zone
but like like if you played this the
right way and just asked her on a date
from the jump you guys could be married
right now
but you played it the wrong way you've
gone through the friend zone no
it wasn't like the friend zone was a
door I chose to open up and walk through
no I was in that room already like
you you you feel like so then why did
why did you keep being friends with her
why don't you like take away the
attention because a lot of times like
girls if they didn't have that attention
from guys all the time like they
probably would like date in their friend
zone and a lot of times like we become
more attracted to guys that walk away
but like if you don't walk away it like
almost makes you lose value to us and
sexual anyways like like wanna [__] like
value
well my God don't waste your time just
just do it do it or don't what
what oh okay well you said
after the problem then I mean
it's a Bittersweet ass problem I guess
until someone else tries
so what if your friend asked her out and
started screwing her with that would
that change things
okay yeah but I'm saying like like
imagine
your best looking friend I don't know
who it is I don't know who it is but
everyone's got one friend that's very
good looking he sees Jess he's like sees
you're with her whatever and he he's
like are you guys dating you say no he
said okay cool I'm gonna ask her out he
asks her out start starts hidden you you
feel some type of way
so why don't you just ask her out
why haven't I asked her out yeah
are you afraid of the are you afraid of
the rejection are you afraid of the
rejection
no but okay but Jess Jess just said
she's thought about screwing you
I know but that that means like like it
possibly like guys this will use this as
a learning example
no you can't you can't go about it this
way because once like you put yourself
like some guys I'm not gonna lie some
guys it's a yes some guys it's a no some
guys it's a maybe and if you're in the
maybe category and you go about it like
no offense no respect I like you you
seem like a nice guy um like the [__]
way which is like the friend zone maybe
like pushing the boundaries for a few
years doing these late night talks
no it's not just
it's not an [__] like I would never
think it's an [__] I mean you don't
have to say I want to [__] you but like
say hey I think you're really pretty you
want to go on a date
like that's that's not
have your friend
no no no I know but see but see but no
no but you're the you're the guy though
you're supposed to lead
like you can't look to you can't look to
a woman to leave let me ask him to jog
my memory let me
hold on
when when when did you ask this question
[Music]
the whole specifics
it is what it is I'll try later when I I
don't remember
to be honest and don't worry every guy
that's roasting you in the chat I'm sure
they've done it like come on no guy's
ever taken an album down bad like it
come on
yeah I don't remember this Ty by the way
I like your shirt your Rafferty
do you see this
I know
what
dude my parents lived in San Pedro they
moved to Compton but this last year
dudes would have happened last year
I don't remember that I don't remember
you all right how about this how about
this you know I'm getting called out on
the chat I mean
I'm getting called out as well
[Music]
so you graduate when
I graduate in December
I I have no clue I haven't figured out
that information yet
so let's say I get out there for your
graduation can we go on a date yeah
ah I'm done what
yo what's up
I never said you were lame
[Music]
okay okay
where are you guys going
what'd you say where are you guys going
where are you gonna take her
what the [__] I'm coming to London what
the [__] how am I gonna take you better
do some research yeah I mean
I just I mean like we like a man with a
plan
don't don't make just Planet that's a
feminine thing
nah but Jesse that's the thing though
you don't know like I know it just is a
dope ass Planner yeah I see I feel like
I'm on a live report hi Dana
I don't care how good of a planner she
is I don't care I don't care how good of
a planner she is we want a guy with a
plan
yo what up Dana hey I got a question for
you Dana
that's true in the house I respect I got
a question for him Ty
[Music]
hold on all on the chat
oh this is Savage yes Pearl is a Savage
I just like I just like to be in the
know
ledge where are we going we're going to
go
foreign
like I want to go and just hit spots
like the [__] Big Ben tower where the
[__] that is
uh
uh the what the ferris wheel how high Q
wanna how wait how far are you from
Italy it's a flight away
I want some pizza man
you you're gonna make me say a word on
this live that I cannot say shut up yo
plan it out plan it out
any more hot Quest
yeah girl said I'm good now make sure
you Vlog it yeah
I will
plan it out
maybe do a reaction video afterward I
mean whatever for the channel whatever
the views
but all right Ty thanks for getting
grilled on live appreciate you
from the 500 people
let's plan it out let me know
all right send me your address so I can
start looking around your area
uh okay
London area they just put London just
put London anywhere in London close
enough yeah just put London literally
anywhere is close
say Where's
well thank the host I appreciate you
oh I didn't think it was gonna go that
way
I didn't either I
saw an opening
I saw I saw an opening
good old Pearl I thought this is your
brother I had a different set of
questions going but as soon as I heard
guy friend I was like give them to me
she said give me the phone as soon as I
knew you were gonna be Reckless
anyways
I think you're gonna be Reckless after
that first question my friends are in
this room
I pay my friends
I'm good but thanks Ty getting on the
call yeah
one brother
I will I'm gonna call you on your like
actual birthday that uh your time
all right bye
what were they saying what's the chat
saying the chat's talking I was like
I was like sir like she's
she's a good planner I'm like
to go pulley
I'm like I'm telling you I think I would
rap oh my god when a guy's asking what
do you want to do what sucks here what
do you want to do or hey I hey we could
do this or this what should you rather
do oh the second one for sure like I I
enjoy planning things and I I'll take
that out I'm a good plan I know how to
like just plan like outings and whatnot
but if it's a dude that I'm interested
in and I I want him to plant and he
asked me what are we doing I'm like man
I don't even want to hang up to you
anymore I don't want to even like do
anything with you because I want I want
you to like take it like take initiative
and plan something I'm always planning
something and that's one thing like when
I do talk to dudes or get into
relationships that I look for
and if it's just me constantly planning
I'm
checked out I mentally checked out like
every time you ask to hang out I have to
plan something or you don't plan
anything and I ask you to plan something
like well I don't know
I think my fourth person has gone into a
date If Ever I go on one is that I will
try free conversation figure out what
she doesn't like like what she doesn't
like doing because I don't want to take
someone to a place where
they'd feel uncomfortable they just
wouldn't feel comfortable after that
I've got like a few little
I know I've got spots that I'm like this
would work quite well for the person
that I'm taking out at that moment I'll
tell her look this is where we're
meeting I want you to
this attire
okay
um if she says no
it's cool like if she says but like I
I'd be telling her this is what we're
doing on the basis that she'd she'd want
to go but like I wouldn't really be
asking her oh do you want to go you know
this is what we're doing we're gonna do
this yeah oh my gosh this is like even
just hearing that this is what we're
doing that's like
rather than what do you want to do yeah
so then when when we go out we'll get
we'll go places
um and then I'll have little surprises
and then yeah that that's how you got
any guy friends Pearl that you can call
yeah let's find out that's the problem I
don't I don't have any guy friends you
ain't gonna die from come on no not not
anyone I've talked to like recently I
have like people I was friends within
College oh my gosh I did ask a guy
friend
to hook up on a stream before like for
the same thing and he like wait what the
chat no I did the Donovan had me call a
guy friend from college and Essay how
I'm in Chicago you want to hook up like
something like that he said no I told
him I told them that he wouldn't do it
but
yeah
um
trying to think who can I call for red
pill questions
ooh for Revenge oh yes yes I am wait
what did they said just looking for
Revenge that's okay
lucky for you
okay let's see some super chats
how many more hours we got oh this is
what happens on a 24-hour stream
one two three
before but you know this horrible 11
hours we've got 11 hours yeah we have 11
more hours no no we've got one that got
along Oh no you're right because it's
five so it's till 12. so five so until
12. now it's 12 hours till five and then
like till five yeah I try to go from
nine so nine till nine a.m which is 12
hours and then at four and then at four
from five fourteen sixteen sorry I can't
do math I'm tired but we good we still
have people yeah we're alive and well
yeah um what time are the other I think
10 o'clock is our next guest oh is it
who we got it's the girls from the last
stream nice I like the the two girl and
not your mother's or whatever auntie and
Sarah is coming later in the day too yo
we go
one slash two uh Jess from netball
okay okay yo please read the super chats
well I'm gonna let you read this one
okay okay it says Pearl you after the uh
you after up for this homeboy was in the
friend zone since 2015 for a reason his
passiveness dried her up okay well it's
better he knows
like as I was saying I'm like he didn't
have to be in the friend zone or he
would have gotten an answer like what
the you're gonna sit in the
sir okay anyways I hope you I'm sure
you're watching Sir you seem like a real
nice guy good looking nice guy you know
we're happy for you but yeah if you if
you let a girl if you wait too long
like a girl's just gonna see you as a
friend forever because girls have three
categories for you it's yes immediate
yes immediate no and maybe but some of
your maybes I know girls like how many
times have you heard a girl say I didn't
really like him at first but then she
becomes obsessed yeah that happens that
happens so
yeah anyways my point is with game you
can go from a maybe to a hard yes
but if you sit in the friend zone yeah
it's not going to happen okay
Joseph's King he needs some vitamin C
for confidence toxic Lord I know exactly
why homeboys in the friend zone not keep
him there this is cringe
um Jess this is how you become Shane new
Leading Men on and then putting them in
the friend zone stop it
become who I don't know what Shang new
is don't know what that is but you're
going to become Shang new you're saying
you what's that what's your new name no
Hurley and Jess if you're five out of
tens I read myself a five you don't have
to do that to Jess
um if you're fives out of tons would you
date a three out of ten hypothetically
he's saying no we're hypergamous if
we're fives we gotta get a six sure yeah
it's like Have you listened at all of
these channels if you're a three you
qualify for two
I don't know what to tell you
um anyways
um mate I would wait for a virgin who's
a woman long term for the win as long as
she shows me affection I'm happy you
don't want bitter experienced lady who
has everything dubs the thing about
virgins and low body counts is that
women the women seem to show a loving
nurturing almost cuddling nature you can
really make love it's emotional when you
go too high or older I think they get
blase rough and freaky [__] a woman
with a high cone will exude certain
traits and mannerisms that you can pick
up on that can't act like a born-again
virgins forever plus men need to know
how to ask the right questions Mt body
count
um question always ask a man what's too
many to hit and what is too many to
marry and also assume they're hooked to
a lie to texture detector
asking me okay
um Matt butcher what is even her body
count what even is who why even ask her
body count you're not getting the truth
dubs to me it's not body count it's why
did your relationships not work out so
20 plus is just insane to me
oh my gosh I got one yeah here's here's
some for equipment streamed up okay well
Sam Pat this is for the for for producer
things here's films for some equipment
stream deck press plus up deck check out
locals.com best of okay never mind best
of luck with your channel from the
states what is your culture sock shock
or red pill moment is the red pill
different for men and for women I've
told one of my red pill moments was that
girl that slept with the she had a
boyfriend that was like buying her house
and stuff and then she slept with her ex
from like five years ago I was like that
was my Alpha Widow yeah
um
okay I think I just saw some over there
in the chat
oh yeah I see him yo they coming in
which refers to any I guess that's how
you pronounce it it says Shang new which
refers to any woman over the age of 27
who is still single applies to a growing
body of women seeking education economic
freedom and a more unconventional life
path oh it's like then their parents
alone basically oh you said wait what
what does Super Chat say okay you gotta
they usually like you I know okay it
comes it comes in they come and go the
channel turned on you quick it's okay I
know when I first started they were
always calling me ugly and then the
better I got of my content oh my God it
was so tiring I was so tired of being
called for like how dare they I was like
hey I have at least a five look
um yeah
sentience oh okay um passionate
Rebellion ladies on the show how would
you rate your lack of level of
femininity skill one to sound oh my gosh
I think this is something I struggle
with femininity yeah because I'm more
I've always been more of a tomboy yeah
so I I don't think I'm super
disagreeable like a lot of the girls I I
see so I don't think I'm like super
masculine but I also wouldn't consider
myself feminine so like because I'm not
I've been working on it but I'm just
naturally not super dressy and stuff and
like into girly [__] so I'd give myself
like a five yeah five for me too because
right in the middle yeah I think because
I think like neither of us are super
masculine yeah but we're not super like
girly yeah yeah happy medium yeah sorry
if you want a very feminine woman yeah
but I've seen you girls turn it on so
that's the that's the key that's the key
you could be able to say I'm like a
father because I think some girls just
have it on all the time yeah because
when you turn it on they don't expect it
and they're like oh wow yeah but it does
it's not like super I but it's because
girls that play sports have a higher
levels of testosterone fun fact wow yeah
no wonder my voice is so deep or whether
I sound like Barry White I'm kidding
she said Barry White
MK c um MK can you do a reaction to
Jordan Peterson addressing the swimsuit
model tweet um probably I don't do
reactions live guys because
um the copyright oftentimes will get it
taken down
at some point I'll do a little bit more
research to like maybe
I don't figure something out where we
can do them live but I just haven't
every time I used to do reactions live
it would always get taken down
um
okay afro Angel can't figure out if um
that was the worst wingman or best [__]
block
but it was brutal Pro great you can
check him but not in front of Jess
that's what I look at I saw an
opportunity I don't know
she can check them
um
um chance what up zantia I missed you I
haven't seen you in the streams in a
minute
um congrats on your 100K Pearl much
success as you continue your journey
Jess when you host again crack that Whip
and keep the guests in line and your
producer you have a masters and can't
read super chats it's true it's true
dang I appreciate it heading to bed
sorry ain't doing nothing next weekend
Pearl just saying
um
Pearl you effed up for this oh okay
what's the one thing that you
need
to feel secure in a relationship Pearl
what do you mean by secure
um
Phil
um how can I explain it like that's the
guy I want no not the guys you want to
to feel like
how do I explain secure because that's
the
it's not like based off of like an
insecurity is to make you feel like
if you were to stay with this guy like
long term he would be able to fulfill
okay I if he got along with my dad and
my dad liked him I think that would be
like
because I know my dad wouldn't let me
pick a guy that I couldn't be with long
term you know what I mean
foreign
against it but then ultimately it's your
decision
and my dad doesn't make decisions for me
but as I've said I mean just because
from like speaking about one of your the
lot one one of the exes that you had
beforehand you explained that your dad
didn't see him as a no but I learned
from that that's what I'm saying like
like so guys what he allowed you to no I
know but he he said what would make you
like pick someone as a husband I broke
up with that ax okay yeah so
um
no because like and then I don't know
guys I've dated like since I've always
like told my dad about
oddly enough that's good
it's sad a little bit
yeah no my little sister
my little sister tells me about guys
that she like because guys can see
through men's [__] faster than we
can sure
yeah
oh it says please watch
Patrice O'Neill
Phillips show elephant in the room and
all of his material he was ahead of his
time should I take another caller yeah
make sense okay this is new
there's been a lot of people that that
have said uh Patrice I thought it was a
woman
at first with the name Patrice
the guy told me to call him
foreign
this once a month it'd be like the worst
day of the month
I feel like we all
yo
oh wait let me put you on speaker hold
on okay
hello
hey hey how are you
good how's it going
good
so you wanted to talk about Steve you
want to talk about Lori Harvey
yeah yeah
on that yeah you know what's going on
with them right Jess yeah ish is in the
other room but yeah okay go on okay
okay
so you know the details as to you know
that Lori Harvey left Michael B Jordan
right yeah she was ready to settle down
yes
you know that she's with that Jack
Harlow guy you're lying
dude look at him
right so here's the thing wait like like
right now she's with him she's with him
now
right what do you think Michael B Jordan
he's 35. uh-huh
Lloyd Hardy is 25.
and she he wants to get married and have
kids but she's for the streets mm-hmm
back for the streets right so one of the
things about it is
a lot of us black men Kevin Samuels made
a point that said
that said a relationship but then
because everyone
a lot of black women think that Michael
B Jordan is gonna end up with a white
chick right I mean they're trying to
find him with a white girl he even takes
a picture with a white brother they go
crazy so he's hiding with Lori Hartman
she's for the street and all of us guys
we knew she was for the streets but you
slide it anyway
so my question to Jack what just may not
care but
um would you get upset at Michael B
Jordan if you ended up with a white
chick after after trying to date Lori
Hartley
don't lie
um no if I honestly no
um
because of uh
moving to London has it
I've seen things just differently I've
seen more interracial couples both ways
out here that it's like
I'm understanding and just like learning
things being around Pearl and just
hearing different things
I it sucks but I can understand
why he would
if
let me say Kevin Samuel said it's not
fair because Serena Williams can vary
that beta-ass Reddit dude and get
celebrated
with a white girl they're frowned upon
and here's the thing
Michael B Jordan is he's gonna get a
younger chick right but it seems to me
that the majority of attractive young
black females aren't ready to settle
down and the expectation is US black men
are supposed to wait for them to get
ready to make major decisions in our
lives yeah so what do you mean it sucks
if you were to do that
um
it's supposed to wait
what's he supposed to do
no I wouldn't I wouldn't say that he's
supposed to wait it would stuck in the
sense like man like
I wish
how do I that they weren't all for the
streets and he
get a young black
hey
call your girl Michael B Jordan I'm not
for the streets but
um it's that and it's like
it's it's a harsh reality that it's like
that and then black men want to know
like oh why do black guys always go for
everybody else but black women but we
don't take accountability for like how
we how we treat them how we make them
feel and just
in Lori Harvey sense that she's not
ready to settle down you've been you've
been dating this man for how long when
did you know that you weren't ready to
settle down I'm pretty sure he's
talking about
um
Seattle Seahawks fan and I I was never
down with Russell Wilson and Sierra up
until I understood what what it was
about Russell Wilson and Sierra are
unfortunately in the black community we
have these black couples that we that
Black America holds in high esteem it
used to be willing to you know Russell
Wilson Sierra if you're one of those
couples it'll make you hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars oh yeah
so
stigma that Michael B Jordan was going
to get with a white girl his PR team her
PR team were like hey you guys are
attractive you guys might fall for each
other or whatever you guys can make a
lot of money
Sierra yeah and I think that that Lori
thought that she was ready to be in
relationship with a man of substance
that have been structured to her life
who's a nice guy but she's got a little
bit of taste of it
yeah
no earlier I had that thought but I
didn't go into detail because I heard
that
in the beginning that their relationship
was a PR stunt he was coming out with a
new movie and it it was like I said
before he started dating dating uh Lori
that or Lauren is it Lauren or Lord Lori
okay sorry Lori that um
he only like white girls and blah blah
blah and so he got with he started
dating Lori and it's like oh this
um image that he likes a black woman
he's dating black woman and then
um this happens and so I don't I don't
know what the truth is what the truth
isn't but if that was a conversation
that wasn't had it should have been had
before this point and if she knew that
she didn't want to settle down with
anybody and it was just a publicity
stomp from the jump in her brain that
should have been
that should have been just communicated
with because
either he would have broke up with her
or she would have broke up with him if
he if he wasn't down with it and she
just would have went back to the streets
or it just would have been a publicity
stunt and they just would have broke up
and been like oh we just wanted to
separate and be like make up some dumb
excuse so I'm not sure
so do you think that
uh well do you think that Lori Harvey is
going to end up 45 alone maybe with a
kid or two wishing that she would have
stayed with Michael B Jordan no
I don't I don't think so I don't think
she'll be wishing that she stayed with
uh Michael B I think that it was just
like Rihanna said just another dude on
The Hit List
she's gonna be a visit to Fox 30 years
Lori Harvey can leave Michael B Jordan
and her future
she can do whatever she wants she can
date whoever she wants
she's for the streets we all know that
but she could be but Michael B Jordan
his career and his future still depends
because black women control the
narrative and control the consumer base
of the black community his career
literally depends on who he dates who he
marries and who he chooses to to have
children with
he he can't just go on to a white girl
or an Asian girl he has to do that
balance to try to find the black woman
or it could negatively affect his career
what do you think about that double
standard
do you think it's true number one and
then what do you think about it go ahead
ish um yeah I do think it's true
um I know just from speaking to black
women in my community how it can be
frowned upon when black men date outside
their race
um
and I understand that Michael B Jordan
has got a image to uphold and maintain
but if I'm being real I think this
opportunity where like she's he's
offered marriage she's said no is the
only opportunity that he'll have to be
like okay I got burnt by a black woman
and
If he if if his true desire was to find
um someone outside of his race this is
the only opportunity he's really gonna
have to do so because
it would be this is the oh I've been
burnt by my own and I'm actually all
good
anytime after this moment it's gonna be
like
why didn't you just try and find someone
else because they'll be like oh you've
healed from it
that's my opinion
yeah okay and Jess what about you um I
do think it's true and
um
um what was your second part the second
part to your question
the double standard true and then
about the question is is do you do you
think that his
his Show Business
um
is attached to who he who he who he
dates marries and has children with
um
yes so yes to both of them I think that
if he
it ought to
it's like when it comes to
from what I've seen when it comes to
black women
it all depends you can get support if
you date a certain a certain one every
day a white girl you'll get less support
if you date uh Hispanic you may get some
support from some um black women you may
not get some support it's just from
something that I've seen so I think
whatever he does is going to
is going to hurt him but I think in this
situation he'll get more support from
black men because and like the ones that
may not have supported him or
vice versa he'll get more support
hmm
black men
intelligent
the black women are the only ones who
wins support based upon who he dates
okay we don't care
cool black guy days as long as he isn't
you know making this look bad and do it
and do all sorts of dumb stuff so black
man he's never lost our support okay
Woody but once again black women's abuse
are valued more and control the
narrative
yeah
noted
um it's just I wish it I really wish it
wasn't like that because we we as black
women want
people to support us and people to
support the community but as soon as a
black man does something that we deem as
an incorrect or redeem as just
unacceptable were the first ones to
diminish them or the first one to cancel
them the first one to just uh push them
away and it's like how how can we expect
other people to support our men if we're
not doing it first from the inside out
foreign
about that girl on the pineapple show
that
that curved that nuclear physicist yes I
didn't wash the whole clip but that
because I got irritated and I just
clicked off of it because I saw the
whole thing I saw the caption and I just
saw I just like saw her demeanor and saw
his so when he was talking I just saw
her demeanor and if he was like hey yo
what up girl I'm a neurophysicist
however you say that neurophysicist
physicist physicist they're ready to go
it's late y'all it's early in the
morning I know
physicists
and like he was like yeah but on the
weekends I like to go out I like to turn
up this that in the third when I'm
coming to pick you up if he talked like
that she would have been like okay yeah
I bet but but because he talked in a way
that wasn't
I don't know how to explain it he was
like oh he's boring it and this that in
the third from just a little clip that I
saw yeah I have a question for Pearl and
Jess I think that Jess kind of gave away
the answer to this question when she's
talking to her quote unquote best friend
oh [__] what is your idea of a when a
guy is being corny I think Jeff kind of
gave it away with that guy she was
talking to before
Pearl what did you do wait what did he
what did he say I couldn't hear him say
it one more time
what is the guy what does the guy do
like
when a guy is being they have a term
called a guy being corny oh kind of like
what gives you the it kind of oh gosh so
many things so like what does a guy have
to do to be get considered corny
um
I think it's funny because I think the
outrage with that video was that guy
really wasn't doing anything to be corny
like it wasn't you know he wasn't so I I
didn't really see it with that so I
think that's why I blew up so much
because there's guys that are
accomplished and have money that like
girls wouldn't sleep with and you can
see why but that guy was like he he had
everything literally he literally he was
just chill
um
but for me it's like when guys put you
on a pedestal I would say
and there's a difference between like
treating a girl right and like putting
her on a pedestal like not having a
background backbone and not being direct
like as a girl we want someone that can
like lead us
and so it's like when a guy's beating
her out like that's what I was telling
your friend is like when a guy's beating
around the bush and like trying to get
get you through the friend zone like we
can feel that and it's not attractive
but what is attractive is hey I like you
do you want to go out
and then being as direct as possible
yeah when they're indecisive
and it
just
yeah Pearl you literally took the words
right out my mouth I was like direct and
just know what they want if they're not
that and they're just like oh
um I don't know it's just like a I was
like okay do you even like want to
interact do you want to do anything if
not well it's like we feel like you're
too scared to do it and if you're too
scared to do it how are we gonna trust
you to like take on life with us
I guess a woman we have to like pick you
to help rate I mean I know they pick us
too but like we have to pick you to help
you know raise kids and like go through
life and life is hard yeah and so if you
if you're too too scared to ask me out
how are you going to protect me when
someone breaks into our house how are
you gonna how are you gonna do anything
like even planning a date it's a sign of
competence because it shows your
competent enough to make a plan follow
through stick to it but if if you can't
even plan a date it's like it's like we
feel like we have to hold your hand and
like walk you through it like that is
the most frustrating thing as a girl
like dating someone that you you feel
like you have to Mother yep
thank you
okay uh I have another question for the
whole room I can start with ish okay yes
as a man because
myself
and all my diet friends we we think that
women had to go through
percent of the rejection that men had to
go through in their lives they wouldn't
be be able to handle it for the room
what percentage
if a man the average guy has a hundred
percent rejection rate what percentage
of that do you think the average woman
goes through or would be able to take
oh gosh
women cannot handle rejection period
what do you think yeah I've
women handle rejection really badly
um and I don't know whether it's because
they
they just they're not used to it the
entitlement of like the amount of guys
that are hollering them
um kind of boost their ego to thinking
that they're above rejection
but it it's it's almost an ugly sight
watching a woman handle rejection
no honestly because like you'll find a
girl like before the rejection happens
is really nice upstanding like amazing
person as soon as the rejection happens
where it's like oh maybe I don't see
this going long term
you can see a really disgusting side to
them and it's just like okay I'm
so yeah it asks you a question I'd say
about five percent
okay on the lower end if that makes
sense
I I think that is that answering your
question I'm not I'd say yeah
yeah
who's next uh
10 yeah what
why
I just don't think girls handle
rejection as well as men do
okay I mean I think we know I should say
I I think that we don't have to face it
so it kind of kills us
hmm
I don't know
imagine imagine being rejected by a guy
that you look at and go
I've spoken to like you perceive that
you've spoken to better than and he's
rejecting you oh I would feel like an
ugly duck then I'd be like
would you feel ugly or would you feel
offended
have you uh
have you ever both okay Jess have you
ever and this is okay sorry kind of a
Red Bull moment had a guy that like you
didn't really think
that like you just didn't find him super
attractive like he's okay and then you
see the girls he dated and you're like
oh wow like he he really like pulls
girls like that like and you maybe like
you see one or two that's like
you deem is hotter than you mm-hmm and
it's kind of like
and all of a sudden
he starts looking more attractive no not
even that it's just more like oh maybe
he's more attractive like than I thought
because his results are showing that I
don't know I've just had a couple times
where I'm like and not that I was
interested but I just like maybe I
ranked him lower than he was
ah
I don't think I'll be like oh maybe he's
more attractive than I thought I'd just
be like oh I don't know what they see in
him but good for them couldn't be me I
just take it as it is
I don't that doesn't like phase me
yeah
I don't know about the rejection thing
females do really take rejection hard
what's the worst rejection you've ever
had have you ever been stood up
hmm
um
let me think this have you ever been
stood up
um no no okay but that's mainly because
the girls I go for
are medium to high interest okay I'd
never I just wouldn't go out with the
girl at slow interest I wouldn't do it I
think it's too much work you you find
yourself
compromising beliefs and you may even
find yourself becoming like developing
like simp nature because you're trying
to impress her so if it's low interest
and not even bothered but medium to high
that's why
that's where I'm at yeah I have it you
have yeah you know what's interesting
I've been stood up too yeah
it's crazy because with the girls in the
room yeah we like speed up like spit up
and like you showed up to the place yeah
you just never what yeah you know what's
crazy I was taking him to a freaking
private I asked him to go to a private
banking event with me I was gonna put
him in a room with more millionaires
than like anyone would get to meet in
their freaking lifetime so you took so
you essentially because it was your
event you were taking like I'm not a
plus one yeah so I asked him to be my
first one man didn't come this is why I
say girls don't take guys out let the
guy take you out no I know everybody was
only because I had a plus one I hate
what you're saying I was like oh just if
you want if I was a guy I would hop on
that be in a room with millionaires yeah
but he didn't initiate it yeah I know I
know but it was a rookie mistake but
like you can do that for your partner
the only time I was thinking it grows up
uh I weighed tables for like 10 years uh
all the way through undergrad uh in grad
school and I would wait on tables of
girls and
um you know a couple times I get a
number left left at the table you know
because girls will never ask you for
your number you know you're at work or
whatever maybe now but you know I'm like
you know I'm like older and um so a
couple times I would get a number on the
table and I wouldn't know who who it was
so so I would call the number and I I
try to get a B oh yeah I'm the five foot
seven brown hair you know this is back
in like the 2000s and stuff I'm the five
foot eight brown hair girl you're like
all of you were five foot eight five
foot seven brown hair so I would I say
hey meet me at this restaurant or meet
me somewhere but stand outside so I can
see you and I would drive by and if it
was the ugly girl at the table I would
just keep on driving
oh wait what
[Laughter]
oh respect it wow that's smart though
but hey this is back in my 2002 to 2003
before like smartphones and Facebook and
Instagram and stuff you know what I'm
saying yeah you got to do what you had
to do
the bigger table would be standing
outside the restaurant and I just like
no sorry wrong one just keep on driving
what do you calling Pearl the whales the
whales it
and then I have another question for ish
is did you know what you were getting
into when you signed on to the
desperately things YouTube channel as as
the producer have you had any moments
where you're like what am I what did I
get myself into over here tonight this
24 hours stream
I'll tell you what I think I think it
was day two and I realized oh I'm not
just in videography
and then I was like oh I need to do
sound oh I need to do oh I need to do
okay all right I'm in charge all right
and then from that moment on it was like
okay
like I I pretty much was from the start
I was like pretty much committed to it
because I did say to Paul like I did
want to help her grow the channel as
much as possible I didn't know what that
meant at the time but um I kind of saw
the vision that she wanted to put out
how did you not know we were doing audio
when I told you we were doing audio no
no no so like I know you may have said
these things I'm not saying you didn't
I'm just saying in my head I'm a
videographer I'm doing videography
that's all I'm doing and then um it was
it was a bigger task than that so
um as soon as soon as I kind of figured
out what I was meant to be doing what my
role was and what I needed to learn
um yeah I I wasn't surprised by
everything that that came along after
that all right
Pearl do you have any questions
um
there's a Red Bull in there if you need
it I know but I feel like my I feel like
my heart is palpating all the
cops Doug MPA uh in the chat Pro may be
a moderator
how many it's been a while hasn't it oh
you're a dog
okay
I'll see you in the chat with a time
I appreciate you Doug well because you
used to always call into the show so
when I did the I used to do call-in
shows like before the stuff like before
I did the real show so like Doug used to
call in all the time so I knew who he
was so when I needed moderators I was
like oh I know dog you can be a mod yeah
it does
yeah well you know I gotta you know good
job on the hundred thousand you know
um uh and this just happens so fast but
be deserved I still this I'm sorry for
any are you letting people I still think
that you need to move back to the US
because there's such a you know there's
such a um there have been a couple of
schemes where the the culture Clash has
kind of taken up a a little bit of the
flow of the show like like earlier you
guys were talking about the Black
Panthers and you guys had it completely
wrong I'm like I
don't know much about the Black Panthers
so why don't you Enlighten us
but it's just
uh yeah the Black Panther well
it's past but all I'm saying is
the cultural class can be kind of
appearances sometimes and like and pearl
has to do some exposition to catch
people up on like a lot of the basics of
America I mean but it also makes for
good content like when you showed that
girl that um the Ben Shapiro gun debate
thing like I'd like to see the type of
thing but there's some cultural class
that happens I know I think I need to
while I'm here
research England's history better
because sometimes I think could be
better if I like knew more about
different
like I I know some things about
England's government but I'm not super
like burst in it so I think I need to
actually research it better yeah
any random questions because I'll answer
them
um how many bodies is Too Many Bodies
um 15 15. ah he's the first one to say
over 10. yeah okay how old are you Doug
I'm 41. if she's 41 is it still 15
um I'm not gonna date a girl how how old
is too old uh 33. okay 30 because you
want kids I'm guessing uh so I don't
have any kids right now in fact you know
I live in the DC area and a lot of us
professional
successful black men we don't have
children
um so and really we should go to DC you
know why why is that Doug why is there
so many professional black men that
don't have kids I think I know our next
city to survives
it's because it's because black women
think that
that they own black men
and black women and what's that no
nothing nothing I just wish for
something go ahead
what I'm saying is a lot of us guys so
women they don't understand the male
experience in the military because the
narrative is all about women and how
tough women have it men have it the the
quest of a man women don't want that
smoke
and they get a small taste of it until
they hit 35 or 33 then they went out see
man we my dad told me when I was younger
because my dad isn't quite the Pearl's
Dad but he was like in the top like
three percent Corporation he made like
400 500.
um
my dad told my brother and I
when we turned 16 you're gonna play the
man's game and the man's game is you're
gonna get a job and work until you're
dead
the best thing you can do is put
yourself in the position to be able to
provide for for a wife and a family if
you if you so choose because a lot of us
the most satisfaction we're gonna get
out of life is supporting our family and
our kids hugging us you know hugging us
on the legs when when we come home this
whole Bachelor thing acceptance is only
a recent phenomenon you know what I'm
saying and so
um black women
will women in general put particularly
black women they dismiss the Journey of
a man and they don't cheat you with the
respect
that of of all the work is taking you to
to become Who You Are
and they treat you as such the level of
misandry and disrespect in this area a
lot of us guys we don't take it and and
we can't tell them anything so all we
can do is vote with our feet
yes if we see equation is we just leave
so that's why there's so many things 53
of black men are single or single and
childless and as you go up the up the
economic ladder that there are more
black men that are single and no no
children almost all my network here
are single
when you know black professional
moving into the White House move over
Joe Biden
yeah I mean yes have I lied at all no
it's just spitting straight [__] and
that's the part that's the part that
sucks I'm like yo like everybody black
women like black love black love but
it's like
why isn't there more of it we gotta look
at ourselves
come on now we gotta do better black
women have you ever called weird
we're a community of individuals they're
just meant that like oh oh a women build
men up not anymore especially in the
back Community we are we are a community
of individuals who have to somehow come
together to make something and
men are more likely to to make the
concessions necessary to be in a
relationship
yeah than women think about this at ish
would you ever move in with a woman into
her house
I don't think I'd be comfortable dinner
but often maybe but what does she own
the house I never want to do that you
want me a man will move a woman
and she will put all of his in the
basement so he can have man cave and
redecorate his whole she will a man will
let a woman nest in his home true
redecorate the whole thing put his stuff
in the basement so he has a man cave in
his house a woman will never give that
man that privilege Everett if you move
into into her house it's always her
house and you're some dude living in it
sure
and if there's a knock down drag out
fight the person that she's gonna put
put the card out on you is this is my
house
yep you're right
live with I've never moved in with a
woman nor would I guys
bro what do you think about this
would you ever let a guy move into your
house
well
when I get married I get a house so but
you you get one with him right
yeah yeah like um like my dad like
another house but my dad has a plot of
land for everyone when we get married
because my dad bought a neighborhood a
while ago and he like um
yeah he bought he bought it was like it
was actually almost bankrupt us at the
time it was in 2007 bad time to buy a
neighborhood like 10 fast and then the
market crashed but they ended up keeping
um 10 of the lots for their kids
so every kid could have a lot when we
get married wow wow and build a house on
it so well what would you say get out
this my property no I mean I just no
it's just like practical like if I have
a free lot why would we pay for a lot
well imagine if you you know if you
begin to successful if you were single
and you were like 34 things 35 because
35 is when the problems start that's
when women will not budge on anything
they have these super well you have a
decade telling problematic okay what's
that I have a decade until I'm
problematic okay so yeah so so imagine
you dropped seven hundred thousand
dollars on a house like you it's your
perfect house right
if if it's the Pearl Kingdom you know
what I'm saying like Casa de Pearl right
you would you wouldn't move you would
let a guy move into your house
and tell you how things should be in
your house
yeah
if he's a daddy yeah
did you hear her
she said if he's Daddy yeah
would you let a guy moving to your house
no I don't I don't think I would
just be that sense of like well
if you if you're moving into my house
what do you have
it'd be like that that's the feeling
that I would have
and I just because with me moving to a
guy's house yeah I would have prefer to
move into a guy's house when it because
when it comes to me and relationships
the one thing that I like need to feel
is like a financial like security and if
you're moving into my house and if
you're moving and if I'm like providing
for you it's just like
I I want to have my own but
I don't want him to per
I won't say that
I want him to be able to in a certain
situation provide for me just from like
my upbringing I don't want to have to if
something happens to me and I
uh run out of money or whatever and I'm
just unstable to where I'm
just down on my luck in a sense does
that make sense
do you want to be responsible for for a
lifetime
I would honestly
I would go 50 50.
honestly
no
so would you like
no idea what would be ideal like you're
perfect perfect situation not like you
would go like what would be ideal if you
could build a man
I was about to say what um homegirl said
in the um the show you went on and she's
like oh he pays it he pays the rent but
I pay for groceries in the car
but if he if he earns more
I would want him to pay the rent and
then I can get the rest of the bills to
where it's
it's I won't say it equals out because
obviously rent is going to be more but I
want him to take the bigger portion of
bills
yeah as bad as that sounds
I
I think that for foreign
would she be willing to cook and clean
with that yeah if he if he's if he's
doing what he
um needs to do I don't mind being I
don't mind cooking I don't mind cleaning
but if he's not doing what he needs to
do and I still gotta cook and still
gotta I'm like uh-uh like I ain't taking
care of no bum
Jess would be a good housewife she's
very organized highlight your girl come
on Michael B come on I'll be Miss Jordan
I honestly like honestly I think that
you're taller than Michael B Jordan
though how tall is Michael B Jordan
he ain't fighting he's been five times
no he's not is he really yeah
yeah you sure okay okay would you still
do because he's not tall enough would
you still date him
no it's Michael B sure
I don't know I know it was Michael B but
Michael be a cup to you like this on his
tippy toes kissing me oh no is this on
Mike yeah
no he ain't wearing no platform shoes
looking like a pimp got the goldfish in
them
any more record questions
no I think we're good Doug thanks for
coming on and calling in
uh yeah so uh congratulations 100K and
Jess uh
I'm totally uh right now but you are
absolutely beautiful oh thank you
um and then ish i really you've been put
in a position
and a group of women who will be even
forced to have to speak for all men and
you've been doing a great job yes I
appreciate you man thank you so much
dude shoot yourself
shut up girl look you've already caused
enough trouble today
he's been friend zone for seven years
you need to go right to the Smashing
when he gets off the plane
okay
no dinner no nothing you need to have
some freaking candle set up in the
bedroom some rose petals and to get to
the Knocking the Boots you know Jesus
Christ
that card now anyway but Pearl great job
and I'll be I'll be in the chat
moderating and uh and here's the 100K
more yes thanks Doug yes thank you dog
all right bye
oh all right question would you go on a
date with him yes or no
he asked you on a date like for real
would you go yeah yeah it seems like I
feel like if guys shot their shot more
like girls would say I would go on a
date with Doug yeah it wouldn't
be cool dude yeah he is he is I was
about to air out my business on this
live but no he's cool
whip it let me in on the business I've
told you this business I've told you
this business Which business do I know
about
a person
don't say it okay yeah you know what I'm
talking about okay air out you've
already put me on the spot I would never
do such a thing for Content that would
be so rude that would be so rude we
don't put content
content anyways
um catch us on patreon
um
catch us on membership yeah let's go to
the membership behind the scenes behind
the scenes yo Pearl we've been doing
this since nine o'clock yesterday it is
607 now I'm so tired yeah I think if I
if I step another hour the adrenaline
will start to kick in again yeah I think
I've got my psycho win there's a moment
after I ate the pizza where I felt my
eyes getting heavy and I was like yo I
could take a fat nap right now someone
said she's down to go on a date with
anyone
I mean it's a date
not with anybody not with anybody chill
out but would you sleep with Doug no no
no
yeah I saw him
well it's not even based on what it
looks like it's just no I just wouldn't
I wouldn't sleep with them because you
don't know them well enough or because
you're not attracted to him like that
I'm not attracted to him like why would
you go on a date
do you have to be attracted to someone
to go on a date you should
why would you go I would I would go on a
date with someone I'm not attracted to
it's called false hope like why would
you why would you why would you put them
through that
okay it's like a dude that's like the
equivalent of a guy
knowing that you like him sleeping with
you and then ghosting you after
okay I can understand where you're
coming from
so I love it wait so what about your
front would you sleep with your friend
you said
you said yeah I thought about it okay so
would you sleep with your friend
oh no no no no no
but you need to cancel it no
if it was
it's not it's not that I'm saying no
it's just yes I'll just say yes yes you
would sleep with him yes okay so you
guys are gonna hook up
[Laughter]
yo Pearl I need you just uh
I can chill you're good
no look at this stuff gives me energy
Pearl's perking up now she loved being
in the know
I love being in the know
I love do you do you have any guy
friends that you would
that you would sleep with
friends in general
um
mostly just because I mean you see me
I'm always working here
um
hey guy thanks ish oh my gosh well
there's one
that from my there there's
like the
the guy that stood me up was a friend
you know so like I would have but he
clearly he clearly wasn't wow he missed
his shot she said she would have
um
trying to think
no I hit it it's all good
no I can't think about it I would tell
you I like can't think of anybody
like going through my phone
like who do I even know who do I text
uh yeah we can turn that all alarm off
because I didn't go to sleep so there's
no need to turn around oh you really
have a 6 a.m alarm I have a 6 30 yep 6
30 alarm no need to have that one going
on for real women allowed topless in
pools in Germany for gender equality
we ain't complaining
when men allowed topless in pools in
Germany for gender equality
yeah yeah
hey
these women talking about gender
equality will find themselves getting
stifled because
of their beliefs they won't go oh yeah
no you can
come through topless
you're just thinking
don't do it please don't do it
what no I thought one of my friends
daughter's daughter graduated high
school
which is going into ninth grade
trying to see is there anyone
let me let me see who's online
no I don't have a lot of friends but
um
oh let me my cousin's probably working
let me see
foreign
let's see oh yeah actually I should
FaceTime someone
who do we got
um
[Music]
oh let's see if we can get my dad on the
line what time is it in what time is it
in Chicago
um
that might be a little too late for my
it's 12 12. 12 12 yeah okay it's 12 12.
um let's see
people have been wanting me to interview
my dad
hello hey Dad are you asleep
okay great I'm on I'm on I'm on my show
and that's good for you keep on your
showing don't bother me
I'm done no no I'm on a 24-hour live
stream
hi everybody I know but it was it was it
was like for the content he said don't
bother me with your stuff that's a long
I know I'm really tired
like I'm gonna do it about 30 seconds I
know but that sounds like I think you
might still be awake
uh well I was thinking about sleeping
I'm in bed oh okay well I'm glad you're
still awake
um so I have some questions for you
and okay what's the question
you see I told you he's never excited to
talk to me
he's about to go to sleep
okay okay anyways anyways okay so no no
let's not go there anyways
um so why do you think women complain
about the pay Gap
but they don't complain that men make up
most prisoners
I don't know I'm not a woman so I don't
really hear what the pay Gap complained
so for that reason and then I think and
the commit more crimes because it's fun
you think men commit more crimes because
it's fun
right now especially this time right oh
okay okay am I your favorite am I your
favorite kid
uh well as of right now I'd say there's
no chance to know why you caught me at
midnight
yeah but like it's like a pleasant
surprise
uh I gotta explain surprises to you
maybe I never did that one
all right
all right well you have fun
figuring out those things for me and let
me know your answer or something
okay all right bye love you
okay bye love you
questions
I think he was very excited
he seemed it yeah I think
he wait hold on
okay
[Music]
oh my gosh who else could I call because
the problem is now they're behind us in
the U.S
so I'm like wait let's see if I need a
phone anyone DM me on Instagram wanting
to talk let's see
um
oh my God me and Josh should read our
Instagram DMs
perfect timing okay wait let's see
viewer from Madison Wisconsin
Okay Madison Wisconsin dude I'm calling
yo
I can't wait for you to read the super
chats
hello
good how are you
so question how many bodies is Too Many
Bodies
um
I guess it depends on
25 like age
it depends on the age
okay okay
um why do you think women complain about
the pay Gap why are you guys laughing
hold on hold on I'm sorry sir there's a
funny Super Chat let me hold on what's
this read it read it
what is it what is it which one were you
laughing at I also I have another one
from Mr Fisher what what is it I want to
be it on the joke when you read it
you'll be another joke yeah do you want
us to tell you or do you want to wait
till you I won't know what it is tell me
all right
you're amazing Paul
and I want you to be the recipe it's a
joke that it seems like a scene oh
there's another part too you have to
read it you have to read it okay
don't make me turn on my laptop I'm
making you turn on your laptop okay hold
on real quick sir
I just my my production team was just
very distracting
um
wait speaking to the mic okay okay
what is the Super Chat so let's
let's go to monetization refresh
what okay why why are you guys the one
from Mr Fisher Mr Fisher
you're amazing ink Pearl oh I would love
to take you on a date
well I don't know who you are dmmer
slide into the DM maybe we'll we'll go a
lot we'll go live but if I if it goes
poorly you can't like I don't I don't
know what these people look like but
maybe the I see a suit in your Avion on
YouTube it's a good sign see chocolate
skin okay I'm sorry Mr Wisconsin I'm
back I'm back okay
okay okay so tell me why do you think
women complain about the pay Gap when
men make up the majority of men in
prison but we don't see feminists
marching the street demanding equality
of Prince and sentences
uh well I feel like a lot of it's just
media
and what does that mean
so I feel like a lot of it's just them
hearing stuff on TV and then
they want a reason to stand up and be
vocal and protest and basically complain
that Living in America
isn't what it is which is amazing you
got
opportunity at the wazoo
and you know a lot of these
females are white girls that are saying
these things
and white women
have it the best out of any race gender
whatever hmm why women have the best
that's just how it is you know even at
my job or Union I'll try to I'll try to
keep my identity uh
as low as possible but I've been at my
job we're a union and
the white women that are there they get
treated way better than
everybody else
so
okay
um
does why do you think women initiate
divorce 70 to 80 percent of the time
foreign
a lot of it is them thinking that
there's something better you know that
like a lot of women
they tend to think
is this the best I can do I remember
seeing a a picture I think it was like a
meme
it was a girl laying in bed like she had
just slept with Superman and her quote
was is this really the best I can do
when she's laying in bed with Superman
but she's wondering I bet you I could do
better
do you think women should settle or die
alone
I would say
most women
their subtle is probably not settling
they're usually their settle is actually
the guy that they should be with well
what I what I mean subtle I mean like
she feels like she's settling because if
she settles for that guy on one hand she
makes him miserable because that's not
who she really wants to be with
but on the other hand her other option
is dying alone so should women settle in
their eyes or die alone
um I would say settle D because
eventually
you you I believe that you can't be with
somebody for
you know a certain amount of years a
certain amount of time
eventually you'll love that person
eventually you'll have feelings for that
person that's just human nature
you know if you if you spend enough time
with somebody you'll learn to like them
you'll learn to
understand where they're coming from
they're
weaknesses their fears and you'll form a
bond that and especially women women
will form a bond with anybody I mean you
see girls that are with guys that you
wouldn't consider good looking
but there's something that guy has and
it's not always money I understand a lot
of the time it is money but
sometimes the guy just has something
that the girl gravitates to and she
feels
like she relates to that person and
you know can can you make a wife out of
a hoe
hopefully not Kanye tried
that how do you define a hoe
uh a woman that
willingly gives her body to
men without
really vetting the person or I mean I'm
a Baptist Christian so
without even getting into my religion
just speaking from a worldly View
I think a girl that gives her body
without commitment from the man
would be considered a hoe and most
people's eyes
so
and when you say commitment do you feel
like a girl shouldn't like a hoe
like do you because now it seems like
nowadays um the general consensus I get
from guys is that they want to sleep
with a girl before they give her
commitment would you say that's true
uh the guy wants it or the girl no the
guy
um commitment on her end yes
um it depends on the guy
um I say your average guy probably yes
okay
or that seems like it's different for
you maybe you're Baptist like somebody
said what part of Wisconsin you from
oh okay I lived in Milwaukee for two
years
yeah I heard about that I mean it's it's
a different a different vibe for sure I
love Wisconsin the people there are like
very hard working I think it's because I
think Wisconsin's like German right I
feel like Germans are always really hard
workers
yeah I like Wisconsin I mean when I
moved up here I didn't
like it at all I hate it um I didn't
want to be back in the snow
but where are you I learned to like it
Where'd you live before
I stayed in Texas for 15 years oh okay I
can kind of hear that in your voice I
don't know why like I didn't think you
were from Wisconsin based on your voice
um
let's see
um how old are you
25. okay how old is too old to date
uh what do you mean by date just oh
sorry like you're looking girl like long
term
oh for me yeah how old is too old
um
I I wouldn't date anybody in their 30s
for sure
um
27 26 would probably be might cut off
okay
um
what is the difference between a woman
not being interested and playing hard to
get
oh well I feel like going on hurrying I
mean there's only for the guys very hard
to to know the difference
um expression in the world we live in
so
I wouldn't I wouldn't uh risk it
if that makes any sense you wouldn't
risk like approaching a girl or like
pursuing a girl that you didn't think
was interested
correct yep so you don't you don't do
like the playing hard to get stuff
you'll just move on
yeah why would you waste your time yeah
no fair enough
um
let me give let's see
why would you
I mean I'm uh I'm a firm believer in
you don't need to really try the girl
wants you
I agree with that if a girl's
yeah girls will chase you down if
they're really into you
um
do you think men should be able should
have to play Child Support ever
yes in what cases
the case that
they agreed
mutually that
they wanted to have a child okay
and then she has it and he bounces
correct
okay
um
do you think that if the dollar
collapses that the dating Market will
change
do you think women will ever settle or
they're going to die alone like what do
you see as the future of the dating
Market
um
well with the with the wave of feminism
I feel like
the future is really weird I feel like
the future is
a bunch of single people
you know using toys and
watching
I guess I'll say corn for the algorithm
thank you thank you I appreciate that
thank you what did he say he said corn
stuff yeah nice good job
sorry continue people never people never
say it even if I tell them so I get
excited go ahead Donovan Donovan Sharp
yeah shout out to Donovan
so you you think right now it's weird
but it'll get better
no it won't get better it won't it'll
get worse
100 yep okay so I feel like at some
point there has to be a reset
yeah
um
oh yeah I don't I don't I don't think so
I feel like
with the way the world's going
with uh you know homosexuality and stuff
like that yeah
it
the more the the Freer you are because
they're being single and
doing what you want mm-hmm
uh would you say you're more
um are you mgtow or would you say you're
more just red pilloware
I'm aware you're aware
yeah okay
okay well thank you for calling in yes
thank you yeah absolutely
um have a good one I'm sure we'll get at
real phone lines hooked up at something
yeah we're still figuring it out but
yeah so call in next time
yeah I mean this this works well and I I
just want to say I think another caller
said you definitely need to
I wouldn't say move back I don't want to
control what you do but
you know I would definitely love to be
on the show if you guys came down
came to the states I mean not not so
much like a freshman pet style but the
the style that you have would work very
well and I felt like something you
should Implement is
talking to
regular guys that meet the criteria that
most women are looking for
because
oh I mean I don't really consider myself
rare
but there's a lot of guys out there that
watch your show that make six figures
may not be considered high value or
maybe a Henry if you do you know what a
Henry is yeah I like that
like they're gonna make money eventually
they're in training or whatever I I
don't remember what the term was but I
know what it means
yeah
um hi earning not rich yet yeah
oh yeah so like like
I would definitely say if you if you
came to the states and had a show like
that where you brought on guys and maybe
girls
um
would
I guess sixes and up
and then had them talk
that'll be a really good show
what city should we go to
uh well you have family in Chicago so
you'd probably yeah
not Chicago anywhere else
well don't you stop family in Milwaukee
okay
um no I don't my brother moved
okay I just meant like what would be the
most entertaining City to watch
oh well entertainment value would
probably be like Miami but
if you want to make an impact
oh
I don't know that's a good question okay
because La is very liberal which they
wouldn't be up for your type of content
Miami
they're more conservative but you would
also get just a bunch of party people
yeah
hmm and nobody looking for serious
relationships
hmm
so
okay I just I get that a lot a lot like
that we should go back to the US but I I
never hear what city when I people say
that so I was just curious
I mean you can start here if you want
why are you you're trying to come on
oh 100 yeah I would fly out or you know
if you come back to the States I'll
definitely fly to be on a show oh okay
depending on where it is so okay yeah I
mean we're here at least another six
months so we'll see where life takes us
after
yeah maybe around like the next scene I
think it's CME
yeah who knows possibly we'll see we're
weighing a couple options so we'll see
yeah
well it's nice talking to you Pearl and
uh
Jess yeah yes
all right you guys have a good night
okay you too good night good morning
goodbye
I laid my head back I laid my head back
and I was like
if I close my eyes I'm out so I was like
let me sit my head up now I know
um
see if any other callers
anybody wanna call in
if anybody wanna Uber Eats us some
breakfast no I'm kidding we got pizza
oh my God I'm still full from the oh you
didn't eat as much I was so hungry
I'm like how you doing back there ish
seems so tired I am
um
I am what the [__] what do you think
there's a One Wing in there yeah there's
one we were being so polite no I I just
like Flats so I ate the Two Flats and I
was like I thought I was being polite I
was like yo just probably looking at a
wing saying she gonna eat it no I love
it for you because I'm like Flats only
you should have said that Wallace it was
hot there's a microwave it's all good
someone said in the future what we
should have did was had Jess host for
eight hours me host for eight hours and
saw our house for eight hours ah I was
like that probably would have been a
better reply yeah hey it's our first
Dream we were ambitious we were like 24
hours yeah I think
we're gonna make it though yeah we're
gonna make it
we are gonna make it guys put some
questions in there let me I'll read some
of the super chats hold on
hold on did Mr Fisher DM you
no I was hoping I was like you could
chew your shot live on the show I was
waiting oh come on Mr Fisher Mr Fisher
oh he did oh he did you dropped his
phone number
let's see let's see are you text me girl
Okay so
Deuce please Pearl Samuels praise good
things guys you'd be saying tell it
you'd be gassing up every manosphere
Creator and telling us we're all the
next Kevin Samuels
none of us can like none of us will be
but thank you
um Jess's socks need a lint roller
is Ellie it's Ellie's hair Ian Fisher I
have to shoot my shot but I don't see
you in my DMs come on Ian shoot it Ian
shoot it pull up Steph Curry oh yeah
not like hurricane I mean
um
if I speak
I respect the grime I'm gonna need you
two to cash out this back to me what the
okay do you cash out us
um why would you go on it on a date with
a guy you're not attracted to hashtag
steak Daddy
not the music my turn my turn on me no
well not even my turn
oh God maybe pull an Ellen DeGeneres
dance party
as a break karaoke
can we play can we play it on the stream
ah sir wait wait wait I think you can do
karaoke like uh versions
on the stream yeah yeah could we hear it
if you played a video could we hear it
no right unless you hold it up to the
mic
um
stf uffs simplus simpletory is a mindset
so that's an expectation empty the
problem with women being able to turn on
her femininity is they can turn it off
just as quick
I think that's everything okay
um
I do have like a honest question because
I'll just ask it is it is going on a
date
that with someone you're not attracted
to attracted to bad even if they say hey
I just want to take you out to dinner
it's like no
no stipulations I just want to like
hang out is that is that a bad thing
should you only go on a date if you're
attracted to somebody and this is just
this is just for my knowledge guys so
don't come for me please I'm learning
um because
no because it's like you're leading him
on because he thinks there's a
possibility of sex and on your end
there's no possibility of sex ever so
guys only ask women out on dates if
there's a possibility of sex
really
yes okay
to eat in general
okay
wow so just know if a guy's taking you
out to dinner he wants one thing at some
point
there's an angle wow you are the end
goal yeah so that's why
I've just realized that guys you're kind
of like
like when I'm going on a date I want to
go on a date with a guy that I'm like so
excited to go on a date with yeah versus
and I know there's there's a balance
between like batting out of your league
but I've just found guys where I'm like
ah maybe like I just end up wasting
their time and it's not like intentional
or malicious like I don't mean to and
maybe I'm like somewhat attracted to
them but they just can't
get it over that threshold or whatever
but I've just found if I'm not like all
in like super excited I just like they I
just end up wasting their time yeah
okay
gotcha it's like weird to ask those
questions because of like my age and I
should like I should know a lot when it
comes to
dating men I guess you can say because
of my age was like
I haven't
I don't there's a lot I don't know
because well I do feel like sometimes
Sports makes you a little less
experienced in a weird way because it's
like you miss a lot of like the years
that people are out doing [__] yeah
that's for sure and then just
not upbringing okay Mr Fisher did he did
he DM you I want to take you on a date
and get to know you let's see call him I
want to follow him back and see first
you think I should just go into the call
okay you know what for the content guys
okay oh you're gonna put your face in it
too
makes sense we don't stream anyway no
well I'm like I gotta I gotta take it
off
I gotta put it on the mic otherwise it's
just my forehead
yeah Mr Fisher um oh Mr Fisher do not
not answer this is your chance my guy he
doesn't want to find love on live hey
this is this is his chance he says he
ain't gonna miss it
oh no
am I getting curved are you getting
stood up
ladies this is not getting stood up
oh
I can hear that clearly hear it now
come on Mr Fisher
you only get one shot
so make it count one shot
we're about to hit 130 000 Subs it's a
crazy thing 100 and wow wow I was way
off yeah way way off
[Music]
okay well
Mr Fisher
um said you better call back you better
be in the bathroom here I was left your
phone in the room
here I was I hope you still have this on
stream and you hear us talking about you
Mr Fisher could have been lost
yeah see now I'm gonna take the girls
out tomorrow
um
it'll be like
they'll be like how is he pulling these
tall [__] because he's an ish he's
like he's got the sauce he's got the
sauce all the females can be like oh my
gosh he has two a black one and a white
one you should walk in with us on your
arm
the plan
yes
sign up for membership so you can see
all this yeah sign up guys Jess is gonna
do some behind the scenes content yeah
tomorrow I'm telling you I'm telling you
it's about to be yo you must get these
guys excited
yo the chat went mad what did they say
no I haven't seen this dish accelerated
his speed oh my goodness Mr Fisher come
on now bruh let's see it energy
we were rooting for you we were all
rolling for you
um
Mr Madison was correct about the impact
one of the things that sets your show
apart from other areas is the manosphere
is the lack of hate and resentment you
present I'm a liberal leading on most
issues you're a good middle ground
I was just curious what city
I don't know it might not be this year
but like maybe the year after I'll go
back to the US but I was just curious
what city you guys would like to see the
podcast in if I ever went to the U.S I
think I pulled this North Dakota no I'm
kidding
um
I'm just curious if you guys would say
the ones that I was looking for let's go
to Utah and find the Mormons and
interview the Sister Wives well I was I
was thinking it would be so cool to do
like a traveling podcast oh yeah I like
do it in a different city but oh God the
amount of work I'm like thinking to set
that up okay first of all you have me
and I love setting up events so oh my
gosh but how are you gonna
you just contact people contact the
venue yeah and then you do it months in
advance you have different before you
put out hire the right person yeah
before you put out any information you
get the venues set up and then you
put out hey we'll be in this city this
day come out yeah there's this we just
have to figure out if we if we could
sell tickets to it you put a cap on it
so you say hey we have this many tickets
available and if more people start
asking then you open up more tickets
oh interesting yeah I think it would
just we'd have to make enough money to
cover the cosplay oh yeah you would so
maybe this would be okay let's see what
the you'd also get sponsors as well yep
oh interesting okay
um Iowa
Chicago people said DC DC hey DC we just
found out about this is so expensive
though I mean it's like we moved from
one expensive city to another yeah
Denver Canada Chicago Washington I like
Denver
yeah Denver's nice Texas Phoenix New
Jersey New York California
San Diego Diego San Francisco Brooklyn
Denver Brooklyn
Montreal DC
Canada Vegas I thought about Vegas
because of the cost but I think I would
hate that city
um Phoenix
the outskars of Vegas isn't bad is when
you get on the Strip that's when it's
yeah crazy
okay I also was thinking of like LA but
the problem with LA is it's so it's so
expensive health is expensive and it's
it's
weird in L.A when it comes to like
content stuff someone said sentence
would buy at least 20 tickets hey we
appreciate it we appreciate it baby la
Miami San Francisco I thought about
Miami it wasn't sentence that said that
someone said that sentence would
I know that's what I'm saying yeah like
New Orleans I've never even thought of
that New Orleans ooh as you imagine yeah
yeah H where would you want to go
oh Massachusetts Massachusetts why
um I'm a Celtics fan
I just want to go to Boston
Massachusetts Massachusetts
[Music]
John Cena you guys remember in rush hour
when uh Jackie Chan was like I always
want to go mask and it's where God did
that's what I sounded like saying
Massachusetts
tongue twister did Mr Fisher message you
back
oh wait he's typing
Mr Mr Fisher you better be have been in
the shower or something yeah what
happened okay
Mr Fish
the fish to tell the Telephone Man
it's not like Mr Fisher you know
what a day
fish did you follow him back
did I I don't know we got to see it I
got distracted I will follow him back I
did just just followed
how many more hours ish
um bro we're not even tonight a.m We
still got more than 12. yeah time is
slowing down okay but I think I think
the girls are coming at 10. I feel like
if we make it to 10 yeah like I feel
like this is this is the worst part if
we make it to 10 a.m the next set of
guests is coming okay
hey chat give us some
um things to do like just to like wake
us up a little bit
yeah let us let us know in the chat okay
um she's interested she's in who's
interested hey I'm just
me I mean I could be oh Mr Fisher
oh let's see oh dang I can do a voice
call not video Mr Fisher well you just
answer it and turn off your video yeah
okay we're gonna try it again
why can't you do a video call huh
because he maybe
he can he can keep it on his face
okay let's see let's see
I'm ready I'm ready
I don't understand his face is it bad
oh why hey I said that
laughs
he's even like a good man
that's a good man sir we are calling you
back sir
I know third time's a charm here three
strikes you're out yeah
is he really
like Mr Fisher active fishy okay Mr
Fisher
come on now bruh
all right don't [__] with the bike he's
just
oh God the audacity just text him that
the audacity he catfishing hang up
did someone say that
I love this chat no no it's done Mr
Fisher
you just said you can do video I mean
you called YouTube audio
you better send another Super Chat to
get Pro's attention can we call in and
shoot our shot at Jess yes who wants to
call in the shoot they shot at me yes
all right hey what's the chat erupt
girls getting ghosted in 4k
and I'm just trying to find love
I'm lonely girls getting coasted in
fortnite okay okay I didn't even see
that oh my gosh actually
what
actually Pearl someone asked me this
question on my last video
um
how is uh
how's it different here when guys shoot
their shots than guys in America when
they shoot their shot
I was here when they dress better
okay
really yeah yeah like I think British
guys just have more fashion
um two
I mean I haven't really dated a lot here
but
I would say especially
oh my God since this Channel's blown up
it's been like
but the guys
are a little bit more like proper in
general
like I don't know
speaking to the mind I think yeah yeah
sorry I don't know the guys are a little
bit more like proper here I would say
what do you think
I would say that and I think
from
from what I've experienced I would say
um the guys are a little bit more direct
here like they'll come up to you and
like say something to you yeah I think
so too
yeah I've been
I've been approached more here than in
the states yeah well I also I feel like
I feel like you get a point in the in
the UK I don't think the girls are as
attractive in the UK
I've said this so many times like I feel
like as a girl you get like a point
coming to the UK and I think as an
American they're like oh American I
don't think it's American really I just
think like girls are prettier in the US
hmm that's interesting maybe like what's
your what's your I think British guy is
like the accent it's different it's
foreign foreign
um yeah no I think
I think you'll find that
people tend to there is a consensus that
there are people in the US are better
looking than the people in the UK but
that goes both genders
um
or else what I've kind of oh wait okay
we got an audio call oh from Mr Fisher
Okay we're we're back on we're back on
is that Mr Fisher yeah
hello
is it on speaker oh wait no it's not
hold on sorry let me try it again hello
hello hi
Mr Fisher we are upset we got some beef
here I I gave you a beef with me now
Look I gave you a call twice yeah twice
oh fortunately my phone is on do not
disturb so it doesn't pop up on my
screen what are you this is the biggest
cap I saw you it said scene
no but I saw your message and then I
immediately called you back on voice
message don't you see that on your phone
that's not what happened okay
um how are you where are you from
good where are you from the US I'm
guessing
yes I am from the US I'm actually living
in New York currently oh wow so do you
think like you think we get along we got
a lot in common
I would say a majority of your views we
do kind of see eye to eye on so I think
we could probably get along oh okay
nice
what these do you post
I'm actually trying
while I'm talking to you which is so
funny but I don't want to have the
background noise in the background oh
okay okay good what what views do we
oppose yeah
politics is that much it's not really a
thing for me that's the biggest thing
which is a big thing for you I know
because you're like
yeah it's one of your biggest things but
apart from that apart from politics
which I don't really have a view on much
I don't care much really oh gotcha
so it's like the rest
go ahead I was gonna ask how old are you
I'm 25. all right so we're the same age
yes we are are you from New York
no I'm not are you from originally
I am from a very small island in the
Caribbean Jamaica
always yo
jackpot
yo Pearl why why is why is that spot on
that's good okay well
um I'll shoot you a DM after the show
maybe we could we could maybe Chit Chat
not on the live
yeah no problem just just you got any
questions for him I'm giving you your
chance do I have any questions I I
grilled I grilled the the guy you were
on the phone with
um go ahead go ahead go ahead put it put
it over there Mr Fisher smash or pass on
Pearl
he's asking me
just in the beginning I have to get to
Nora first before I can do that I
wouldn't get an immediate smash no
well hopefully me on the line
of course she's attractive yes she's
sexually attractive and appealing for
the eyes yes she is so is that a smash
yes all right okay that's all I had
thank you what you got anything ish you
got anything no no
I don't need the bike back the bite back
yeah what's the bite back one day when
you come for me
I don't want the time but even I'm gonna
do it regardless yeah I know but like I
don't know here's your chance okay
anyways nice to meet you sir
have a good one
you too bye
maybe maybe I Found Love we'll see guys
well we'll see I told you though it's
always when he said that I said yo
because I always say the guys that are
interested in me are usually either
Nigerian
or Korea when he said that I said yo
curl
how no I'm telling you I don't know why
they sense it they said you liked it you
like to shoot me like yeah that's why
you like the [__] especially if someone
comes up to me and they say like my dad
watches you like it's always I'm like is
he is he is he Caribbean or Nigerian
it's always one of the two yeah some
shoulders they're like shimmy foaming I
don't know
wow
have they given us ideas on what to do
okay I think
let's see they said send a
7.99p Super Chat
um yeah do Truth or Dare with me and
Jess Truth or Dare send in super chats
Jesus you go first Pearl truth or dare
nervous you
there there yeah okay super uh chat put
a dare in there
and we'll pick one of them
they should pick the first one yo
within reason
no no no sexual stuff on the camera no
no no no
this is not only fans
but for the right price don't I'm
kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding
no
we are not hoes
it's something for a good one read it
but it was just not a super chat it
doesn't have to be is it it's a dare
yeah
what is it oh I think this is super [__]
incoming could be wrong
oh the people are co-signing it as well
now
do you want to hear it yes
ice bucket challenge what the [__] is an
ice bucket what oh
you get water and ice in a bucket and
you dump it on your head
all right we could do the outside
we could do it
yes guys what time does Co-op open we
need some ice hey YouTube well we got us
we got a bag
really we call us okay that's a bucket
as well oh yeah we got we got us yes
here we go can we move it are you sure
it'll fit are you sure it'll make it
there watch this let's go are we are we
sure I wanted
your home so you can have a change of
clothes do you want to um
do you want to change the different
color shirt so you're not Girls Gone
Wild out there okay you look out I got
you don't need no only fans content good
one chat yo uh I love it I love it look
go easy on me if I choose dare don't
don't do anything outrageous for me
but I hope you all been liking this 24
hour uh live we do it for y'all
um
keep watching
there's people coming soon we suffer for
y'all
anything for content
within reason
yes Pearl is ready let's get this
[__] it filled up
you guys are lucky I take Truth or Dare
very seriously
all right is that enough eyes
that's all the ice we got
hey don't make sure it's not chunky I
don't want it to like hurt me yeah sure
you know I mean you gotta like break it
up a little hot water and then melt it
up
challenge we got
they said yeah ice bucket challenge 100K
is no joke so quickly is is the real
deal thank you I know I know I I can't
believe it's only been three four months
I don't even crazy I gotta look on the
day I started it I don't know what it
was
and now what episode is this
would you consider
Nick Cannon a high value man
no
I don't know I think
even Kevin Samuel said if you got too
many baby mamas it just makes you look
bad
um like that you can't run in certain
circles
so would that not be considered
[Music]
a high value man exploring his options
or no well you can explore your uh okay
this is the pillars of a high value man
10K per month he must have had it from
three to five years of other men must
accept you as high value a network of
high value men visibility is LinkedIn
level and utility useful to others in
the group but they don't automatically
count entertainers okay because
oftentimes like
like Jay-Z would be considered high
value I don't I don't know how Nick
Cannon made his money
so I but are they signed that deals like
is it one of those where that show might
be making a little money but because
there's so many middlemen
yeah and and it's like
like you can explore your options but
like that that's just a lack of like
self-control okay like I think there's a
difference if a guy had multiple maybe
wives but multiple baby mamas yeah like
that's just not a good look
uh
yeah no dick discipline celebrities
aren't high value men okay like a high
value man would be like a VP okay okay
versus it like a rapper like a rapper is
at high value oh okay
um unless like like Jay-Z would be
because he he has he conducts himself
like a business okay does it make sense
yes it does I I thought that
when you reach a certain like dollar
amount you're considered a high value
man that's what I don't know it's not
money oh okay because then other other
men also have to accept you and I just
don't see like a VP of a company
accepting Nick Cannon as a high value
man but I could see Jay-Z being accepted
yeah yeah I can see that yeah Nick
Cannon you all look sleepy we are do I
look sleepy let me let me rub my eyes
loopy
wait
It's a beautiful morning you guys want
me to sing a song give me a song to sing
oh it's just ready he's been waiting for
that she's ready we got the ice bucket
y'all he's like there it is irritating
you lately I said y'all get online ready
I'm ready for this see we have the
bucket guys as you can see oh my
goodness
because there's cameras up
It's a beautiful morning Dr Dre even oh
you're gonna do it through the window oh
yeah so I'm going to stand in the window
with my mic uh
can a woman make a man high value no no
okay a man can make a woman high value
because a woman's more judged like
based on because a woman's judged up
more on the men that she can attract
and a man's more judged on the
woman that he can get
okay I dare you to do the Ice Bucket
Challenge too
I didn't it's not my turn to do truth or
dare
I didn't choose yet
[Music]
now you gotta have 50 50 ice to water
ratio and it needs to sit long enough to
get really cold
foreign
yes obviously anything for Content
within reason yeah yeah within reason
she can yeah a girl a hot girl does
enhance his ex in his appearance I will
give you that
like why do you think men hang around
pretty women
wait
oh
I was like why am I hated they hate that
I told you to change your shirt
they said dang it Jess
sorry I didn't want to eat uh
demonetized I thought of that either
yeah
I gotta look out for my girl thank you
yeah she would have been upset if I
wouldn't have said it but
I understand I feel like I've read
peeled you so much that I can't red pill
you I can't think of anything you don't
know
oh goodness
you might okay if you were in a food
fight would you throw pies at them or
squirt ketchup in their face
ah
during a food fight
how big is the ketchup bottle it was one
of them Costco Brands it's I'd probably
do ketchup anyways like it's a pie I
feel like you can just do it wipe it off
and keep going yeah and my age isn't oh
accurate all right it's just telling us
to get going all right Miss Pearl
all right guys I'm doing the ice bucket
challenge
um I hate you all
but
if you guys if I don't get a super chat
for this
I I'll still love you but you know I'm
just saying help a girl out
[Music]
foreign
I will I will
laughs
so how you feeling
I know I know I know go get this right
yeah you get one shot at this only one
shot all right I think the chat should
be able to see this
um obviously we can't see if they can or
not uh chat tell me if you can see this
is it not updating here
yep I got thumbs up all right cool
thumbs Up's good for me all right ready
to go in three
two one
yeah
[Laughter]
I'm awake
wow I can't believe we did that
oh goodness thanks chat
oh I'm gonna truth
they did that ah nah nope
one good one good one woke her up woke
her up for sure
wow
[Music]
it's so cool
laughs
there she is she's back stop mocking me
you don't know what I've been
oh that was but nah watch out Ellie
Ellie about to tear up these boxes yo
good job chat
good job I love the following yo this is
good-ish
yeah
yo
man good job good job Chad
we are we up in this
lo siento
coughing in that
oh watch out Ellie back up girl yo
who's next ain't nobody next I am not
next you see this on the top of my head
it was on the top of my head truth
uh truth
chat
all right chill set set stay
ice bucket every hour
[Music]
okay
all right
[Music]
Truth or Dare she said truth I said
truth
um
pearls done SEAL training thank you
dear Pearl to call her dad right now
um
they said that was Revenge for what oh
yeah oh that might have been even
[Music]
or they were saying open the door
it was a window y'all what we could have
did was open that done it with the the
door and just kept the door open
ER
um yeah I think I'd taken the wrong
camera oh okay
I didn't know that camera was the right
camera everyone everyone wants me to ask
you your body count
um
let's see
holding still training I respect it
oh who's your favorite sibling
also just because I wasn't gonna ask her
her body count on live it doesn't mean
she's a hoe stop it yeah
it just look at the internet there's no
number you could tell like
um
I'm a virgin someone said it earlier
wow guys I need you to I need you to
chill
anyways no it's not a breath oh my God
it's not a red flag okay she's not okay
anyway I'm gonna just continue
who's your favorite brother
um
oh wait wait no I know the answer to
that there's no way you've done that
okay yeah back to the original one who's
your favorite sibling my favorite
sibling
don't do it Ellie
I don't want to answer that because I
love them both but it'll be my older
brother your older brother yeah
but
I don't know yeah
I don't like it I don't like it because
I love my little brother
do you feel like
being red pill are you happier now or
are you happier in ignorance
it's not so much like
happy happiness I would say like
happiness is
the same I'm more aware now and I wish I
would have known some of this stuff
earlier in life I think I would be in a
different position yeah now but I
wouldn't say that I'm
unhappy now that I know this stuff it is
like a little bit like
I was saying earlier how I was like dang
like I'm all I'm at my wall I'm almost
at my wall my mom was at 30 but
I'm still like in shape so it's just
like I I'm not gonna like focus on that
and be like oh my gosh I don't know when
it's gonna happen like if it happens it
happens cool do you think you're gonna
put more like time towards it happening
in the future I probably yeah I probably
will and I'll probably
because like I I don't I don't put any
time towards it I think that's common
with athlete athletes yeah like
especially tomboys like I don't think
we're used to like because a lot of us
growing up didn't get a ton of attention
because we're just we're talking yeah
like and so I think a lot of us
don't really
how I put it like I feel like a lot of
us want to be in relationships but we
don't necessarily know like where to go
to find the men and yeah we're not like
the smoothest yeah at all you don't have
that like like the girls that can just
go up and be like naturally like
effortlessly you know what I mean like
because we're just used to like we play
basketball yeah I just do Sports in
school I'm like talking to guys like
yeah being one of the guys yeah yeah and
I always thought that like oh yeah like
I don't know why guys don't like me I'm
like them so why won't they like me I
didn't know how to talk sports I can do
this I can do that like why don't they
like me and then now I know I'm like
they don't like that I'm like dang like
because they want the girl that makes
them like feel like a man almost
and that because I I don't know I'm sure
there's someone you can think of off the
top of your head there's someone that
like comes to mind for me that just has
that natural like like they're very
comfortable around men and not in like a
sexual way but just a very they're easy
like they're very flirty
oh no no you can't think of anyone no I
could think of like
what are you doing ish he's a dance oh
okay
stay awake oh I got you I got you
and yeah that's that was my but I've
just found that like top at tomboy girls
have dating problems but it's not in the
same way like other girls do yeah
because we're just we're Sports
would you date someone in the military
I think it all depends on
what branch
what what branch would you not date
the ones that it'd be harder I won't say
I wouldn't date it'd be harder for me to
date the ones that get like deployed for
a long period of time oh I like
um military men I mean I kind of like
uniforms it's like uh they just they
seem like they're more masculine
sometimes
um
I someone asked me if I did yeah I would
date someone in the military
um I someone asked me in the chat how
did I first meet Ally so I've met ali
um through Donovan we were on a panel
called not all women
and then one the first time we
like I had her on my channel was I had a
guest cancel and so I just emailed her
in like last minute she hopped on it was
great and then we were like friends ever
since
um
um congrats on 100K Pro it seems like
yesterday I discovered you and fresh and
fit keep up the good works you got to
bring the show to the states Las Vegas
who knows we'll see Vegas we're going to
USA tour
they say you look young in the chat you
do look young like I wouldn't guess that
you're 28. really thank you I appreciate
that
I gotta stay looking young I gotta fool
these men out here like I'm still not
even approaching my wall I'm just at the
start no no I'm gonna peek I'm gonna use
this I'm gonna be like girl mid-wall
reacts
I'm at the start of the approach
yo it's crazy because I don't even like
it's like weird to be like yo I'm
turning 28 literally in a week and I'm
like
yeah it's it's kind of
oh gosh
oh he's scaring yourself who do you
think would win a game of 21 in
basketball it's me
I think I could take you you could you
would put up a good fight I'm not saying
that but I would win I I think it
depends on
how on you were with your shot because
here's the thing okay
you you absolutely are quicker than me
but I cannot rebound you
there's no way there's no way
hmm oh yeah you two have played with
each other yeah yeah there's no way
so if you're not making your shots I'm
getting the rebound
not necessarily not necessarily
I would say I would
it would be
foreign
you would have you would have a better
chance of getting it but if I shoot it
and I know it's off oh I'm sprinting or
ready to go for it you can out you can
outrun me for sure you're quicker I
don't know I think it'd be a good game
yeah
we should do it one of these days yeah
um someone said 28 24 was my guess oh
wow thank you appreciate it yeah I'm I'm
a center and Jess is like a power
forward yeah
um
is this a 24 hour stream yes
who got the
thank you for coming on it okay what was
the biggest truth bomb that you found
out from Red Pill like what were you
most shocked about like what out of all
the videos I showed you what one shocked
you the most
um
or shows either or
trying to think
um a nscc Celtics I see you sorry
anyway Aaron
oh yeah Celtics yo my mom [__] I told
her I was gonna call my mom was like
it's just right it should may have been
right and I was like yeah I was like
I'll call you later and tell you tell
them that you said that she's like okay
but I saw that this morning I was like
if she's on to something oh bless her
ioma was amazing
um
what'd you ask me
I don't remember I'm getting tired what
was the question
um oh well what video shocked you the
most
um it was the one
with
um
Thomas yeah so that was the one that
shocked me the most
I was just like
learning about laws that were created
and why they were created
and just like seeing the effects of
when those laws were created
it was just like yo what no I think that
was my favorite video it didn't it
wasn't the most viewed but that video it
did well yeah
I don't know because he he it was funny
watching you change your mind on that or
like change your perspective because I
had the same like watching you is so
funny because I I think I thought like
you did before like a couple years ago
ah okay so it's funny watching you go
through it because I I really was pretty
conservative most my life but in college
I kind of bought into some of that like
ideology okay and then I started getting
into this content and I was like oh
like kind of like yeah it's just funny
to watch it in real time and it's like I
said on the video it's interesting to
hear just oh goodness not me shoving the
mic in my mouth
I hit it hey calm down Jack calm down
chat
calm down chat I don't even want to know
what they're gonna say but um it's like
interesting and it was what was the
man's name of the video you showed me
after that the other one
Jordan Peterson no no the other black
man oh a Larry Elder yeah it was just
interesting to see
um to see black just black men talk
about this stuff because
if you talk about stuff like that you
get called out in the black community
and it's like why can't we think
differently and be different and talk
about this type of stuff
yeah it's kind of weird because
sometimes I feel weird like
okay I put it
like
it's kind of weird how the US is set up
like the black community the white
Community the Mexican Community because
all those communities are so are so
different yeah like because a Nigerian
guy is going to be completely different
than like a guy from the US oh for sure
it's just like why do we group it like
that and even even me like a German girl
from I'm German like a Heritage but a
girl from Germany is going to have a
completely different experience than me
yeah or like polish or like whatever the
yeah
um I I don't know I've thought about
that often like why do we
why do we separate it by skin color and
not by where people are from but I guess
it's because of just how
America was built in a sense I don't
know I don't know I think it's the media
more that
creates it
yeah
because if I if I lived if I was born
and raised on this side of the world I
wouldn't want to be called black I would
want to be called where I'm from because
I know I would know where I'm from I
wouldn't be called either Nigerian or
Jamaican or Puerto Rican Dominican you
said you wanted to I wanted to do uh the
ancestry thing but I haven't done it yet
I've gotten I've gotten Latin I've
gotten Caribbean I'm like I'll take it
all take it all someone can you look up
how much do homeless people make or how
much do homeless people get like paid in
California
because I remember you saying that
before and I was flabbergasted that they
made 600 I saw somebody say it in the
chat and someone was like nah they make
more than that
foreign
California annual salary 67 500. they
have an annual salary I don't I don't
know this is what it just
yeah I guess
um so I
still sat in the right place at the
right time during a certain type of hour
they might be making ten pound a second
and that's not every second yeah
you might walk out of five pounds
someone else might have all ten dollars
someone might be feeling generous today
fifty dollars yeah they are making more
than anyone on minimum wages making
wow and then all they've got to do is
hide the money
I mean you've already got coins yeah
help me
does the does the state pay them in
California or no
or a state give a mic an incentive
oh I'm sure the California is so bad how
much do homelessness is atrocious out
there and it's gotten worse yeah I mean
there's a reason like it's not
I got paid to be homeless oh wait let me
I got paid to be homeless in San
Francisco it takes one phone call Old
School junkie says he moved to woke City
because he got he gets 620 a month that
pays for his Amazon Prime and Netflix
and the cops are like Neighbors
what a self-proclaimed old school junkie
who moved from Texas to Calif San
Francisco because it's effing easy to be
homeless there claims he got paid by the
government to live on the streets
getting 620 in cash per month hundreds
of food stamps where he sells narcon and
enjoys his Amazon private Netflix this
right now is literally by choice if
we're going to be realistic they pay you
to be homeless
um
says here says James a homeless man with
face tattoos who has been living in San
Francisco since June told Michael
shelburger in San Francisco a book about
how the city's Progressive leaders are
worsening homeless and inequality and
crime James said it only took one phone
call to receive government assistance
including hundreds of hundreds in cash
and food stamps approximately a hundred
dollars notes free money
and then that free money is his
motivation to remain homeless a [__]
cell phone bro 200 food stamps and 620
in cash a month forget it why wouldn't I
do it you know it's for a [__] free
money dude he explained why would I want
to pay rent I'm not doing [__] I've got
a [__] cell phone I have Amazon's
that I have Amazon Prime and Netflix on
the interview came as the city's
homelessness and drugs problem has
worsened amid the national opioid crisis
that's escalated over the pandemic
um I don't know
that's that's
ridiculous and it is sickening
like
how how bad was it when
when you were out there last
California oh so bad they're everywhere
oh my God if you if you have if you see
it now it's even
worse and it's just like
you're
how do you expect to clean up a city or
clean up just a state if you
if you're paying people and they're like
I gotta work 620 a month
and all I need is a phone bill and I
just have to pay
um maybe maybe 200 a month for like a
phone bill and like him Netflix and
Amazon Prime and I can pocket the rest
and do what I want oh why wouldn't I be
homeless
yeah oh I saw one he had a whole uh like
TV like those old school like TV stands
where the cabinets on the bottom and the
side on the street and it was like set
up and everything speakers in it and
then he had his little setup in front of
it
the people working yeah
like and and that's the thing that's why
like
I don't know I think the older people
get the more conservative I mean because
you're right you're about to make a
killing on memberships yeah yeah sign up
please
and um
and like you're gonna have money you're
not gonna spend it like freaking people
that don't work yeah and like refuse to
work because it's one thing if you've
never been given opportunity or don't
know how to do it because I have a lot
of empathy for people that like like my
my parents I've just always had an
entrepreneurial mindset because if
you're around
you know one percent parents like of
course you're gonna have that mindset
but yeah
how I put this like
it's it's another thing if oh the preg
Adam slack yay Adam thanks for signing
up
we'll reveal our body counts on the
premium plus sign up I have a version so
you're not gonna get an app what I said
I'm a virgin so you're not gonna give a
body count
[Music]
um
but no I think that like I don't know
conservatism makes so much sense once
once you understand how the world works
and like nothing's really holding people
back it's like choices and I feel like
the older you get the more you see like
people are kind of at where they're at
most of the time because of their
choices yeah there's some people that
were like Delta bad a lot in life and
maybe like they could have been a
millionaire but they're only gonna make
a hundred thousand because they're
without fit like 80k as opposed to
because of their lot in life but like I
don't I don't see people that
consistently try and are like innovating
new things like I don't see them become
unsuccessful
like most of the people I see that make
bat like that end up in bad places make
bad choices to get there yeah
this is sad sad thing about it
I think they want us to
Pro put your microphone down a tad um
oh no
oh she's rocking at the light oh she's
looking at me no it's the light
yeah yeah you see you didn't think that
light so many times yeah I don't know
Gary could you you can put her back in
my crate in the crate yeah she's fine
oh
they're red pill match in my room
[Music]
hmm
someone said we should come to Germany
I could play in Germany but I've been I
haven't done any of the recruitings I've
been so busy I'm like uh whatever oh
okay fifty dollars from Eddie my old
butt is tired but you ladies and
gentlemen are killing it kudos to all
you all time to pass out bro or so get
some z's for us please yeah we'll be up
another
13 and a half hours
[Music]
look up a Zillow studio apartment in
California your choice on City uh you
gonna pay for it
yeah you you're gonna pay for it because
you're saying your choice on the city
it's expensive in California Pearl how
many women's mindsets have you changed
when it comes to Red pills stay
impartial and keep holding everyone's
feet to the fire that's what makes you
great a lot she's she's changed a lot of
women
yeah I would say I've I don't
how do I put
it's okay just leave her
um I mean I don't know I think I've
in like made people's eyes open a little
bit but like how much does this stuff
really impact most people's day-to-day
life
you know what I mean yeah I don't know
but I think like I think the best thing
that comes from this mindset is just
like you feel like you can do anything
when you don't feel like anything's in
your way and like I I think like
watching this stuff a couple years ago
like led me to the content that made me
like plan out my life because when I was
I remember I was trying to figure out
like what I was interested in and like
how to how to stop drinking and I
basically like looked I wrote down all
the things that I would do without
anyone just to see what I was interested
in like like I I wrote it down that I
wasn't actually interested in it unless
I would do it alone oh okay so I was
like what do I do when I'm alone and it
was like conservative it was like media
Sports
and music oh those are the things I do
and so I started like taking steps
towards each one to like build my life
so
I started learning YouTube I started
learning guitar now I can play it and
then
um
I went I applied to play overseas so
it's kind of cool to like see it like
three years later wow yeah that's
awesome yeah so but I I feel like this
stuff made me like think that far ahead
because shout out Jordan Peterson I
really like Jordan Pearson and what he
talked about in that video
just as philosophical mindset what do
you think about them lowering the REM in
the WNBA
go ahead ish
it's got something to say
I think it was a great idea
um
with good intentions
okay and more so than anything the
reason why I say that is because
if
we can understand that men's sport and
women's sport are two different sports
in their own rights and they come with
their own skill sets yeah
and there's a reason why we're separated
in that kind of and we can kind of
celebrate our differences you would see
that in order to
kind of recognize all right they're
different sports what would make
the second
more entertaining if not being able to
kind of compete
on the financial level with the MBA and
I think lowering the rim would have
allowed for a bit more excitement
especially by
I can dunk on a knife at Rim really you
have bunnies like that yeah you know I
mean so like and I I know the feeling of
being able to get back if it was at nine
feet I probably would be dunking by now
I'm saying just
one minute Dunk Contest cut back you
know what I'm saying it's Jordan is so
dead
I totally understand that
you can kind of get more people doing
that than
it's more exciting we'll get more people
in the seats you get more people in the
seats because there's more to show but
then in retrospect I can understand why
people would feel disrespected
uh with the idea because it's like oh
well
we should I don't I don't think it's
right but they they're looking at it
from a standpoint or like we should be
equal to men like uh there's not much of
a difference we're playing the same
Sport and I'm just like if we were not
playing the same sport there's a
difference if we were supposed to be
equal to man we would have the same
basketball and it would be called
WNBA they're just about the NBA yeah
it's not ours is not called M MBA it's
not men's mbas yeah it's just the NBA
there's a reason for that so that'd be
cool if they lowered their Ram is the is
the court the same dimensions or is it
different from what I know it's the same
dimensions but like that can uh vary
from country to Country oh okay well I
say country like organization so the MBA
has its own dimensions and then fiber
which is the uh
basically for everyone else yeah they
had their Dimensions so
um the NBA three-point Line's a bit
further back than the fiber 3.9
I know that in college I don't know if
they changed the rules for men's
basketballs men's basketball is still
220 minute halves
two 20-minute halves
um but no quarters yeah so they changed
it for women oh they changed yeah they
changed it um my last year playing in
the states I changed it to four four ten
minute quarters I was just like people
okay that makes sense yeah but they
didn't they didn't change the men they
left the men the same
I don't know why
I think I don't know if there's like
more scope for women to go and play in
Europe
so then by changing it in college it
kind of allows them and helps them with
the transition to Europe because over
here do men play two tournament halves
or no four calls four ten minute calls
see I'm I'm I was used to that because
we played quarters in high school and
everything
I think they should test it out for a
season lowering the rim to nine feet yes
I agree caught them testing it yeah to
see like if the ticket sales went up or
anything or if anything changed but
here's the thing like imagine you lower
it by a foot more women can dunk
that's just yeah and it's more
achievable
I just
I just didn't see I'm not
completely opposed kind of don't like
the idea of like
having to learn Anew but if I could dunk
that'd be
yeah I think I probably dunk on that
road you would be able to get paid no
you get paid to play what we got a
dunker yeah well no then everyone yeah I
don't think I don't think it'd be as big
of a phenomenon no okay do you think
um
would you if someone in the chat wants
to know would you ever be a second or
third wife
no I gotta be number one okay would you
rather what if your option was between
that or die alone
because if I had to be a second or third
wife or die alone I'd probably pick
second or third wife
yeah I've seen how some of these second
and third wives are living and they they
live good like one of them pulled up in
the Lambert yeah like
I can understand this certain things
that you go through but
dying alone
I'm alone now and if I don't find
somebody in the next few years I would
die alone I'm kidding
I'm playing I'm playing I'm playing I'm
playing I'm playing what the chat say no
we'll pause
[Laughter]
like I'm done with this girl I'm over it
still I'm like I'm so tired
no I'd probably I'd probably choose the
second or third wife once a man is aware
that he has the capacity to attract the
attentions of a younger women he
previously had limited access his
actions define the wall for women who
are approaching their threshold Rollo
tomasi
speaking facts we are really doing this
uh ish rank yourself one to ten
and I can't pick seven okay yeah the
number six seven and a half yeah
because I know I'm not an a what would
make you an eight what would make me an
eight if I go in shape
okay
rank yourself one to ten
I would say
I may be ambitious here and chat May
blow me up
I would say eight eight
I was like oh God no they'll cast you up
no they'll be like she's off phew what
is she talking about
they already know they already know what
are they saying they agree with me
is
dang someone says 6.5 see that chat's
real chat's real that's not that bad I'm
telling you though
how dare you disrespect my hair
I said old high five who are you look at
your look at your
name they love it the chat is out here
five old with my old hair you would say
I'm a five yeah and then I'm like your
old hair
you get immediate feedback on the way
you look from the chat don't worry or
whenever you make an outfit or wardrobe
change they'll tell you
appreciate it
five yeah but I don't know if they're
talking about you or me just
I don't know I think the high rankings
definitely for you
I said don't look someone said don't
look don't look
she ain't even wearing makeup was it who
left to right
you're late you're late you're late
let's see someone said did you get that
person I said let me call in
okay
I hear that
thank you Brian e
they said we trying to Humble you Jess
We're not gonna say what we really you
guys haven't seen me from the waist down
I'm telling you
wait actually I'm gonna read something
someone someone emailed me the other day
okay
you can tell me if this is true this
chat is hilarious I love it okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna some guy thanks for the
Super Chat guys some guy wanted to tell
me
let me find it
okay
um
okay this is how men think and judge see
this is how men judge you and see you
most men think most women are fine so
I'll let you so I'll let you start off
with the 10. having one to two kids
minus one each one for minus one for
each additional child one for each
different father one for minus one for
each child over the age of five minus
one for each child under the age of one
not wanting children negative four
if you want to spend time and money on
your own children you must be open to
giving us some of our own having six to
ten previous sexual partners minus one
minus one for each behind Beyond ten
declines pair bonding ability having
tattoos minus one minus one tattoo near
for each tattoo near your intimate Parts
minus two for each tattoo remaining on
your reaching on your Intimates one for
each viable tattoo hand neck Lipper
upper behind the ear three for each face
tattoo or minus three sorry having
pierces anywhere other than your ears
minus one minus one for each lip and or
bull ring piercing minus one for each
facial surface piercing minus one for
each quarter inch stretch under tunnels
minus three to five for each unlisted
Body Mod being aged 26 to 30 minus one
being age 31 to 35 minus two being age
36 to 40 minus three minus one for each
year Beyond 40 ability to reproduce
matters being overweight minus this one
being obese minus two being morbidly
obese minus three having fat flips
hanging over your elbow minus one having
a thick or wide nose minus one having
bad teeth minus two not understanding
what modern modern feminism is sexist
minus one not understanding anti-fascism
is fascism minus one my not
understanding socialism can't be
Democratic minus one not understanding
Scandinavian countries aren't socialist
minus one not understanding communism
can exist because amongst other thing
power corrupts minus one having a q I
have an IQ minus under 120 minus one
having an IQ under 110 minus two having
an IQ under 100 minus three if I have to
be proactive smart and have potential so
should you using the amount of makeup of
plasterer could apply to it minus one
having fillers minus one having dreads
minus one having hair lash extensions
minus one having fake eyelashes minus
one having colored lenses minus one
having a funky hair color minus one on
having armpit hair minus one having
armpit or intimate hair painted a funky
color minus one minus one for each and
any implant except if it's due to past
cancer being being
revealing dressed in public minus one
wearing leggings or jeggings as pants
when not doing sports or yoga minus one
minus one
leggings you can see through leggings oh
okay okay so so
really they're not pants
no the type of leggings with I think he
would be referring to are the type where
like
I can see what your underwear looks like
oh okay like I can see the color I can
like it may be black but I can see it
all I can tell I'm looking
yeah
okay okay making a hair bun on top of
your head minus one believing that you
are healthier anyway minus one saying
you're curvy or a whole lot of women
when you read morbidly obese minus one
saying you know you you know what you
want minus one saying you're a strong
independent woman minus one unironically
saying phrases saying you're a princess
so you don't so you deserve a prince
minus one looking for a sugar daddy
saying you're your own sugar daddy or
anything sugar daddy minus one being a
dancer minus one being an erotic dancer
minus two dang it being an exotic
actress minus three being
um and being a sex worker minus four
having been a sex for a minus three
having no real Hobbies minus two
favorite sexual pose
um being starfish or doggy minus one
using toys on yourself longer than seven
inches or wider than 1.5 minus one
average man has four five by one two
okay being pescetarian minus one being
vegetarian minus two being vegan minus
three being polyamorous minus 67. minus
one minus one for smoking cigarettes
minus two for being 420 friendly minus
two for smoking cigars minus one for
smoking weekly
minus two for smoking daily minus two
for using party drugs minus two for
using unprescribed drugs
minus three for using hard drugs mine is
ten for being addicted to any drug
minus one for using the word bro minus
one for using the word [__] minus one
for saying you're funny minus one for
saying you're a good genuine person
minus one for saying you have a good
personality minus one saying you're not
crazy minus one for saying you're
feminine minus one for saying you're a
wild child minus one for saying you're a
pure Soul who are you who are you trying
to convince not men for online dating
add the following starting to look for
something serious but your profile is
only selling your body minus one if you
want a serious above average man you'll
have to bring more having only photos
with filters minus one having only clear
unclear photos minus one having no
information on your profile minus one
having a list of Demands for your men
minus one saying what you you don't know
why men list their height on their
profile minus one having having your
insta name on your profile minus one
your Sims only want to invalid validate
you are you all your Sims only
invalidate your value if you want a man
more than 20 centimeters tall then you
then you or over 180 centimeters tall
minus one wait if you want a man more
than 20 I feel attacked men and women
only differ five seven centimeters on
average
um
if you still have a positive number if
you still if you after all this you
still have a positive number we'll look
at your personality and common interest
but at that point most men will still
will still date you based on looks
fifty percent of men are fine with
dating 50 percent of women and thirty
percent of men will be fine with dating
80 percent of women which is a big
difference between the 83 percent of
women who only want to date eight
percent of men
and they sent you that email yeah I was
like they typed up that whole email yeah
I was like this man is dedicated Why
didn't
I didn't and Jesus you respect it yeah I
do you know what it was of course we're
talking on an unrealistic kind of level
but some of the things that he was
saying in terms of what would get minus
that what level so like the minus ones
to the minus twos to the minus fours to
the minus 67s do you think the tattoo
thing is true
for some men yeah
because they they'd be looking at it
like yo your body's a temple like yeah I
know I know I've heard that my mom like
told me never to get a tattoo because
like of the way men look at it
you'd be like you better not get a
tattoo because like a future date will
see it and not want to date you
and it it could be
you look at it and it's like it's an
easy disqualification and here's the
thing men look to qualify you so to find
a to see a tattoo and
yeah
it might not even mean anything it might
mean something really sentimental I saw
a Twitter thing that said every tattoo
is 10 dicks she sucked
I'm like now here's the question
are they lying
I would say there's probably a
correlation between tattoos and how
[__] the girl is
I would I will say probably I don't
think it's like everything yeah but you
have to use your discernment but like
that's different it's a correlation yeah
there's definitely a correlation
what
what tired yes it hit me like a great
train right now should we should we do
the water challenge no it wakes you up
no
I don't have a change of clothes
I just need
I suppose
yeah I got close yeah all right yeah
yeah
yes my hair oh yeah no actually yeah
I understand it's a long day I don't but
um it's the struggle yeah yeah I don't
get it I used to have an afro
it won't it'll drip and it's just a long
long process it'll look
they think I'm they saying I'm a five
five now they'll be like ah see a one
she looked like she from back in the day
yes yes do you do you have you have you
only dated white girls or you date black
girls too oh
you just said earlier white girls no no
wait yeah you said that you said white
girls earlier you said like guys so they
they assume that you date white girls
and that you do okay okay you don't
discriminate white girls okay okay
wait okay I don't it doesn't matter just
okay yes you do okay so questions like
it wasn't that like races oh okay you
don't discover the discriminate okay
okay whatever like no I just it wasn't
that deep of a question so it's a
follow-up question do you prefer when
black girls have like their natural hair
or do you prefer when it's like like
what how do you like what's the most
attractive hairstyle
black girls with their natural hair yeah
that's what that's what I it's because
they like love her like though she's got
her natural hair out everyone's like
yeah Jess is so hot I've got more Super
Chats on her hair like than ever wow
thank you I appreciate it it was
supposed to be different but you know
the struggle yeah but that's what I've
heard it's like but guys what about I've
debated getting hair extensions because
I've always wanted really long hair and
I think it's like pretty but is that
unattractive if a girl has hair
extensions
that's what that's why I haven't gotten
it is because I'm like I feel like it
depends because you'll find that like
if if you do it yourself right sometimes
it's quite visible that you've done it
yourself and like you'll see with them
falling out which is like
it's not it's not good it's not good
but I guess if you get a hairdresser to
do it and like they they put it in such
a way where it's like
it doesn't look bad it doesn't look
like you've done it yourself then I I
think it could look really nice what
time is Sarah coming today
oh yeah
oh yeah perfect
I said oh yeah perfect
like everybody Sarah can host them we're
gonna take a nap
y'all deserve it
you too it's just it's just holding up
the best we this is why we need men men
are soldiers yeah I'm not sleeping
I ain't sleeping I'm staying up for 24
hours I'm with you chat
oh they said that
oh gosh
um
I see you and I see
um help me with Colin Josiah okay DM me
on Instagram Josiah you have my
attention
so
I thought he wanted to call in is he in
my DMs are idiot oh okay okay
I think
I don't know I'm I'm calling
I think I found him in my DMs
crazy
thank you
I'm trying to be like you
you're going bowling
with your teammates
oh tonight
yeah are you crazy
oh do you want to play smash or pass I'm
gonna show you people in the manosphere
you're
oh goodness okay it's gonna get hurt
okay if anyone that knows me in the
manosphere sees this
I'm sorry this is all all fun and games
for content for Content it's not
personal
but I got I gotta show Jesse I gotta
show Jess these people
can you give me it hey darling darling
honey
um can you give me can you give me a cup
of water
thank you
I feel like it can't get worse than this
like like it has to get better
I think we're about to like be over the
humping
humping oh I'm just trying to make sure
they can hear you oh you know what I'm
saying I was like okay I'm gonna show
her I'm gonna show her people on
I'm coming babes guys put in the chat
who we should smash or pass okay and
then I'll have I'll have ish put it on
the screen
see the
silky bite
oh also you know what you know what
story I've wanted to tell in a live
actually
I want to give feedback on one-on-ones
that I bought from the manosphere
I'm the type of [__] I'll pay for
coaching
and there's somebody in the manosphere
that I want to talk [__] about like
respectfully
now if you're seeing this
okay if you see like okay so I've I've
bought some one-on-ones this is before I
even had a platform and I want you to
know which ones help so let's start with
Donovan
I Donovan I never bought a one-on-one
with him but
I talked to him enough a lot of people
would say why why do you associate with
Donovan they tell me all this stuff that
I don't that's got nothing to do with me
okay nothing at all to do with me so I
don't know why you guys keep bringing it
up I don't I don't know what he's doing
over there all I know is when I have no
subs he was always willing to talk to me
and help me
so
yeah okay so so that that I never bought
his one-on-one but if I did I'd
recommend it okay
okay the next
one-on-one session I bought
was
I
I bought the roommates now oh really now
the roommates yes I would like to say I
respect you guys a lot I really do I
think you run a great business
but that was the most trash
that was the most trash ass call I've
ever had in my life Wow I saw them when
I went to Miami yeah that was oh my gosh
I'm gonna tell you what happened so it
was
um I think his names have fees right
okay and I was asking him for like it
like I basically wanted to just like
pick his brain about social media right
and
I think like sometimes people on YouTube
like
they just have their way they view the
world that they don't really listen to
you because they they're like oh I know
exactly who you are I want to view it
through that lens
and
I was asking like what's the best way to
like monetize a platform and monetize
content and I didn't mean
well in one he was like in the car and
there was like a train like it was very
disorganized I'm like okay I paid like
like 100 bucks whatever it is for this
session and it might have been more than
that might have been 200 I don't
remember what it was but it was like a
good chunk of change I'm like and you're
driving
you're driving the audacity
like okay but I guess I guess I
I wouldn't do that I think that's
unprofessional but you know yeah you go
anyways again huffy's it's not personal
I really like your content I like you I
I doubt you'll even see this but if you
do I like you but like
that this meeting was so trash like I
can't even and then he wasn't I was
asking him about social media and the
best way to monetize the platform and he
kept saying you have to want it you
can't just jump to being monetized and I
was just like okay but like long term
like what's the best way to now like
what he could have said was live
streaming and super chats that's what I
found out or he could have said
um creating you know 10 minute video
clips with the hook closer to the Ender
he could have said looking for key
pieces like three key pieces of
information you have to work with the
title the thumb like he could have um
and he could have said you have to look
at like through what lens so like if I
was going to talk to someone about
monetizing their content I might say you
have to look through what lens you're
trying to monetize through are you are
you an information are you providing
value giving them information coaching
them are you providing entertainment
like what's what's your go around now
I'm not claiming I'm an expert there's I
don't really do want to I I've only done
like one one-on-one but
this man just spends 30 minutes like
lecturing me
about basically how I need to produce
more content I'm like huffies I'm at 20
000 subs and I've and I've I've done
like three like probably two one to two
thousand pieces of con I'm not like a
newbie at this anyways my point my point
is this
my point is this
um I I really did not enjoy that at all
um I I felt like that was like the
biggest like I I ended that meeting and
I was like I wasted my money and I I was
so disappointed because I thought he
would be the most helpful like he seems
dang yeah
um the cabin Samuels actually didn't pay
for it because it was like after our
call but that was helpful he told me
yeah to dump my boyfriend my boyfriend
at the time I did great great idea
um
then so if he was still a rip Godfather
um no I know sad but
yeah no I know it says you don't need
much advertising now
but
you could just DM Abba and preach I was
actually looking for consultations from
ABBA it's okay like now
well Abba has a three-hour video just uh
going through like smaller channels
um and basically giving them critiques
randomly wow which I watched and it was
so helpful wow so huh
oh yeah that's just Abba himself
yeah I don't
I I but if they ever did consultations I
think they'd be really good at it no
they definitely would I like carbon
preach but I don't know I was just like
oh so you're oh my God I was so mad that
whole day I was like talking [__] that
whole dirt because I really hate wasting
money and it's one thing if you tried
and like you just failed right you did
the best you could maybe the advice
didn't hit but sir you're driving how
can you say oh my God I was so mad
um anyways
Donovan and I think those are all the
people I've had consultations from okay
but now smash or pass so yeah okay so
Jess you got to put these people on the
screen the roommate smash or pass
when I thought about the roommates
earlier when you said I thought about
two dudes that they had on there
it was like these
dudes that were talking about how to
look like a high value man and they were
like in suits and whatnot but no the
actual remains uh pass
oh my gosh what
YouTube only lets you do a 12 hour
streams
recording with the chat
so is this not so apparently we're gonna
see I guess it might
we'll just restart the stream no it says
make sure you stop the channel at 11 55
so that it saves on the channel YouTube
won't let you save the stream at 24
hours like it'll it'll just cut
okay it's good to know wow thank you
chat
so at 11 we're taking a nap
so
um we started at 9 30. yeah 9 30 okay so
we have okay that's fine
um
thank you for the one dollar
thank you for all the super chats thank
you so much guys you've been keeping us
alive
uh we up
barely
can make it we'll make it so the other
thing I was going to talk about was is
that the only one
oh no no oh I just forgot what we were
doing I'm tired I would I would smash
even though I'm sorry I didn't like your
consultation but I think they're cute
you don't think the roommates are cute
they just give me an interesting vibe
okay so now like it would be like
weird I've been preach smash or pass
I don't know which ones ABBA is the one
with dreads preaches the taller ones you
want to put them on the screen yeah
preaches the one with dreads ABBA is the
one is a taller one I'll say yeah
Abba preach
maybe Abba
and both of them like they'd be in my
maybe category
yeah
Personality yeah
um okay what about
someone said Dawn
DeMarco I don't know who that is
uh pass
um please I cannot get these pictures up
fast enough
see what else the chat says
no Jack can research this one because
way too fast
and fist pass
um oh who's the best looking guy in the
nanosphere
do you know what you guys I'm talking
about that were on I don't know if
they're in the manosphere if they're
just for like
how to look like a high value man Andrew
Tate
I don't know who that is
that's a pass
just is that positive I don't know who
Andrew Tate is
pass
um
foreign
we already did Don DeMarco or DeMarco
yeah we did him
do you know who Patrice O'Neill is no
everybody's been saying him I think
that's going to be our next reaction
video Pearl yeah I think we have to
everybody's been saying it I thought it
was a woman someone said it in the
on the memberships
and I was like Patrice O'Neal I don't
know who that is and I thought it was a
woman
oh pass a black man
pass
I sounded like white chicks when I said
that Jay Waller
smash smash
what about
um Sterling Cooper
smash smash
okay
um
hey guys
uh oh what about do you know who
mediocre tutorials and reviews no
um
Daniel said him earlier and I didn't
know who he was he's an immediate smash
for me really yeah I think is it really
it English it's not English again yeah I
don't oh him yeah smell like smash I
like him smash I just watched one of his
videos the other day
um
Jordan Peterson
yeah I love him have you seen um what
was the last guy's Channel's name
mediocre review yeah yeah MPR have you
seen his video we were talking about
women who uh
or men who are raising babies that
aren't theirs have you seen the video
where this guy
um he's a light-skinned black guy where
he
um
either he gets the DNA test or the girl
gets the DNA test
um and he finds out that the
girl he's been raising isn't his baby
yeah yeah
it was so deep
okay we're gonna do rich Cooper I don't
think you'll find him attractive
mostly because I don't so
I was like the older guy
um
no no
it's not a bad looking guy he's just out
of my like age
Brett Cooper
did we just say that one Michael B
Jordan
is he in the manosphere
but I'd smash
[Music]
come on bro we got it we got this bro we
gotta go chop Paul needs you're
encouraged pump it up pump it up this is
the worst idea I've ever had in my life
this was Paul's idea just to let
everyone know this is Jess's idea
no it's a smart idea
why did I think of this
you went you went let's do a 24-hour
live stream I said huh he was like yeah
as soon as possible when she said that I
thought it was going to be like next
month
Thursday Thursday
I'm just someone who has to do but I
have an idea I have to do it immediately
I respect it I don't really like plan it
think it all the way through I just do
it you said this Thursday I was like me
personally I was like I need to
facilitate this so if if this is what
Paul wants to do then I'm I'm here for
it yeah same I was like you just stop me
like sometimes I need to be held back
know your productivity yeah I can't I
don't want to be the one to cap it like
you're doing well and it wasn't a bad
idea where it'd be like yo she needs to
be stopped yeah it's not like you were
like let's have a 24-hour stream and
every hour on the hour we're gonna take
shots like if you would have said that I
would have been like nah I should have
got more gas but I was so busy this week
I just I just got to London a week ago
I'm not nuts yeah literally I feel like
I've done so much I think I think this
has been interesting we've we've gotten
some interesting uh content for these
people
it's true if they have any questions for
us
when you 24 hour live stream you gotta
wake up start the stream instead of
being awake for the whole day
yeah you know what in hindsight we
should have done so small we should have
did it in the morning and then did the
the podcast all night like why on Earth
why would why did I do it this way hey
it's okay we live and you learn
living room
roller tomasi smash or pass I I've seen
him in that music video you showed me
um what's this what's that song
um I thought mommy's in the club yeah
she's gonna need a babysitter
you're gonna need a babysitter that
mommy's in the club yeah I saw and saw
him like real quick in that and I don't
I don't know who he is
uh what happened to the homeboy with the
crazy story he said Josiah
Josiah okay we got
wake me up before you go go cause I
don't
so
Chad give me a song and I'll sing it
if I know the words
I love me some karaoke
so much for a crazy story
what
uh
Whole New World there you go a new
Fantastic point of view
no one to tell us no or where to go or
say we're only dreaming A Whole New
World
octaves um
how's that next part go
I don't know I'll take you anywhere it's
time to spend
now I'm in a whole new world with you
now I'm in a whole new world
[Music]
undeniable feeling soaring humbling
revealing on a Magic Carpet Ride A Whole
New World this one who said cringe in
the chat [__] scream I bet you can't
sing either
give us another song earlier racing in
iCarly oh what I was gonna say earlier
before we started the um stream I know
so many like Disney theme songs that it
said I know Hannah Montana's theme song
like Hannah Montana Hannah Montana no
not that one no okay and I I will there
will be some days where I will turn on
Hannah Montana and bump it like
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah describe a
great date you've been on oh
this is probably the best date I've been
on ever
it was the last guy I talked to I
remember telling him like if I was able
to go on a date I just wanted to be
simple I just want tacos and
um
I want tacos because I love tacos and I
want my favorite wine and then we can go
and do uh whatever and so I had told him
that multiple times and it was one night
he was like okay like get get ready I'm
gonna meet you here and pick you up and
and take you to go get something to eat
and then we're gonna go somewhere
afterwards I was like okay do I have to
dress up he's like you can dress casual
cute I said all right so
pick me up and we were gonna go to this
Taco spot but he was like have you had
this place before and I said yeah I
already had that I've had that place he
was like oh okay well I wanted to take
you somewhere you hadn't had so I went
to this other spot got the food
and then we went to a drive-in and then
he pulled out my favorite bottle of wine
I was like
why don't you marry him I came here
foreign
I was like in my head I was like yo I've
told you I told you this months ago and
like usually when I tell guys that it
never happened so I never thought it was
going to happen and he got me my
favorite uh Mexican candy as well and I
was like what the freak I was like wow
do you think you could have married him
if you stayed
I don't know about Mary because I wasn't
in that like mindset is like married but
I would have if I would have stayed
there I probably would have like dated
them yeah I dated him
oh my God you could be right with a ring
right now
I don't know because I didn't even know
if he was in that mindset okay he didn't
have that conversation no okay because
we we never progressed onto
um because we were leaving dating like
being official what not
it was like
I I gasp I was like this is really
happening I never thought this would
like happen in life okay what about
what is the worst date you've ever been
on
foreign
my second boyfriend
um I flew out to
um Georgia to visit him and uh
we barely spent time
um Christmas day I was there and it
uh he left and went and hung out with
his friends and so it wasn't until like
the second to last day where
we um actually like went out to eat
somewhere but
the car ride was silent we sat in
silence at dinner
and then we had an argument in the the
park
and then
I went back we went back to his house
and it was just quiet just quiet the
whole ride and then I flew home
wow yeah it was
then I was like got back I was like yeah
you know what
I think this is it's gonna work out now
he's married
good for him
is it good for him
he found a bag but
that was funny oh my gosh I can't the
worst date oh my gosh actually this was
so this wasn't a date but I was all I
wanted in my last relationship was to or
one of my I can say which one one of my
relationships
um was to go to karaoke and I literally
asked for like months and I like kept
asking like I was like all I want to do
is go to karaoke and always say no and
so this one day he says that I can go to
karaoke
and I was like I was so excited I got
like dressed up I wore my red dress and
if you say yeah I was so excited to go
to karaoke I got like super dressed out
and the man like literally like we're
about to leave and then we got into like
it wasn't even I forgot what it was I
said
I made a joke that he didn't like but I
was like kidding you know what I mean
but like I took it too far so I was like
oh sorry cancels we'll go
wow
it sounds like it was looking for an
excuse no he definitely was but I was it
was so sad because I was like
oh my God I was so excited like you
didn't understand like I Love karaoke I
love oh my God I kill karaoke same and
that was like the only thing I wanted to
do oh my God we should go to karaoke one
of these nights
legit do you like karaokeish
not really I like to sing but I don't
like karaoke okay I Love karaoke can't
sing but I love karaoke I mean I think I
think we do have fun there I think so
too
get me turn on some Anita Baker at
karaoke I'm killing it yup turn on
Montel Jordan This is how we do it oh
shutting down the place I promise you
that's what I did huh I'll call read
remember so it's a bit of a problem for
me
you don't need to read you know if you
know the song if you know the song it's
looking good if not oh you pick songs
you know
yeah how do you do you think the world
would change if all the countries
announced in a week that the government
would no longer intervene in any way
shape or form with Family Matters and
all babies bees must have a paternity
test for the man to claim his child
oh I think a lot of super chats
we got some requests oh yeah I think
Corey RP wanna have a deep chat got a
deep question I think a lot of women
would
um
if they knew that the man would get um
attested and they knew like he would
know that he's not the father I think a
lot of women would be more cautious
yeah I'm more careful because
I don't think women are like I'm gonna
have this baby and I'm gonna raise it on
my own I want to be a single mother yeah
if they knew like
um
I'm a hoe I'ma sleep around and this man
that I am with
may not be the baby's father so yeah
I chat really think we can't sing you
know
talking about
careful you don't get copyright okay
copyright bro we'll sing a copyright
okay one I sing fire I'm just too
exhausted but I won't make it this 24
hours okay
okay I'm calling this
quiet out there please we're live
streaming
anyone we know no it was I think it was
just a win or someone like walking out
the door
okay
hello
hello can you hear me yeah I can hear
you
okay I
apologize I'm over here in Miami
oh you're in Miami oh Miami
in Miami
how's everything how you doing good
we're just dying on streams
how long are you doing you said 24 hours
right yeah yeah we're at 12 so we got 12
more oh
oh God good luck to that thanks
um so did you have a question comment or
what what made you want to call in
I mean I love what you do you know you
uh there's not a lot of women that
represent you know like men or anything
you go on Tick Tock they bash man all
the time and
um you and a few other girls I mean I
don't really know too many but uh kind
of like back up man but
um the thing I was trying to get at was
like an ax that I was with which is
crazy because like
this whole thing of
um believe all women or whatever it is
crazy you know like I I was with a girl
for a bit and um and she she kind of she
lied to me completely about everything
about
um having a having a kid
wait she had she had a kid that she
didn't tell you about
no like
we knew each other for about five years
from like mutual friends like say we
went to the bar we see each other
nothing crazy all right so then you know
five years passes whatever and then
um we see each other we hang out
she says she has a kid I said okay cool
she wants to hang out whatever
um
you know a couple months passed we hook
up
and she comes to my place you know I
have a place in Fort Lauderdale a place
in Brickell as well comes over
everything is cool I go to her place
everything is cool
um she said she has a kid two bedroom no
toys no nothing around the place I'm
like you know kind of kind of awkward
you have a kid but there's nothing
around that that you know shows you have
a child
kid you know you say you have kids like
six years old I mean something should be
around you know
she she basically led me on to this
thing like oh the father had
um custody they're up in New York
gave me this whole thing kind of
believed it for a little bit
and um
you know we we kind of hung out here and
there and then basically what happened
was
um
we we would chill here and there
and she would tell me about her kid all
this stuff I mean
uh the call dropped oh the call dropped
he's in Miami the place hit that why on
Earth would she lie about it like having
a child I don't know the place where
he's at looks very familiar like the
palm trees I know like oh that's all we
can see but it looks like a place I
stayed at in Miami I was like oh my gosh
wow Miami's so beautiful yo
Miami is muy bonita
sound like he was about to get into some
Russia some juicy juicy
maybe I'll see if he calls me back could
you can you guys hear it when I put that
on the
I I can hear it fine I'm just curious if
the chat can hear
I mean I'll try calling him back
I don't jack give us a song in the
meantime in between time oh they did it
on the soup shots oh they did yeah under
the seat
he's coming I'm like sorry get your tail
Hill Sarah I need you get your ass
um
I don't know all the little mermaids
probably my least favorite Disney movie
so I don't know all those words
smash your past Stalin
the crab no Stalin like the the Stalin
like me Stalin pass
that's it Sebastian is the crafting
Stalin that's like saying smash or pass
Hitler
another song
por favor
let me get up hold on guys
[Laughter]
Cody you want some of this Red Bull
yeah okay
yeah there's some in the fridge
he said yeah
shotgun yeah
just imagine if Pearl was like we're
gonna have a show Thursday night and
Friday night and we're gonna end the the
24 hours with this show
I'm I texted I said I'm gonna try to
convince Pearl to cancel the show uh
Saturday and we'll go out
[Laughter]
I was just like oh I seconded this he
said I I feel you guys I said hey I said
I was my original plan was to have a
show Saturday and these Rascals
I said hey how about we how about we can
you imagine after a month of work
not even two weeks for this one already
asking me for days off
oh luckily
I don't feel you guys working together I
could feel it I was like I feel like the
coach
in high school when it asked to cancel
practice oh he said I like the sign of
that I said yes
yeah if you said Club it would have been
cooked oh no you said if you said like
let's go out
no and I was like you know what we can
just do this show when you said dinner I
was like I do like food yeah and it's
free and I didn't even know I was buying
food at the time I mean we didn't yeah
we didn't know it was gonna be you then
either and now we know all right
like the video
um like the video people I'm so tired
the fish needs some cash in his pockets
yeah honestly that's expensive gals yeah
these are about to read my pockets guys
so yup help me help me we're about to
get to read it on Saturday
I'll bring my camera yeah take a couple
photos yo and then float is about to be
crispya fire
you must charge my flash not that I've
ever used it before but I do videos
where should we go super chat for dinner
in London
be nice
tomorrow three dollar signs or more
you hear that three songs three dollar
signs yeah three three stalls three
dollar signs or more guys tell me tell
me
um
I really want to go to Big Easy
yeah yeah that I'm with that but is it
fancy enough to like dress up hold up
yeah no it's not you pause now
no okay guys tell me red pill facts I
can tell Jess yes hey
he said Wendy's
first of all Mr Jimmy we are not gonna
dress fancy and go to y'all wanna the
members want to see some some good
looking girls in some dresses did I
expect my channel to grow this fast
McDonald's chocolate chip these are my
guys no they they speak in fact yo yes
guys if you pick yourself up
tomorrow and we're all dressed up and
you take us to KFC I'ma be pissed okay
wait I have a I have I'm picking you up
I like that you're dry you're drying
yeah that's true okay what's your
thought Pearl
assistant
what is it never mind
yo yo we on the street might as well
speak your mind
I had the cameras on you let's go no no
type it in your phone say no this is
like a it's not even bad it's just like
so stupid say it we said a lot of stupid
stuff yeah this is the time
chat
how's that stupid no I was just thinking
like like I clearly I'm not gonna get a
pet dog but like whatever oh a pet duck
I thought you said I wanted to try that
I thought I just like brought one like I
feel gonna be a great Vlog [__] the ciao
Ellie Ellie would eat that Doug I think
it's food
um
oh okay super cat
explains what causes
boys that have to decide I respect that
what did what did the Super Chat say
um superchat said they want to have a
call
um or one of the guys in the chat said
because the Red Bull Channel I have to
decide where we go
oh you have you can order anything off
the KFC menu the audacity
hello hello hello how did you find the
red pill
um I was in a four and a half year
relationship
um
Basin engagement this is um
then a few things transpired
um that I realized that I had this kind
of rose-tinted view of my relationship
the
um led me to lose quite a bit of money
I'm not gonna lie I was as simple at the
time
so it's a mix of actual money and then I
also bought a house during the
relationship and but I sold my Tesla
shares to do so
so if you want calculated earnings I've
lost it's about between 200 and 300K no
yeah
um because I I had about
20 30k worth of Tesla shares and I
managed to get in when it was around 170
pound a share and then obviously during
covert they shot up to around 1700 so
um
that was the biggest gripe to me because
um obviously I was a lot more invested
than my partner was
what happened why'd it end Ed
up well
um so I'm just trying to turn you off
right um
basically
during covid we moved out the house I
purchased back into her family home
don't I don't advise ever living with
someone's parent by the way because it
just ruins any sort of relationship
Dynamic if you need to argue there's
always a third party getting involved
um so and I kind of feel like her family
was a bit of a cult mentality
um mainly because they all lived next
door to one another so next to my uh at
his parents house was her null and
Granddad and then next to them was
around an uncle and next to them was
over aunt and uncle
uh so much so they had knocked down all
of the walls at the back of each of his
houses so they could just walk into
anyone's houses at any point
uh that was crazy for me anyway
because I'm not used to that kind of
like don't get me wrong I love my family
but
um that kind of close contact every
every day everyone just walking into
everyone's houses isn't really good for
me
um
and
early on in the relationship we split up
and I wish I'd stayed split up and one
of the things we split up I don't know
whether you what you class is cheating
or not but
um
basically there was this guy who we were
both aware that was attracted to her
um and he alliterated it to her plenty
of times and
wanted to me
come on
um which is kind of like a red flag to
me because
if you know that the person's interested
and you only want to meet up with you on
your own then that's kind of like your
facility and that kind of behavior
um so we had a big argument about it
um and I said well I'd be happy to go
along with you guys I don't know I don't
think this is me being a
bearing or anything like that and then
if he's comfortable with me being there
then it's fine because sometimes I feel
like
when guys just see you as the boyfriend
they don't have to give the [__] about
oh sorry I don't really care too much
about you whereas if they see you as an
individual then you know
might cause them to think twice but
moving forward so he agreed it was not a
good idea to go and then I later found
that
she went anyway
um
and lied about who she went with which
caused us to separate for for a time
um but he said she said you had nothing
to worry about because he was very calm
anyway and I said well in my back of my
head I was like well if she if he wasn't
Camp would it have been an option like I
don't understand why you'd even say that
kind of comment mm-hmm
um so fast fast forward
um that became a red line in my
relationship in terms of West at the bar
of what's acceptable or not and I was
working during covert because I lost my
job I'm a financial account report
because I worked in the the rail
industry at the time
um all the trains were shot was shot
down
on that to produce overheads because the
the way that the company earned his
money was mileage around on the rails
so less trains less mileage means less
Revenue so I was working three jobs just
to match the salary that I was on like
uh like TV just doing like packaging any
so basically
um well that was happening she started
getting more and more distance and
um anything I would say to anybody in
relationship
if something feels off it probably is
um did you notice I feel like you've got
notices changes in behavior before you
do
um
so basically she was facilitating chats
with other guys behind my back again
well see I can never prove that she
actually went ahead and cheated that I
think if she had different yeah but
girls don't know
yeah
um so I was trying to arrange a surprise
like birthday party for it because we
were coming out of like the back end of
covert and so I went to speak to some of
our friends to arrange to survive um
surprise birthday party when I got there
they said um the people wanted to speak
to you for like the last two years
because
we've got a list of things
that
might actually said about me that they
wanted to see whether they were true or
not
when I got back to arrange this uh
surprise birthday party I was I was
there from about two in the afternoon to
about two a.m and that's how long the
list was there was um so many claims of
abuse
um 10 I've been looking in bathrooms and
all this thing and all of this just came
up nowhere to me so it was absolutely
crazy and um while I was while this
discussion was taking place with her
friends which I'm a lot of friends
generally back up their girls so this
was a big surprise to me that you know
they'd be honest and while I was there
um talking to their friends she was
actually having a
good date with some guy that I didn't
know about
um so they
so they're going for these list of
accused accusations against me
um and it was kind of
me because I'm usually quite a prompt
responder in terms of messaging and
maybe that day I'd responded to her once
because generally when I'm talking to a
group of people I kind of shut off from
my phone and engage with the
conversation in place and especially of
that nature when I'm being accused so
what happened
um so while that was taken place she was
blowing up my phone and then she started
telling her friends because she was
blown up their friends I think he's
stalking me I think he knows and quite
clearly I wasn't because I was sitting
opposite them discussing all the things
she was accusing me of so she's still
walking following her
um you know oh wow like stalking and all
that stuff
yeah even though we were in a
relationship at the time yeah I'm like
physically abusing her and and all these
things were completely Wayside to me
because obviously I'd committed to
buying a house with hers getting to get
engaged in my mind and all of this and
it's just interesting she'd never kind
of let me hang out with those friends so
I think she'd be in pushing's narrative
like they said for like two years and go
around telling anyone who's prepared to
listen for her to be a victim just to
get like attention like she would go
around telling all the lads that you
know he's awful to do and then they were
saying that these Lads would you know
considering coming to fire me and beat
me up and I was just completely
oblivious to all of these accusations
against me and I only found out on the
off chance that you know of their
friends tell me and she would be telling
their friends I'm only with them because
at the time of before I lost my job due
to covid I was working for a fast
fashion brand
um I don't want to say anything or
anything um
and so I forget discounts for that kind
of thing like 50 off and like like I had
a lot of perks to my job and those were
the excuses she was coming up with why
she was still with me that she would say
to her friends that she wouldn't say to
me so you know once I'd heard all this
stuff you know talking through hours and
stuff
um it was nice to reflect the person
actually was
um to her friends because we'd only hung
out a few times and they were saying
comments when we hung when we were
hanging out which I didn't quite
understand they were like oh you're
actually a really good boyfriend you're
really affectionate and I just thought
that a really strange comments because I
was just
being me kind of thing but now but then
it all lined up because she'd been
painting this picture for about two
years of of this like years of abuse but
they could never understand why she
wouldn't leave or like contest anybody
should be concerned about she's been
telling them that you were abusing her
for years yeah yeah yeah and then like
that's why they would never want to hang
out with me and then when they did and
we we sat down there was just right
they said she was like a pathological
liar basically yeah basically yeah yeah
um so they wanted to call her out on it
but she would never like yeah and she'd
never want to like meet up with them at
the same time yeah yeah so yeah that's
great that's pretty cheap for me yeah
yeah that's that's a crazy red pill
story
um thank you for calling in yeah
yeah yeah thank you good luck with your
stream um thank you so much and I've
been following since about 10 000
subscribers so
um all right so you're here for the rap
reactions yeah yeah like it's just
honestly the way that your channel has
just exploded since then like you
obviously do whatever right and don't
don't think that when I even think that
you understand that you've got that uh
female advantage of talking about this
subject because not many do so
but yeah all the better and keep working
hard thank you so much I appreciate it
thanks have a good one bye bye bye
ah so nice
that was a really crazy story crazy
story but just be crazy I mean don't
I hope people didn't think I was
laughing at his story no caught myself
we're getting hysteric I'm not like I'm
just being honest this is hysteria it's
sinking it I literally caught myself
thank you Gene for the Super Chat that
gave me a rush of adrenaline to not fall
asleep 100 100 Canada dollars yeah I
think I'm a black dude but it took me
about 10 years to get red pilled in the
end of one year Watching
MSNBC really did it for me at first I
liked it but then I started noticing
that they very often omitted the context
to manipulate the story congrats and
good luck thank you so much Corey RP old
we treat people better outside our race
why
I don't I don't I don't know I don't
know why
I don't know I'm gonna I'm gonna get a
new adrenaline wave you wait you wait
till this Red Bull kicks in it's kicking
in for me yeah this is you like I feel
like I mean you're an opposite like
exhaustion schedule
like everyone I'm about to give up like
you're you're going no good
um can you toss me my phone uh-ish
no phones on the live I'm just kidding
I'm about to call my cousin he's still
up
I hope you did too that's why I handed
it to you
um since Pearl ignores my Ig DMS
congrats on the 100K I've been
Associated congrats what's your igl look
it up you said Pearl you're ignoring me
maybe this is him we'll see
did you put it on the charger did you
turn it on on the back did it on charge
no
Pros calling somebody anyways hello
yo
what
was that from Texas it's about like
three o'clock what time is it over there
oh I'm sorry did I wake you up
I was calling you back I'm an
all-nighter okay he's in for the Long
Haul yes we love it it's three o'clock
okay
um so tell me what made you want to call
in you got a question comment concern
I don't know I watched it last year and
was subscribed
oh thanks
oh
so y'all y'all barely awake are you what
is he watching right now I'm watching oh
he's watching right now hey yo what up
what up what up what up okay tell me how
many bodies is Too Many Bodies
y'all are still in that question that
was like three hours ago but we haven't
asked you that question I'm gonna ask
you okay okay I don't need this
criticism
did you hang up on him yeah
don't unsubscribe though
yo no
throws a Savage
feel better well I don't know about it
he said I don't need this
my question
not not the time not the time to
criticize
[Laughter]
okay Pro's a Savage right now come on
cuzzo
I got I got six percent
don't do it back in don't do it
yeah don't do it
hey yo because oh say hi to the people
he wouldn't criticize our questions no
say hi to the people Jonathan you want
to criticize all questions yeah
don't make me do it
wait let me see this is my cousin
Jonathan that's Pearl
good how are you you guys look best ish
over there
thank you so much I'm dying yeah we're
going we're going 24 hours
is 2 am well not anymore what'd you say
it's three in the morning it's 8 50 in
the morning
okay so tell me tell me is he red pill
does he watch the show have you I think
he's watched a few episodes
um Pearl's gonna ask you some questions
and you're going to answer them on live
okay so tell me why why
do are women looked at as oppressed
through all of history
when men had to fight in the wars and
women got to be protected
to that beginning part why
are women looked at as oppressed
throughout history when historically men
had to fight in the wars where women
were protected
hmm
I feel in some way and some time there's
a
there's a war there was a rule I guess
in some in some way where
men just found
I feel like men just felt like
we had to be more masculine I guess a
woman just had to be the more like
caretaker as we had to be like the
providers and
I think it's just like a mental but like
strategy has like um
I don't know I like I guess like being
more masculine I guess if that makes
sense
so I like having a different
um
mindset
yeah well like I was like um that like
that that level but
um
what is the word
hierarchy
no
yeah I mean that's a really good
question but like to be straightforward
is like band is really thinking about
everything and all the history it was
really just men just wanted to have and
just be looked looked upon just as like
just royalty you know I mean in all ways
looked at us what do you say royalty men
were looking at it like like yeah they
had to be like higher up as yeah
right but do you think that they were
looked at as royalty or they were
capable of doing the things that made
them Royal it's like what does the king
have to do he has to lead people into
battle were women really capable of
doing that then
woman uh I feel like a viewer yeah I
feel like there was a lot of so I can
feel like I know there's a probably half
a woman who wanted to do
things that men wanted to but of course
was okay so you're a woman you don't
have to strengthen stuff to do that so
I'm I'm about six feet tall I'm taller
than most men
I I can deadlift close to 300 I can
squat like 250.
he said you were Amazon yeah but but
here's here's my thing
for most men I would not beat in combat
even so
so like before like most of human
history we didn't have guns yeah and
swords are heavy so it's body armor
so how would women lead us into victory
historically
the the strategy I feel like they would
have
um as you women just have a more sharper
mindset I would say when it comes to
just strategizing and figuring out a
plan so sometimes you know back then men
just wanted to kind of so if that's true
if that's true why didn't they only use
women
if that would help them win
why did they only use why didn't they
why didn't they
because they didn't want to look lesser
than than a woman
so if you were going into battle
would you want a man leading or a woman
leading
[Laughter]
a man no no no I'll say woman I'll say
woman you and then after that because I
I sound up I personally been around you
know so many women were like
they you know like y'all just think
really differently you know I mean like
it's just something about it like y'all
how am I to think about war about
fighting and and also
um strategizing how to protect everybody
versus you know man is like we're
we're we're thriving to just kind of
just win the war and you know if we lose
people behind hey that's cool they all
signed up for it versus I feel like
sometimes women would
would want to try to
win the war and save everyone at the
same time even if women are more
emotional and men are more logical
so you would rather have an emotional
woman
lead you into battle
than a man
than a logical man
a weaker a weaker more emotional women
you know she weak okay a balance of
probabilities
who's stronger men or women
if you want to go like physical wise
people say men and we feel different
yeah
okay who do you know who's better at
chess men or women
chess yeah
oh I do not know that question man
there I don't know why I just know men
dominate in chess logical thinking yeah
more logical yeah
I'm gonna control my motion more about
that or something like that it's just a
logical thinking
oh I just I feel like you're capping a
little bit like I just don't I feel like
you're like trying to like make it like
so it's politically correct no I don't
think I don't I really don't believe
that you would pick Jess to lead you
into battle
that's all right it was just his brother
oh man again I'll build different so
this is I I'm not surprised that he's
answering these questions like this are
you a simp
oh no you kind of talk like one a little
bit that's fine this is 12 o'clock at
night for me so you just eating a
different demeanor he's in a different
mindset different what's different about
your mindset I'm I'm chill I'm chilling
right now you see like a nice guy
yes I'm all right I'm cool nice nice
dude
he's a sweetheart so you you think women
were oppressed throughout history
press yeah
oppressed
oppressed yeah
[Music]
can we give back a good example I mean
there's there's a few but what would you
say specifically like overall if there's
a few
I know no
what he said no no because he's a
there's a few give me some examples I
said if I said overall there's a few of
them
this is
just say it to say no
no
no why okay what's another question why
do we have women's empowerment and not
men's empowerment
because I don't think a lot of men are
willing to be as open
about certain things and probably a lot
of things that bother them versus women
and women are more willing to
um I feel like combine more just talking
collab and you know be in a group to be
willing to open versus men it's like
some some of us will be hella hesitant
to
you know even just just share one little
thing about us you know it's like you
know I'm scared to take my shirt off
around other men because you know it
feels a way but
yeah do you think that if
if there is a group called men's
empowerment that women would get behind
that
could there be some overall though do
you think women will go behind it or do
you think women would be like
um what do you mean men's empowerment
y'all are empowered every day yeah yeah
you may want to have something like us
women do not [__] all that me men ain't
[__] man get go suck a little big ass
[__]
hi baby
yeah they sound weird because you know
me because like I'm so 50 50 with [__]
but I feel like overall
it would it would we would try
but it would be a big ass argument
and you know and I feel like yep one
would be like nah man y'all probably
could have had y'all moments a long time
ago but this is about it we're gonna
keep it our way y'all can find something
you know y'all got your men's club y'all
got your golf so y'all got this let us
have ours
okay
question why do you think women will say
things like I want a man that makes six
that's six feet make six figures and is
six inches
but when a man says I want a woman
that's thin it's fat phobic
there would you like that
um
what do you mean they really be like
that it's all
you say one thing you say one thing
against a woman is this phobic is that
phobic or if I if they say I don't date
single mothers they're shame for it
Kevin Samuels when he said women over 35
are leftover women
I don't know what else you'd call them
they're the ones that are leftovers
rest in peace
women have no problem telling men that
they ain't [__]
but if men do the same then they're
ashamed why is that because we can't
handle the truth
we're not used to it you said
yeah and especially like coming from
women
how can men not handle the truth when
men are shamed all the time and they
don't do anything about it but when
women are ashamed they're the ones that
complain you think you're saying that
women can't handle the truth because
when someone tells them something no no
men men can't oh okay why
why you think that
does that means from what I'm from what
I've seen personally but like and I feel
like
um okay insecurities I can understand
that from what you've seen because
California
how old are you
I'm 29. 29 are you single
nah
yeah
in a relationship no I'm not I'm not I'm
asking for it okay how are you good
you're good if you were if you were
dating how old is too old to date
um
29 after like too old for me would be
40. really you go up to 40. wow oh yeah
that's like the new 40 now that's the
new 40 like uh you're good at 29. oh
yes I am 17. okay I have another
question are you are you pro-life or
pro-choice
Jesus
can you
break it down to me are you are you
pro-life or pro-chart like abortion yes
or no
oh
oh you're pro-life
well I understand like is good right I
mean it's it's whatever pro-life is
you're against abortion yeah against
abortion yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah so do you think
women shouldn't have the right to have
an abortion at all ever
um for me truly is
it's it's really on them you know I was
like hey it is their body it is their
Temple
and it is you know they're
you know like creation of you know what
they have and
[__] it's like it's tough because like
who am I you know I've never I I can't
create that out of me so I was like I
can't never really say
you know they should be
against it
making their own choice break it down
for them bro I know I'm just I'm just
getting confused if he's pro-choice or
pro-life because I I thought he said
pro-life but he's a pro-life but yeah
telling somebody else that they can or
cannot do something is
is like he's against telling somebody
what they can or cannot do with their
body okay yeah okay but if it was on
like a ballot where he had to say it
like choose like pro-life or poor choice
he would vote for life so you so if it
was up to you it'd be illegal
yeah okay okay no I'm just trying to
understand so do you know anything about
Planned Parenthood
do I know anything about Planned
Parenthood yeah like the history of it
I'll be honest with you no okay so did
you know that Planned Parenthood was
started by a eugenicist
and so she her goal was to eliminate the
black population
and did you know the black population
would be double today if it wasn't for
Planned Parenthood
yeah 80 of Planned Parenthood locations
are in Black area like black
neighborhoods wow what also like the US
would be the new Africa what what do you
say he said he feels like the US would
be the new Africa
yeah
another another part of it yeah so how
why do you think it is that Planned
Parenthood can
exist even though it has racist Origins
and the the founders basically
accomplishing her goal
because again she is limiting the black
like she's stopping the black Rays from
reproducing basically like that's what
she wanted to do
but
if if a norm if Nike was found have
racist Origins people would be in an
uproar
where's that like did they try to do it
like no I wasn't Nike okay yeah that is
true because everybody's rocking Nike
you know and Nike is a worldwide brand
that everybody wants to show off and
wants to be part of
and so you're up there for Nike did show
one one wrong thing one racial thing
it'll be 50 50.
okay
that 47 of black pregnancies are aborted
474 per thousand live births
say that one more time 47 of black
pregnancies are aborted 47 that's wow
crazy wow 48 474 per thousand live
births
but there nobody talks about this
no
wow I think
I don't know why nobody talks about it
but I think the people that protest
protest against
um the planned parenthoods if they knew
this information and was and was protest
protesting against something like this
it would be more effective than just
saying pro-life pro-choice and they
don't care
yeah did you see the did you see the the
show I did
uh abortion did you were you here no you
weren't here no I told the whole room
full of feminists and I I was telling
them about this and their response is
well it's probably different management
oh you're lying it doesn't matter if the
management changes whatever is rooted on
is going the crazy thing is this guy
hold on because this let me find the DMS
because this guy was like laying it out
for me because I got uh you guys should
follow reclaim your throne I did a
collab with him and he was the only like
showed me the studies that went a lot
because I didn't believe him first when
he said 474 per thousand live bursts I
was like there's no way it's that high
that's crazy
um but he said he said okay what'd you
say
Wheaties
[Music]
um
79 of abortion clinics in the America
are in the black community and brown
Community origins of Planned Parenthood
was a Eugenics project created by
Margaret Sanger influenced by a Nazi
scientist originally named
the
I don't want to say that but the project
um the fact that black women are
advocating for this is insane
um the matter
the matter
um black women are three times more
likely to abort their fetuses the reason
why is because it's readily accessible
it's like
um black no black women know this so
they're more sexually irresponsible
that's true
um Margaret Margaret Sanger wrote this
speech oh let's read it I didn't even
read this
okay hold on before you read all right
because I'm gonna let you go if you want
to plug your IG or anything go ahead and
do it
oh yeah here if y'all want to um see
some you know some new things from
massage therapist about to do some
dancing and [__] some skits I'm at um at
Jrock underscore Davis
tuning with me and follow me my journey
for some upcoming things that I want to
pursue in
um my world of healing and health yeah
if y'all are ever in Southern California
hit him up he's the one of the best
massage therapists ever and I'm not just
saying that because he is my cousin yo
he has healing in his hands not like
Jesus but
he'd be working through him glory okay
let me not start preaching on this live
so um love you Cuzzo and I will talk to
you later
bye
nice to meet you
all right and we're actually gonna read
this I'm gonna read it yeah go ahead
moment I haven't read this before
Eugenics and others who are laboring for
racial betterment can succeed oh before
you Genesis and others who are laboring
for racial oh sorry good before Eugen a
six this is harder than you think over
here before exactly I see why everyone
struggles on this show before Eugenics
and those
what am I doing I'm sorry guys I'm
struggling okay
before Eugenics and others who are
laboring for racial betterment can
succeed they must first clear the way
for birth control like the advocates for
of birth control the Eugenics for
instance are seeking to assist the race
towards the elimination of the unfit
both are seeking are seeking a single
end but lay emphasis upon different
methods Eugenics emphasized the mating
of healthy couples for the conscious
purpose of producing healthy children
the sterilization of the unfit to
prevent them from populating the world
with their kind and they may perhaps
agree with us that contraception is
necessary measure among the masses of
workers where wages do not keep Keen
with the growth of the family and its
necessities of food clothing housing
medical attention education and like we
who Advocate birth control on the other
hand lay all our emphasis upon stopping
not only the reproduction of the unfit
but upon stopping all reproduction where
there's not economic means of providing
proper care for the children who are
born into health
the Eugenics also believe that a woman
should bear as many healthy children as
possible as a duty to this day we hold
that the world is overpopulated Eugenics
employer insists that a woman's first
duty is to the state we contend her duty
to herself is her duty to the state we
maintain that a woman's possessing
inadequate knowledge of her reproductive
functions is the best judge of time and
conditions under which a child should be
brought into the world we further
maintain that it is her right regardless
of other considerations to determine
whether she shall bear the children or
not and how many children she shall bear
if she chooses to become a mother
to this end we insist that informed
information and scientific regard
scientific contraceptions be made open
to all we believe that if information is
placed within the reach of all we will
have
made it possible to take the first
greatest step towards racial betterment
and this step assisted in no small
measure by the educational propaganda of
eugenics and members of similar schools
will be taken while I personally believe
in the sterilization of feeble-minded
the insane encephalitic
I think it's like syphilis I have not
been able to discover the measures that
are more superficial and detriment
deterrence when applied to those
constantly growing stream of the unfit
they are actually they are excellent
means of meeting a certain phase of the
situation but I believe in regards to
those as in regards to other eugenic
means that they do not go to the bottom
of the matter neither the mating of
healthy couples nor the sterilization of
certain recognized types of the unfit
touches the great population unlimited
reproduction of those whose houses and
clothes and food are all inadequate to
physical and mental health
these measures do not touch the great
masses who through economic pressure
population and slums and the population
and their helplessness
other helpless diseased and incompetent
masses who overwhelmed all the Eugenics
can do this with economic conditions is
better
sorry guys birth control on the other
hand
not only opens the way to Eugenics but
it preserves his work crazy
furthermore it not only prepares the
ground in natural fashion for the
development of higher standards of
motherhood and family life but enables
children to be born better cared for in
infancy and better educated birth
control of itself by freeing
reproductive instincts from its present
chains will make a better race
wow um a family sub subsisting upon
certain wage will will naturally give
better care to one or two children upon
that wage than it would do for six four
six eight ten and two children are much
much less likely to go into child labor
factories and sweatshops than eight or
ten the situation is too plain for the
argument concrete examples of the
Eugenics effects of birth control are
the most convincing evidence in Holland
where birth control is taught in clinics
conducted by nurses trained for that
purpose military statistics show the
average stature of men increased four
inches over 30 years ninety percent of
the men were fit for the Army service
where in the United States 50 percent
were the fighting qualities of the
French
um his endurance and his Fitness
um Okay blah blah blah blah Eugenics
without birth control seems like to us a
house builded upon the Sands it is at
the mercy of rising stream of the unfit
it cannot stand against the Furious
Winds of economic pressure
which have been buffered into a partial
or helpless tool
to help with a tremendous proportion of
the human race only a free
self-determined motherhood can rest any
unshakable structure of racial
betterment wow not [__] up big time
like I don't understand why
uh like I just feel like this should be
huge but nobody cares I would say that
qual uh that goes along the feminist
group The hate group they're just
undercovered Mike oh sorry I forgot we
wrote a podcast
no and the other thing is that they were
getting tired guys no the other thing
though is they
when I did that show okay there and I
said
they basically had the argument because
they would say basically that poor kids
didn't know how to use birth control and
I'm like that is so offensive to poor
people
you're telling me poor people don't know
what condoms are yeah and you're telling
me that poor people don't know how to
take a pill every day
at the same time every day it's not
rocket science
I'm not they're broke not stupid I know
that's the that's a dumb excuse
to support this junk poor people don't
know how to take birth control
it's already formulated for you they
give you the pack and they say take it
same time every day bye well think about
it they said propaganda what then sex
said came in schools brother teaching
you how to use this [__] it's like it's
it's literally yo yeah there's there's
so much there's so much stuff that is
just like
circling and like there's something in
the center that is circling around
everything is like connected I want to
break down the family yeah yo I don't yo
it started yeah
it was it you put her in the hallway
like like close both yeah sorry go ahead
no I was just saying um what came what
came first uh welfare or abortions
who's wrong
one I think the welfare
it was around the same time because
wait wait actually
one
Roe versus weight when was it I got I
got this wrong last time I was live so I
am going
because it's like with welfare you're
breaking up oh my gosh right right at
the same time there's the 1965 was the
development of birth control wow it's
like you have welfare that's breaking up
uh the home and then you have
um
abortions yeah and they're both
affecting the black community yeah like
substantially that is crazy yeah no it's
like it's but no like nobody wants to
talk about it because oh
it's helping no it's no it's not because
there's going to come a time if this
keeps happening and these numbers keep
Rising that in America
there will if these numbers this is from
I may not be correct but this is just my
thought process
at 9 18 in the morning with no sleep
that if this stuff keeps happening and
the black home keeps being broken up and
uh kids keep getting aborted and
um what was my third Point Jesus I lost
it abortion birth control and
yeah oh and
um my third one is
and with uh
just close the door in the hallway
um with
interracial
um interracial couples and them having
babies I'm not saying anything's wrong
with that but I'm just what why I added
that in that there's going to come a
time where
there's not going to be a full like a
hundred percent black person in the U.S
and black women are at the highest rate
of dying during birth and so it's it's
like why why would it why would black
women why would black women want to have
babies if there's a high percentage that
they're gonna die oh my gosh that's a
myth too is it really a myth it's higher
than white women and like other races
but it's still not high it's not like
high enough for people to be affected by
it really wow why did they push that
break down to the family oh my goodness
wow I don't I don't know why they but
it's like that's what I I can't stand
the left because I just think like oh
that's yeah wow that's I just I keep
saying the same thing over and over
again because it's it's crazy that's
and then when I've said that so many
times like my goodness
oh yeah and and then they they also okay
and the other crazy thing is they would
act like and it's crazy the arguments
that you'd sound like the Eugenics
argument the the feminists that were
here and I don't think anyone did they
say no but the first they would say
they're not smart enough to use birth
control which I was like
yeah
and then the second thing they would
talk about is that
the birth control thing and then the
second thing is that
um
that management the management switched
which I actually the guy was telling me
that it didn't but I didn't look look at
it that closely but then the third thing
is they were saying that
oh my God okay I lost it I'm two times
it doesn't like that that it doesn't
matter if the management switch if the
if you have if you have the same
management for like
we'll say 50 years and the people that
were hired in didn't know about this
oh we gotta end the Stream
[Music]
yeah okay guys we're gonna end the
stream real quick and just restart it
because I just found out there's a 12
hour limit